I CALL TO ORDER THIS HEARING OF
THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE HAS VIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SOMEONE WELCOME
EVERYONE HERE -- SO WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO IS IN THE FOR A
FIRST PART OF THE HEARING WE'RE
GOING TO COVER VERY YES VOTE
ONLY ITEMS -- FROM THE MERGE HE
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY THE
STATE.
THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT THE
DEPARTMENT MANAGED HEALTHCARE
THE PARM HEALTHCARE SERVICES
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES.
ALL VOTE ONLY ITEMS ARE PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT EXCEPT FOR UNDER THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT ISSUE
NUMBER.
TWO DEPARTMENT MANAGED
HEALTHCARE ISSUE NUMBER THREE
THE PARMA SOCIAL SERVICES ISSUE
NUMBER THREE AND APARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES ISSUE NUMBER SIX
SO WE WILL DO THE REMAINDER
BALANCE OKAY MILLION OR AS A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THEN I JUST WANT BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY TAKE THE ONE MENTIONED
THAT THE SECOND PART.
IN THE WILL TAKE THE THOSE ITEMS
INDIVIDUALLY THE SECOND PART
WILL COVER THE PART OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES DEPARTMENT AGING
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES.
THE FARM DEVELOP THE SERVICES IN
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS --
WE ARE ALSO GOING TO TAKE UP
SOME OF THOSE ITEMS AS WELL --
THIS.
SOON THAT WE HAVE A THE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE AND WE
BEACH THOSE ITEMS AS WELL AS SO
WE MAY VOTE ON MANY OF THOSE
ITEMS AS WELL -- THE STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS WE WILL BE PUTTING --
ON ON CALL YEAH.
THE HOLDING OPEN SORRY KEEP
THINKING ABOUT THE FLOOR SANTA
CALLS ON CALLS ON OF THE HOLDING
THEM OPEN -- SO WE WILL
GENERALLY BE TAKING -- PUBLIC
COMMENT.
WHEN WE GET TO DISCUSSION ITEMS
AT THE END OF EACH -- DEPARTMENT --
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH SO --
WITH THAT I ALSO WANT TO MENTION
THAT TO I APPRECIATE THAT --
EARLIER THIS MORNING -- THE
GOVERNOR IS PUT OUT HIS -- MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL AND OF COURSE
WE CERTAINLY HAVE TREMENDOUS
RESPECT FOR THE GOVERNOR BUT IT
IS THE JOB OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
COMPOSE THE BUDGET SO -- WE'VE
CERTAINLY -- ALWAYS WELCOMED AND
PART OF THE GOVERNOR APPRECIATES
HIS PROPOSAL THAT WE WILL BE THE
ONES CRAFTING THE BUDGET HERE --
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD HERE SO WITH
THAT -- LET'S GO AHEAD AND FIRST.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR TO CONSENT CALENDAR AND
HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER STONE --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI.
AUTO RESEARCHER A YES YOU TAKE
ROLE FIRST OF THAT'S TRUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET'S FIRST
ESTABLISH QUORUM THAT'S TRUE
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T AND TO VOTE
OKAY SO.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR CORPUS CORN [inaudible]
RICARDO [inaudible]
STONE.
ALL RIGHT THEN I ASSUME THAT THE
NOW THAT WAS SAVAGE FORM YOU ARE
MOVING THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T TAKE A MOTION
INTO THE SET THE MOTION UNTIL
THEN SO IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STONE.
CIRCLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
HI HELLO.
STONE.
EXCELLENT OKAY SO NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT ISSUE NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS THE SNIFFS DISCLOSURE
INTEREST IN BUSINESS PROVIDING
SERVICES IN THE NATION. EIGHTY
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE SIDE.
MOTION SIR MOTION.
OKAY THANK YOU THE MOVE BY
CENTER TADO -- CIGARETTE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THIS ITEM.
I AUTO.
STONE NO [inaudible]
OKAY. NINE NEXT ITEM IS
DEPARTMENT MANAGED HEALTHCARE AT
ISSUE NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH
CARE SERVICES PLANNED MERGERS
AND ACQUISITIONS IMPLANTATION AB.
FIVE NINETY FIVE IS THERE A
MOTION. TO MOVE AYE SIR TADO
ETCETERA PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALL RIGHT OUR DAUGHTER.
STONE NEW.
THANKS ITEM IS THE PARMA SOCIAL
SERVICES ISSUE NUMBER -- THREE
SO THAT IS THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ON THE CALIFORNIA NEW
COMER EDUCATION WELL BEING
PROJECT IS THERE A MOTION.
THE MOVE BY CENTER TADO SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I DON'T KNOW.
STONE.
OKAY.
AND FINALLY IF THE ISSUE UNDER
THE FARM SOCIAL SERVICES ISSUE
NUMBER SIX TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ON THE WORK CONSENT OF
NUTRITIONAL SUPPLEMENTS -- WINS
TWO PARENT POPULATION -- MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER TADO --
SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI TOTAL.
STONE.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO ACTUALLY GETTING
CALL OUT ALL THE OUTS IN ITSELF
OKAY SO FOR OFFICES STATEWIDE
PLAN IS A FOR THE CONSENT COUNT
OF COURSE WAS -- THREE ZERO
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT THAT'S
OUT. TWO ONE ON DEPARTMENTS
HEALTH CARE ISSUE NUMBER THREE
THAT WAS OUT.
TO ONE FARMER SO SHE'LL SERVICES
ISSUES NUMBER THREE THAT WAS OUT
TWO ZERO AND DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES ISSUE NUMBER SIX THAT'S
OUT.
TWO ONE AND WE WILL GET BACK
INTO A RHYTHM OF THINGS THAT.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS
TODAY OKAY EXCELLENT RIGHT SO
NOW WE CAN MOVE ON TO OUR ITEMS
FOR DISCUSSION OUR FIRST ISSUE
IS UNDER DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES -- CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S SRVICES.
CAN BRING UP -- THANKS FOR THAT.
THE GULF OF ALL RIGHT.
I'M HERE. TO IRATE [inaudible]
SO THIS.
ALL RIGHT SO THIS IS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE WHOLE
CHILD MODEL.
SAW FIRST HAVE THE AGENCY
PRESENTED WITH AN UPDATE AND WE
HAVE A PANEL.
XIN PANELS WELL -- ALL RIGHT.
SO FOR THE RECORD AS IT WAS
COMING UP CAN EVERYONE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES.
AND WELCOME.
RICHARD FEIGEN FOR CAN'T
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THANK YOU.
HI MY OFTEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY ALTMAN CO HEALTH PLAN
CEMETERY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
COALITION THANK YOU.
I AM ALLEY BERKELEY OUTREACH
EDUCATION MANAGER FOR THE WHOLE
CHILD MODEL PROJECT AT FAMILY
VOICES OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
YES NEAR I MEAN THE WHOLE CHILD
MODEL INTO AND THE COUNTY
ORGANIZED HEALTH SYSTEMS --
STARTING WITH -- PILOTS THAT
ROLLED IN ON JULY FIRST I'M
HEALTH CLINICS IMITATE HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN THE LONGEST
RUNNING FOR SEVERAL YEARS -- AND
THEN WE ADDED THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR HEALTH
WHICH IS SANTA CRUZ MONTEREY
MERCED COUNTY.
AND SEND CAL HEALTH -- SAN LUIS
OBISPO AND SANTA BARBARA -- BACK
LAST JULY -- ON JANUARY FIRST WE
IMPLEMENTED -- THAT COUNTIES AND
PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN SERVICE
AREA WHICH ARE DEL NORD HUMBOLDT.
LAKE LASSEN MORAN MENDOCINO
MODOC NAPA SHASTA SISKIYOU
SOLANO CINEMA TRINITY IN YELLOW.
AND THEN LASTLY -- ORANGE COUNTY
HAD BEEN SLATED TO GO LIVE ON
JANUARY FIRST WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS AROUND SOME OF THEIR
PROVIDER.
NETWORK -- CAPACITY ANDSO WE
RESCHEDULED THEM AND PUSH THEM
TO JULY FIRST WE HAVE SENSE --
UNDERGONE A LITTLE BIT MORE AND
ANALYSIS OF THEIR NETWORK AND
THEIR VARIOUS DELEGATED MODELS
AND THEY WILL BE GOING.
LIVE JULY FIRST THE NOTICES OF
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF GOING OUT
TO BENEFICIARIES IN THAT AREA --
WHEN WE DID THE HEALTH PLAN
READY NESTS FOR THE COUNTY
ORGANIZED HEALTH SYSTEMS --
PRIOR TO HAVING CHILDREN BE
ENROLLED -- FOR THE FULL SCOPE
OF SERVICES NOT ONLY FOR CCS
SERVICES BUT ALSO FOR THEIR
OTHER.
CARE NEEDS -- WE DID A PRETTY
THOROUGH JOB IN TERMS OF
SUBMISSION OF DELIVERABLES FROM
THE PLANS -- THIS WAS NOT ONLY
FOR NETWORKS BUT ALSO FOR
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THERE
WERE A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX DELIVERABLES THAT WE
REVIEWED AND APPROVED THROUGHOUT
THE PHASES OF THE IMPLEMENTATION --
THERE HAVE BEEN REVISED
MEMORANDUMS OF UNDERSTANDING
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE BETWEEN THE
PLANTS IN THE COUNTIES -- AND
THEN WE HAVE -- MADE PLANS GO
BACK AND CHANGE SOME OF THEIR
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE TO
BETTER REFLECT SOME OF THE NEEDS
AND THE UNIQUE FEATURES OF
HAVING THIS POPULATION ENROLLED
IN THE PLAN -- WHEN WE DID THE
NETWORK ADEQUACY -- THE PLANS
HAD TO MEET THE SAME NETWORK
ADEQUACY AND CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS -- AND HAD TO SHOW
THAT THEY HAVE CCS PANEL
PROVIDERS WITHIN THAT NETWORK --
THOSE WERE ALL CERTIFIED BACK IN
JULY -- FOR ORANGE COUNTY WE NOT
ONLY -- CERTIFIED THEIR NETWORK
AS A PLAN BUT WE ALSO -- LOOKED
AT THEIR THIRTEEN DELEGATED
THIRTEEN DELEGATED -- MODEL
NETWORKS AND HELP THEM TO THE
SAME CRITERIA AND CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS AND SO THAT WAS
WHAT MADE US.
FEEL -- FAMILIAR ARE FAMILIAR TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE GOING FORWARD
WITH THE JULY ONE DATE WITH
ORANGE COUNTY BECAUSE OF KIND OF
THE DIFFERENT -- ISSUES THAT
THEY HAVE IS A PLAN -- WE HAVE
DONE CONTRACT AMENDMENTS --
RATES HAVE BEEN DONE -- WITH THE
PLANS -- THOSE ARE PENDING --
CMS APPROVAL WE HAVE DONE --
ELEVEN FIFTEEN TECHNICAL WAIVER
AMENDMENTS TO REFLECT THE
PROGRAM AND THE COUNTIES IN
WHICH THE WHOLE TOP MODEL IS.
IS LIVE -- SINCE ORANGE COUNTY
IS THE LAST COUNTY THAT IS GOING
LIFE ON JULY FIRST -- WE HAVE
APPROVED A THIRTY DAY CALL
CAMPAIGN -- FOR THE PLAN TO BE
REACHING OUT TO BENEFICIARIES
AND FAMILIES STARTING BETWEEN
MAY TENTH AND MAY THIRTY FIRST --
BUT THE NINETY AND SIXTY DAY
NOTICES HAVE ALREADY BEEN MAILED --
AS YOU NOTED THE AGENDA -- WE
ARE GOING TO BE CONTRACTING WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO TO CONDUCT AN
EVALUATION -- IT'S SLATED TO
START -- IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND
HAS A DUE DATE OF JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE HAD SHARED
THIS EVALUATION PLAN WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS WE HAD DISCUSSED IT
AT THE CCS ADVISORY GROUP WHICH
WAS LAST MONTH -- AND WE HAVE
RECEIVED FEEDBACK FROM A VARIETY
AS INDIVIDUALS AND SO WE'RE
CONSOLIDATING AND REVIEWING THAT
NOW -- WE HAD A WRONG DEADLINE --
WHEN WE SHARED THE EVALUATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS -- LAST MONTH
AT THE CCS ADVISORY GROUP SO WE
HAVE REFLECTED THAT THE MODEL OR
THE EVALUATION WILL BE DONE
THREE YEARS FROM THE DATE IN
WHICH EVERYTHING IS FULLY UP OF
OPERATIONAL SO THAT AGAIN IS
JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
I THINK THAT -- SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WE RECEIVED ROM
STAKEHOLDERS -- REFLECTED IN
INTEREST IN HAVING ADDITIONAL --
ITEMS SUCH AS DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT PHARMACY HOME HEALTH
SERVICES -- SO WE'RE LOOKING TO
TALK WITH YOU CASF ABOUT THE
INCLUSION OF THOSE -- SPEAKING
TO CASE MANAGEMENT I KNOW THAT
THERE IS AN INDICATION AND THE
AGENDA THAT THERE WERE CONCERNS
RAISED TO THE COMMITTEE AROUND
BOTH CASE MANAGEMENT --
TRANSPORTATION ELIGIBILITY AND
WE HAVE TO JUST BE HONEST IS
THAT THE FIRST TIME WE HEARD IT
SO I'M YOUR AGENT WAS THE FIRST
TIME THAT THAT'S BEEN RAISED TO
US SO.
WE'RE HAPPY TO HEAR FROM THE
PANEL TODAY WHAT THOSE CONCERNS
ARE BUT LIKE I SAID WHEN WE HAD
A CCS ADVISORY GROUP MEETING --
LAST MONTH THOSE WERE NOT --
RAISED HIS ITEMS BUT CERTAINLY
WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CONCERNS ARE -- AROUND
ELIGIBILITY LAPSES -- SO
CHILDREN IN CCS HAVE BOTH
MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY THAT IS DONE
BY THE COUNTY AND THE COUNTY
RETAINS THAT MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION AND AND SOME OF
THE REASONS FOR THAT -- FOR US
IS THE PLANS ARE PAID A
DIFFERENT RATE -- FOR CCS
ELIGIBLE CHILD BASED ON THEIR
CCS SELLABLE CONDITION AND WE
WANTED THE COUNTY SO KIND OF
RETAIN THAT -- SAFETY MECHANISM
IF YOU WILL I'M JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT SOMEONE WAS CONFIRMING
THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAD A CCS
CONDITION WHICH MADE THEM INTO A
DIFFERENT RATE STRUCTURE -- I
KNOW THAT -- THERE'S ALSO MEDI
CAL ELIGIBILITY SO FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE CHILDREN THAT
ARE IN.
CCS ALSO HAVE MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY YOU HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT ELIGIBILITY IS BEING
DONE AND SO BOTH OF THOSE -- ARE
AT THE AT THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE COUNTIES AND SO UNLESS OF
COURSE THEY'RE DEPENDENT COUNTY --
BUT THAT'S A SMALL POPULATION OF
COUNTIES THAT WE DO THE MEDICAL
DETERMINATIONS FOR SO -- IF IT'S
A MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY ISSUE
OBVIOUSLY MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY
CONTINUES TO BE HANDLED BY THE
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT.
IF IT'S A MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY
NOT MEDI CAL BUT MEDICAL
ELIGIBILITY ALSO STILL RETAINED
BY THE BY THE COUNTY MEDICAL
DIRECTOR IN THE CCS PROGRAM --
TRANSPORTATION -- HAS BEEN A
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR US --
WE DIRECTED THE PLANS -- LAST
YEAR TWO YEARS TIME FLIES -- TWO
YEARS AGO -- THAT THEY HAD TO
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION TO THEIR
ENROLLED BENEFICIARIES
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
SERVICE THAT THEY WERE RECEIVING.
WAS WITHIN THE PLANTS FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY SO IN SOME CASES
IF A HEALTH PLAN A CEMETERY --
MEMBER IS NEEDING TRANSPORTATION
TO A DENTAL APPOINTMENT EVEN
THOUGH SAN MATTEO IS NOT
RESPONSIBLE -- ARE AUTHORIZING
THE DENTAL APPOINTMENT THEY DO
RETAIN RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT APPOINTMENT.
AND THAT HAS BEEN -- AS WE HAVE
HEARD -- BOTH THE RAPIDLY
INCREASING AND A WELL USED
BENEFIT AND I THINK IT SPEAKS TO
THE IMPORTANCE AND UNDERSERVED
ME THAT BENEFICIARIES WERE
HAVING DIFFICULTY AND GETTING --
TRANSPORTATION AND RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION TO APPOINTMENTS
AND SO THAT IS CERTAINLY
CONTINGENT -- YOU KNOW ON MAKING
SURE THAT CCS CHILDREN IN THE
WHOLE CHILD MODEL ARE ALSO AND
THEIR FAMILIES ARE GETTING
TRANSPORTATION APPROPRIATELY SO
TO THE APPOINTMENTS THAT THEY
NEED FOR CCS RELATED SERVICES --
WITH THAT I AM HAPPY -- TO STOP
AND AND EITHER TAKE QUESTIONS
ARE REACT ONCE THE PANELISTS IS
DONE WITH THEIR COMMENTS.
OKAY SO I THINK WE'LL DO IS
WE'LL DO THE PANEL NO OF LA --
COMMENT FINANCE AND THEN WE'LL
TAKE QUESTIONS SO -- WE WON'T BE
A MOVE ON TO SOLD IN.
THANK YOU AND SO I'M GONNA I
KNOW YOU SEE OF THE AGENCY MORE
TIME BUT WE CAN TRY TO KEEP YOUR
REMARKS TO THREE MINUTES
APPRECIATED.
I'LL TRY -- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO A TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY -- AS JENNIFER SAID WE ARE
THE LONGEST WE'VE HAD THE WHOLE
CHILD MODEL FOR SOME TIME -- I'M
HERE BECAUSE IN MY COLLEAGUES
COULD MAKE IT THIS MORNING SO I
DID TALK TO ALL OF THEM AND
COLLECTED SOME INFORMATION FROM
THEM AND HOW THE IMPLEMENTATION
IS GOING.
I DO WANT TO JUST SAY THAT YOU
KNOW REMIND EVERYBODY UP.
YOU KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
WHY WE WHY LEAST WHY THE HELL
PLANET SAN MATTEO WAS REALLY
INTERESTED IN THOSE MODELS
BECAUSE BEFORE.
YOU KNOW THEY WERE SILENT CCS
SERVICES AND SILENT PLAN
SERVICES AND WE FOUND THAT
PEOPLE WERE CONFUSED -- WE DID
FOCUS GROUPS BEFORE WE STARTED
AND PEOPLE TO KNOW WHO TO CALL.
AND THEY ALSO -- THEIR PROBLEMS
AT THE CCS NURSES COULDN'T
REALLY ADDRESS SO LIKE A LOT OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT CAME UP FOR
WITH PHARMACY IN RESPONSE THE
PHARMACY.
SO -- WE WE REALLY WANTED TO
HAVE A HOLISTIC APPROACH WITH
CARE COORDINATION AUTHORIZATIONS --
PHARMACY ALL THE SERVICES
TOGETHER AND WE THINK IT LEADS
TO A BETTER EXPERIENCE FOR THE
CCS BENEFICIARIES.
ARM.
SO SOME JUST A REAL QUICKLY A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES OF LOCAL
PROBLEMS WERE ABLE TO SOLVE
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE CCS UNDER
OUR UMBRELLA -- I MENTION
PHARMACY SO ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS WE DID WAS WE SET UP A
SPECIALIZED CCS FORMULA.
SO THAT THE POLICY HAS MEMBERS
DIDN'T HAVE TO GO TO PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS THAT MANY AYBE
THE GENERAL MEDI CAL POPULATION
OUSTED.
THIS IS BEFORE BEFORE THE STATE
RAISE THE RATES FOR HOME HEALTH
ON FOR A PARTICULAR TWENTY FOUR
HOUR.
DUTY NURSING WE RAISE THE RATES
FOR FOR SOME PROVIDERS IN
EXCHANGE FOR THEM DOING A MUCH
BETTER JOB SO THEY HAVE TO DO A
GOOD QUALITY JOBS TO GET THOSE
HIGHER RATES.
FARM SOON RESPONSE TO SOME OF
THE OTHER QUESTIONS THAT CAME UP.
SO IN CASE MANAGEMENT ARM ALL
THE PLANS REPORTED THAT THEY DO
CASE MANAGEMENT DIRECTLY.
THE OUT REACH -- ON POINT IN
ROMAN ON THE CCS INDIVIDUAL
ORDERED WHAT PANI TRANSITION AND
THROUGHOUT -- THE TIMES THE CCS
INDIVIDUAL INC AND THEY JUST
STARTED THEY DO FOCUS ON THE
HIGHER RISK MEMBERS.
THE PLAN STAFF TO DELIVER THOSE
SERVICES INCLUDE NURSES SOCIAL
WORKERS MOM LICENSE CARE
COORDINATION STAFF.
WHO THAT DELIVERS THE SERVICE
OFTEN DEPENDS ON THE MEDICAL
ACUITY OR COMPLEXITY AND THE
ISSUES IDENTIFIED SO FOR EXAMPLE
SOCIAL WORKERS WILL DEAL WITH
THE -- SUCH.
A LOT OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE
PSYCHOSOCIAL ISSUES THAT HAVE TO
BE DEALT WITH.
ON THEY ALSO REPORTED THAT THEY
WORK IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE P.
C. P. M. SPECIALISTS TO ENSURE
THE CCS CONDITION ISN'T THE
NEEDS ARE MET AS WELL AS ALL
PREVENTIVE.
AND PRIMARY CARE SERVICES.
AS FAR AS LAPSES IN MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY -- THE DIRECTOR
EXPLAINED WELL THE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF ELIGIBILITY I JUST WANT
TO COMMENT THE PLANS OF A REALLY
STRONG INCENTIVE TO KEEP PEOPLE
MEDI CAL WE DON'T GET PAID WE
CAN YOU KNOW PROVIDE SERVICES.
SO WE ALL DO OUR REGION SUPPORT
TO ASSIST MEMBERS WITH PAPERWORK
IN ELIGIBILITY WE COORDINATE
WITH THE COUNTY CCS OFFICES AND
THE COUNTY MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY
OFFICES.
AND WE FRANK WE HAVE BIG
CHALLENGES HERE ALL BECAUSE THE
CCS STAFF HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MEDS -- OF WHICH IS THAT YOU
KNOW THE SYSTEM THAT IS THE
SYSTEM OF RECORD OF ELIGIBILITY.
AND SO THEY KNOW WHEN SOMEBODY'S
RE DISCRIMINATION IS COMING UP
WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS IS PLANTS
AND SO WE DO DEPEND ON THEM TO
GIVE US A HEADS UP BUT WE WILL
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO TO KEEP
SOMEONE ON MEDI CAL.
BOMB AS FAR AS THE MAINTENANCE
AND TRANSPORTATION BENEFITS ALL
THE PLANS REPORT THEY PROVIDE
THE CCS MAINTENANCE AND
TRANSPORTATION BENEFITS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE CCS NUMBER
LETTER.
LETTING YOU REIMBURSEMENT
LODGING PARKING MILEAGE
REIMBURSEMENT BUT IS ON THE
DIRECTOR MENTIONED WE ALSO
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION BENEFITS
ANYWAY UNDER MEDI CAL SO AT THE
HEALTH PLAN WE PROVIDE
WHATEVER'S THE MOST GENEROUS TO
RECEIVE EASIEST FOR THE FOR THE
MEMBER TO USE -- I WON'T GET
INTO THE EVALUATION TOO MUCH I
THINK WE GENERALLY SUPPORT
EVALUATION THAT'S IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF SB --
EIGHT FIFTY SIX WE CAN CERTAINLY
SUBMIT IN WRITING IDEAS ABOUT
METRICS I JUST DO WANT TO SAY
THAT -- THE THE UCS THE CASF
TEAM DID THE CCLI AND CAL MANY
CONNECT VALUATION DID A GREAT
JOB THE TELEPHONE SURVEY DATA IS
VERY RICH AND PROVIDED A WEALTH
OF INFORMATION.
AND FINALLY YOU KNOW IT'S EARLY
IN THE PROCESS REALLY WANTING
COURAGE THE DIRECT AND LOCAL.
ON COMMUNICATIONS THAT'S HOW
WE'RE GONNA SOLVE PROBLEMS IS A
LOT OF PEOPLE GO THROUGH
RIGOROUS AN APPEALS PROCESS OR
TELL US -- WE WILL WE WE WE ARE
EAGER TO SOLVE THE ISSUES AND
START THE SHOES AND WORK THROUGH
THEM.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WE HAVE -- MAYOR OF
MORTON.
HOSPITALS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR INTEREST IN
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY SIX AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
CCHA HAS PARTICIPATED IN
QUARTERLY MEETINGS WITH THE
STATEMENT STATEWIDE CCS ADVISORY
COUNCIL INITIAL STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS OF MOST OF THE COUNTY
ORGANIZED HEALTH SYSTEMS OR
COAST.
AND REGULAR MEETINGS WITH THE
CHILDREN'S REGIONAL INTEGRATED
SERVICE SYSTEM OR CHRIS A GROUP
OF PARENTS PROVIDERS AND COUNTY
CCS STAFF FROM TWENTY EIGHT
NORTHERN COUNTIES.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
INCREDIBLY HARD WORK THE
DEPARTMENT THE KOS PROVIDERS
FAMILIES AND OUR FELLOW
ADVOCATES A PUT IN DURING THESE
MEETINGS AND ESPECIALLY IN
BETWEEN THEM TO ENSURE THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM
PROGRAM GOES SMOOTHLY -- TO
SEVERAL DELAYS TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM
WHICH WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT
THE DEPARTMENT I WAS REALLY
MAKING SURE THE COUNTIES WERE
READY BEFORE THEY WERE ALL THAT
OUT BUT DUE TO IMPLEMENTATION.
WERE ONLY JUST STARTING TO GET A
SENSE OF HOW THINGS ARE GOING IN
PHASE ONE COUNTIES AND EVEN LESS
SO IN PHASE TWO COUNTIES -- AND
SO WE ANTICIPATE THAT SOME NEW
ISSUES COULD ARISE ONCE THE
CONTINUITY OF CARE PROVISIONS
LAPSE WHICH WILL ONLY START TO
HAPPEN THIS SUMMER AND PHASE ONE
COUNTIES AND SEVEN MONTHS AFTER
THAT FOR FACE -- TO WITH BUT
WITH ALL OF THAT IN MY AND I'M
JUST LIKE TO LEAVE THE COMMITTEE
WITH THE THE FOLLOWING POINTS
AND AGAIN THIS IS BASED ON
ANECDOTAL STORIES -- AND ME TO
TALK ABOUT THE EVALUATION OF THE
END BUT THAT TO US IS WHY THE
EVALUATION IS SO IMPORTANT
THAT'S ALL WE'RE EVER GOING TO
GET AND WE WNT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE REALLY KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING -- AS WE MOVE FORWARD
BEFORE WE EXPAND THIS OUT TO
OTHER COUNTIES.
SO A FIRST WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS BUT WE'VE HEARD THAT AT
LEAST ONE OF THE CO IS MAYBE
DELEGATING ITS RESPONSIBILITY
FOR CASE MANAGEMENT AND
TREATMENT AUTHORIZATIONS TO
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS.
WHICH WE DO NOT BELIEVE IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF SB
FIVE EIGHTY SIX WE HAVEN'T YET
HAD THAT CONVERSATION WITH THE
CLOTHES WE WILL BE DOING THAT --
AS A RESULT OF THIS PROCESS BUT
WANTED TO FLAG THAT.
SECOND WE HAVE HEARD THAT SOME
COUNTY CCS OFFICES MAY BE HAVING
TROUBLE GETTING THE
DOCUMENTATION THEY NEED FROM THE
COAST TO DETERMINE MEDICAL
ELIGIBILITY FOR CCS WHICH THEY
HAVE TO DO PERIODICALLY -- AT
STILL THEIR RESPONSIBILITY EVEN
IN WHOLE CHILD MODEL COUNTIES
AND THIRD THERE MAY BE SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR CCS
FAMILIES DUE TO LOT THE LOSS OF
THE UNOFFICIAL SOCIAL WORK
FUNCTION THAT THE CCS A CASE
WORKER SOUTH.
PERFORMED ONE EXAMPLE OF THIS
INVOLVES WHEN A CHILD MEDI CAL
LAPSES SOMETIMES BECAUSE OF
PAPERWORK ISSUE.
AND THEY HAVE TO BE RE ENROLLED
AND COUNTY CCS APAS TYPICALLY
HELP FAMILIES DO THIS I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD FROM ADULT MEN THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF
THE CLOTHES ARE DOING BUT WE'RE
NOT NECESSARILY HEARING IT'S
HAPPENING UNIVERSALLY -- AND
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF HAND
HOLDING THAT WE'RE STILL KIND OF
TROUBLE SHOOTING -- WITH THE
COSTA WANTED TO FLY ABOUT.
LEADING UP TO THIS HEARING WE
DID START SOME INITIAL OUT REACH
TO THE CLOSE ABOUT THESE
CONCERNS WHICH REALLY WERE JUST
STARTING TO AGGREGATE AGAIN WERE
NOT EVEN A FULL YEAR INTO
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM TO RESOLVE
THESE AND WE'RE HEARING A LOT OF
STORIES ABOUT HOW PROVIDERS AND
MEMBERS AND FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
GETTING A LOT OF THEIR PROBLEMS
ADDRESSED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SO
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO HEAR THAT
WE THINK THAT'S HOW THIS.
REALLY SHOULD BE HANDLED.
SO FINALLY I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT A CONCERN WITH THE
WHOLE TOP MODEL EVALUATION I WAS
VERY HAPPY TO HEAR FROM THE
DIRECTOR THAT THE DEADLINE HAS
BEEN MOVED OUT WE'RE NOT THAT.
WAS A CONCERN IT SOUNDS LIKE
IT'S BEEN ADDRESSED -- IN
ADDITION WE DID PROVIDE COMMENTS
TO THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT THE
DRAFT SCOPE OF WORK THAT THEY
RELEASED AT THE LAST US CCS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE MEETING.
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS THE
DRAFT THAT WE SAW REFLECTS THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE SB SB FIVE
EIGHTY SIX FOR THE EVALUATION.
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS IN THE STATUTE ARE
DRESSED ONLY SPARINGLY IN THE
SCOPE OF WORK AND OTHERS NOT AT
ALL -- AND THE SCOPE OF WORK IS
OVERLY DEPENDENT UPON THE USE OF
SURVEY DATA -- SURVEY
INSTRUMENTS OF UNKNOWN VALIDITY
TO MEASURE ASPECTS OF THE WHOLE
TOP MODEL IMPLEMENTATION LIKE
UTILIZATION ACCESS ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND WE THINK THOSE
COULD BE BETTER MEASURED.
BY CLAIMS DATA AND COUNTER DATA
AND EVEN SUCH A CHART SAMPLING.
THIS EVALUATION IS INTENDED TO
ENSURE THE CHILDREN IN THIS
PROGRAM ARE GETTING THE CARE
THEY NEED BEFORE IT'S EXPANDED
TO NEW COUNTIES AND WE THINK
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE GET IT
RIGHT -- THAT WE WOULD URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER WHETHER
ADOPTING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
TO ENSURE THE VALUATION
ADDRESSES THE REQUIREMENTS AND
FINALLY TO SEX HAPPENS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT MISS
BERKELEY.
OBSERVERS THEY'RE JUST LIKE TO
SAY THAT WE AT FAMILY VOICES OF
CALIFORNIA REALLY HAPPY TO HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INPUT BASED ON WHAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING FROM CCS FAMILIES.
ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE DURING
THE TRANSITION TO THE WHOLE
CHILD MODEL IN VARIOUS PARTS OF
THE STATE.
FAMILY VOICES HAS BEEN INVOLVED
IN MAKING SURE THE FAMILY
PERSPECTIVE IS HEARD IN THE
COLLABORATIVE PROCESSES BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
FIVE SB.
FIVE EIGHTY SIX AND ONE OF OUR
CURRENT PROJECT IS A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO PROVIDE OUR
REGION EDUCATION.
IN THE FORM OF WORKSHOPS
WEBINARS RESOURCES AND PHONE AND
EMAIL SUPPORT TO FAMILIES AND
FAMILY CENTER STAFF AROUND THE
TRANSITION TO THE WHOLE CHILD
MODEL -- AND TO LISTEN TO THEIR
STORIES ABOUT THE LEAD UP TO YOU
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
NEW PROGRAM.
A MORE STREAMLINED SYSTEM OF
CARE FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH
SPECIAL HEALTHCARE NEEDS IS
NECESSARY FOR BOTH PATIENTS AND
PROVIDERS STATEWIDE.
AND MOMENTS LIKE THIS PROVIDED
CRUCIAL SETTING FOR US TO COME
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MODEL CREATED. TO REACH THAT
GOAL IS DESIGNED IN A FAMILY
CENTERED WAY -- WE'VE HEARD A
LOT FROM FAMILIES AND A FEW
PATTERNS HAVE EMERGED KEEPING IN
MIND THAT IT IS STILL EARLY ON
I'LL BEGIN BY SAYING THAT ONE OF
THE FIRST STEPS TO FAMILY
CENTEREDNESS IS GETTING
INFORMATION OUT IN AN ACCESSIBLE
WAY -- CURRENTLY THERE'S ROOM
FOR IMPROVEMENT AROUND HOW
FAMILIES LEARN ABOUT THE CHANGES
THAT HAVE COME OR ARE SEEM TO
COME WITH THE WHOLE CHILD MODEL.
FAMILIES WHO ARE CURRENTLY WELL
AWARE OF THE CHANGES ARE THE
SAME FAMILIES WHO ARE
HISTORICALLY ONE FORMED ABOUT
SYSTEMS NAVIGATION DUE TO THE
TIME RESOURCES.
LANGUAGE CAPACITY AMONG MANY
OTHER THINGS TO SEEK OUT AND
UTILIZE THAT INFORMATION.
I'M EVEN AFTER THE WRITTEN
NOTICES AND PHONE CALLS BY THE
DEPARTMENT IN PLANS -- AN OUT
REACH ME -- WORKSHOPS AND
MEETINGS BY THE PLANS. FOR
FAMILIES MANY FAMILIES AND
PROFESSIONALS WE'VE CONNECTED
WITH DURING OUR WORK ON THIS
PROJECT STILL DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THE WHOLE CHILD MODEL AND WHAT
IT MEANS FOR THEIR CHILDREN'S
CARE -- ANOTHER PATTERN THAT
WE'RE SEEING IS THAT A LOT OF
FAMILIES ARE REALLY FEELING THE
LOSS OF THE CARE COORDINATION
AND CASE MANAGEMENT OF THE NURSE
CASE MANAGER THEY WORKED WITH
THROUGH THE COUNTY PRIOR TO
IMPLEMENTATION.
WHEN CONNECTING WITH HEALTH
PLANS STUFF ABOUT THEIR CHILD
CARE MANY CARE GIVERS ARE GIVEN --
THE MEMBER SERVICES PHONE NUMBER
AND THOSE -- AND TOLD THAT THOSE
WHO STUFF THE PHONE LINES ARE
ABLE TO HELP AND ADDRESS
CONCERNS.
AND THE SPECIALIZED AND
PERSONALIZED CARE COORDINATION
OF THE MOST MEDICALLY COMPLEX
CHILDREN IN THE STATE IS ONE OF
THE MOST VALUABLE BENEFITS OF
THE CCS PROGRAM.
AND THEIR PLACEMENT OF THAT
BENEFIT BY THE PLANS JUST
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE COMPARABLE AS
IT CURRENTLY STANDS -- AS FAMILY
VOICES THE WORK WE'VE DONE
AROUND THESE ISSUES WAS
DEPENDENT ON THE COLLABORATION
AND COMMUNICATION AND TEAMWORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
THE HEALTH PLANS OTHER FAMILY
SUPPORT AGENCIES AND HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS AND COUNTLESS
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN INVOLVED
IN THIS TRANSITION SO I JUST
LIKE TO EXTEND A BIG THANK YOU
TO EVERYONE INCLUDED IN THAT
LIST -- AS WELL AS THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE HERE TODAY FOR PUTTING
IN THE WORK TO IMPROVE CCS FOR
OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU AND FINALLY A FISCALLY.
THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN SPECIALTY
CARE COALITION.
CSEC REPRESENTS OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED PEDIATRIC SUBSPECIALTY
PHYSICIAN STATEWIDE THE PROVIDE
LIFESAVING AND LIFE ENHANCING
CARE FOR CHILDREN ENROLLED IN
CCS.
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT LEGISLATURE AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATION SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX
THAT AUTHORIZED THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF WHOLE CHILD
MODEL INCLUDED BOTH PATIENT.
AND PROVIDER PROTECTIONS
INCLUDING MAINTENANCE OF CCS
STANDARDS COMPREHENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT BY QUALIFIED STAFF
CONTINUITY CONTINUITY OF CARE
PROTECTIONS AND A ROBUST
EVALUATION TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAM IS DELIVERING ON ITS
GOALS.
WE ARE NEARLY IN.
WE ARE NEARLY A YEAR END FOR
PHASE ONE IMPLEMENTATION AND SIX
MONTHS FOR FACE TO WITH FACE
THREE THE LARGEST COUNTY IN
TERMS OF CCS POPULATION
SCHEDULED FOR JULY FIRST.
WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS ON
BEHALF OF DH CS THE PLANS
PROVIDERS COUNTIES AND FAMILY
AND CHILDREN'S GROUPS TO ENSURE
THAT THE TRANSITION FOR EACH OF
THESE PHASES GO AS SMOOTH AS
POSSIBLE TO ENSURE NO HARM FOR
THESE MEDICALLY COMPLEX CHILDREN.
WITH RESPECT TO HOW
IMPLEMENTATION IS GOING I WILL
PREFACE IT BY SAYING IT IS STILL
VERY EARLY.
WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF FEEDBACK
FROM MEMBERSHIP HOWEVER ISSUES
MAY ARISE OVER TIME.
WE HAVE RECEIVED SOME POSITIVE
COMMENTS WORTH NOTING TODAY. TO
GREATER ADMINISTRATIVE
SIMPLICITY FOR AUTHORIZATIONS
AND BILLING WORKING WITH ONE
PAYER INSTEAD OF TWO ALSO AS
WELL.
AS WELL AS THE CARBON PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPAND OR
ENHANCE PROGRAM AND SERVICES SO
ONE EXAMPLE IS CAUGHT ITS
CHILDREN'S CENTER IS WORKING
WITHIN CAL HEALTH PLAN ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A COMPLEX HEALTH
CARE MEDICAL HOME MODEL.
WE HAVE ALSO RECEIVED SOME
ISOLATED CONCERNS AND ONE REGION
RELATED TO DELAYS IN
TRANSPORTATION FOR PATIENT AND
FAMILY IS WHICH CAUSE MISSED
APPOINTMENTS.
AND LIMITED ACCESS TO DM ME
WHICH IS -- REALLY A PROBLEM IN
MANY REGIONS STATE RIDE -- AS
WELL AS CONTRACTING WITH
SATELLITE HOSPITALS AND EVEN
SOME PROVIDERS HOWEVER THE
PLANTS HAVE MADE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT TO RECTIFY THESE ISSUES
AS THEY ARISE.
SOME PROBLEMS EARLY ON OR ARE TO
BE EXPECTED -- WITH THE HEALTH
CARE TRANSITION OF THIS
MAGNITUDE.
CSEC ALSO SUPPORTS THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE
EXPECTATIONS AND REQUIREMENTS AS
IT RELATES TO CASE MANAGEMENT
SHOULD BE COLLECTIVELY DISCUSSED
AND AGREED UPON.
SO THAT THERE IS CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE PLANS AND CCS
PROGRAMS.
I OFTEN THINK ABOUT THE FAMILY
CARE MAPS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED IN FORUMS SUCH AS
THESE FAMILIES ARE COMMONLY
NAVIGATING DOCTORS APPOINTMENTS
FROM NOT JUST ONE BUT MANY
SPECIALISTS.
AND NEED SUPPORT BEYOND THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AFFECTED CASE
MANAGEMENT WILL OFTEN RESULT IN
BETTER FAMILY EXPERIENCE BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND EVEN REDUCE
HEALTHCARE COSTS.
WHILE THE PRACTITIONER
EXPERIENCE IS IMPORTANT IT IS
THE FAMILY EXPERIENCE THAT IS
PARAMOUNT WHEN ASSESSING WHETHER
TO PULL CHILD MODEL IS
DELIVERING COORDINATED HIGH
QUALITY CARE.
I'M GLAD THAT FAMILY VOICES IS
HERE TODAY TO LEND THEIR
PERSPECTIVE OF THE FAMILIES.
WITHRESPECT TO THE EVALUATION
WE CAN MEND THE DEPARTMENT FOR
CONTRACTING WITH A REPUTABLE
UNIVERSITY TO CONDUCT THAT WE
AGREE THAT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THE VALUATION DESIGN MEETS THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LAW.
AND HOW OLD THEY WILL BE
MEASURED SHOULD BE CLEARLY LAID
OUT IN THE SCOPE OF WORK WITH
REALLY NO BIAS OVER ONE MODEL OR
THE OTHER.
THE METHODOLOGY SHOULD INCLUDE A
NUMBER OF METRICS THAT EXTEND
BEYOND TELEPHONIC SURVEYS.
AND IT IS APPROVED IN IT IN AN
YEAH AND IT IS PRUDENT TO KNOW
WHETHER PLANS OR HEARING TO THE
CCS AND STANDARDS INCLUDING
REFERRALS TO CCS PANEL PROVIDERS.
AS SPECIAL CARE CENTERS TO
MAINTAIN THE HIGHEST QUALITY OF
CARE FOR HIS TEETH MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN.
WE ALSO AGREED THAT A MINIMUM OF
TWO YEARS OF DATA FOR EACH
COUNTY SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN THE
EVALUATION DESIGN -- I'LL CLOSE
WITH THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THE COUNTY ORGANIZE
HEALTH PLANS THE LEGISLATURE
FAMILIES PROVIDERS.
AND THE COUNTIES AS WELL AS
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THE
BEST POSSIBLE CARE FOR THESE
CHILDREN.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMMENCEMENT LEO [inaudible]
FINANCE.
OKAY QUESTIONS ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OKAY BYE DID IF YOU DID HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS I WANT -- TO THE
SPACE ON THE FIRST OF ALL IT'S
ALWAYS HEARD IT THE NO THE LOSS
OF THE CARE COORDINATION.
CORD CARE CORNERED COUNTY IS THE
IS THE SELLER IS OF SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN AND I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
A CARE ACCORDING TO THE HEALTH
PLAN -- SO I GUESS ONE QUESTION
IS IS THAT -- YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT ISSUES ABOUT POTENTIAL
LAPSES -- YOU KNOW SOME OF THOSE
FATHER PEOPLE WORK ON TIME AND
SO FORTH.
IS THE CARE KOREAN THE HEALTH
PLAN TASKS WITH HELPING SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN ON CCS EVEN IF
THEY'RE NO LONGER AND ROLE THAT
HEALTH PLAN BECAUSE THERE'S
LAPSE OR SOME OTHER PROBLEM THAT
HAPPENED.
DOES IS THEY ARE THEY ARE THEY
ARE THEY GOING TO BE THERE.
BUT UNLIKE THE K. THIS THE
COUNTY COORDINATOR ISN'T TIED TO
WHETHER YOU'RE YOU KNOW I MEAN
IT'S SO I DO SOME WORRY ABOUT
THESE GAS OR SOMEONE'S AS O.
OKAY WELL YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
NOT IN OUR PLAN YOU KNOW YOU
SELL OFF WHATEVER AND NOW IT'S
NOT MY PROBLEM.
BECAUSE IT'S YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT
ROLLED CELLS ARE TIED TO THE
HEALTH PLAN I'D IT'S GOING TO BE
SURE THAT SO WHOSE.
THIRDS IS IS IS THAT POINT OF
CONTACT PERSON GOING TO ALWAYS
BE THERE FOR THEM.
SO ALL ALL STARTIN IN MY AND I
CAN TALK ABOUT LIKE ON THE
GROUND SO IT DEPENDS -- IF YOU
ARE A FAMILY WHOSE CHILD IS BOTH
CCS ELIGIBLE AND MEDICALLY
ELIGIBLE AND THEY'RE TIED
TOGETHER.
AND YOU ARE SENSE EITHER ONE
WHICH IS MEDICAL EIGIBILITY
RENEWAL OR MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY
RENEWAL AND YOU DO NOT RESPOND --
IT DEPENDS ON THE COUNTY IN
TERMS OF HOW LONG THEY TRIED TO
PURSUE THE FAMILY TO REDO THE
REDO TERMINATION IT'S AN ANNUAL
RE DETERMINATION.
AS A FAMILY DOESN'T RESPOND IN
THE AND THE PATIENT IS NO LONGER
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI CAL BECAUSE OF
THE FOR THEIR FAILURE TO RESPOND.
THEN THE PLAN WILL BE SHOWING
THEM AS A MEMBER ON THEIR NEXT
MONTHLY ENROLLMENT FILE BECAUSE
WE WOULD TERMINATE THEM FROM
COVERAGE.
IF THEY CALLED AND SAID HI.
I USED TO BE A MEMBER OR I
THOUGHT I WAS A MEMBER WHAT
HAPPENS THE CAMP THE COUNTY
HEALTH PLANS OFTEN AND OTHER
PLANS DO AS WELL WHICH IS YOUR
ELIGIBILITY IS NOT SHOWING AND
THEY WILL SEND THEM BACK TO THE
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT
WHICH IS.
THE APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR THEM
TO GET THEIR MEDICAID
ELIGIBILITY.
RE DETERMINED SO THEY CAN HELP
ON THAT BUT IN TERMS OF LIKE THE
CARE COORDINATION IF YOU'RE NOT
SHOWING MEDICAL.
OR MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY THE PLAN
CAN'T DO A WHOLE LOT BASICAYE
WELL I GUESS I GUESS THE THING
IS IS THAT WHAT I'M HEARING IS
AN AND THIS CAN GET PRETTY
COMPLICATED ALL RIGHT -- IS IS
THAT THE CARE COORDINATORS THE
CALCULUS OF ACTUALLY HELPING
FAMILIES KEEP ON TOP OF THESE
DEADLINES AND SO FORTH SO I I
UNDERSTAND THAT SOMEONE JUST
TOTALLY DOESN'T RESPOND AND THEY
COMPLETELY FALL OFF.
AND THEY CERTAINLY SHOW UP
THAT'S ONE THING BUT I KNOW IT'S
I'M THINKING YEAH BASICALLY I'M
EXPECTING THE SAME LEVEL SERVICE
THEY GOT BEFORE.
THAT THE EXPECTATION NUTS SAID
THAT THAT YOU KNOW AT LEAST
CLUES ON IS NOT ELIGIBLE WHO
WOULD HAVE BEEN HELPED AYE
COUNTY COORDINATOR.
BUT BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE THE
COORDINATOR TIED TO THE HEALTH
PLAN.
THIS CHANGING RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN WEATHER I WORK FOR THE
COUNTY -- WAS WORTH IT DOES THAT
CHANGE THE LEVEL OF SERVICE THAT
THE THAT THE FACING YET THAT THE
FAMILY WILL GET.
THAT'S WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ANSWER IS NO I MEAN THE CARE
OKAY SO THEIR EXPECTATION IS
THEY WILL HELP SOMEONE EVEN IF
IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE WE HELP
WITH THE PAPERWORK WE HELP WE DO
EVERYTHING OKAY.
SO IT'S NOT GOING TO BE TOLD
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT.
WE YOU KNOW I YOU ARE LATE AND
PIECE OF PAPER SO NO HELP WOULD
BE OUR MEMBER AS WELL.
BUT I MEAN THEY'RE NOT WE DON'T
GET SAYS IT ROMAN R. ALRIGHT
OKAY WELL ITSELF SO I SO THAT I
MEAN THAT'S AN ISSUE I I JUST
WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE GOT TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE MAKE THIS AS
SEAMLESS AS POSSIBLE AND CLEARLY
SO IS NOT.
ELIGIBLE I MEAN I GOT THAT BUT
OF LATE THEM I'M HEARING IS THAT
PEOPLE GAIN PING PONG AROUND
DIFFERENT OFFICES AND THAT'S
WHAT I HEAR I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN TELL ME THAT'S WHAT HEROES
FROM FAMILIES LIKE.
I HAVE YOU KNOW I'M ALWAYS BEING
PING PONG AROUND DIFFERENT
PEOPLE AND THAT'S REALLY THE
VALUE THAT THE AND I THINK WHEN
I HEAR LOTS OF CARE COORDINATION
PERHAPS THE PERSON FAMILY VOICES
CAN CLARIFY -- IS IS THAT WAY IT
IS IS SOMEONE WHO CAN ACTUALLY
HELP ME DO SAID I'M NOT LIKE
TOLD GO TO THIS PERSON CALL THAT
NUMBER IT'S CENTER AT LIKE NO I
WILL HELP YOU.
DO I SPEAK TO THE YEAH SURE --
SO.
WITH THE LOSS OF THE COUNTY IN
PLAYED NURSE CASE MANAGERS WERE
HEARING ABOUT -- FAMILIES MIGHT
CALL INTO THAT NUMBER SERVICES
NUMBER OR IN SOME CASES THEY DO
HAVE A DIRECT CONTACT WITH
SOMEBODY AT THE PLAN -- BUT
WE'RE HEARING THAT FAMILIES ARE.
GETTING DIRECTED TO YOU KNOW
DAHLE OTHER DEPARTMENTS OR JUST
GIVEN UP SEVERAL DIFFERENT.
NUMBERS TO CALL TO ADDRESS
DIFFERENT ISSUES SO -- ONE PHONE
CALL MIGHT HAVE HAPPENED
PREVIOUSLY BEFORE IMPLEMENTATION
AND NOW WE'RE HEARING THAT THAT
ONE PHONE CALL HAS TURNED INTO
MULTIPLE PHONE CALLS IN SOME
CASES.
OKAY SO HOPE WE CAN ADDRESS THAT
YEAH THERE YEAH I I SEE THAT'S
WHY I MEAN I WAS TEACHERS AND I
SEE TO CARRY AROUND THESE
BINDERS RIGHT [inaudible]
OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO KEEP TRACK OF FAMILY
IS OFTEN -- ACTING AS THE CARE
COORDINATOR IN THAT CASE --
SORRY OUT THOSE BINDERS ARE
REALLY REAL THING THEY'RE HAPPY
YEAH AND THEY'RE BIG RIGHT AND
THAT'S WHY I SAID WE TALK ABOUT
THE CARE MAPS SO SOUGHT S I
HOPE AND I HOPE THAT'S PART
EVALUATION TO THAT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT.
SO I THINK THAT COMING DEBTS --
THE OTHER.
IT I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO THE
EVALUATION -- HEY YEAH I PROCEED
THAT WE'RE DOING TELEPHONIC
SURVEYS AND THAT CERTAINLY GONNA
BE VERY VALUABLE I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO GET THE THE
THE EXPERIENCE FROM THE FAMILIES --
BUT I HEARD ALSO BROUGHT UP THAT --
I MEAN THERE'S OTHER SOURCES OF
DATA AS WELL -- RD SO WERE THAT
WAS MENTIONED SO WE LOOKING.
AND THEN ACTUALLY TELEPHONIC
SKINNER NAY REALIZED OR CERTAIN
EXPENSES INVOLVED BUT WELL IT
WAS LIKE CCS SEVEN CALL ONE
PROGRAM RATE THAT REALLY WE HAVE
KIND OF LIKE THREE GROUPS OF
PATIENTS.
IN THERE RIGHT SO YOU HAVE
THERE'S A GOOD CHUNK TO COME
THROUGH THE WHO ARE YOU. TO COME
TO THE NEXT YOU.
YOU HAVE -- CHILDREN WITH C. C.
L. WITH -- CCS CONDITIONS NUMBER
COM AND THAT'S WHY THEY'RE CCS
BUT THEY'RE PROBABLY A LITTLE
MORE -- COMMON AND THEN YOU HAVE
THE ONE WITH THE REALLY RARE
ONES RIGHT THERE WHERE IT'S KIND
OF FROM A MANAGED CARE POINT OUT
FROM A MANAGED CARE PLAN IF
YOU'RE CUTTING THEIR DOT LIARS I
MEAN THEY'RE NOT IT'S IT'S IT'S
YOU KNOW HOW TO BUILD A NETWORK
AROUND.
YEAH ONE OR TWO PATIENTS RATE
DEPENDING ON THE LUCK OF THE
DRAW HOW MANY YOU HAVE YOUR PLAN.
AND I HOPE THE VALUATION DOESN'T
LIKE JUST LUMP EVERYONE TOGETHER
AND AVERAGE IT ALL OUT.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT GONNA BE
REFLECTED WE NEED TO LOOK AT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT AT EACH OF THOSE
GROUPS AND PARTICULARLY THE OUT
LIARS I MEAN ANYWAY CCS IS A
PROGRAM FOR THE OUT LIARS THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE A SEPARATE PROGRAM.
WE DON'T JUST SAY HEY WHAT WE
THINK IT'S NOT A GOOD I JUST A
ROLL THEM ALL INTO JUST A
MANAGED CARE PLANS A WILL GUESS
WHAT YOU'RE ON YOUR YOUNG.
TO GET THAT THAT THAT THAT THE
RARE CONDITIONS AND ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE THE THE SUBGROUP THAT
HAVE THESE REALLY RARE
CONDITIONS.
YES EVEN THAT -- YOU YEAH THIS
TO BE A PROBABLY I'M LIKELY TO
HAVE PROVIDE YOU KNOW THE THE
SPECIALISTS EVEN IN YOUR
IMMEDIATE AREA MAYBE IF YOU HAVE
YOU KNOW REALLY BIG.
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL THAT WORK
BUT THOSE LIKELY IS AND WE NEED
WE SHOULD EVALUATION IS NOT JUST
AVERAGING EVERYONE OUT ACROSS
ALL THOSE PATIENTS RIGHT THEY
NEED TO BE LOOKED AT AS A
SEPARATE.
ENTITIES THOSE THAT HAPPENING
AND EVALUATION.
SO THE RESEARCHERS CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO A VARIETY OF DATA NOT
SINCE THE TELEPHONE SURVEYS I
DON'T HAVE A VALUATION IN FRONT
OF HUNDREDS OF PAGES BUT OF
COURSE WE WOULD MAKE
ADMINISTRATIVE DATA.
AVAILABLE TO THEM SO THEY CAN
LOOK AT IT FOR WHATEVER TRENDS
AND OUT LIARS AND OTHER THINGS
SO I DON'T.
AND WE WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THAT OKAY SO I MIGHT BE
SURE WERE.
NOW IT'S NOT COMING BACK AND
SAYING -- WE DEVELOP THE DESIGN
AND I THE AVERAGE CCS PATIENT
SOUNDING THERE SUCH THING AS AN
AVERAGE CCS PATIENT.
WE PUT THAT TOGETHER AND I
APPRECIATE WE'RE GOING ON EARLY
ON THAT'S ALL I EVER HEARD SELL
WILLARD AND ONE SISTER -- BUT I
ALSO HOPE THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED
TO HAVE A GOOD EVALUATION AND WE
SHOULD BE WAITING FOR THOSE
RESULTS TO COME BEFORE YOU MOVE
MORE VULNERABLE CHILDREN INTO A
SYSTEM THAT -- YOU KNOW MAYBE
COUNTY NOT YEAH I'D APPRECIATE
THAT ACTUALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
ONE CHALLENGES CCS HAS ALWAYS
BEEN IS THIRTY AT THE SEPARATE
PROGRAM LAYERED ON TOP OF SO HOW
WE BRING THIS TOGETHER BUT
THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS WE COULD
HAVE BROUGHT THOSE TOGETHER AND
I THINK THAT.
SO WE'RE TRYING ONE WAY BUT I
WANT TO BE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING INTO THAT -- WE WERE
DOWN TO GET THESE ARE KIDS WHO
ARE -- NOW THE MOST VULNERABLE
IS A REASON THAT PROVE THE
PROGRAMS OF CREATED.
THEM TELL ME DECADES AGO NOW.
A LONG TIME AGO SO [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT.
THIS ISSUE. NINETEEN WITH THE
WITH THE MICROPHONE.
SOMEWHERE SCUTTLED BECOMING
STV'S AND TRY TO KEEP REMARKS
TWO UNDER MINUTES AND OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE FREE TO SUBMIT MORE
WRITTEN MATERIAL AS WELL OKAY
WELCOME.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR PAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M LAURIE SO MEN AND I'M
DIRECTOR OF CHRIS THE CHILDREN'S
REGIONAL INTEGRATED SERVICE
SYSTEM THAT YOU HEARD REFERENCE
BY MIRA MORTON.
AS SHE SAID WE ARE A TWENTY
EIGHT COUNTY MULTI DISCIPLINARY
COLLABORATIVE THAT'S FOCUSED ON
TRYING TO BUILD A MORE EFFECTIVE
MORE EFFICIENT MORE FAMILY
CENTERED CCS PROGRAM IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AT LEAST.
AND I REPRESENT CHRIS ON THE
STATE'S CCS ADVISORY GROUP.
I WOULD SORT OF SPEAK FOR A
SECOND TO THE EVALUATION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF
THAT ROBUST EVALUATION AS YOU'VE
DISCUSSED.
AND WE ARE PROJECTING WANNA CALL
UP THREE ELEMENTS ALL THE
EVALUATION COMPONENTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED UNDER SB FIVE EIGHTY
SIX MUST BE ADDRESSED IN THAT
EVALUATION WE WANT TO SEE
METRICS THAT ARE SPECIFIC. TO
CCS CHILDREN AND THEIR
CONDITIONS AFTER THINK IS THE
POINT THE SENATOR WAS MAKING.
AND WE WANT A METHODOLOGY THAT
IS BROADER THAN TELEPHONE
SURVEYS AS VALUABLE AS THEY ARE
WE WE BELIEVE A LOT OF THESE
METRICS CAN ONLY BE IDENTIFIED
TO CHART REVIEWS.
WE HAVE PROVIDED WRITTEN
COMMENTS TO THE DEPARTMENT ON
THE EVALUATION I'VE MADE THOSE
AVAILABLE TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WE ALL WANT AND EFFECTIVE
QUALITY EVALUATION AS MANY OF
THESE CHILDREN ARE BEING MOVED
TO A BRAND NEW HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY MODEL.
OF AND SO WE THINK THAT THESE
POINTS ARE CRITICAL TO BUILDING
THAT EFFECTIVE EVALUATION AND OF
COURSE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
MAKE THAT EVALUATION HAPPEN.
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI KELLY HERTIE WITH
CHILDREN NOW -- I JUST WANT TO
THANK ADD THAT TO APARTMENT AND
ADVOCATES AND THE LEGISLATURE
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT'S GONE
INTO THE TRANSITION SO FAR.
AND UNDERSCORE THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES AROUND AND THE
NEED TO REALLY HAVE THE
EVALUATION AND HERE STRICTLY TO
WHAT WAS NEGOTIATED THROUGH SB.
FIVE EIGHTY SIX I'M WE KNOW THAT
SWEAT WHAT MEASURE WHAT IS
MEASURED MATTERS AND WE REALLY
NEED THE EVALUATION TO WEIGH
WHETHER THE WHOLE CHILD MODEL IS
BETTER FOR THESE KIDS AND
FAMILIES.
THAN THAN THE ALTERNATIVES THAT
THE UNDERLYING PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
BACK KNOW ERIC AIRS ON BEHALF
THE MARCH OF DIMES AND JUST WANT
TO ECHO MY **** THE COMMENTS OF
ALL MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SPOKEN
TODAY ALREADY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
I GUESS I JUST THOUGHT HEARD
MULTIPLE TIMES ABOUT TOUCH BEING
SURE WITH HERE TO THE REGIONAL.
LAW AND I THINK PEOPLE RAISE
CONCERNS THE VALUATION ISN'T
HITTING ALL THOSE ELEMENTS SO.
CAN YOU MAYBE TOUCH ON WHY
PEOPLE TELLING ME THIS. FIVE I
HONESTLY LIKE I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING -- E RECEIVE COMMENTS
FROM A LOT OF THE PEOPLE SITTING
THIS TABLE AS WELL AS THE PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM WERE LOOKING ADAM --
WE BELIEVE THAT WE ARE AT
HEARING TO THE STATUTE AND IN
SOME CASES THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED -- OR THE FIRST TIME
THAT WE HEARD THEM WAS IN YOUR
AGENDA.
SO WE'LL GO BACK AND WE'LL TAKE
A LOOK AND WE WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE AN EVALUATION THAT
WE ALL BELIEVE IS APPROPRIATE
AND ACCURATE.
OKAY -- OKAY WELL -- FIRST OF
ALL I I HOPE NO ONE SHY ABOUT
COMMUNITY ON THE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS -- TIME AT
THEM THE LITTLE BOTHERED THAT.
THE FIRST TIME YOU'VE HEARD WAS
THROUGH US -- SO I HOPE PEOPLE
ARE COMMUNICATING I WOULD AGREE
THAT THAT YEAH.
YEAH SO -- SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
FIGURE OUT WHY THAT IS HAPPENING
IN.
YES DO YOU WISH SPEAKER THAT I I
DO WANT TO ACTUALLY SPEAK TO
THAT SINCE COMING UP AND WE
ACTUALLY NOTHING THAT WE RAISED
WITH THE COMMITTEE IN THE LEAD
UP TO THE HEARING IS ANYTHING
THAT IT'S ALL BEEN SUBMITTED IN
WRITING.
NOT NECESSARILY DIRECTLY FROM
CCHA BUT IT'S THINGS THAT I
AGGREGATED THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED IN WRITING TO THE
ADVISORY COUNCIL.
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE I WILL
SAY THAT THERE WERE SOME THINGS
THAT GOT SUBMITTED I THINK
WITHIN A TEN DAY WINDOW OF THE
LAST MEETING WE WERE TOLD BY THE
DEPARTMENT THAT THAT WAS TOO
CLOSE TO THE MEETING AND WE HAVE
TO WAIT UNTIL THE NEXT MEETING
TO DISCUSS THEM.
BUT THERE'S NOTHING THAT HAS NOT
BEEN SUBMITTED THAT I RAISED
WITH THE COMMITTEE PRIOR TO THIS
MEETING SO.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL -- WILL
HOPEFULLY WE CAN CREATE SOME
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO
BE SURE THAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE
REYES AND CAN BE ADDRESSED AND
CERTAINLY WITH.
OBVIOUSLY -- SINCE THE ORIGINAL
FOSTER IS A BILL IN THE SENATE
WOULD BE VERY ONE BE SURE THAT
WE ARE COVERING ALL THE ELEMENTS
THAT WAS THE AGREEMENT AND I
KNOW THAT IS YOUR INTENT AS WELL
SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE AND THAT AND EVALUATION
FINAL EVALUATION.
BY FORTY ABOUT THE FINAL
EVALUATION PLAN THANK YOU.
OKAY ANYTHING ELSE RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE IT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THAT'S SOMETHING.
ALL RIGHT SO NEXT UP WE HAVE
DEPARTMENT AGING
[inaudible]
THE PEOPLE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
LET'S SEE HERE.
GOT A LOT OF PIECE OF PAPER.
THIS IS A CASE OF THIS IS ALL.
THIS IS THE THIRD ON OKAY CAN
ASK EVERYONE TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES THE RECORDS PLEASE
WE'LL START WITH THE AGENCY
PLEASE -- MARK BECKLEY ACTING
CHIEF HAPPY -- TO DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PART OF AGING
WELCOME HE THOMAS CAMERON DEPUTY
DIRECTORATE MINISTRATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING ELIA.
JACQUI BRAZIL ELIA.
GINNY BELLA LU FINANCE WHICH WAS
WROTE APARTMENT FINANCE I THANK
YOU THANKS FOR MUCH SO.
I DON'T SEE HIM FOR AGING HERE.
OKAY SO WE HAVE -- THREE ITEMS
AND THEN THE THEN WE APPROVALS
FOR INVESTMENTS THAT WILL GO
HEAD START WITH -- ISSUE NUMBER --
ONE SPRING FINANCE LETTER FOR
THE SS I CASH OUT REVERSAL
IMPLEMENTATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE I THINK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY AND TO PROVIDE YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF OUR SPRING FINANCE
LETTERS -- IS THE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME OR SSI CASH A
REVERSAL IMPLEMENTATION VIçT
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING --
REQUEST IS AN ADJUSTMENT TO
INCREASE THE DEPARTMENT'S
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY BY A ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS. TO
PROVIDE OUR REGION APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE VIA A LOCAL AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING TO SENIORS
RECEIVING SSI BENEFITS WHO MAY
BE NEWLY ELIGIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S BENEFITS.
THESE FUNDS ARE CURRENTLY
BUDGETED WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AND WILL BE
PASSED THROUGH TO THE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING VIA AN
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT.
THE STATE NETWORK OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING WILL PROVIDE
OUR REGION APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE FOR THE POPULATION OF
OLDER ADULT SSI S. S. P.
RECIPIENTS.
THAT ARE NOW NEWLY ELIGIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE TRIPLE
A.'S TO DEVELOP A METHODOLOGY TO
ALLOCATE THESE FUNDS TO EACH
AGENCY.
AND THE TROUBLE IS WILL BEGIN
OUR REGION ASSISTANCE ACTIVITIES
STARTING JULY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
BEFORE WE MOVE I THINK -- WILL
AVAIL COMMENTS.
FINANCE COMMENTS ACTUAL INDUCED
LET ME MOVE THROUGH THE THREE
AND THEN TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEN WE WILL ACTUALLY VOTE ON IT
S. LIKE SELF.
ALRIGHT SO THIS MOVE ON THEN TO
ISSUE NUMBER -- TWO FINANCE
LETTER.
THANK YOU THE SECOND ISSUE IS
SHE'D ALREADY.
OUR FEDERAL TITLE THREE FUNDING
AUGMENTATION REQUEST.
IN THIS REQUEST THE DEPARTMENT
IS ASKING FOR AN INCREASE IN
IT'S A FEDERAL TITLE THREE FUND
AUTHORITY.
OF SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
OF THIS AMOUNT SIXTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION IS FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE
AND EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINETY
SEVEN THOUSAND IS FOR STATE
OPERATIONS.
THIS FUNDING REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S PORTION OF
ADDITIONAL TITLE THREE GRANT
FUNDS INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FEDERAL BUDGET ACT.
THESE FUNDS WILL BE DISTRIBUTED
TO THE LOCAL AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING AND LOCAL OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAMS TO AUGMENT THEIR
CONGREGATE NUTRITION.
HOME DELIVERED MEALS SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES HEALTH PROMOTION CARE
GIVER SUPPORT.
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN FAMILY
CARE GIVER AND DISEASE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
WE SIXTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
LOCAL ASSISTANCE DOLLARS IS
DISTRIBUTED AMONG VARIOUS TITLE
THREE PROGRAMS ACCORDING TO A
FEDERAL FUNDING FORMULA.
CALLED THE INTERSTATE FUNDING
FORMULA AND WILL BE ALLOCATED TO
EACH PROGRAM AREA IN THE
FOLLOWING MANNER. NINE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS WILL GO TO
NUTRITION PROGRAMS COVERING BOTH
CONGREGATE AND HOME DELIVERED
MEALS. FOUR POINT SIX MILLION
FOR BEFORE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
THREE POINT ONE MILLION WILL BE
FOR FAMILY CAREGIVER SUPPORT.
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND FOUR DISEASE PREVENTION.
AND ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND FOR A BUT TO MEN
PROGRAMS.
THE STATE OPERATION PORTION OF
THIS REQUEST IS TO FIND SEVEN
POSITIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT. TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL OVERSIGHT AND
ADDITIONAL STATE SUPPORT TO THE
TITLE THREE GRANT PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU LA -- COMMENTS.
FINANCE QUESTION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OKAY.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE SPRING FINANCE LETTER
MEDICARE IMPROVEMENTS FOR
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS.
ACT AUTHORITY YES.
SO MEDICARE IMPROVEMENTS FOR
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS ACT WERE
MET BY EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE.
THE DEPARTMENT REQUESTS A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO AMEND
EXISTING PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO
ALLOW CDA OR THE DEPARTMENT
AGING UPON APPROVAL FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO
INCREASE ITS FEDERAL FUNDED
FORTY WHEN ADDITIONAL MIP OUT OR
MEDICARE IMPROVEMENTS FOR
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS ACT
CRAMPONS.
ARE WORDED TO THE STATE THIS
PROCESS WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO BRING THESE FUNDS
INTO ITS BUDGET WORK QUICKLY AND
DISTRIBUTE THE GRANT FUNDING TO
ITS LOCAL AREA AGENCY ON AGING
PARTNERS IN A MORE TIMELY MANNER.
THE MYTH THE GRANT IS USED TO
PROVIDE OUR REACH AN APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE VIA LOCAL TRIPOLI'S
TO SENIORS WHO MAY BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE LOW INCOME SUBSIDY.
AND THE MEDICARE SAVINGS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU HELLO.
FINANCE QUESTION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT OF ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE THREE SPRING
FINANCE LETTERS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THAT'S RIGHT [inaudible]
MORE.
THANK YOU WELCOME HELLO LISA
COLEMAN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
ADDITIONAL PERSON FOR THE STATE
OMBUDSMAN OFFICE.
THIS POSITION WILL BE FOCUSED ON
DOING TRAINING TO BETTER ASSIST
THE LOCAL PROGRAMS OF WEEK.
WE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU STRETCH OKAY
SEEN OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT -- IS
THERE A MOTION TO MOVE ALL THREE
ITEMS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THE MOTION IS
TO MOVE ALL THREE ITEMS THAT'S
ISSUE NUMBER ONE TWO AND THREE
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY THEIR SOUND
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR PAN HI -- TITLE CENTER
STONE [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO THAT MEANS BOTH ISSUE ONE
ISSUE TWO AND ISSUE THREE ARE
ALL OUT THREE ZERO THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
NOW WE WILL HAVE OUR PROPOSALS
FOR INVESTMENTS I JUST ASK YOU
TO SERVE MOVED TO THE SIDE HERE.
AND WE HAVE. THREE PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT HERE SO WE'LL START
WITH -- THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION.
EIJI AGENCIES ON AGING AND THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION AND THE
FILLING CENTERS WHO'S SPEAKING
THERE AND ON THE INCREASE
SUPPORT FOR THE NO WRONG DOOR
MODEL [inaudible]
COME UP [inaudible]
THIS THIS DOWN TO SEVEN THIRTY
LEFT.
OKAY I THINK IT.
PLEASE PLEASE COME UP TO THE
TABLE.
AND WE CAN ASK IF.
SO WE ASK THAT COLLECTIVELY --
THREE MINUTES PRESENTATION FOR
ALL THE PRESENTERS.
RIGHT SO IF YOU INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FIRST FOR THE RECORD
THAT WON'T COUNT AGAINST YOUR
TIME AND THEN WE'LL.
BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON E. LIKE TO
LIGHTEN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE PERRIN CENTER FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS.
THANK YOU.
AND VICTORIA JUMP WITH THE
VENTURA COUNTY AREA AGENCY ON
AGING OKAY PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING US
HERE ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT IS
A PRIVILEGE TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF OF SP -- FOUR
HE LIKE TO LEARN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE MEN CENTER FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE MARIN
AGING AND DISTANCE.
RADIATION ADULT SERVICES WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED AND EMERGING ASIAN
DISABILITY RESOURCE CONNECTION
AND HOPE TO SOON BECOME THE
STATE'S NEXT FORMALLY DESIGNATED
EIGHTY ARE SEE.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASING NEEDS FOR LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS WTH
DISABILITIES.
A CRITICAL ELEMENT AT THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVEL WILL BE THE
ADOPT WILL BE ADOPTING A NO
WRONG DOOR MODEL IN WHICH PEOPLE
ARE CONNECTED TO SERVICES WITHIN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. TO AGE IN
PLACE MAINTAIN THEIR DIGNITY
SUSTAIN THEIR FINANCIAL WELL
BEING AND THRIVE.
THE KEY DRIVER TO NO WRONG DOOR
IS THE AGENT DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THE EIGHTY OR SEE SERVICES A
SINGLE POINT OF CONTACT. FOR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AT -- SEES
PROVIDE FOUR CORE SERVICES
ENHANCED INFORMATION AND
ASSISTANCE OPTIONS COUNSELING
AND ASSISTANCE SHORT TERM
SERVICE COORDINATION AND PERSON
CENTER TRANSITION SUPPORT.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
TELL YOU SERENA STORY A CONSUMER
OF MARIN COUNTY IS EMERGING
EIGHTY RC.
SERENA IS FIFTY EIGHT YEARS OLD
AND LIVES WITH BOTH CONGENITAL
HEART DISEASE AND MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS.
SERENA IS SINGLE AND LIVES ON
AROUND TWO TO OUR CIRCUMSTANCES
YEARS EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT
SOCIAL ISOLATION.
HER ONLYSOURCE OF INCOME HAS
BEEN SOCIAL SECURITY DISABILITY
INSURANCE WHICH PAYS FOR LESS
THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED A MONTH.
IN HER OWN WORDS.
I WAS AT A POST ACUTE FACILITY
AFTER A HEART ATTACK AND TOLD
THE DISCHARGE NURSE.
I DIDN'T THINK I'D EVER BE SAFE
TO GO HOME.
SHE TOLD ME TO CALL JULIA AT THE
EIGHTY R. C..
JULIA CAM AND MET WITH ME AND
SIGNED ME UP FOR MEALS ON WHEELS
PARA TRANSIT AND IN -- SUPPORT
SERVICES SHE ALSO HELP ME AND
ROLE AT LIFELONG ADULT DAY
HEALTH PROGRAMS.
I WAS STILL SCARED TO GO HOME
BUT YOU WE MADE SURE THAT I HAD
THE SUPPORT AROUND ME EVERY DAY
FOR THE FIRST FEW MONTHS THAT I
WAS AT HOME.
THE EIGHTY R. C. NURSING STUDENT
INTERNS ALSO CAME TO ME AS SOON
AS I WAS JUST CHARGE AND WORKED
WITH ME TWICE A WEEK ON MY
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT.
AND PHYSICAL THERAPY EXERCISES.
NOW IT IS ONE YEAR LATER AND I'M
STILL USING THE SERVICES JULIA
CONNECTED ME WITH INCLUDING
MEALS ON WHEELS PARA TRANSIT AND
THERAPEUTIC SUPPORT.
IT HAS CHANGED MY LIFE.
MARIN COUNTY SERVICES THE TIP OF
THE SPEAR WEN IT COMES TO THE
STATE'S AGING AND DISABLE
DEMOGRAPHICS IN TWENTY TWENTY
THE NUMBER OF OLDER ADULTS IN
MARIN WILL REPRESENT A THIRD OF
THE COUNTY'S OVERALL POPULATION.
MARIN ALSO HAS ONE OF THE
STATE'S HIGHEST COST OF LIVING
AND I COULD TELL YOU IT IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS ARE
MERGING EIGHT YEARS HE HAS
SUPPORTED OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY INDIVIDUAL CLIENTS WE
PROVIDED ASSISTANCE WITH A
HUNDRED INTO MEDICAL FACILITY
HOME TRANSITIONS.
WE'VE DELIVERED SHORT TERM
SERVICE COORDINATION TO
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN INDIVIDUALS WE ALSO WORK
CLOSELY WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH
CARE PARTNERS INCLUDING KAISER
UCSF.
MARIN COMMUNITY CLINIC AND
SUTTER.
AND THROUGH THOSE PARTNERSHIPS
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED
HEALTH CARE UTILIZATION AND
LOWER THE OVERALL COST.
INVESTING IN THE STATE NO WRONG
DOOR MODEL THROUGH OUR DATE HERE
SEE WILL CREATE A SAFETY NET FOR
THOUSANDS OF SERENA STRUGGLING
TO SUSTAIN THEIR INDEPENDENCE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR HER TITLE
AND TAKE THE COMMITTEE IN
ADVANCE FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU HE'S UP ALL YOUR TIME
SO YOU I JUST.
MAKE A VERY BRIEF [inaudible]
NEWS MIGHT [inaudible] FIVE THE
OLDEST BE BRIEF I WON'T SHARE
STORY -- THANK GREAT VERY
BRIEFLY.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK -- I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND
HOW A TRUE PARTNERSHIP LIKE THIS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IS
TRANSFORMATIVE TO THE COMMUNITY
THE PEOPLE WE SERVE.
BY 1100% BELIEVE IN THIS MODEL
AND THE NO WRONG DOOR MODEL AND
SEE IT AS A REAL COST EFFECTIVE
SOLUTION TO PROVIDING
COORDINATED SYSTEM OF
INFORMATION AND ACCESS FOR ALL
PERSONS SEEKING.
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS -- I'VE
BEEN THE DIRECTOR SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR I KNEW ABOUT
MY LOCAL INDEPENDENT LIVING
RESOURCE CENTER.
BUT DIDN'T REALLY KNOW WHAT THEY
DID OUR INTERACTIONS WERE VERY
LIMITED THEY WERE SILO ROAD WE
DIDN'T SHARE CLIENTS ARE PEOPLE
INTO US FOR THEM FOR SERVICES.
IT WAS AN UNCOORDINATED SERVICE
SYSTEM -- WHEN WE STARTED
TALKING WITH THEM -- THINGS
REALLY CHANGED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL -- SO I A YOU DON'T NEED
IS NEED A WE DON'T KNOW WHEN
PEOPLE COME TO OUR DOOR WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO WANT -- WE JUST
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS A
SYSTEM IN PLACE WHERE SOMEONE
CAN COME IN THE DOOR.
AND WE CAN PROVIDE THE HELP THAT
THEY NEEDED AND WE BELIEVE
EIGHTY ARE SEIZE OUR THAT SYSTEM
AND SO WE THINK IT'S SENATOR HER
TADO -- FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- IN
ADVANCE FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FOR THE PART OF
AGING.
FROM THIS.
OUT WE JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
ARE EIGHTY SER EIGHTY R. C.
PARTNERS DO WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE PROFESSOR.
OKAY DELEO ANY COMMENTS THAT
FINANCE.
YEAH AND WANTED TO SHARE THIS
TIME AND ALSO THE FIRST TIME
SEEING SO ANY DETAILS YOU CAN
SHARE WOULD BE APPRECIATED OKAY.
AND JUST JUST LET ME KNOW WHAT
WE'LL DO IS WE'LL HEAR TO THREE
PROPOSALS RESIDENTS IN THE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON EACH
THEMSELVES JUST. TO PEOPLE NO
OVERHEAD DO OKAY A QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS A CENTER JOHN
DO.
IT PLEASE.
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OBVIOUSLY THERE
IS A NEED THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR TAKING YOUR TIME AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ALL THOSE
AT THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT I
REALLY NEED THIS AND SO -- I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THESE ISSUES.
OKAY AND I ALSO -- APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- I
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PUT OUT
HIS -- THE THE MAY REVISE BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE STILL WORKING TO
THE PROCESS I APPRECIATE FINANCE
AND THE AGENCY -- BECAUSE WE ARE
HEARING MANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS -- SO
AS WE CRAFT THE FINAL BUDGET.
FOR THE STATE THAT YOU'RE OPEN
TO CONTINUE TO HEAR THESE
PROPOSALS WHICH OF COURSE ON
BECAUSE OF TIMING WISE THE ARE
BEING PRESENTED TODAY.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT AS WE TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN HELP
OUR SENIORS.
THANK YOU.
AND THE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
HM THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- NEXT UP WE HAVE OUR
DIGNITY AT HOME FALL PREVENTION
PROGRAM AND SEE AND WE HAVE --
TWO PRESENTERS LORNE ROLE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND
JOHN -- MILK FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR ALL OF FROM A
MOBILE SCHOOLS TO SOCIETY.
PLEASE COME UP -- YEN S.
[inaudible]
THAT. THREE MINUTES COLLECTIVELY
SO KEEP IN MIND THE SECOND
SPEAKER MAY WANT TO ACTUALLY SAY
SOMETHING.
SO I THINK WE'VE PRETTY MUCH STE
FOLLOW THE SAME RULE THE WHOLE.
YEAR SO HOPEFULLY PEOPLE.
IF YOU NEED I CAN CERTAINLY
SIGNAL LITTLE BIT LIKE ONE
MINUTE TO MINUTE [inaudible]
DELETED.
HELLO WELCOME ALL RIGHT SO IF
YOU WANT TO GO HEAD FIRST
INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD AND THAT WILL COUNTY MY
NAME IS LAUREN RALPH AND I'M A
CALIFORNIA SENIOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
AND I ASSISTED IN WRITING THIS
SAM.
SOME OF THIS PROPOSAL AND I
THINK.
SENATOR JACKSON FOR PICKING IT
UP AND TAKE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING TO ME THEY OPEN
AND THEN THE OTHER SPEAKER YES
YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF MY NAME
IS JOHN.
MY LOW
AND I AM HERE REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL IN THIS SOCIETY AND
THIS IS HIM LESS VOICE OKAY
EXCELLENT THANK YOU ANYA SAVE --
DOING KNOWLEDGE CENTER JACKSON
IS IT IN A VERY.
STRONG ADVOCATE FOR THIS
PROPOSAL HAS SPOKEN TO ME MANY
TIMES ABOUT THIS NOT ONLY THIS
YEAR BUT FOR YOU THIS YEAR'S AS
WELL SO THANK YOU WELCOME.
SO I HAD AN INTEREST IN IN FALLS
PREVENTION FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
SON I WORKED AT THE COUNTY.
AND I WORKED.
FOR THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM SO I SAW A LOT
OF MY OWN PERSONAL HISTORY.
MY STEP MOTHER -- HAD A SERIOUS
FALL.
SHE WAS SO I THINK SHE WAS.
EIGHTY AND T. SHATTERED HER
FEMUR.
SHE WAS IN THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY FOR A NUMBER OF MONTHS
BECAUSE ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
SHE WAS A VERY LARGE WOMAN.
SHE HAD TO USE A WHEELCHAIR
UPPERPART OF HER RECOVERY --
AND WE COULDN'T GET.
A WHEELCHAIR INTO HER HOME.
IN FACT WE COULD GET A
WHEELCHAIR IN HER WE'VE TEAR
INTO MY HOME SO THAT I COULD
CARE FOR HER AT AT HOME EITHER.
SO SHE STAYED THERE FOR MANY
MANY MONTHS COSTING A HUGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY -- AND THEN
EVENTUALLY HE DID GET HOME.
CHEN ANOTHER FALL.
WE MOVED HER INTO AN ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITY CHEN OTHER FALL.
AND THEN SHE WENT.
SO AS STATED -- IN THE IN THE
PROPOSAL IN THE BILL.
SIXTY THE SIXTY BY TWENTY THIRTY
AND WE CAN ESTIMATE BASED ON
PAST HISTORY THAT ONE IN.
THREE PEOPLE OVER SIXTY WILL
HAVE A FALL.
SO YOU CAN SEE THAT THAT
TRANSLATES INTO A HUGE NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE.
IN CALIFORNIA WHO WILL BE
FALLING AND THE COST OF THOSE
FILES IT'S GOING.
TO JUST BE EXPONENTIAL.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
INTERVENTIONS CAN PREVENT 11223%
OF THOSE FALLS.
SO WE I THINK THIS IS BY MY
OPINION AND I'D LIKE TO STATE.
THAT THIS COMMITTEE AND
CALIFORNIA HAS A HUMANITARIAN.
RESPONSIBILITY TO IMPLEMENT
FALLS PREVENTION [inaudible]
HI INTERVENTIONS [inaudible]
AND UP.
I ALSO THINK THEY HAVE A
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME [inaudible]
HI.
I WAS VERY LUCKY TO HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH MS AT AGE.
SIXTY BECAUSE IT IS A DISEASE
THAT USUALLY HITS YOUNG ADULTS.
UNFORTUNATELY BY THE TIME I WAS
DIAGNOSED I WAS SECONDARY
PROGRESSIVE.
WHICH IS AS BAD AS IT GETS AND I
HAVE PROGRESSED RAPIDLY.
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS.
AFFECTS MUSCLE STRAIN BALANCE
COORDINATION.
ALL OF WHICH MAKES FALL
[inaudible] TO TO FREQUENT
[inaudible]
EVENT.
MY WORST FALL.
I BROKE IT ALL THE TOOLS IN MY
LEFT FOOT.
SO FAR I'M LUCKY TO GET HIM
[inaudible]
OF IT ALSO.
UNFORTUNATE THAT IT COULD HAVE
BEEN MY HANDS TO MY ARMS BECAUSE
YOU CAN SEE.
I USE THEM.
WE OVER THE YEARS WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO A NUMBER OF THINGS TO
GET OUR HOME.
SO THAT WE CAN STATE THEIR WE
PUT GRAB BARS ON THE TOILETS
GRAB BARS ON THE WALL IN THE
BATHROOM.
SMALL RUBBER RAMPS TO GET OVER
THE THRESHOLD AT THE FRONT DOOR.
AGAIN LUCKY NO STAIRS.
I HAVE A BAD CASE.
THAT I CAN HOLD ON TO TO CHANGE --
POSITIONS.
IT HOLDS ALL MY STUFF I REMOTE
MY PHONE.
THE GOOD STUFF AND IT KEEPSME
FROM FALLING OUT OF BED.
MY PERSONAL FAVORITE.
YOU'LL LOVE THIS.
SWING AWAY DOOR HINGES SO THAT I
CAN GET INTO MY OWN BEDROOMS AND
BATHROOMS.
IN MY OWN HOME.
THESE MINOR AIDS ALLOW ME TO
MAINTAIN MY QUALITY OF LIFE A
THREE MAN ACTIVE BUT MY
COMMUNITY LIKE.
VOLUNTEERING AT THE ZOO.
THE FINANCIAL COST OF CHRONIC
DISEASES DISABILITIES AND OLDER
FOLKS OF ALL OF WHOM I REPRESENT
CAN BE ONEROUS.
FIRST YOU SPEND ALL YOUR
AVAILABLE CASH THEN YOU SPEND
ALL YOUR SAVINGS.
THEN YOU START DRAWING ON YOUR
RETIREMENT FUNDS IF YOU HAVE ANY.
FINALLY YOU.
DEPEND ON THE KINDNESS OF
STRANGERS.
AND THAT'S HEARD HOUSING
MEDICAID IN THIS ESSAY.
I HAVE SEVERAL FRIENDS IN THAT
LAST GROUP WHO COULD REALLY
BENEFIT FROM THIS WONDERFUL
PROGRAM THAT YOU'RE OFFERING.
I BELIEVED IT.
AT SB TWO EIGHTY WOULD BE A REAL
GIFT FOR ALL OF THEM.
I SINCERELY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS PROGRAM AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANKS MUCH IN THE
COMMENTS FROM THE PART OF AGING.
WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED THE
PROPOSAL'S WAIT ON A POSITION.
OKAY ALEJO.
FINANCE ALLEN'S QUESTION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO I ACTUALLY.
OF MAY POSE A QUESTION FOR LOW
FOR LA -- AND ALSO FOR FINANCE
BUT I SAID LA A WORKS FOR US SO
BUT I WILL ALSO HAVE.
BUT YEAH WE'VE TALKED THE END
THIS IS A BACK TO THE THIS
SOUNDS LIKE AN INVESTMENT THAT
MIGHT BE ABLE TO SAVE US MONEY
ACTUALLY SO I HAVE MET IN MY
YOUTH -- AS AND YOU KNOW THE
FUTURE SHOULD ACTUALLY WORKED ON
A PROJECT ON ON THE TERATOLOGY
PROJECT -- WE LOOKED AT THE
ISSUE OF FALLS AND I GUESS ANA
IF THIS IS A BUDGET COMMITTEE --
SO THEY DID FALLS DO AND AND
SPECIALLY RELEASED THE FRACTURES --
UNFORTUNATELY TO INCREASE
MORTALITY NOW RELIES ON A
BUDGETARY STANDPOINT THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY THAT DOESN'T
ALWAYS MEAN MORE MONEY -- BUT
IT'S REALLY THE HUMAN COSTS BUT
ALSO I MEAN I THINK IT'S MORE
LIKELY PEOPLE MIGHT END UP THAN
NEEDING TO THE STATE -- NEEDING --
NO LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES PARTICULARLY A MORE
INTENSIVE -- TYPES OF CARE --
SPECIALLY A FRACTURED PEOPLE
DON'T HEAL AS QUICKLY SO --
DON'T A AGAIN I I DON'T KNOW IF
PEOPLE FUND BUT THERE'S MORE
STUDIES HAVE BEEN DONE AT THIS
BY I DO WONDER LIKE FOR EXAMPLE --
THIS IS A FAIRLY SMALL AMOUNT --
I REALIZE -- THAT -- IF YOU SEE
THAT A LOT OF THINGS -- ROAD TO
THE STATE BUDGET BUT IN TERMS OF
THINKING ABOUT HOW HE FALLS YOU
HAVE TO PREVENT.
THAT ACTUALLY WOULD HAVE
RESULTED IN A COSTS THAT WOULD
pBEEN THAT WOULD EXCEED WHAT THIS
REQUEST IS.
AND IF WE WERE ABLE TO SAY THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO PREVENT THAT MANY
FALLS THAT WE SAY THIS IS A COST
NEUTRAL EVEN COST SAVINGS OR
PREVENT MORE FALSE SO.
PEOPLE COULD LOOK AT STUDIES
RELATED -- TO IF YOU HAVE GRAB
BARS WHICH IS NOT WHAT THE WHAT
THE RATE OF FALLS ARE IN AND THE
CONSEQUENT CONSEQUENTIAL COSTED
ESPECIALLY SINCE.
MEDI CAL IS THE PRIMARY PAYER.
FOR LONG TERM CARE SERGIO LONG
TERM CARE SERVICES NURSING HOME
CARE AND AS WELL AS MANY SEE
YEARS -- DO DEPEND ON IT
ALTHOUGH MEDICARE'S ALSO THERE.
FOR SOMETIMES HOSPITALIZATION AS
WELL SO -- AND IF THERE'S ANYONE
CAN TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THAT
AND HOPEFULLY THAT CAN BE
CONSIDERATION AND AND THIS
CONSIDERATIONS PROPOSAL.
AS I SEE LINE NODDING
[inaudible]
OKAY -- WERE HAPPY IT SEEMS LIKE
THE PRESENTER REFERENCE SOME
STUDIES WERE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE PRESENTERS TO GET THOSE
CITATIONS BUT THEN ALSO DO --
SOME ADDITIONAL LOOK TO SEE IF
THERE WERE OTHER STUDIES --
PARTICULARLY ON NOT ONLY THE
FALL PREVENTION BUT TO SEE IF
THERE'S SOME STUDIES THAT LOOKED
AT THE NECESSARY COST SAVINGS
AND WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO
COURTNEY.
AT THE GOOD THAT SOMETHING
FINANCES BY HOPEFULLY BE WILLING
TO TO CONSIDER AS WELL.
YEAH I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY DATA
SOURCES IS YOU KNOW THAT'S HOW
WE CONDUCT STUDIES SO I'D HAVE
TO SEE WHAT THE ALLEY -- COMES
UP WITH OKAY ANG ANGELS COME
OKAY.
EACH MAN ON THAT THAT OKAY SO
HOPEFULLY -- SOMEONE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS --
AND I KNOW THIS.
CERTAINLY PROVED PREVENTION FOR
ITS OWN SAKE IT'S NOT ONLY FOR
THE MONEY PART BUT I THINK EVEN
FROM A FISCAL POINT OF VIEW IT.
HOPEFULLY -- ALSO PENCILS OUT AS
WELL SO THANK YOU THANKS MUCH OF
PRESENTATIONS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FOR OKAY.
FINALLY WE HAVE THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING AND SEE THEIR
PRESENTERS WILL BE -- TO SAND
READ -- HIS WITH THE YELLOW
HEALTHY AGING ALLIANCE IN
VICTORIA.
JUMP WITH THE VENTURA COUNTY
AREA AG AGENCY ON AGING WELCOME
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
AGAIN.
IF YOU THREE MINUTES
[inaudible]
COME TOGETHER.
OKAY WELCOME TO YOU INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES FIRST FOR THE RECORD.
I'M SUSAN REED I'M FORMALLY
CHIEF OF STAFF TO SENATOR CAROL
LOU AND CONSULTANT TO THE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE.
AND NOW RETIRED A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF YELLOW
HEALTHY AGING ALLIANCE A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS.
AND I'M HERE ON THE
COLLABORATIVE BEHALF OKAY THANK
YOU.
I'M VICTORIA JUMP WITH THE
VENTURA COUNTY AREA AGENCY ON
AGING ARE EIGHT OKAY WELCOME
MUCH OF AN BEGIN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS THE
COLLABORATIVE REPRESENTS THIRTY
SEVEN STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS
AND TWENTY ONE REGIONAL GROUPS
THAT ADVOCATE OR PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
CARE GIVERS.
THE COLLABORATIVE URGES YOU TO
APPROVE SENATOR JACKSON'S
REQUEST FOR ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
DEVELOPMENT OF A MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING WHICH CORRESPONDED LEE THE
COLLABORATIVE STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
WE'VE ADOPTED A SET OF
PRINCIPLES WE BELIEVE SHOULD
GUIDE THE MASTER PLAN EFFORT AS
FOLLOWS.
THE MASTER PLAN MUST BE
COMPREHENSIVE AND EQUITABLY
ADDRESS THE WHOLE PERSON NEEDS
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
POPULATION.
THE PLANNED DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
MUST BE INCLUSIVE.
AND THE PLAN ITSELF MUCH BE
ACTIONABLE WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION CLEARLY ASSIGNED
AND SUBJECT TO LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT.
ABOVE ALL THE PROCESS IN THE
PLAN MUST REFLECT INVESTED
COMMITMENT AND LEADERSHIP FROM
THE GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE.
INCLUDING ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE STATE BUDGET TO SUPPORT
MASTER PLAN DEVELOPMENT WOULD BE
A SUBSTANTIAL AND CLEAR
INDICATION OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
COMMITMENT.
MEMBERS STUDIES AND REPORTS
ISSUED OVER THE LAST THREE
DECADES INCLUDING BY THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION THE STATE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
THE STATE ASSEMBLY THE STATE
SENATE STATE UNIVERSITIES.
AND P. P. I SEE.
HAVE CALLED ON CALIFORNIA TO
CREATE A COHESIVE AND
COORDINATED SYSTEM THAT
ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF OUR AGING
POPULATION.
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
ACCOMPANY THIS POPULATIONS GROW.
THE ISSUES ARE NOT ONLY
HUMANITARIAN BUT ALSO ECONOMIC
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES AND
FOR THE STATE.
THE TIME IS PASSED FROM POLICY
MAKERS CAN CONTEMPLATE WHAT
IMPLICATIONS THE AGING BABY
BOOMER WAVE WILL HAVE FOR THE
STATE.
WE HAVE ARRIVED AND THERE ARE
MORE TO COME.
ALREADY TOO MANY SENIORS ARE
LAPSING INTO POVERTY OR EVEN
HOMELESSNESS MEANWHILE SOCIAL
SECURITY MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
ARE BEING ASSAULTED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
WE ASK YOU TO STEP UP AND SIGNAL
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE WELL
BEING OF THE AGING POPULATION.
BY PROVING THIS ONE MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST I WILL SUBMIT MY
TESTIMONY WITH A LIST OF THE
COLLABORATIVE MEMBERS AS WELL AS
A LIST OF STUDIES.
DOCUMENTING THE NEED FOR THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING TO THE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
I THINK YOU SHOULD THE FOR
THIRTY SECONDS.
THIS IS NOT MY DAY -- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME -- I'VE BEEN THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER COUNTY
AREA AGENCY ON AGING SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR AT THE TIME I
BECAME DIRECTOR THERE ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
THAT IS SINCE THE DOUBLED.
IN THAT TIME -- WHAT HASN'T
CHANGED IS THAT THE SYSTEM'S
BUILT IN PROGRAMS PUT IN PLACE
WAY BACK WHEN -- WERE DESIGNED
FOR A POPULATION THAT HAS
DOUBLED -- ON THE LOCAL LEVEL I
HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO FAMILIES THE
CARE GIVERS OLDER ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
ON A REGULAR BASIS WHY THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO MEET THE MOST BASIC
HUMAN NEEDS AND THAT THERE IS NO
PLAN IN PLACE THAT WILL HANDLE
THE AGING POPULATION.
I AM OFTEN ASKED ON A REGULAR
BASIS QUESTIONS LIKE.
WHERE IS EVERYBODY GONNA LIVE
WHEN NOBODY CAN AFFORD TO MOVE
WHO'S GOING TO PROVIDE IT -- IN
HOME CARE WHEN SOME OF THE
WORKERS ARE THE LOWEST PAID WHAT
HAPPENS TO A PERSON THAT DOESN'T
HAVE A CARE GIVER HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO PAY FOR SERVICES.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO HANDLE
ALZHEIMER'S CAN PUBLIC TRANSIT
HANDLE THE INCREASED AND LASTLY
WHAT IS THE STATE DOING?
AND ARE THEY THINKING OF THESE
THINGS -- I'D BE OF SADLY I KNOW
THE ANSWERS -- WHAT'S BEEN BUILT
IS A COMPLEX SYSTEM A LOT OF
STATE AGENCIES THAT DO A LOT OF
THINGS.
BUT IT IS A DIFFICULT FRAGMENTED
SYSTEM AND THAT IT DOESN'T WORK
FOR EVERYONE -- I'M HOPEFUL FOR
THIS PLAN AT LEAST IT WILL GET
US TALKING ABOUT THE RIGHT
SUBJECTS ALMONDS WITH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE EIGHT JUST SET THAT AS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A MASTER PLAN
AN AGING IS.
THAT VERY SECTOR IN ME TO
TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
PREVIOUSLY -- OF THAT INCLUDES
ENGAGING WITH STAKEHOLDERS ARE
TRIPLE A PARTNERS SEE FOR A AND
OTHER PARTNERS -- IN TERMS OF
THE RESOURCES THAT WE TAKE TO
DEVELOP A MASTER PLAN THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WILLING TO
ENGAGE IN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT --
PLAN LIKE ENGAGE AND CHARLIE.
THANK YOU HELLO COMMENTS FINANCE.
QUESTION TWENTY MEMBERS.
OKAY.
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION OF PRE SHEET
THE GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP -- IN
NO HEAT AND IS SAY THE STATE
ADDRESS -- HE OUTSIDE LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT -- ACTUALLY THIS
VERY SUB COMMITTEE -- LAST YEAR
POINT OUT WE NEED MORE LONG TERM
PLAN FREE SHEET ELLIE IS -- HELP
IN THAT WE HAD WE HELD OUR OWN
HEARING ON THIS VERY ISSUE
ESPECIALLY LOOKING AT THE
BUDGETARY ASPECTS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND CERTAINLY WE FOR WANT TO BE
SURE THAT -- WE ARE -- OF YOU
KNOW PUTTING THE PIECES TOGETHER
AND AND PLANNING FOR THE FUTURE
AND BE SURE WE CAN WE'RE HERE TO
HELP OUR SENIORS SO -- AGAIN
THANKS VERY MUCH AND I'M SURE
THAT -- I HAVEN'T SEEN WHAT THE
MAY REVISE SAYS ABOUT THIS BUT I
KNOW THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
THING PIECE FOR THE GOVERNOR --
IN TERMS OF DEVELOPING A MASTER
PLAN SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
RIGHT WITH THAT -- WILL GO AHEAD
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE THREE
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS OF IT
AGAIN ASK PEOPLE IF YOU CAN KEEP
YOUR REMARKS TWO UNDER A MINUTE.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEASE A COMMON
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION AND PROUD
MEMBERS OF THE COLLABORATIVE WE
STAND IN SUPPORT FOR ALL --
THREE THE NO WRONG DOOR
CERTAINLY THE MASTER PLAN OUT WE
WE WISH.
TO OFFER OUR SERVICES IF THE
GOVERNOR'S INTERESTED IN THE
OMBUDSMAN PERSPECTIVE AS
ADVOCATE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT A MORE IN DEPTH PROPOSAL
FOR FALL.
PREVENTION AS AS WE LOOK AT THAT
AS A WORK DETERRENT FOR RESIDENT
FOR OLDER ADULTS NOT MOVING INTO
ASSISTED LIVING OR SKILLED
NURSING PREMATURELY.
WELCOME.
BACK TODAY MICHELLE JOHNSTON
WITH THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
AND WE TO REMEMBER YOUR HEARINGS
LAST YEAR AND ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE MASTER PLAN.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
CONDUCTOR PAN AND SENATORS
CALLAHAN -- CONTROLS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION OF
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHT EIGHTY RC
NAM TRONG DOOR PROPOSAL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS ERIC HARRISON WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT ESPECIALLY IF
THE FIRST TWO PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
OKAY I SEEN ON ALSO THE
MICROPHONE WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
OPENED THE PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT.
AND THINKS FOR MUCH SO LET'S
MOVE ON WE HAVE THE TO
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
.
OKAY SO WITH.
ALL THAT WENT ON OKAY ALL RIGHT.
APRIL CAN PLEASE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES FOR THE RECORD FIRST
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
PALMIERI ACTING DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THANK YOU ALEJO.
JACQUI BRASILIA.
LEO.
AND IT'S JUST THE PRINCIPLE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE OKAY SO -- WE
HAVE -- THREE SPRING FINANCE
LETTERS AND THEN WE HAVE SOME
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS SO
WILL.
TAKE EACH OF THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTERS.
WAS THE ONE THAT -- AND WE WILL
VOTE WE WILL TAKE UP -- IF
THERE'S OF ISSUES WITH THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE ISSUE ONE
AND TWO I THINK THERE'S AND
THERE'S SOMETHING WITH ISSUE
THREE THAT WERE THE HOLD OFF ON
FOR RIGHT NOW SO HOLD THAT OPEN.
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THOSE AND THEN WHAT
WE'LL DO IS -- WE WILL THEN FEAR
THE PROPOSAL'S INVESTMENT CELL.
OKAY WELCOME ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL
GO AHEAD BEGIN AT ISSUE ONE THE
SPRING FINANCED LEOPARD LETTER
ON INCREASE INSPECTIONS OF CHILD
CARE CENTERS AND FAMILY CARE
HOMES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- LAST
YEAR IN THE BUDGET -- THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AGREED TO TWO YEARS WORTH OF
FUNDING -- FOR INCREASED
INSPECTIONS IN CHILD CARE
FACILITIES THAT FUNDING COMES
FROM THE CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT
BLOCK GRANT WHICH IS A FEDERAL
GRANT THAT PROVIDES.
A NUMBER OF FUNDING STREAMS FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
IN CHILD CARE -- PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
THE CURRENT STATUS OF OUR
INSPECTIONS AND CHILD CARE IS
ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS THAT'S
INCREASED FROM ONCE EVERY FIVE
YEARS JUST A FEW YEARS AGO BUT
WITH THIS FUNDING WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE -- TO FIND ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS OF EVERY CHILD CARE
IN CALIFORNIA OF WHICH THERE ARE
ROUGHLY -- FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
THIS PROPOSAL SIMPLY PUTS THE
POSITIONS WITH THE MONEY THAT
WAS APPROVED LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU ANY COMES FROM MILLION --
THE CONCERNED WITH THE PROPOSAL --
ONE TECHNICAL POINT THAT WE
WOULD FLAG IS THE POSITIONS ARE
PERMANENT BUT THERE IS
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE FEDERAL
FUNDS BEING AVAILABLE IN FUTURE
YEARS.
SO -- JUST SOMETHING TO TRACK IN
THE NEAR TERM.
FINANCE.
THE QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSESSORS STONE FIGURE WAS
CHIRLA WHY WAS IN POSITION -- TO
THIRTY GRANTED LAST YEAR WHEN
THE FUNDING CAME ALONG WITH IT.
THIS WAS AN AGREEMENT THAT
HAPPENED VERY LATE IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS LAST YEAR SO THERE JUST
WASN'T TIME TO PUT IT ALL
TOGETHER.
OKAY SO THE THE MONEY THAT WAS
ALLOCATED IS JUST SITTING.
IT IS WE'RE ACTUALLY IN THE
PROCESS.
THE HIGHER UP INDIVIDUALS FOR
THE FOR THE COMING YEAR SO THEY
WERE READY TO GO STARTING JULY --
ONE AND THE FUNDS CAN BE
EXPENDED OVER A PERIOD OF THREE
YEARS.
OKAY ENDED I HEARD YOU SAY THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE PLANNING ON
VISITING FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
FACILITIES EVERY YEAR.
YES IF YOU HAVE THE PERSONNEL TO
DO THAT WE WILL ONCE WE GET
THESE POSITIONS.
QUITE QUITE A CHALLENGE GOOD
LUCK.
IT WILL BE ASKING QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT LATER.
EIGHT OKAY [inaudible]
OUR EIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
AND JUST -- TO ELLIE AS POINT
ABOUT -- THE PRINCE HE OF THE
POSITIONS YOU ARE YOU CONFIDENT
ABOUT THE ON GOING FUNDING WE WE
ARE CAUGHT WAIT WE ARE HOPEFUL
ABOUT THE ON GOING FUNDING THIS
IS THIS WAS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
PROVIDED BY BY.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE C.
C. D. B. G. BLOCK GRANT -- WE
ONE NEVER KNOWS FROM YEAR TO
YEAR WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MAY OR MAY NOT DO WE HAVE HOPES
THAT IT THAT IT MAY -- HOWEVER
WE DO HAVE A A LOT OF ATTRITION
WITHIN THIS PROGRAM -- AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE THESE
POSITIONS WILL BE THE PEOPLE
THAT WE'RE HIRING INTO THESE
POSITIONS WILL BE ABLE TO REMAIN
EMPLOYED AS PERMANENT EMPLOYEES.
OKAY SO WE SEE THERE'S A LOT OF
IT TRADITION YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE TRADITION IN THE
ATTRITION AMONG CHILD CARE ROOM
THREE OH AND YOUR STAFF THE
EMPLOYEES AND THE STAFF JEFF
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO I SHE OF THE MID
THAT I'M NOT SO HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT HAVE YOU READ IT RECOGNIZED
OR CERTAIN REALITIES THERE BUT
THE THAT HAVING A LOT OF TURN
OBVIOUSLY MEANS THAT WE'RE
SPENDING A LOT TIME.
HIRING TRAINING THAT PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING RIGHT SO.
WE MIGHT WE ARE WORKING ON
RECRUITMENT RETENTION -- BUT
THESE THESE THE STAFF HAVE BEEN
VERY VERY DIFFICULT CASE LOAD
SURE IS A LOT OF FACILITIES
THERE NOT THE HIGHEST PAID
EMPLOYEES -- BY ANY STRETCH OF
THE IMAGINATION FOR THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT THEY HAVE SO
AND PARTICULARLY IN BAY AREA AND
THE SACRAMENTO AREA IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO RETAIN EMPLOYEES.
OKAY AS WELL WILL MAYBE
SHEFA-'AMR EXTENDED CONVERSATION
ABOUT THAT IN TERMS OF THAT NOW
I STAFFING BUT I MEAN I'M SURE
YOU KNOW THE QUALITY INSPECTIONS
AND SO FORTH WE HAVE SO MUCH
TURN SO I APPRECIATE YOU RAISING
THAT ISSUE BUT THAT'S OKAY.
RIGHT -- ISSUE NUMBER -- TWO
FISCAL MODERATE OVER SAID COUNTY
OPERATIONS SPRING FINANCE LETTER
SO ON THIS ISSUE WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING TO DO IS ACTUALLY
REESTABLISH UNITS THAT SAID.
IN OLDEN DAYS -- EXISTED TO
ALLOW US TO DO COUNTY THIS CALL
MONITORING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS -- APPROPRIATELY
ANXIOUS TO ENSURE THAT -- WHEN
WE WHEN KEPT THE STATE RECEIVES
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WE PASS ON
THE COUNTIES THE COUNTIES ARE
ACTUALLY EXPANDING THOSE FUNDS
APPROPRIATELY -- WE HAVE BEEN --
COBBLING TOGETHER THROUGH
REDIRECTION OF EMPLOYEES -- A
UNIT.
ISHE TO TRY AND DO THIS COUNTY
FISCAL MONITORS BUT WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO DO IT IN ANY KIND
OF A ROBUST OR MORE EFFICIENT
WAY HAVING THE STAFF.
ON BOARD WERE ALLOW US TO
CONDUCT AT LEAST FORTY SIX
MONITORING VISITS PER YEAR AND
WITHIN TEN YEARS GET TO EVERY
SINGLE COUNTY.
WE BELIEVE -- BASED ON
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- FNS AMONG OTHERS
THAT THAT WILL MEET THEIR
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS THE
REGULATIONS TO MEET THEIR
FEDERAL STANDARDS.
I THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS MILLION --
THANK YOU WE'VE REVIEWED THE
PROPOSAL ME AGREE THAT THE
WORKLOAD HERE IS JUSTIFIED AND
HAVE NO CONCERNS OKAY FINANCE.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY
THIS MOVE ON THAT ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE THREE FINANCE LETTER PC P.
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
PETERMAN CO CHIEF DEPUTY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT -- WE'RE WE'RE
PROUD OPERATED NUMBER REALLY
VITAL HOUSING PROGRAMS -- THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO RUN THEM
THE WAY THAT WE THINK THEY NEED
TO BE RUN AND ALSO THE WAY THAT
COUNTIES.
AND OTHERS WHO ARE RECEIVING THE
FUNDS THINK THEY NEED TO BE RUN
IN IN TERMS OF OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
INDICATE THE NEED FOR MORE STAFF
WILL ALSO POINT ONE OF THE
POSITIONS HERE IS -- IS A
RESEARCH STAFF TO HELP US DO
SOME EVALUATION OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM
WHICH IS ALSO A VITAL NEEDS SO --
APPRECIATE -- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS ITEM.
OKAY THANK YOU.
LEO.
NEW MAJORS A CONCERNED ON THIS
PROPOSAL WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ON ON ONE TECHNICAL
QUESTION OKAY SO THERE'S STILL
SOME [inaudible]
OKAY FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
RIGHT UP PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE
THREE SPRING FINANCE LETTERS THE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY SEEING NONE -- SO -- TAKE
UP -- ISSUE ONE AND TWO AND I
THINK WE'LL DO A LEASE -- THREE
HOLD OPEN BECAUSE UNTIL THAT
UNTIL THE FINAL ISSUES RESOLVED
SO IS THERE A MOTION ON ISSUES
ONE INTO.
OKAY SPIN MOVE BY CENTER HER
TADO CLASSIC ENTRY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SENATOR PAN HI.
BUT HER DAUGHTER.
CENTER STONE.
OKAY SO ISSUE NUMBER -- ONE IN
ISSUE NUMBER TWO ARE BOTH OUT
THREE ZERO AND AND ISSUE NUMBER --
THREE IS BEING HELD OPEN THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO -- SHE CAN MAKE A
LITTLE ROOM UP FRONT WE HAVE A
SEE HOW MANY FROZEN SERVICEMEN
HERE.
WE HAVE SEVEN PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT.
SO IT STARTED OFF WITH THE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR IMMIGRATION
EMERGENCIES [inaudible]
ACTUALLY HERRINGTON.
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES OF SAN
DIEGO. TO PLEASE COME UP.
ALL RIGHT THERE A HERE
[inaudible]
SHE HERE.
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES
[inaudible]
ASHLEY HERRINGTON.
OKAY -- ALL RIGHTS.
ALL RIGHTS -- SINCE YOU'RE NOT
HERE LET'S MOVE ON TO I
SHOULDN'T HAVE NUMBER TWO FOSTER
YOUTH IN RICHMOND PILOT PROGRAM.
AND FOR THAT WE HAVE -- VIRGINIA
CORRIGAN USE LAWCENTER
[inaudible]
HERE OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
TAKE HER.
WELCOME AND WE ASK THAT.
WITHIN THREE MINUTES PLEASE
THANK YOU SAVE A LOT OF TROUBLES.
WE'LL KEEP IT BRIEF -- MY NAME'S
VIRGINIA CORRIGAN I AM A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH USE LAWCENTER I'M
MORE PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
REQUEST FOR FUNDS FOR THE FOSTER
YOUTH IN RICHMOND GRANT PILOT
PROGRAMS.
ON EXTRA CURRICULAR IS LIKE ARTS
SPORTS VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS ARE A
VITAL PART OF CHILDHOOD IN THERE
ALSO A CRITICAL INTERVENTION TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE
IN OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
UNFORTUNATELY FOSTER CARE GIVERS
CURRENTLY RECEIVE NO FUNDING FOR
EXTRA CURRICULAR.
SO THE FOSTER YOUTH IN RICHMOND
GRANT PILOT PROGRAM IS A STEP
TOWARD ADDRESSING THE BARRIERS
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE FACE TO ACCESS
THESE ACTIVITIES -- SOCIAL
SCIENCE RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES
THE PARTICIPATING IN
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES
ACTUALLY HELPS YOUNG PEOPLE'S
BRAINS REQUIRE PHYSICALLY FROM
TRAUMA.
ON THEY'VE ALSO BEEN PROVEN TO
IMPROVE ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE AND
REDUCE RISKY BEHAVIOR.
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY --
EXTRACURRICULAR PARTICIPATION
PROVIDE YOUNG PEOPLE WITH VITAL
CONNECTIONS TO SUPPORT OF ADULTS
TO BE CAN YOU CAN BECOME MENTORS
ROLE MODELS IN LIFETIME
CONNECTIONS.
THE SUPPORT PROVIDED BY THIS
EXTRA CURRICULAR PARTICIPATION
CAN ALSO IMPROVE PLACEMENT
STABILITY.
ON ANY CAN EVEN LEAD TO
COMMITTED CARING PLACEMENTS FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN FACT I HAVE --
WORK CLOSELY WITH A YOUNG WOMAN --
I SEE WHY SEE MEMBER WHO
ACTUALLY FOUND A PERMANENT
PLACEMENT WITH HER BASKETBALL
COACH AND IS THRIVING THERE.
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE ALL OF
THESE BENEFITS THE COST OF
EXTRACURRICULAR IS CONTINUE TO
POSE A BARRIER FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND IS PART OF DEVELOPING A
POLICY BRIEF ON THIS ISSUE AND
AS OUR WORK THROUGH OUR WORK
WITH THE QUALITY PARENTING
INITIATIVE WE'VE SPOKEN WITH.
ON YOUTH CARE GIVERS AND AGENCY
STAFF ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND WORK
DIRECTLY IN TWENTY SEVEN
COUNTIES AND OVER AND OVER WE
HEARD STORIES ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO COULDN'T AFFORD TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ACTIVITIES
THEY WERE PASSIONATE ABOUT -- SO
THIS BUDGET REQUEST SIX TO TAKE
A STEP FORWARD TO AMELIORATE THE
BARRIER THE REQUESTED FUNDS
WOULD PERMIT FOR PILOT COUNTIES
TO PROVIDE GRANTS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE -- WE
REQUESTED FUNDS THAT WOULD
PERMIT YOUNG PEOPLE IN THOSE
KIND AND COUNTIES TO RECEIVE UP
TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
APPROXIMATELY THE COST -- OF AN
EXTRA CURRICULAR ACTIVITY -- AND
THEN DATA COLLECTED DURING THE
PILOT WILL BE USED TO EXAMINE
CONTINUING OR EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM SO ALL YOU THINK
CALIFORNIA CAN ACCESS IT -- JUST
DO WANT TO MENTION THAT FEELING
TO PROVIDE THIS ON THIS
OPPORTUNITY HAS COSTS BOTH HUMAN
AND FINANCIAL TO OUR FOSTER
YOUTH.
UNFORTUNATELY WE KNOW THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE IN FOSTER CARE CONTINUE
TO EXPERIENCE NEGATIVE OUTCOMES
IN IT EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
BOTH DURING AND AFTER THEIR TIME
IN CARE OR AND FAILED TO
EXPERIENCE PLACEMENT STABILITY
IN PERMANENCY ESPECIALLY OUR
ADOLESCENCE.
SO -- THE FOSTER YOUTH IN
RICHMOND GRANT PILOT PROGRAM WAS
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF ON THE
FAMILY FIRST ACTON CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AND HELP FOSTER
YOUTH EXPERIENCE A HEALTHY
JOYFUL CHILDHOOD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE AGENCY SOCIAL SERVICES.
NO WILL RESTART WE WOULD
STRONGLY AGREE THAT THE X.
RECORDER CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES
AND PARTICIPATION IN SPORTS AND
OUTSIDE ACTIVITIES ARE VERY
IMPORTANT FOSTER.
OKAY ELLIE OF ANY COMMENTS
FINANCE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WELL THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
RIGHT -- NEXT WILL TAKE UP --
TRADITIONAL HOME HOUSING
PLACEMENT PLUS PROGRAM -- JOHN --
SO WE HAVE AMY LAEMMLE EXACT
ACTOR JOHN BURTON -- ADVOCATES
FOR USE WELCOME.
WE HAVE TWO SPEAKERS WITH OKAY
SO AGAIN THREE MINUTES TOGETHER
RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU DOCTOR
PAN A MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS AMY LAEMMLE AT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF TODAY'S
REQUEST TO EXPAND TO TEACH
PEOPLE US -- TEACH PEOPLE US IS
A THE STATE'S ONLY HOUSING
PROGRAM.
FOR HOMELESS FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
IN CALIFORNIA IT'S BEEN
EVALUATED EVERY YEAR SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND BEEN FOUND TO
HAVE A POSITIVE OUTCOME
SPECIFICALLY IN THE AREAS OF
INCOME AND EMPLOYMENT.
DESPITE ITS EFFECTIVENESS
HOWEVER THIS ESSENTIAL STATE
PROGRAM IS A RISK THE STATE
BUDGET FOR TEACH PEOPLE PLUS HAS
REMAINED UNCHANGED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WELL THE COST OF
HOUSING AS WE ALL KNOW HAS
INCREASED 50%.
AS THIS HOUSING COSTS TO
SKYROCKET SKYROCKETED YOUTH
AROUND THE STATE REQUIRE THAT
THIS HOUSING PROGRAM MORE THAN
EVER -- SO IN AND IN ESSENCE
THIS IS A LONG STANDING
SUCCESSFUL STATE PROGRAM.
THAT IS REALLY OFFERED A BETTER
BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR THOUSANDS OF
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND WE ASK
OUT FOUR EIGHT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION. TO USE THIS
OF EXISTING AFFECTED PROGRAM TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AMONG THE
SMALLER POPULATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS
VERONICA I'M HERE WITH THIS YEAR
NET.
AND I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
EVERY FOSTER YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA --
I WAS ACTUALLY PUT INTO CARE
WHEN I WAS FOUR YEARS OLD AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN ON MY EIGHTEENTH
BIRTHDAY I WAS KICKED OUT -- AND
I BECAME HOMELESS AND BECAUSE OF
T. H. P. I WAS ABLE TO BECOME
REUNIFIED WITH BOTH MY YOUNGER
BROTHERS.
AND TODAY I'M ACTUALLY -- THE
STANISLAUS COUNTY I OP
COORDINATOR.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THINK SO MUCH INDIA
COMES FROM FOR SOCIAL SERVICES.
WE UNDERSTAND OKAY FINANCE ROLE
IN THE AREAS OF SERVICE THEY
ARGUE WITH THE DEPARTMENT SORRY
OVER THERE.
WE UNDERSTAND THE ROLE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS PLANE PROVIDING A
SUPPORT AND STABILITY TO FOSTER
USE -- AND WE APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION THEY SHARE THE
REQUEST WITH US AND ASK FOR
FEEDBACK AND AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ENGAGE IN THAT CONVERSATION OKAY
THANK YOU L. L. [inaudible]
FINANCE.
JUST REYES PART OF FINANCE AND
JUST LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT --
THIS PROGRAM IS PART OF THE TWO
THOUSAND LIMóN REALIGNMENTS TO
THE FUNDING LEVELS -- ARE
DETERMINED BY COUNTIES TO THE
EXTENT THAT -- IF THIS WAS A
PROPOSAL INCLUDED IN THE THE
BUDGET WOULD BE ON TOP OF THE
FUNDING THAT'S REALIGN TO
COUNTIES FOR THIS ISSUE.
OKAY OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY YES THEY MERE GRADUATION.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
RIGHT -- NEXT UP IS THE
CALIFORNIA PEER RUN WARM LINE
AND WE HAVE -- PETER MURPHY FROM
THE MENTAL HEALTH ASSOCIATION
SAN FRANCISCO WELCOME -- GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DOCTOR PAN AND OTHER US SENATE
MEMBERS I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY MY
NAME'S PETER MURPHY AND I'M I'M
FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH
ASSOCIATION SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M HERE TO DISCUSS A PROPOSAL
TO FUND THE STATE WIDE -- RUN
WARM LINE -- AND I THINK IN THE
NOTES IN THE AGENDA IT SAYS TWO
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS ARE
ACTUALLY -- REQUESTING HOPING TO
GET THREE POINT SIX WHICH IS I
THE THE OTHER INFORMATION THAT
WE SENT -- AND WE'RE WE'RE
MAKING THIS REQUEST BASED ON OUR
EXPERIENCE WITH -- THE SAN
FRANCISCO APPEAR ON ONE LINE
WHICH HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE
SINCE -- TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
THERE WAS A TIME.
STARTING IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WERE
ABLE TO TAKE WE'RE ABLE TO SERVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AND
THEN OUR FUNDING WE HAD TO CHOP
A GRANT OR FUNDING -- EXPIRED
AND TO THE LAST FISCAL YEAR
WE'RE CURRENTLY FUNDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN
SAN FRANCISCO -- IN WHICH ALLOWS
US TO HAVE -- VOLUNTEERS SO --
PEER COUNSELORS HOWEVER -- IT'S
ONLY COVERAGE FOR THIRTY SIX
HOURS PER WEEK AND WE CAN ONLY
SERVE THE BAY AREA.
AND WE'RE HOPING TO ADD TO RE
EXPAND A FULL CAPACITY -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THE WARM LINE AND
IT SAVES LIVES AND SAVES MONEY I
MEAN A WARM LINE IS -- IS A
SERVICE TO KEEP UP PEOPLE OUT OF
CRISIS -- THUS -- STATING THAT --
THAT MONEY ON EMERGENCY ROOM
SERVICES AND HOSPITALIZATION --
AND ALSO PROVIDE SUPPORT WENT
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT WHEN -- SAFES
THERAPISTS OR RATHER SERVICES
AREN'T AVAILABLE -- I'VE BEEN ON
THE LINE MYSELF I WAS I MEAN
ACCOUNTS OR SINCE REALLY --
TWENTY FIFTEEN IDENTIFIES AN
ALCOHOLIC IN ATTICS AND ALSO --
UP HERE IN RECOVERY AND AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH -- ITSELF TO SAVE
MY LIFE I WOULD SAY -- AND AND I
HOPE THAT WE CAN EXTEND IT TO
OTHERS ANOTHER ASPECT OF OUR
PROGRAM IS THAT YEAH EVERYONE ON
THE PROGRAM IS -- IS A PEER
COUNSELOR AND SUPER PROVIDING
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
THOSE RETURNING TO THE WORKFORCE
SOMETIMES FOR THOSE THAT IN A
REALLY NEVER BEEN IN THE
WORKFORCE SO -- WE SEE THAT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT ASPECT AS WELL --
I'M REALLY GLAD TO BE HERE I
BELIEVE THAT -- ACTUALLY THE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S REVISIONS THAT
CAME OUT TODAY INCLUDED THIS
FUNDING IN THE IN THE BUDGET AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT.
THAT THE SENATE WILL -- WILL --
KEEP IT THERE. FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD WAY TO PUT IT ON
CENTER WIENER HAS SUPPORT WRISTS
AND AND ALSO THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE SO WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL THIS OF FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY THANK YOU -- A CONCERT FORM
SOCIAL SERVICES [inaudible]
OF CAPTAIN CHRIS COOK PARMA
FINANCE OUTSIDE THIS ROOM IS
CORRECT THE MAYOR VISION DOES
INCLUDE THREE POINT SIX MILLION --
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE FUND
DOLLARS FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS
FOR THIS PURPOSE OKAY EXCELLENT
ALL RIGHT ALEJO.
BECOMES OKAY AND OF COURSE --
FINANCE SORRY ACTUALLY TO
CLARIFY ITS IN DH CS IS BUDGET
OKAY IN THE EIGHTY S. AS WELL
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
SORRY WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
IF IT CATEGORIES OKAY ANY
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT OKAY WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
FOOD IS CERTAINLY GLAD TO KNOW
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S A GLUTEN HIS
PROPOSAL SO WE'LL THINK ABOUT IN
OURS.
MAKING THINGS MUCH THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT OKAY SO NEXT UP IS THE
OPEN HOUSE AND SHANTI PROJECT.
AND HIS PRESENTING FOR THEIR SO
WE HAVE -- BECAUSE SHE GROWING
HOPE RECOUNTS THAT FROM THE
SHANTI PROJECT AND KAREN THIS
GOAL T. -- FROM OPEN HOUSE SO.
DOW WELCOME AND AGAIN. THREE
MINUTES TOGETHER.
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES FIRST.
I AM KAREN SCOTT TEDDY THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE OPEN
HOUSE.
IT UNTIL SHE GREW A EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SHANTI
PROJECT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS REQUEST AND FOR SHEDDING
LIGHT ON THIS ATTENTION THE
LARGE BREATH OF WHICH I THINK
WE'RE ONLY NOW STARTING TO
REALIZE.
IN FACT IN THE BY THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY THE STATE WILL
HAVE MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND AGING LGBT INDIVIDUALS
LIVING HERE.
THE SPECIFIC REQUEST CAME OUT OF
THE EFFORTS ORIGINALLYSTARTED
BY ONE OF YOUR CURRENT COLLEAGUE
SCOTT WIENER WHEN HE WAS ON THE
CITY -- BOARD IN SAN FRANCISCO
HE HELPED INITIATE A
GROUNDBREAKING I TASK FORCE
REPORT THAT HAD MANY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THIS
DEMOGRAPHIC.
IN ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT
RECOMMENDATIONS IS WHAT WE HOPE
YOU WILL SUPPORT TODAY WHICH IS
TO INCREASE THE RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE GREATER MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT.
YOUR SUPPORT AND EFFORTS TO
REDUCE ISOLATION AND LOOKING
BEYOND JUST OUR REQUEST OUR HOPE
IS THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH AN
INNOVATIVE MODEL CONTINUE TO
ESTABLISH WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING.
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND THERE MAY
BE POTENTIAL TO BE ON THE PATH
DOWN THE ROAD TO TAKE THIS MODEL
AND SHARE WITH OTHER COMMUNITIES
IN THE STATE WE DID THIS WITH
THE LGBT BILL OF RIGHTS WHICH
SCOTT THROUGHOUT SENATOR WE ARE
FIRST INTRODUCED IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS NOW.
BEING IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE.
WE KNOW THAT ALL SENIORS IN
CALIFORNIA FACE SIMILAR PROBLEMS
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE LONG TERM
CARE AFFORDABILITY AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT WE KNOW
THAT THOSE ARE AMPLIFIED
SIGNIFICANTLY FOR LGBT Q.
SENIORS -- WHILE 60% OF LGBT Q.
SENIORS LET ALONE AS COMPARED TO
ABOUT 20% OF THE GENERAL SENIOR
POPULATION AND THE VAST MAJORITY
REPORT FEELING HIGH LEVELS OF
ISOLATION.
ISOLATION PREVIOUSLY THOUGHT OF
AS EARLY AS A MENTAL HEALTH RISK
HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE HIGHLY
PREDICTIVE OF NEGATIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES MORTALITY AND INCREASED
HEALTH CARE COSTS AS PEOPLE AGE.
TWENTY AN OPEN HOUSE ARE WELL
ESTABLISHED ENTITIES WERE
SEEKING AND ISOLATION AND LGBT
Q. SENIORS NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
THESE HEALTH DISPARITIES BUT LET
US ALL REMEMBER ESPECIALLY AS WE
HEAD INTO THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF STONE WALL.
BUT THESE ARE THE HEROES AND THE
ACTIVISTS OF THE LGBT Q.
MOVEMENT ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO
EXPAND OUR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
OR SUPPORT SERVICES AT OUR
VOLUNTEER CONNECTION PROGRAMS
WHICH HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE ISOLATION
IN THIS POPULATION.
WE BELIEVE THAT WITH MORE
SUPPORT WE CAN NOT ONLY SERVE
MORE SENIORS IN OUR AREA BUT
THAT WE ARE CREATING THE
INNOVATIVE MODELS OF CARE THAT
CAN BE UTILIZED ACROSS THE STATE.
TO SERVE LGBT Q. SENIORS AND
OTHER MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS
WILL BE ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO
INCLUDE THEM IN WE DO SUPPORT
OUR COLLEAGUES EARLIER WITH THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING.
HAS IT ISN'T ENOUGH TO JUST
THINK OF ONE TYPE OF PERSON
AGING AND THIS STATE BUT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THINK OF THE
MARGINALIZED RESILIENT AND BRAVE
POPULATIONS WHICH INCLUDE OUR
LGBTQ SENIORS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CONSIDERING OUR REQUEST.
THANK YOU -- ANY COMES FROM AS
FAR SOCIAL SERVICES.
OTHER THAN SHOULD TO RECOGNIZE
AND ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THESE THIS
IS A POPULATION DOES HAVE A AND
NUMBER IS VERY SPECIFIC AND AND
REAL CHALLENGES AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT ANY -- YOU KNOW
ACTIVITIES AND CONVERSATIONS
AROUND THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU
LA YOU.
KNOW FINANCE.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HOLD ON JUST
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RESTAURANTS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- NEXT UP IS THE
OFFICES OF YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
AND THE VERSION AND WE HAVE
DARIA.
THERE IS THERE IS IT --
FINANCIAL CENTER OF YOUTH LAW
AND ANTHONY ROBLESS FROM THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION
[inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
OKAY WELCOME [inaudible]
HE'S JARGON [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALWAYS KEEP IN MIND YOUR OTHER
SPEAKERS AT THREE MINUTES OKAY
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
HOME GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME HERE MY NAME IS --
AND TO THE WORLD IS AT THE
JUSTICE COALITION [inaudible]
AND WE ONE OF THE LEADING
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION TO HELP
DEVELOP AND WORK ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALLEY COUNTY'S
FIRST OFFICE OF YOUTH DIVERSION
AND DEVELOPMENT. ONE OF MY
FAMILY WAS DEVASTATED BY
INCARCERATION THE DEPORTATION
AND HOMELESSNESS.
MY FATHER WAS ARRESTED AND
DEPORTED WHEN I WAS ABOUT SIX
YEARS OLD.
AND SET UP THAT MY BROTHER WAS
LOCKED UP IN A PROBATION CAM FOR
STEALING FROM SEVEN ELEVEN
AROUND THE SAME TIME WE FOUND
OURSELVES HOMELESS MY MOTHER
BECAME A SINGLE MOM WITH A SIGN
IN PROBATION CAM.
A FEW YEARS LATER MY FIRST
ARREST CAME AT THE AGE OF TWELVE
AND I WAS CONVICTED OF VANDALISM.
AND POSSESSION OF DRUG
PARAPHERNALIA.
THE CUBS THAT ARREST ME INSULTED
ME AND CHALLENGE ME BY THING I
WOULD NEVER MAKE IT IN JUVENILE
HALL AND LITERALLY LAUGHED AT ME
OF THE SCOLDED MEAN INTIMIDATED
ME INSIDE THE POLICE STATION.
THAT EXPERIENCE BECAUSE MY SELF
ESTEEM AND THAT ME VERY ANGRY
ALSO LEFT ME WITH A JUVENILE
RECORD.
I HADN'T BROUGHT MORE RUN INS
WITH THE POLICE GROWING UP WHEN
I TURNED EIGHTEEN I TRIED IN
THIS IN THE ARMY.
I SCORED A NINETY FOUR ON THAT.
THE HIGHEST SCORE MY RECRUITER
SAID THEY EVER SAW AND THEY
BEGIN RUSHING TO SIGN ME UP.
WHAT TO DO A LIVE SCAN MY FIRST
FOR US AT AGE TWELVE CAME UP AND
I WAS BARRED FROM IN THIS THING?
HOW THEY TRY TO FIND MY WAY TO
LIVE FOR THE YOUNG THE DOG KIND
OF FOUND ANY AND SPEND TIME IN
O'MALLEY COUNTY JAIL?
IF I DID A VERSION PROGRAM I
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO IN THIS
THAT WOULD HAVE NEVER CAUGHT UP
ALLEN YOU SIT DEEPER INTO THE
SYSTEM.
IN OTHER COUNTY THE NUMBER OF
YOUTH LOCKED UP IN YOUTH PRISONS
A DEMONIC DRAMATICALLY DECREASED
BECAUSE CRIMES GOT SIGNIFICANTLY
DOWN YOUR PROBATION BUDGET HAS
INCREASED BY OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN BALLOONING TO
OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
AS A RESULT F THE COUNTY SPEND
BETWEEN 300-100-0400 THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TO INCARCERATE
YOUNG PERSON WELL IT ONLY COST
BETWEEN A HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
PRS A VERSION INTO YOU
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES AND UNTIL
THE OFFICE OF YOU THE VERSION OF
ALAMO THIS TABLET SAYS HE DOES
KNOW DEPARTMENT DEDICATED TO
COORDINATING A PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH TO YOU DEVELOPMENT IN
OUR ENTIRE COUNTY OF ALMOST TEN
MILLION PEOPLE.
AND WHICH TWO POINT TWO MILLION
OR 22% OF THE POPULATION ARE
YOUTH UNDER.
EIGHTEEN MAKING ALLEY COUNTY THE
LARGEST THE YOUNGEST LARGE
COUNTY IN THE NATION AND EVEN
MORE PEOPLE THAT ARE.
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
CALIFORNIANS COUNTIES WITHIN
SPEND BILLIONS ON THE PUNITIVE
SUPERVISION AND INCARCERATION OF
YOUNG PEOPLE BUT ALMOST NOTHING
ON COORDINATING YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES.
IT'S WELL PAST DUE TIME TO
INVEST IN PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THAT WORK FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT'S TIME TO PRIORITIZE THE
FUTURE OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND
IT'S TIME TO DIVEST FROM
PUNISHMENT AND INVESTED
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DARIA THE REASON I AM AN
ATTORNEY AT THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
AS YOU HEARD FROM ANTHONY SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT CAN HAVE LONG
LASTING DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS ON
YOUTH WITH THAT IN MIND LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PASSED SB
FOUR THIRTY NINE AND ALLOCATED
THIRTY SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO YOUTH PRE ARREST OF
VERSION PROGRAMS DEMONSTRATING
ITS UNDERSTANDING THAT A PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACH WHICH PROVIDES
ACCESS TO SERVICES OUTSIDE OF
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
THE MOST APPROPRIATE AND COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO IMPROVE YOUTH
OUTCOMES.
AND PUBLIC SAFETY THIS ONE TIME
BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR THE
OFFICES OF YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND
DIVERSION PILOT PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE INTERESTED COUNTIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED. TO
COORDINATE SUCH SERVICES FOR
YOUTH AND COMMUNITIES OF HIGH
NEED.
THIS NEW APPROACH WILL USE A
PUBLIC HEALTH PLANS TO LOOK AT
ROOT CAUSES OF WHY YOUTH ENTER
THE SYSTEM AND WILL COORDINATE
PRE ARREST INTERVENTIONS.
OUTSIDE OF THE COURT SYSTEM
ALTHOUGH SOME PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS HAVE DIVERSION
PROGRAMS THAT THEY ARE AVAILABLE
TO YOUTH AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
ARRESTED WHICH NOT ONLY IS
HARMFUL TO USE.
IT'S ALSO MORE COSTLY NUMEROUS
STUDIES DEMONSTRATE THAT FORMAL
COURT PROCESSING INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF FUTURE CRIME WITH
THAT IN MIND WE SPOT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH ANY
COMMENTS FROM DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES.
AND WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO WORK
WITH -- ANYONE ON THE ON THIS
PROPOSAL WE CERTAINLY DO SEE THE
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED
WITH CRIMINALIZATION VIEWS THE
TEGULAE THOSE THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TOPOFFERS
SYSTEM.
OKAY THANK YOU HELLO
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
PRIDE THE FINANCIAL PART OF THE
PROPOSAL FROM CENTER MINING
SINCE OUT OF THE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT.
OKAY -- NEXT TO HAVE -- THE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR NON MEDICAL
OUT OF HOME CARE -- FROM THE
SYSTEM THE FROM THE SAME PER
GUESS IT'D ADRIANA REALISTS
ASSEMBLY IS TO WELCOME.
WELCOME WE HAVE TWO SPEAKERS
HERE.
OKAY I RIGHTS REMEMBER.
THREE OKAY IT WAS GETTING THE
pBETTER HERE THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I MEAN
JENNIFER LESS WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WE'RE REQUESTING
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING PER YEAR FOR THREE YEARS
TO SUPPLEMENT THE CURRENT
REIMBURSEMENT RATE PAID. TO
LICENSE RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
THAT SERVE INDIVIDUALS.
WITH LIVING WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS OR EITHER HOMELESS OR AT
RISK OF BEING HOMELESS THE SIZES
FACILITIES ARE KNOWN AS BOARDING
CARE AND PROVIDE HOUSING AND
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR ADULTS OF
ALL AGES WITH COMPLEX HEALTH.
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS WHICH
REQUIRE TWENTY FOUR HOUR CARE
AND SUPERVISION.
THESE FACILITIES CARE FOR THOSE
WHO MIGHT OTHERWISE BE HOMELESS
AND HELP THEM GAIN THE TOOLS
THEY NEED BEFORE MOVING INTO A
LOWER LEVEL OF KERR.
HOWEVER THIS VALUABLE HOUSING
SAFETY NET IS QUICKLY
DISAPPEARING.
THESE FACILITIES CANNOT KEEP
THEIR DOORS OPEN DUE TO THE
INCREDIBLY LOW STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE.
THE ONE THOUSAND FIFTY DOLLARS
PAY PER MONTH BY SOCIAL BY SSI
BENEFICIARIES IS SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH.
CONSEQUENTLY MANY FACILITIES
REFUSED TO ACCEPT LOW INCOME
CLIENTS WHO WOULD THRIVE IN ONE
OF THESE FACILITIES BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT SUSTAIN THEMSELVES
FINANCIALLY WITH ONLY THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS A DAY.
OUR REQUESTED THE REQUESTED
FUNDING WOULD INCREASE THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR ABOUT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE.
BY A THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH
AND STATEWIDE.
THIS INITIAL INVESTMENT WOULD
ADDRESS IMMEDIATE URGENT NEED TO
CONFUSE RESOURCES INTO THE
SYSTEM OF CARE WE BELIEVE THIS
IMMEDIATE SHORT TERM FUNDING
WILL STAY A STAR A STAVE OFF
IMPLEMENT THESE FACILITIES.
FROM CLOSING THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND LISA
KUDROW REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
ON'T DISK THIS PROPOSAL IS
CONSISTENT WITH A MOTION
RECENTLY PASSED BY OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THAT DIRECTED OUR
HEALTH AGENCY TO EXPLORE
SOLUTIONS TO THE FUNDING AND
QUALITY CRISIS FACING THESE
LICENSED RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
IN LA COUNTY WE'VE LOST MORE
THAN EIGHT HUNDRED LICENSED BEDS
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
AT A TIME WE WERE SEEKING
SOLUTIONS FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO LOSE THESE FACILITIES.
WHICH ARE ON THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE AND HOUSING FOR PEOPLE WITH
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS.
OUR COUNTY IS DOING WHAT WE CAN
WERE USING LOCAL FUNDING TO
SUPPLEMENT RATES FOR TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS INCLUDING A
THOUSAND FORMERLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS.
BUT IN OUR COUNTY THIS IS A
SMALL FRACTION OF THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED THIS LEVEL OF CARE.
WE KNOW OTHER COUNTIES ARE
LIKEWISE DOING WHAT THEY CAN
INCLUDING SENATOR STONE INLAND
EMPIRE HEALTH PLAN AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES DOING WORK IN THIS AREA.
ON TO SUPPORT THESE ENDANGERED
FACILITIES BUT WE NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL HELP
US STABILIZE SOME BOARDING CARE
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH
YOU TO EXPLORE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTIONS THAT HELP
PEOPLE WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS LIVE LIVES OF DIGNITY
AND MEANING WHICH IS REALLY WHAT
WE ALL WANT.
SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS -- WE SEE IN THE
FACILITIES THAT WE LICENSE --
NOT JUST FOR THOSE WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS AND AND THEY
DON'T RESIDENT FACILITIES BUT
ALSO FACILITIES FOR SENIORS.
THAT THOSE THAT WILL TAKE US A
SIGH RECIPIENTS -- FREQUENTLY
TAKE ONLY SS I RECIPIENTS WHICH
MEANS THAT'S ABOUT SINGLE
FUNDING STREAM THAT THEY HAVE
AND IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO RUN
A VERY HIGH QUALITY OPERATION WE
EVEN WITH THE BEST OF INTENTIONS --
WITH THAT FUNDING STREAM WE ARE
ENGAGED AND HAVE BEEN BEEN
ENGAGED IN CAN WILL CONTINUE TO
BE ENGAGED WITH CONVERSATIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. TO LOOK FOR WAYS -- THAT
WE CAN IN ADDITION TO WHAT WE
ARE FURTHER DOING TO TRY AND
SUPPORT TO TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO HELP THESE FACILITIES OPERATE.
AS EFFECTIVELY AS THEY CAN TO
LOOK FOR OTHER OPTIONS AND SO
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION WE THINK IT'S
VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU HELLO.
FINANCE COMMENTS OKAY QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALRIGHT WELL
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION PRECIADO.
Q. AND FINALLY -- THIS WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK -- TO SHOULD --
THE INCREASE FUNDING FOR
IMMIGRATION EMERGENCIES I
UNDERSTAND -- WHO'S WHO'S IN.
RESPOND TO SERVICES OKAY WHAT'S
HER NAME.
ACTUALLY HERRINGTON OKAY
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE COME UP AND
AGAIN PAST THE THREE MINUTES.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE ALL THE
TIME IF YOU DON'T WANT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE SPEAKING?
JUST YOURSELF OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
RIGHT RIGHT WATER PAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
HERE TODAY MY NAME'S ASHLEY
HERRINGTON THE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
MANAGER FOR JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICE IN SAN DIEGO.
JEFF THIS IS THE KERN OPERATOR
FOR THE SHELTER FOR ASYLUM
SEEKING FAMILIES RELEASED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
ALONG OUR BORDER WITH MEXICO.
SINCE OCTOBER TWENTY SIXTH
JEFFERSON THE SENATE -- RAPD
RESPONSE NETWORK HAVE SHELTERED
OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
VULNERABLE ASYLUM SEEKING
CHILDREN OF PARENTS POLICE BY
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE STATE'S
PARTNERSHIP AND ALLOCATING THE
FUNDS NEEDED EARLIER THIS SPRING
FOR A NETWORK TO CONTINUE OUR
SUPPORT OF SERVICES. FOR FAMILY
SLING VIOLENCE PERSECUTION. FOR
IT NOT FOR THE SHELTER FOR
MIGRANT FAMILIES OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS AND SAN
DIEGO AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES
WOULD BEEN RELEASED BY FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES ON OUR STREETS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOUR
UPDATED BUDGET REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
BE APPROPRIATED GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
IMMIGRATION RAPID RESPONSE
RESERVE FUND. FOR A TOTAL OF A
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION.
OUR SHELTER OPERATES TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
SERVING BETWEEN SIXTEEN HE
RIVALS EACH NIGHT WITH SERVICE
ABOVE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
INDIVIDUALS.
UPON ARRIVAL MIGRANTS ARE SCREEN
BY LICENSED CLINICIANS FOR
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES AND
SERIOUS ILLNESSES AND THEN
RECEIVE LIMITED TREATMENT FOR
INFECTIOUS URGENT MEDICAL
CONDITIONS.
MIGRANTS AND RECEIVE A HOT MEAL
NEW CLOTHING SHOWER A SAFE PLACE
TO SLEEP AND WORK FOR THEIR CASE
MANAGERS TO BOOK TRAVEL TO
CONNECT WITH LOVED ONES ACROSS
THE U. S..
MIGRANTS TYPICALLY STATE OR
SHELTER FOR ONE OF THREE DAYS.
THE PROVISION OF HEALTH SERVICES
IS A CRUCIAL COMPONENT OF OUR
SHELTER OPERATION BOTH TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE AND TO
IDENTIFY ANY URGENT HEALTH NEEDS
OF ASYLUM SEEKING FAMILIES.
CURRENTLY ONLY A PORTION OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PROVIDED AT
THE SHELTER ARE FUNDED.
OUR GOAL IS TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE STATE
COUNTY AND NONPROFIT HEALTH
PROVIDERS TO IDENTIFY
SUSTAINABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING
FOR CENTRAL HEALTH SCREENING AND
TREATMENT. TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE THE SHELTER WE ESTIMATE
THAT THE THREE YEAR COST WILL BE%
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THIS
INCLUDES SHELTER OPERATIONS
HEALTH SCREENING AND LIMITED
SCOPE HEALTH TREATMENT TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
COMMUNICABLE ILLNESSES.
THE CURRENT HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
MODEL INCLUDES ONSITE HEALTH
SCREENING PROVIDED BY THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO LICENSE CLINICIANS
AND CONTRACTED PROVIDERS.
AS NEEDED TO FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CLINICS PROVIDE LIMITED
TREATMENT ON SITE.
WE WANT TO REITERATE THAT THESE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
NOT CURRENTLY FULLY FUNDED.
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IS
UNIQUE IN THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT DOES NOT PROVIDE
PRIMARY CARE SERVICES AS PART OF
ITS MODEL OF DELIVERY.
THE COUNTY HAS BEEN RESPONSIVE
TO THE HEALTH CARE NEEDS OF
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS RELEASED
OR SHELTER TO DATE. TO MAXIMIZE
THE EFFICIENCY OF HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY IN THE NEW FISCAL YEAR
IS RECOMMENDED THAT NONPROFIT
HEALTH PROVIDERS ASSUME THE ROLE
OF HEALTH SCREENING UNLIMITED
SCOPE HEALTH TREATMENT.
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO WOULD
LIKE TO RESUME THE ROUTINE AND
CUSTOMARY ROLE OF EPIDEMIOLOGIC
SURVEY ONCE ANOTHER KEY
FUNCTIONS OUTSIDE OF ROUTINE
PRIMARY HEALTH SERVICES.
NOTIFICATION OF A SEARCH
SITUATION THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO MAY PROVIDE FRONTLINE
ASSISTANCE WITH COMING OFF OR
ASIANS.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE FROM
THE IMMIGRATION RAPID RESPONSE
RESERVE FUND AT TWENTY FILAMENT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO COVER
THREE YEARS OF SHELTER
OPERATIONS.
INCLUDING HEALTH CARE ON THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER.
THANK YOU.
AYE COMMENTS FROM -- THE PARTIAL
SERVICES.
WE'VE BEEN VERY HAPPY TO PARTNER
AND WORK WITH JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICES FOR THEIR WORK THAT
THEY'VE DONE IN THE SAN DIEGO
BORDER MORE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND AND
BELIEVE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
RAPID RESPONSE FUNDS BEEN.
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO MAKING
THE DIFFERENCE IN THE GAP -- FOR
THIS YEAR AND FOR THE COMING
YEAR SO WE'RE HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
FURTHER CONVERSATION OKAY THANK
YOU OHIO [inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible] FOR JAMIE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES AS NOTED
EARLIER WE TWO POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IS PROVIDED THIS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR FOR JEWISH SEARCHES
FAMILY TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES.
AND WE ALSO JUST RECENTLY
APPROVED ANOTHER NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FIRST THE HEALTH CARE
COMPONENTS THAT ARE PROVIDED BY
TO THE CLINICS ARE THERE.
AND JUST ONE ANOTHER ALSO
THERE'S TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BUDGET -- IF -- FOR THIS
PURPOSE AND WILL CONTINUE WORK
ADDRESS SEARCH AND FOR THE GREAT
WORK THEY'RE DOING.
OKAY THANK YOU.
BYE COMMENT YES CENTER STONE.
FIGURE OUT ONE IS JUST SO I
THINK THE JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES
FOR THE JOB THAT YOU'RE DOING
WITH THE INFLUX -- THAT YOU'RE
EXPERIENCING -- MAN I KNOW THIS
IS PROBABLY NOT UNDER THE
PURVIEW OF THE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE BUT I WAS JUST CURIOUS --
HOW YOU'RE ASSESSING THE THE
NEEDS FOR IMMUNIZATION WENT OUT
PEOPLE ARE PROBABLY COMING OVER
WITH VERY LITTLE DOCUMENTATION?
ARE YOU ABLE TO ERR ON THE SIDE
THAT WE'RE NOT SURE AND WE'RE
GOING TO IMMUNIZE AS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE -- OUR WORST MEASLES CRISIS
IN -- IN A LONG TIME WITHOUT IN
TWO THOUSAND WE'VE EXTINGUISHES
DISEASE SO WE HAVE CASES OF
WHOOPING COUGH WHICH CAN BE A
FAILED DAWSON'S FOR AN INFANT.
SO I WAS JUST CURIOUS HOW YOUR
YOUR YOUR YOUR NAME DISCUSSING
THAT WITH YOUR YOUR PEOPLE THAT
ARE COMING IN.
HOW ARE YOU VERIFYING AND IF YOU
CAN'T VERIFY WHAT HE DOING?
THANK YOU -- SO J. A JEWISH
FAMILY SERVICES PROVIDING KIND
OF THOSE SHELTERING IN CASE
MANAGEMENT OVERSIGHT BUT WE ARE
IN -- COMMUNICATION WITH THE
HEALTH PARTNERS INCLUDING THE
COUNTY AND THE TO FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS AND
THEY ARE WORKING AND HAVE
PRIORITIZED -- PREGNANT WOMEN --
IN MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS THE
IMMUNIZATION CENTER AND
IMMUNIZATIONS AROUND ANY OF THE
CONDITIONS THAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THE SHELTER.
FUTURE PLANS -- ARE TO INCREASE
THAT TO WORK WITH THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO AND THE CLINICS TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE MONITORING THAT
BECAUSE I'VE AS YOU'VE STATED
PEOPLE ARE COMING IN WITH VERY
LITTLE MOVES REALLY NO
DOCUMENTATION -- SO WE'RE DOING
IT ON AN AS NEEDED BASIS -- KIND
OF KNOWING WHILE WEIGHING THE
RISKS OF IN THE NEWS THAT
IMMUNIZING VERSES I'M NOT
PROVIDING IMMUNIZATIONS SO.
IT'S DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT'S
ON OUR RADAR NO I LIKE YOUR TIME
SENSITIVE -- SEPARATION OF
PREGNANT WOMEN FROM THE
POTENTIAL POPULATION MAY BE.
EFFECTIVE OF THE THE DANGERS OF
A MINISTER OF MEASLES ISSUE NO
IT'S A PEOPLE ARE A SYMPTOMATIC
FOR FORTY SIX DAYS BEFORE --
THEY COME DOWN SYMPTOMS AND WHEN
YOU'RE PUTTING -- HIGH DENSITY
OF PEOPLE CONGREGATING TOGETHER --
WE WANT TO SEE -- A MEASLES
EPIDEMIC -- EMANATING FROM SAN
DIEGO AND SPREADING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S ONE THING IS I THINK
SENATOR PAM -- I HOPE THAT DO
YOU KEEP IT ON THE FOREFRONT OF
OF YOUR EFFORTS [inaudible]
IT IS.
HAVING A IT'S ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT TO US AND IT'S
DEFINITELY ON THE FOREFRONT
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I WANNA THANK YOU SO MUCH I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT -- AND THAT
THE ME THAT MY RETURN COMING
FROM.
WHETHER IT'S MEXICO CENTRAL
AMERICA ACTUALLY -- THE MUSICIAN
RATES ARE VERY HIGH THERE ARE
HIGHER THAN THEY ARE HERE SO.
THAT HASN'T BEEN A LARGE NO A
SIGNIFICANT RISK OF ACTUALLY
BRINGING THOSE TYPES OF DISEASES
IT IS REQUIRED FOR THINK
REFUGEES AND IMMIGRANTS TO THE
UNITED STATES TO BE IMMUNIZED
STUFF THAT THAT POINT SO -- BUT
CERTAINLY -- YOU KNOW THERE'S I
APPRECIATE -- THE DETENTION TO
THAT ISSUE SO THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WELL THANKS VERY MUCH --
SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT A MAGNET WE HAVE --
SEVEN PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'VE HEARD TESTIMONY ON
ALL SEVEN OF THEM.
SO I ASKED FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
THAT YOU CAN PARTICULARLY JUST
FOCUS TELL ME WHICH ONES ARE THE
ONES YOU PARTICULARLY SUPPORT --
THAT THAT WOULD BE GREAT -- SO
AGAIN -- ASK THAT YOU KEEP YOUR
REMARKS.
TWO UNDER A MINUTE SO PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT.
OKAY WELCOME SO.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE ON MY
NAME IS LOUISE MADRID DIRECTOR
WITH DESPAIR NET.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
EXPANSION OF TEACH PEOPLE LAST.
I SPRINTED AS ONE OF THE LARGEST
TEACHING PLUS PROVIDERS IN THE
STATE WE HAVE OFFICES IN EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF YOUR DISTRICTS
RIVERSIDE SACRAMENTO -- BY CELL
AREA -- AND WE JUST HERE TO URGE
TO SUPPORT -- THIS BILL -- LIKE
AMY SAID EARLIER WHETHER WE LOOK
AT IT FROM A FISCAL POINT OF
VIEW OR HUMANITARIAN POINT OF
VIEW IT MAKES SENSE -- AND I WE
ARE TO YOU PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN CENTERS.
MY NAME IS MARCUS CRISTINA SOME
POWERFUL FROM THE TO BE PLUS.
NOT ONLY IS A TO SPEAK YOU.
ALMOST ON THE PROCESS FOR MY
LEGAL STATUS.
AND I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE LIKE ME.
THE NEW TOWARDS EVEN TWICE OR
EVEN TRIPLE AS HARD AS ANYONE
ELSE TO KEEP UP WITH EVERYONE.
JUST WANNA SAY YOU GUYS ARE THE
FOUNDATION FOR US.
KNOWING TO BUILD A FUTURE OF
OURSELVES BEFORE THE YOUNG KIDS
ALSO.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF HISTORY THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS THAT CALDERON ELLIS
I'M FROM YOU COUNTY I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE -- FOR TEACH B. PLUS
EXPANSION.
I'M ACTUALLY A PROGRAM TO SPENCE --
I'M GOING TO YUBA COLLEGE AND
TRYING TO GET MY ASSOCIATES IN
SCIENCE FOR TRANSFERRING
COMPUTER SCIENCE.
BUT I'M GOING TO GO STATE -- I
THINK IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
THAT MOST FOSTER KIDS HAVE BAD
ROLE MODELS AND BAD ROLE MODELS
TEND TO LAND -- BAD HABITS TO
THE PEOPLE OF THE RAISING -- I
THINK FOSTER YOUTH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY MORE LIKELY
TO RUN IN TROUBLE WITH THE LAW
OR DIFFICULTY THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIFE -- TO TO BAD PARENTING --
LIFE HAS A HABIT OF TEACHING YOU
THESE LESSONS AND NOT ALWAYS IN
THE NICEST MANNERS AND TEACH
PEOPLE PLUS PROGRAM HAS ENABLED
ME -- TO LEARN A LITTLE BIT MORE
SHELTERED ENVIRONMENT LIKE MOST
KIDS CAN ACTUALLY -- GO HOME AND
MOM AND DAD -- BY MCCARTY CARE
OF AMINO FEMALE DOES LAUNDRY --
AS FAST AS WE USUALLY DON'T HAVE
THAT SO I THINK THE PROGRAM IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
TO CONTINUE AND INCREASE OUR
SUCCESS I HAVE A FIVE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER AND PROGRAMS ALLOWING
ME TO GO TO SCHOOL TO PURSUE A
DEGREE THE FIRST COLLEGE DEGREE
MY FAMILY.
AND HOPEFULLY I'LL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE BETTER OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MY DAUGHTER'S RESULTS -- THE
SURVIVAL PROGRAM I HOPE TO SEE
MORE FUNDING [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LINDSAY MORE AND I'M EMPLOYED BY
LUTHERAN SOCIAL SERVICES.
I SERVICE THE CASE MANAGER I
SUPPORT THE T. H. PLUS INCREASE
MEANT BECAUSE IT'S A SOLID
PROGRAM AND IT PROVIDES FOR OUR
YOUTH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAVID
SAMA I WORK FOR WHICH WAS SOCIAL
SERVICES OF SACRAMENTO.
AND I HEAR AND SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION PROPOSAL.
FOR OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME'S -- KERRISON WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
I'M HERE -- IN SUPPORT.
OF OFFICES OF YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
AND DIVERSION AND ALSO --
INCREASE FUNDING FOR NON MEDICAL
OUT OF HOME CARE -- BOTH -- HAVE
MAJOR IMPACTS ON PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND SO WE ARE AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MAKE DAVIS --
LITTLE SOCIAL SERVICES CASE
MANAGER SAM LOOKING COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF EXPANDING TEACH BE
PLUS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SO
TORTILLA SWEENEY I AM FROM THE
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY I WORK WITH
ELLIS SAYS AND I'M HERE SUPPORT
OF EXPANDING.
THB PLUS OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS LIEBERMAN YELLS
AND I'M WITH ANY ALTERNATIVES WE
PROVIDE TV PLUS SERVICES AND
SEND YOU AN ORANGE COUNTY I FLEW
HERE TO BE HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
THE TEARS BE PLUS EXPANSION.
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO I'M IN A GARRISON I'M THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR A FAMILY SERVICES
AND WE HAVE SEVENTEEN OFFICES
LOCATED THROUGHOUT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT
HOUSING COSTS HAVE RISEN ACROSS
THE BOARD AND ARE YOU THERE
REALLY STRUGGLING TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THEIR FULL POTENTIAL
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
AND WE'VE SEEN SOME OF OUR
GREATEST SUCCESSES IN THE TEACH
P. PLUS PROGRAM INCLUDING
RECENTLY A CLIENT OBTAINING HER
BACHELORS IN SOCIAL WORK DEGREE
AND A AND APPLYING TO A MASTER'S
PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS A CLIENT WHO OPENED
HER OWN LICENSEDDAYCARE -- AND
IT SO I'VE ALSO IN ADDITION I
HAVE A WRITTEN STATEMENT --
REGARDING SOME OF OUR POSITIVE
OUTCOMES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CAN YOU CAN SUBMIT
THAT TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
WELCOME.
HI AMY LOT FROM THE CUSTER
COUNTY TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THAT OR ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THAT EXPANDED OUT FUNDING -- I
JUST HAD A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT
I WANTED TO SHARE -- SOME
MENTION SPEND MEN -- THERE'S
BEEN MENTION OF THE INCREASE IN
THE HOUSING COSTS.
WHEN I FIRST STARTED HERE
APPROXIMATELY TEN YEARS AGO IT
WAS FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
FOR A ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT?
WE NOW HAVE ONE APARTMENT
COMPLEX INBOTH FELT THAT HAS A
STARTING -- BRAND OF TWELVE
HUNDRED A MONTH -- WE ALSO HAVE
A LOT OF USE THAT ARE GOING TO
SCHOOL AND DE INCREASE FUNDING
WILL CONTINUE TO ALLOW THEM AND
MORE -- USED TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
PRODUCT A MORALIS WITH THE
SPIRIT AND I AM THIS STANISLAUS
COUNTY I OP COORDINATOR AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF
AB I'M SORRY.
TEACH PEOPLE AS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
SIMONE TURRET FROM JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH HERE TO
SUPPORT TEACH BECAUSE EXPANSION
WE HAD FOR YOUNG ADULTS HURLEY
ARE TODAY UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE
OF SCHOOL AND WORK WHY ONCE AND
FORTUNATELY.
FORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THOSE
OBLIGATIONS HOWEVER THEY WERE
ABLE TO STAY I WANTED TO READ A
VERY BRIEF STATEMENT FROM ONE OF
THEM.
MY NAME IS KEY JOHN SWIFT AND
I'M ONE OF THE YOUTH
PARTICIPANTS AND TEACH PEOPLE US
I'M ALSO CALLED STUDENT
ATTENDING SOLANO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
MAJORING IN DRAFTING AND ESIGN
THE TEACHER BE PLUS PROGRAM IS
GREATLY IMPACTED MY LIFE.
IN ALL ASPECTS OF MY PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH AND EDUCATION
AND MY WELL BEING HELPING YOU
ACHIEVE GOALS SUCH AS PURSUING
OUR PURCHASING MY FIRST CAR.
HAD BETTER TRANSPORTATION TO GET
TO SCHOOL TEACH ME HOW TO PAY
BILLS MANAGE MONEY FIND
EMPLOYMENT EVERYTHING.
MOST OF ALL TO THREE PLUS IT'S
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY AND
TIME TO REACH MY GOALS IN A HOME
IN WHICH I WOULD NOT HAVE
WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM.
WE ALSO -- SUPPORT THE AS J. BAY
DUMBER NOW BECAUSE FOR YOUTH
ALSO SUPPORT THE FOSTER YOUTH IN
RICHMOND PILOT PROGRAM.
AND ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS WHO WAS HERE WANTED TO
ALSO EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THE
TEACHERS PEOPLE'S EXPANSIONS
THAT LEFT A MESSAGE WITH ME.
OKAY THANK YOU THANKS WELCOME.
HELLO COURT ABLE TO SKEW THE
YMCA OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY HERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE TEACH PEOPLE US
EXPANSION -- IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WE HAVE A WAITING LIST OF
SEVENTY NINE YOUTH -- WITH
MULTIPLE SERVICE PROVIDERS OF
THE PEOPLE DOING THIS WORK IN
THESE PROGRAMS WORK HARD TO BE
MENTORS FOR THESE YOUTH IT'S A
CRITICAL RESOURCE. FOR THEM AND
WITH THE SUPPORT WE SEE THEM
START TO THRIVE AND THERE WERE
THE OF THRIVING IN THERE WERE
THE TO LAUNCH AND HAVE THIS
CHANCE SO -- PLEASE CONSIDER
THIS EXPANDED INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
LARA'S WONDERSHARE SPARE NOT
SUPPORT ALSO FOR THE FOSTER
YOUTH IN RICHMOND PILOT PROGRAM
M. AND AS WELL AS ON THE
GOVERNING COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND SUPPORTERS EXPANSION TEACH
REQUEST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR PANIC
COMMITTEE MEMBER STEPHANIE HI
FULLER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES WE WILL BE DELIGHTED.
TO SEE THE LIVES OF OUR FOSTER
YOUTH IN RICH THROUGH ACCESS TO
ACTIVITIES AND ARE FULLY ON
BOARD IN SUPPORT OF THE
EXPANSION TEACH PEOPLE LESS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI INTERESA COMSTOCK WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY NINE LOCAL
MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
BOARDS -- WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM SEVEN THE BUDGET REQUEST TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR NON.
NON MEDICAL OUT OF HOME CARE AND
WE KNOW THAT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BOARDING CARES ARE CLOSING --
OR AND WE KNOW THAT INDIVIDUALS
WITH SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS ARE
BEING -- PLACED HOURS AWAY FROM
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THIS IS A
VITAL RESOURCE AND SO WE URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THAT FUNDING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS MAURICE
REGISTER FROM THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND WE WILL ALSO
LIKE TO SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR
NON MEDICAL OUT OF HOME CARE.
IN ORDER TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
AND ACCESS -- TO BEAVER HEALTH
SERVICES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BARBARA WILSON LCSW FROM MENTAL
HEALTH HOOK UP.
I BRING YOU GREETINGS FROM SOME
OF THE AGING PARENTS WHO HAVE
ADULT CHILDREN WHO RESIDE IN.
A. R. F.'S AS WELL AS SOME
RESIDENTS OF A. R. S. WHO ARE
ABSOLUTELY TERRIFIED THAT THEY
WILL LOSE THEIR COMMUNITIES OF
CHOICE.
DUE TO THE CURRENT LOW RATE OF
REIMBURSEMENT WE SUPPORT THE
PASSAGE OF THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS ASHLEY DIABLO AND
I'M WITH CHILDREN NOW WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE TEACH
PEOPLE PLUS PROGRAM -- TO HELP
INSURE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH CAN
HAVE ACCESS ACCESS TO AND STABLE%
HOUSING.
THANKS THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME IS MARISSA
GONZALEZ I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS WE REPRESENT TEN
THOUSAND SOCIAL WORKERS
APPROXIMATELY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
WE STANDS STRONGLY BEHIND TEACH
PEOPLE PLUS AND HOPE THAT YOU
GUYS CAN PLAN PASSES EXPANSION
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE TWO
THOUSAND FOSTER YOUTH THAT HAVE
BEEN ASSISTED THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM.
WHEN LEAVING AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTEEN OR EIGHTEEN THEIR
HIGHLY ECONOMICALLY SENSITIVE
AND I THINK MOST OF US CAN
CONCUR THAT WHEN YOU'RE LEAVING
HIGH SCHOOL YOU DON'T EXACTLY
HAVE A STABLE FOOTING SO?
IF YOU CAN PASS THIS WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
BROWN SUGAR BUT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM SEVEN
INCREASE FUNDING FOR NON MEDICAL
OUT OF HOME CARE -- PASSAGE OF
THIS -- BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL
HELP US STOP THE DARK CLOSING A
FACILITIES IN LA COUNTY TO BRING
PORN PROPERTY SUPERVISORS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I GET AFTERNOON RIEMANN WATERMAN
DAUGHTERS OF THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW WORK FOR THE
CENTER COUNTIES JUSTICE
INITIATIVE -- I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT SB FORTY THREE THE
OFFICER YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
VERSION -- BEEN WORKING FOR
TWENTY YEARS OF YOUTH --
IMPACTED BY THE JUSTICE SYSTEM I
CURRENTLY A MENTOR ABOUT ELEVEN
YOUNG PEOPLE SOME OF THEM ARE
HERE TODAY BUT I FEEL LIKE I
WANT EXPRESS -- SUPPORT FOR THE
CREATION OF OFFICE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT DIVERSION PILOT
PROGRAM SEARCHING SANTA CLARA
COUNTY I THINK THAT IS SUPER
IMPACTFUL FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
TO BE INVOLVED IN PRO SOCIAL
SERVICES SUPPORT SERVICES AS A
ALTERNATIVE TO INCARCERATION I
THINK OF MYSELF INCLUDED GREATLY
BENEFIT FROM INVOLVING WITH ME
BASS ORGANIZATIONS AND PROGRAMS
AT THE HELP YOUNG PEOPLE
LEADERSHIP PROGRAMS MENTORSHIP
PROGRAMS.
THE PRO SOCIAL PROGRAMS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS HAVE YOUR THE
S. I'M FROM WATSONVILLE EVERY
PERCENT CUT US IN A STRONG
SUPPORT BILL.
THANK YOU EIGHTY TO CYCLE FOR
WHAT YOU SUPPORTING THE THE YOU
DEVELOP.
THAT THIS BE FORTY THREE OKAY
THANK YOU.
RIGHT WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS HAVE YOU ACROSS
THE OTHER AND FROM THERE A
CALIFORNIA AND I AM WITH GOT US
AND I SUPPORT SB FOUR THIRTY
THREE OFFICES.
OF YOUTH AND DEVELOPMENT I THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
I OTHER MONIES ALONG THE RIDGE
OF AREA FROM GIL CALIFORNIA WITH
GOT US AND I SUPPORT -- BILL SB.
FOUR THIRTY THREE THANK YOU
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALEXIS HISTORY
I'M FROM YOUR CALIFORNIA I'M
HERE TO REPRESENT YOU THE LINES
AND I SUPPORT SB THIRTY THREE
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND DIVERSION
BUT PILOT PROGRAM THIS IS MY
STATEMENT.
I JOINED UTILIZED IN THE ENDING
OF TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN I HAVE
LILLIAN TO THANK FOR INTRODUCING
ME TO THIS PROGRAM BEFORE I WAS
INCHES INTRODUCED TO THIS
PROGRAM.
I WAS LED TO THE STREETS AND I
HAD A MENTALITY OF FINDING WAYS
TO MAKE EASY MONEY.
FROM BEING PUT TO AND FROM BEING
PUT -- TO SITUATIONS I HAD
TURNED INTO SOMEONE I HAD NEVER
THOUGHT.
THAT I'D EVER BECOME.
BUT WHEN LILLIAN SILVA HAD
ISSUES MANY TO MANY.
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THEY HAD.
KEEP ME BUSY AND SHOW ME THAT I
AM CAPABLE OF DOING MORE TO
CREATE A BETTER FUTURE FOR
MYSELF WITH.
WITHOUT HELPING OVER WITHOUT
ENDING UP IN BARS.
ON WITH THIS PROGRAM I HAD BEEN
HELPED AND WAS ABLE TO BUILD
MYSELF AND RECENTLY I'VE BEEN
DOING WAY BETTER THAN BEFORE.
I'VE ALREADY ACCOMPLISHMENT MOST
OF MY GOALS AND SET MYSELF THAT
EXCEPT FOR MYSELF.
AND MY AND I'M SO MAKING OTHER
GOALS.
MYSELF AND FOR MY FUTURE -- I
HAD LEARNED THAT I AM CAPABLE
FOR A DOING MORE FOR MYSELF MY
FAMILY.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO HI THE
SUPPORT THIS ARM.
THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE IT WILL BOB.
HI THE INCREASE AND DECREASE THE
POSSIBILITY OF CHOOSING A LOCKED
UP AND HELP THE COMMUNITY --
MORE.
A. B. THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH.
WELCOME TO ALL.
HI MY NAME'S WILLIAM CENTERS ON
FROM YOUR CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT YOU TO LANCE AND I
SUPPORT AS BEFORE TO TO YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AND A FRAZIER.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS THE IRA -- FROM GROW
WITH THE WITH A GODDESS AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT S. B. PORT.
THREE THREE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS DAISY ARSIA I'M
FROM GILROY I'M WITH THE
PROGRAM'S NATURALLY AND I AM
HERE TO SUPPORT SB.
FOUR THIRTY THREE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS DEANNA I CAME HERE
TO SUPPORT.
SB. FORTY THIRTY THREE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME -- CARGO SHIA I AM FROM
GO CALIFORNIA AND I AM FROM THE
GROUP CURTIS.
AM HERE [inaudible] TO SUPPORT.
THE VISION SB FOUR THREE THREE
NINE THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI AM J. RUBY FROM GODDESS IN
EUROPE CALIFORNIA FROM THE SAID
NATIONAL PROGRAM YOU TO SUPPORT.
THE OFFICE OF YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION AS BEFORE DO DO YOU
HAVE A LITTLE STORY TO TELL
ABOUT MY YOUTH EMPOWERMENT.
I MEAN IS THE NATIONAL YOUTH
ALLIANCES AND NOT SHOWS MY
CONNECTION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN I RECENTLY GRADUATED
FROM CONNECTION.
BEFORE I MILLIONS OF I WAS A
CHUBBY KID AS MY GRANDFATHER WAS
SAY ME AND I WAS GETTING IN
TROUBLE I WOULD LISTEN TO MY MOM
MY ELDERS.
AGAIN THE TROUBLE IN SCHOOL. ONE
DAY I HAD A MEETING WITH MY
COUNSEL SHE ADVISED ME TO GO TO
LILY AS OF THIS GROUP ONCE I
STARTED THE PROGRAM I WAS ALWAYS
CHANGING ME.
MEANING I DIDN'T GO ANY DISHES
BUT MY EL DUCE I WAS LOSING MY
TEACHERS MORE MY GRADES HAVE
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY WITH THEM
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
EVEN THE COUNCIL TO INTRODUCE ME
TO SING NATIONALLY HAS SAW THAT
I A CHANGE IN THAT I APPROVED MY
ATTITUDE.
DURING SCHOOL AND AFTER SCHOOL.
ONCE I GOT CLOSER TO THE OTHER
YOUTH PROGRAMS HE GAVE ME A
FEELING THAT ANOTHER FAMILY.
WE'RE ALL STRONG ROLE IN OUR IT
WITHIN THIS GROUP.
AND HELPED ALL OF US GOING FROM
EITHER THE STREETS THE GANG LIFE
AND DRUGS.
IT HELPED ALL OF US IN A HELP ME
MORE BUT THE PROGRAM GAVE ALL OF
US A SECOND FAMILY WHO MADE ALL
BE RELATED TO BLOOD BUT LOW TO
SMOKE AXIS OF FAMILY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS JOSEPHINE I'M FROM
YOUR A CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING EAST ALLIANCE AND I
SUPPORT SB.
FOUR THREE THREE HE'S DEVELOPED.
THE REGION FOR FOUR YEARS AND I
HAVE A STORY.
WHENEVER WE LIVED IN WITH MY
GRANDPARENTS I HAD HAD ANGER
ISSUES.
AND BEING AROUND SO MANY PEOPLE
HAD MADE ME ANXIOUS AND ANGRY.
BUT WHATEVER I MET LILLIAN SO
LIVE FROM YOU SO I AND SHE DID
HELP ME.
FROM SIX GOING INTO SEVENTH
GRADE SUMMER SHE TAUGHT ME THAT
I WAS ABLE TO TALK TO HER.
AND THAT I TO SAY SHE'S HAD
DISAPPEARED IT CAME TO ME THAT
IT'S NOT MY FAULT FOR ANYTHING
IN THAT LIFE HAS ALWAYS DO.
OR THAT THE EVERYTHING THAT LIFE
HAS THROWN AT ME HAD A REASON TO
MAKE ME STRONG AND TO TEACH ME
HOW TO AVOID OBSTACLES IT THOSE
OBSTACLES CAME BACK LATER IN
LIFE.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE DRUG USAGE
THE SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND OUR
VOICE AND WHAT TO DO TO LEAVE
THOSE -- SITUATIONS.
THE **** THE THE SYMBOL THAT IS
A MEASURE AND NOW.
IS A MESSAGE AND THE GIRL IS
HOLDING A FIRE.
AND THE FIRE SYMBOLS NEGATIVITY
IN THE BANK IN THE WORLD BUT
EVERYBODY HAS A FIRE.
BUT THE BEST FEELING THAT SHE
TAUGHT ME IS THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE NOT PUTTING OUT THE FIRE
BY YOURSELF AND EVERYONE GOES TO
THE PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY.
I WENT I HAD BEEN THROUGH AND
THINKS THIS NATIONALLY AND YOUTH
ALLIANCE HAS MADE ME REALIZE
THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
NAME'S OF THAT TIAS I AM THAT'S
THE FACILITATOR YOUTH MENTORSHIP
A SPECIALIST FOR GOT US IN YOUR
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT.
AND WE ARE HERE TO SUPPORT SB
FOUR THIRTY THREE AND THIS IS
VERY FUNDAMENTAL VERY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR USE.
AS WE NEED THEM TO BE DIVERTED
INTO THESE PROGRAMS.
INSTEAD OF INCARCERATING THEM
WITH A HIGHER PROBABILITY OF
COMING OUT.
AND REPEATING THESE OFFENSES SO
BEFORE WE PUT THEM BEHIND BARS --
THEY'RE STILL AT THE YOUNG AGE
TO BE ABLE TO TURN THEIR LIFE
AROUND JUST AS TO OF MY MENTORS
ARE HERE TODAY THEY WILL NOT
AMEND IDEAS AND LILLIAN SILVA.
BECAUSE OF THEM AND THEIR
PROGRAMS WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL I AM HERE TODAY AND I
WORK WITH YOUTH IN MY COMMUNITY.
TO MAKE A CHANGE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS TIFFANY BALL AND I'M
FROM YOUR CALIFORNIA AND I'M
HERE TO REPRESENT YOU TO LINES
AND I SUPPORT SB FOUR THIRTY
THREE YOU DEVELOPMENT AND
DIVERSION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME IS ISABEL
SAMPLES I'M HERE WITH YOU THE
LINES FROM GORY AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT SB.
FOUR THIRTY THREE THANK YOU.
WELCOME MY NAME IS MANDATORY IS
AND I'M FROM THE CITY OF GOING
WITH THE YOUTH ALLIANCE AND I'M
HEARD AS FAR AS BEFORE THE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DIANA
TEAMS I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE YOUTH ALLIANCE AND AS YOU
COULD HEAR FROM SOME OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE HERE TODAY THE VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE DIVERSION PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND GIVE A CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
ONE OF THE HIGHEST.
RATES OF DO CITATIONS AND NO
CREATED EDUCATION NO PRE.
AND JUSTICE SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT
DIVERSION PROGRAMS THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND DIVERSION
WILL PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO COORDINATE AND
PROVIDE SYSTEMIC INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THAT -- YOU DEVELOPMENT
DIVERSION PROGRAM THAT IS SO
NEEDED IN MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT SB FOUR THIRTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS KILLING DEAN WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AT POLICY LINK AND WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND DIVERSION.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
DAPHNE DESIGN NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE TEACH FEE PLUS EXPANSION
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROVIDES SOME OF THE MOST BASIC
MEANS AND ALLOWS.
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH TO FLOURISH
AND WE ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE OFFICE OF YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
VERSION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
COMMINGLED COMMUTERS AS
COALITION HONORED TO BE HERE FOR
THE OFFICE REDEVELOPMENT VERSION
AND I'M PROUD TO BE COSPONSORS
OF THE BILL THAT WOULD PUT THESE
PILOT PROGRAMS IN SEVERAL
COUNTIES.
LA COUNTY USED TO HAND OUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CITATIONS TO YOUNG PEOPLE EVERY
YEAR AT A HUGE COST TO THE
COUNTY AND A HUGE COST OF
FAMILIES.
IN ADDITION OUR NEW DIVERSION
PROGRAM WILL -- TAKE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE ABUT TWELVE THOUSAND
A YEAR AWAY FROM PRE ARREST.
DIVERSION -- FOR MYSELF MY FIRST
FELONY CONVICTION WAS AT THE AGE
OF TWELVE AND I STILL HAVE
THINGS ON MY RECORD THAT BARMY
FROM CERTAIN PLAN ALL THESE
YEARS LATER SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
EDUCATION GROSS ABOUT THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES REQUEST
FOR ON MEDITATION ON IMMIGRATION
SERVICES.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
FACING ARROW DONE PUBLIC COMMENT
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NONE APPRECIATE OTHER
PRESENTATIONS THAT THANK YOU TO
ALL THE YOUTH OF CAM.
NOW THIS IS YOUR FIRST TIME
TESTIFYING BEFORE COMMITTEE BUT
WE ALWAYS WANT TO WELCOME
EVERYONE INCLUDING ARE USE. TO
EXPRESS THEIR VIEWS HERE SO WITH
THAT -- I'M GONNA DO SUGGEST --
BEEN SITTING HERE FOR AWHILE
TAKE A LITTLE FIVE MINUTE
STRETCH BREAK AT LEAST I HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO GET UP -- AND THEN
WE'LL GO AND MOVE ON TO
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENT TOOLS --
VOTE OF THE SERVICES SO I
UNDERSTAND ANNE EXCITED WILL
TAKE A LITTLE WHILE SO ALL RIGHT
SO TAKE A TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
OKAY SO JUST -- ANNOUNCEMENT
FROM THE SERGEANTS -- IT GIVEN
THE TREMENDOUS INTEREST IN THIS
ISSUE WE ARE OPENING THE UPPER
GALLERY [inaudible]
CELL
[inaudible]
OKAY
RUGGED [inaudible]
OKAY.
RIGHT FOR ALL [inaudible]
NO.
ARE IN OKAY SO I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED HERE SO WERE.
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND WE HAVE. TWO TWO
ISSUES -- SO JUST A FEW SMALL
THINGS TO TAKE CARE OF SO WE
HAVE THE VENDOR RATE STUDY AND
THEN WE HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT -- SO ALL RIGHT SO
WE'LL SEE THAT PUTS A SO LET'S
JUST FOR THE RECORD FOR SEVEN
RELIGIONS INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
AT THE TABLE HERE SO START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NANCY
PARCHMENT DIRECTOR DDS THANK YOU.
I AM EVERY SEGMENT -- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF GOLDEN GATE REGIONAL
CENTER OKAY THANK YOU.
SANDERS SMITH CHAIR WAS THE
COUNCIL DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES
THANK YOU.
AND SEE WHO ELSE IS.
JIM NIGHT WITH THE DDS OKAY.
STEPHEN PLOWS HE WITH BIRDS
ASSOCIATES THE CONSULTING FIRM
THAT ASSISTED DDS WITH RATE
STUDY.
OKAY FINALLY HEADACHE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND MARK NEWTON ALEJO A FINANCE.
STEPHEN PUBLIC FORMA FINANCE.
CHRIS CUPPED PALM FINANCE OKAY
SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL HAVE A
PRESENTATION ABOUT THE VENDOR
RATE STUDY BY THE AGENCY.
AND THEN I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
TWO PANELS ACTUALLY --
COMMENTING ON THIS AND THEN
WE'LL HAVE LA -- COMMENT I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE A REPORT THAT
YOU KNOW TO SHARE WITH US AND
THEN WE'LL SEE FINANCE HAS ANY
FINAL COMMENTS AND THEN.
WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO.
MUCH GOOD DIRECTOR AND BEGIN.
FOR YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN.
SENATOR STONE -- WANTED PROVIDE
YOU AN OVERVIEW OF RATE STUDY
AND BUT I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
AGAIN -- STAFF ID A REMARKABLE
JOB IN SUMMARIZING ISSUES IN THE
AGENDA -- BUT I DO WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND PROVIDE SOME
HIGHLIGHTS.
AS TO THE PROCESS OF OF THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS -- IT.
JUST BY WAY OF BACKGROUND WANTED
JUST GIVE -- SOME DISCUSSION
AROUND THE QUESTION OF WHAT WAS
THE IMPETUS FOR THE RATE STUDY
AND IN -- A COUPLE YEARS AGO AS
AS EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT THERE
WAS -- FUNDING AVAILABLE THROUGH
A. B. X. TWO ONE AND THROUGH THE
FINDING OF A. B. X. TWO ONE
THERE IS PROISIONS WITHIN THE
LANGUAGE. TO REQUIRE RATE STUDY
BUT I ALSO WANT TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND IS TO
THE COMPLEXITIES OF OUR SYSTEM.
AND COMPLEXITIES AS TO WHAT IS
WITHIN OUR RATES TO GIVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE CONTEXT TO IT.
SO AS EVERYBODY IS AWARE AND AS
YOU KNOW THAT WE ARE A SYSTEM
THAT HAS TWENTY ONE REGIONAL
CENTERS IN PROVIDING SERVICES
THAT SOON TO BE PROJECTED TO BE
A LITTLE BIT OVER THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS -- WE
ALSO HAVE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
SERVICE CODES OVER THE YEARS OF
SERVICE CODES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED THAT HAD BEEN USED TO
ACCESS SERVICES FOR CONSUMERS
THAT -- SERVICE PROVIDERS OUR
VENDOR TO UNDER.
WE HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DIFFERENT SERVICE CODES
WITHIN THOSE SERVICE CODES
THERE'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
SUB CODES AND THEN YOU HAVE
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS AS I
WAS SAYING.
SO THEN YOU HAVE KIND OF FLARING
ON DIFFERENT MULTIPLE -- RATES
WITH IN A DIFFERENT PART OF THE
STATE DEPENDING ON WHAT REGIONAL
CENTER WHEN YOUR RATES WERE
ESTABLISHED AT WHAT POINT WE
HAVE -- AND NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT OUR RATES ARE SET TO
THAT I I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY
MORE -- POINT OUT WE HAVE -- DDS
SET RATES -- THAT HAVE BEEN
BASED ON PRIOR YEAR'S ON COST
STATEMENTS AND COST REPORTING
HOWEVER -- THERE HAVE BEEN --
KIND OF A FREEZE AND AT A SHIFT
FROM DOING ANY COST REPORTING WE
ALSO HAVE THE SET RATES THAT ARE
BASED ON THE ALTERNATIVE
RESIDENTIAL MODEL WHICH IS
ESTABLISHED FOR THE REST --
COMMUNITY -- CARE FACILITIES
THAT ARE MORE FAMILIAR WITH.
THERE'S ESTABLISHED RATES IN
THIS IN STATUTE THERE'S ALSO
RATES THAT ARE BASED ON
PROVIDERS USUAL AND CUSTOMARY.
THERE'S RATES THAT ARE TIED TO
MEDI CAL AND THEN THERE'S ALSO
RATES THAT ARE NEGOTIATED BY THE
REGIONAL CENTE -- DURING THE
TIME WHEN THERE WAS THE
RECESSION -- THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF ACTIONS THAT WERE TAKEN THAT
ALSO -- KIND OF CONTRIBUTED TO
THE COMPLEXITIES OF OUR RATES
SYSTEM ONE WAS RATE FREEZES THE
OTHER WAS KIND OF MEDIAN RATES
WHEN IT WAS APPLIED TO KIND OF
TO THE BROADER NEGOTIATED RATES.
DURING THAT TIME IT IT REALLY TO
KIND OF SET IN PLACE WHERE
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU WERE AT
WHAT POINT IN TIME IS KIND OF
WHERE YOUR RATES WERE
ESTABLISHED.
THIS IS KIND OF IMPORTANT AS FAR
AS WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCE -- KIND OF A
PARAMETERS OR EQUITIES WITHIN
EACH OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS --
ONE OF THE EXAMPLES THAT I LIKE
TO GIVE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THAT
COMPLEXITY IS WHEN YOU COMPARE --
ONE REGIONAL CENTER THAT HAS
RATE SUCH AS SOUTH CENTRAL THAT
MAY HAVE DIFFERENT RATES THAT
WERE SET AT DIFFERENT TIMES AND
YOUR NEIGHBORING REGIONAL
CENTERS SUCH AS WEST SIDE
REGIONAL CENTER THAT HAVE HIGHER
RATES.
PROVIDERS ARE HARDER TO GO TO
THAN WITHIN -- THE OTHER
REGIONAL CENTER SO CONSIDERING
ADDING AND STAYING IN ALIGNMENT
WITH KIND OF THE INTENT OF THE
LANGUAGE WITHIN A. B. X. TWO ONE
ONE OF THE THINGS IS REALLY KIND
OF ASSESSING.
KIND OF OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM SO
WHEN WE MOVE FORWARD A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WE HAD A REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL THAT WENT OUT -- IS A
COMPETITIVE BID PROCESS BURNS
AND ASSOCIATE WAS ONE OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAD APPLIED --
BURNS AND ASSOCIATE HAS BEEN
DOING -- RIGHT STUDIES AND A
NUMBER OF STATES TEN STATES IN
TOTAL SO BASED ON THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND BASED ON THEIR
PROPOSAL THAT WAIT THEY WERE
SELECTED -- I DO HAVE STEVEN
PULASKI WHOSE INTRODUCED HIMSELF
WHO IS HERE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS SHOULD ANY COME UP
TODAY IN OUR DISCUSSION -- AGAIN
JUST TO TO FOCUS THEN ON THE
SCOPES OF OF OF THE RATE STUDY
IT WAS REALLY ONLY LOOKING AT
THOSE RATES WITH IN KIND OF THE
DDS AT RATES THE STATUTE YOU
KNOW NOT LOOKING AT THOSE THAT
ARE LIKE THE USUAL AND CUSTOMARY
OR THOSE THAT ARE TIED. TO MEDI
CAL SO WHEN YOU REALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT IS UNDER THE SCOPE
OF THE RATE STUDY THAT WAS
CONSIDERED AND EVALUATED IT WAS
REALLY ONLY SIXTY DIFFERENT
SERVICE CODES -- WHICH ALSO
REFLECTS ABOUT 90% OF OUR
PURCHASE A SERVICE.
WITH BURNS AND ASSOCIATES
ASSISTANCE -- WE DID A NUMBER OF
THINGS TO GATHER INFORMATION TO
HELP INFORM THE STUDY. ONE OF
WHICH WAS I'M GOING TO OUR
PROVIDERS AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT
ARE THE COSTS THAT ARE WITHIN
THEIR EXISTING KIND OF SERVICE
DELIVERY AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT ARE
THOSE ELEMENTS WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT INFORM KIND OF WHAT
THEY'RE DOING -- AS FAR AS
SERVICE DELIVERY NUMBER OF HOURS
FOR STAFFING WHAT AT THE WAGES
WHAT ARE THEIR OVER TIME.
NOW WE DO WANT -- TO BE AWARE
THOUGH THAT THAT HAS ONLY ONE
ELEMENT BECAUSE REALLY THE COST
OF THOSE SERVICES IS OFTENTIMES
REFLECTIVE OF WHAT THE RATE THAT
THEY'RE RECEIVING.
SO IT WASN'T A AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE PROCESS OF BEING INFORMED
BUT ALSO THEN TAKING A LOOK AT
PUBLISHED DATA THAT WOULD ALSO
INFORM SO WHEN WE'RE TAKING A
LOOK AT BLS DATA FOR WAGES IN
USING OTHER ELEMENTS THAT IS
GOING TO AND THAT.
INFORMED THE RATE MODELS WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT IN THIS PROCESS
ANOTHER PART OF IT WAS -- BEING
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW CAN WE BE
TRANSPARENT NOT ONLY IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPMENT OF THE
RATE MODELS AND COMPLETING THE
RATE STUDY.
BUT ALSO MAKING SURE THAT AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE MODELS IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
TRANSPARENT GOING FORWARD.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN BEING ABLE TO
SEE WITH IN THE ELEMENTS OF THE
RATE MODELS WHAT ARE THOSE
PIECES SO BEING ABLE TO SEE
WHAT'S THE STRUCTURE OF OF STAFF
COMPENSATION FOR EXAMPLE WHAT IS
THE STRUCTURE THAN.
FOR KIND OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
WHAT IS SO STRUCTURE FOR
OPERATIONS AND SO SHOULD THERE
BE TO DISCUSSIONS THAT NEEDED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT A LITTLE BIT MORE
GRANULAR.
EVEN IN THE FUTURE SHOULD THE
RATE -- MODELS BE IMPLEMENTED IT
WOULD GET -- THE FLEXIBILITY TO
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW TO ADDRESS SE
WAGE ISSUES IN THE FUTURE SHOULD
THAT BE A DISCUSSION THAT COULD
OCCUR -- WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE TOOK A LOOK AT KIND
OF REGIONAL DIFFERENCES WHAT
WERE THE THINGS THAT WERE
INFLUENCING WEATHER IS WAGES
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION COST WHAT
WERE THOSE REGIONAL DIFFERENCES
AND SO THE RATE STUDY ALSO
REFLECTS THAT.
AND WHAT IS REFLECTIVE IN IN THE
MODELING THAT THAT WAS
ULTIMATELY -- RELEASED IN THE
RATE STUDY AND MARCH.
OF THE PROCESS THAT WAS REALLY
ALSO IMPORTANT WAS MAKING SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS THERE IS A NUMBER
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT KIND OF
VENUES IF YOU WILL.
THAT ALLOWED FOR THAT DIALOGUE
AND ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS ONE WAS WITHIN THE
DS TASK FORCE AND HAVING A RATE
STUDY WORK GROUP WHICH WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
INPUT IS.
TO KIND OF HOW WE WOULD BE
MOVING FORWARD BUT ALSO THAN
GIVING US INFORMATION AS TO THE
PROVIDER -- STUDY THAT WENT OUT --
SO THOSE THERE WAS A SERVICE
PROVIDER STUDY THAT -- WE HAD --
RELEASED WE HAD -- EACH OF THE
THE SAMPLINGS AT THE DIFFERENT
IN SCOPE SERVICES THAT RESPONDED
TO THAT -- PART OF THE
DISCUSSION WITH THE DS TASK
FORCE WAS ALSO ASKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE VERY AWARE OF
IT AND I'M.
MINDFUL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
IS RECEIVING SERVICES CONSUMERS
AND FAMILIES WHAT WAS IMPORTANT
TO THEM.
AND SO AS KIND OF MOVING FORWARD
WITH THAT WHAT WE DID WAS WE WE
WORKED WITH BURNS AND ASSOCIATE.
THEY HAD A SUBCONTRACTOR HSR I
WHO HAD THEN WORKED WITH SOME
STAKEHOLDERS TO DESIGNED.
ASUS A SURVEY OF CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES START HAVING SOME
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WAS IMPORTANT
TO THE SERVICE DELIVERY --
COMMON THEMES THAT WE HEARD THAT
WERE IMPORTANT TO THE SERVICE
DELIVERY FOR THEM WAS REALLY
STAFF STABILITY EIGHT MAKING
SURE THAT STAFF WERE TRAINED.
MAKING SURE THAT THERE WAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT HOW COULD
THAT CAN HELP IMPROVE THE
QUALITY.
OF OF THAT SERVICE AND THAT
EXPERIENCE FOR THAT PERSON --
ALL OF THAT INFORMATION HELPED
INFORM ELEMENTS WITHIN THE RATE
STUDY AND SO WHEN YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THE RATE MODELS ARE
CERTAIN ELEMENTS THAT ACTUALLY --
DO TOUCH ON MANY OF THOSE AREAS
ONE IS WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THE STAFF TRAINING THE RATE
MODELS -- DO REFLECT ON
COMPONENTS FOR REQUIREMENTS FOR
STAFF TRAINING ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS IT ALSO INCLUDES --
DISCUSSION AS TO THE ASSUMPTION
THAT THE STAFF TRAINING WOULD
INCLUDE SOME CULTURAL COMPETENCY.
AND THEN THE OTHER PIECE THAT
WAS -- INCLUDED AND THAT WAS
ADDRESSING THE UNDERSTANDING OF
BILINGUAL STIPENDS YOU KNOW FOR
ON THE COMMUNITIES THAT -- TO
HAVE LANGUAGE ACCESS TO INCLUDE
A SL.
SO THOSE WERE SOME SOME PIECES
THAT WERE IMPORTANT TO INCLUDE --
WITHIN THE CONSIDERATION O THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OF THE MODELS --
WE ALSO WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE RECOGNIZE SEEN KIND OF
THE DIFFERENCES IN THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF SETTINGS SO WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT NEEDED --
TO INFORM US AND THAT IS WHERE
HAVING FURTHER ENGAGEMENT WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDERS WAS IMPORTANT.
SO WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET WITH A NUMBER OF THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND
ADVOCACY GROUPS. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE
POINTED CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE
IMPORTANT TO PARTICULAR SERVICE
KIND OF CATEGORIES IF YOU WILL.
THE OTHER THE OTHER PART THAT I
THOUGHT WAS REALLY HELPFUL WAS
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE OUR
CONSULTANTS GO OUT AND VISIT
PROGRAMS.
THAT THEY WOULD UNDERSTAND THE
PROGRAMS AND OF OF THE WHOLE
PICTURE OF IT ALL WE CAN'T HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AND DO AN EVALUATION
OF OUR SYSTEM.
AND THE RATES IS UNDERSTANDING
WHAT ARE THE REQUIREMENTS WITHIN
STATUTE AND THEN WHAT ARE THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE WITHIN
REGULATION SO THERE WAS ALSO WE
ALSO DID A FULL SCOPE REVIEW OF
OUR REGULATIONS AND STATUTES TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ALSO BEING
VERY MINDFUL OF THOSE
REQUIREMENTS.
SO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
BUT I DID WANT TO PROVIDE YOU
KIND OF THAT.
THAT -- REVIEW WE DID -- DO A
RELEASE WE WE WALK THROUGH THE
MODELS WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS
WENT WITH TWO PRETTY IMPORTANT
MEETINGS ONE ONE IN THE NORTH
ONE IN THE SOUTH.
AND THEN WE'RE STILL IN THE COMP
WE WE HAVE THE COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMUNITY AND THE INPUT FROM THE
PARTICULAR GROUPS THAT HAVE
SUBMITTED THEM.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING ALL OF THOSE COMMENTS.
THERE'S A LOT OF THEM AND WE
STILL NEED TO CONTINUE -- TO GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN BE INFORMED AS
TO WHAT THAT TELLS US WITHIN THE
EXISTING MODELS AND THE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT THAT WERE PUT
FORWARD.
THANK YOU -- ACTUALLY BEFORE
MOVEON MATES THAT AND AND DID
YOU ANSWER IT OUR FINANCE
ANSWERS SO UP SEE THAT MAY
REVISED CAME OUT FROM THE
GOVERNOR SO WHAT IS THE SO WE
HAVE THE RACE TO THE OTHERS WERE
HAVING HEARING ON IT RIGHT NOW.
WHAT IS A PROPOSAL FOR THIS
COMING YEAR IN REGARDS TO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO WITH THE RATE
STUDY -- SO WHAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENTS PLAN --
HE MOVING FORWARD INTO FOR THE
NEXT BUDGET YEAR -- THANK YOU SO
IN THE MAY REVISED -- THE MAY
REVISE DOES REFLECT THAN A
PROPOSAL -- FOR FUNDING FOR HEAD
OF A OF A RATE -- CONNECTS UP
WOMAN TO OR THERE'S A DRESSING
SOME RATE ISSUES IS VERY
TARGETED.
TARGETED INTO VERY SPECIFIC
CATEGORIES SO IT'S WITH ARM
LEVEL FOR ARM FACILITIES SO
COMMUNITY CARE FACILITIES ARM.
IT IS WITH SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT
[inaudible]
SUPPORTED LIVING.
FAMILY HOME AGENCY.
AND AND SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORTS
THAT ARE VERY SPECIFIC TO
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS ON KIND
OF A ONE TO ONE BASIS AND
THERE'S THREE SPECIFIC SERVICE
CODES.
PERSONAL ASSISTANCE SUPPLEMENTAL
SUPPORT AND TRANSPORTATION
ASSISTANT.
AND SO LOOKING AT THOSE ALL OF
THOSE HAVE KIND OF A A BROAD
BRUSH WITHIN KIND OF THE SYSTEM
AS FAR AS TAKING A LOOK AT KIND
OF THOSE TARGETED AREAS.
WE DO KNOW THAT WITHIN OUR
RESIDENTIAL COULD COMMUNICATOR
FACILITIES FOR ARM THAT IS THAT
PARTICULAR.
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT IS HERE WERE
SEEN THE DECLINE OF PROVIDERS.
AS SO LOOKING AT SOME.
PROBABLY TWO TO THREE KEY THINGS
WE WANTED TO LOOK AT IN MOVING
FORWARD WITH MAKING A MEANINGFUL.
KIND OF INVESTMENT TO STABILIZE
THEM REALLY CRITICAL ISSUES ONE
IS THAT STABILIZING RESIDENTIAL.
THE OTHER IS TAKING A LOOK AT
HOW CAN WE SUPPORT COMPLIANCE
WITH H. CBS.
SO YOU HAVE YOUR PRESUMED --
SERVICES SUCH AS SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT SUPPORTED LIVING YOUR
FAMILY HOME AGENCY IS ALIGNED
WITH THE H. CBS -- AND TAKING A
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN MOVE THOSE
ISSUES FORWARD THE OTHER IS THAT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THOSE
SUPPLEMENTAL AND SUPPORT
SERVICES.
THOSE ARE THE SERVICES THAT WE
DO SEE A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT KIND
OF LOWER RATES THAT ARE HARDER
FOR PER -- PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE.
TO KIND OF GET TO HIRING THE
STAFF THAT WOULD BE NEEDED SO
THIS WOULD BE GETTING TO SOME
WORK FORCE.
STABILIZATION WITH AND THE
INDIVIDUALIZED SUPPORTS -- JUST
TO TOOK.
TAKE A SECOND LONGER IN LOOKING
AT SOME OF THAT PERSONAL
ASSISTANCE GOES INTO SUPPORT
CENTER FAMILY HOMES IT CAN ALSO
BE FIRST THE KIND OF IN
CONJUNCTION WITH SUPPORT A
LIVING.
SO LOOKING AT KIND OF THAT BROAD
BRUSH SO.
IMPORTANT THEMES WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS IS SABILIZING
SOME VERY TARGETED SERVICES THAT
REALLY KEY TO SERVICE OF PORTS.
THE OTHER IS COMPLIANCE WITH H.
CBS MAKING SURE THAT WERE ALSO
TAKING A LOOK AT INDIVIDUALS
WITH SOME SIGNIFICANT NEEDS THAT
NEED THAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS.
SO PROJECTED IS IS I DON'T HAVE
THE SPECIFIC DOLLARS IN FRONT OF
ME I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BUT ON
AN ANNUALIZED BASIS IT'S TWO
HUNDRED MILLION.
THAT WOULD BE GENERAL FUND IN
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION THAT WOULD BE
TOTAL FUND.
AND SO AS FAR AS THE OVERALL
PLAN SO WE HAVE SO IT SOUNDS
LIKE THIS KIND OF PHASED IN
APPROACH OF SORTS ARE AMENABLE
AS FAR AS THE OTHER AREAS DO YOU
ANSWER.
MORE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT OR
IS THAT I MEAN HELP TO WHAT
DEGREE ARE YOU LIKE -- WE'RE
DOING THIS ARE WE'RE STILL
DISCUSSING ABOUT HOW WE DO THIS
I'M SURE PEOPLE WHO KNOW HOW TO
COMMENT ON THAT.
NO ABSOLUTELY I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION IT IT REALLY IS TAKEN
AS THE NEXT STEP TO A BROADER
DISCUSSION AND SO USING THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE WHICH HAS REALLY BEEN KIND
OF LIKE THAT -- THE KEY AND THAT
THE HEART OF WORD MUCH OF THE
CONVERSATIONS HAD BEEN HAD.
SO OVER THE SUMMER BRING IN THE-GROUP BACK HAVING THAT BROADER
SYSTEM DISCUSSION ON SOME TO
PROBABLY.
PRIMARY FOCUS DISCUSSIONS ONE IS
KIND OF THE DIFF.
THE SYSTEM AND THE COMPLEXITIES
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A COMMENTS BACK
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE RATE
STUDY.
HAVE KIND OF THE THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF LOOKING AT
SOME OF THESE ELEMENTS WE DO
KNOW THAT OUR SYSTEM IS GROWING
I'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS WE TAKE A
LOOK AT OUR GROWTH IT'S YOU KNOW.
TWELVE TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
NO WE WE KNOW THAT OUR
EXPENDITURE GROWTH IS GOING YOU
KNOW PRETTY SIGNIFICANTLY A ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS JUST BASED ON
OUR OUR OUR SERVICE DELIVERY AS
IT EXISTS TODAY.
IS ABOUT 729% SO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THOSE THINGS SO HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONSA SUMMER IN
TOTALITY AS WELL AS TAKING A
LOOK AT REALLY KIND OF THOSE
THAT OVERSIGHT OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS.
SERVICE SYSTEM TALKING ABOUT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THE OVERSIGHT
TALKING ABOUT WHAT ARE THOSE
THOSE OUTCOMES THAT ARE ARE TO
SERVE THE INDIVIDUALS THAT -- WE
HAVE RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR OKAY WELL WHEN WE GO AHEAD
ANDMOVE ON TO OUR FIRST PANEL
ON YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT THIS --
SO IF SANDERS SMITH -- CHAIR OF
THE CITY COUNCIL DEVELOPMENT TO
DISABILITIES AND THEN FOLLOWED
BY ERIC SIGMUND HE'S A DOCTOR
GOLDEN GATE REGIONAL CENTER
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS TOWN.
CENTER SMITH THE CHAIR STATE
COUNCIL ENVELOPMENT DISABILITIES
AND CONSTITUENT OF YOURS SENATOR
PATH.
THE THIRD THE COUNCIL'S IS
THIRTY ONE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITY FAMILY MEMBERS AN
AGENCY WRAPS I AM THE PARENT OF
A CHILD THIRTY SEVEN YEARS OLD
THAT'S NOT TO STICK AND HAS
EPILEPSY IN THIS NONVERBAL.
THE PROVIDING FISCAL RELIEF FOR
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
ISN'T LIVED EVERY DAY BY PEOPLE
RECEIVING SERVICES TO THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AS PART OF THIS
RATE STUDY WHICH WE WERE ABLE TO
BE PART OF A STAKEHOLDERS WE ASK
ELEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE IN OUR
STATEWIDE NETWORK.
THE SIMPLE QUESTION ARE YOU
GETTING ALL THE SERVICES YOU
NEED TO LIVE THE LIFE YOU WANT
IN THE COMMUNITY. 65% OF
RESPONDENTS SAID NOW THEN WE
ASKED WHY.
MANY SAID BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO
FIND PEOPLE TO DO THE WORK FOR
LOW PAY AND WHEN THEY FIND
SOMEONE THAT'S PERSON LEAVES FOR
BETTER PAYING JOB.
WE PROVIDE ALL THESE RESPONSES
TO THE COMMITTEE AND THEY HAVE
THIS INFORMATION.
THE STATUE STATES THAT THE RATES
THAT HE SHALL ADDRESS THE
SUSTAINABILITY QUALITY AND
TRANSPARENCY OF THE COMMUNITY
BASED SYSTEM THE RATES CITY IS
LARGELY LARGELY TRANSPARENT WE
PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH
DEPARTMENT SUGGESTIONS.
AND HOW TO IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY.
AND LOOKING AT SUSTAINABILITY WE
ASK THAT YOU LOOK AT HELD
DIFFERENT PROVIDERS WOULD BE
IMPACTED.
THE MODEL AS COMPLEX AS THEM
DIRECTOR SUGGESTED.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WE HEAR
THAT EXCELLENT PROVEN PROGRAMS
LIKE SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT AND
INFANT DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
WOULD RECEIVE A REDUCTION.
THIS WOULD MOVES BACKWARDS WE
ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER A HOLD
HARMLESS SITUATION PROVISION
THAT WAY PROVIDERS EITHER DO THE
SAME OR BETTER UNDER THE NEW
MODEL.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES WANT BETTER
QUALITY SERVICES BETTER QUALITY
COMES FROM INVESTING IN
WORKFORCE WE ASK THAT YOU LOOK
AT WAYS TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
CHOOSING THESE TYPES OF JOBS AS
CAREERS WE WANT THE SAME FOR
PEOPLE FOR PEOPLE IN OUR LIVES
DAY TO DAY.
AND DAY AND OUT WE WANT PEOPLE
WE CAN TRUST WHO CAN COME INTO
OUR HOMES AND GET US UP IN THE
MORNING WE ASK THAT THE RATES
STEADY PROVIDE PATHWAYS TO
BETTER PAY THROUGH TRAINING --
CREDENTIALING.
ALSO CONSIDER FACTORING IN THE
COMPLEXITY AND DIFFICULTY OF THE
JOB THEMSELVES THE SENATE IS
CONSIDERING THE RATE STUDY
DURING A TIME WHEN THEY CAN PUSH
FOR CHANGE.
LIKE THE CHANGES OF THE AT AGE
CBS REGULATIONS CONSIDER
PROVIDING HIGHER RATES FOR
SERVICES THAT MOVE THE SYSTEM
FORWARD AND TO SIMPLY.
DELIVERY WE PROVIDE THE
COMMUNITY THE COMMITTEE A LIST
OF VENDOR CODES THAT WOULD HELP
TO THIS THE COUNCIL IS DEEPLY
GRATEFUL TO THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE SENATE FOR THE CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN AND
SENATOR STONE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AMERICA EGGMAN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR GOLDEN GATE
REGIONAL CENTER -- REPRESENTING
OUR COULD TODAY -- A REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE COMMENT ON
THIS NG VITALLY IMPORTANT STUDY
AND AND RATE SETTING --
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THANKS TO
DDS AND THE LA -- FOR THEIR
GREAT WORK ON THIS ISSUE ON
THESE ISSUES.
I'VE BEEN IN SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
FOR A FULL THIRTY YEARS NOW IN A
CAREER THAT SPANNED EVERYTHING
FROM DIRECT SERVICE AS A JOB
COACH. TO LEADING PROVIDER
AGENCIES AND NOW REGIONAL CENTER.
IN MY EXPERIENCE THERE IS NO
MORE IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP IN
THE LANHAM ACT SERVICE SYSTEM IN
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
PERSONS SERVING THE PERSON
DIRECTLY SERVING THEM.
ALL OUR PLANS FOR SERVICE
DESIGNED QUALITY ASSURANCE
MONITORING ACCOUNTABILITY DO NOT
AMOUNT TO A HILL OF BEANS.
IF THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL AND
THE INDIVIDUAL RECEIVING SERVICE
SUPPORT IS NOT A QUALITY
RELATIONSHIP THAT IS SUSTAINED --
CONSISTENTLY OVER TIME AND THE
BEST WAY TO HAVE THAT SUSTAINING
IS TO RECONNECT ACOSTA SERVICES
WITH THE RATES PAID FOR SERVICES.
SARCASM FIVE OVERALL -- THEMES
WE'D LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER THE
FIRST A SIMILAR TO THE LAST
SPEAKERS.
DO NO HARM IT SOUNDS SIMPLE BUT
WITHOUT CAREFUL CONSIDERATION OF
THE IMPACTS OF NEW RATES IN NEW
RATE SETTING METHODOLOGY IS THE
LOSS OF SERVICE OPTIONS.
AND SPACES IN THE SHORT TERM
SEEMS LIKELY AFTER DECADES OF
UNDERFUNDING. TO ELIMINATE
SERVICE OPTIONS WITHOUT
INCUBATING A NEW SERVICE WITH
DIVERSE AND SUSTAINABLE OPTIONS
MAY LEAVE INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SERVICES.
SECONDLY LET'S CHARTER PASSED
PATH TO THE GREATEST GOOD WHEN
IN AND OUT BURGER HAS STRONGER
STARTING WAGES AND BENEFITS AND
PROVIDER AGENCIES CAN OFFER
THERE IS SOMETHING FUNDAMENTAL
FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG WITH THE
FUNDING METHODOLOGIES.
WE ASK DIRECT SERVICE STAFF TO
HOLD THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF AN
INDIVIDUAL IN THEIR HANDS
SOMETIMES LITERALLY.
AND WE ARE ABLE TO COMPENSATE
THEM LASSEN FLIPPING BURGERS.
WE NEED TO BETTER RATE WE NEED
BETTER RATES TO RECOGNIZE AND
PROFESSIONAL LIVES WORKFORCE.
THIRDLY -- LET'S TRY TO CREATE A
REAL SUPPORT OPTIONS AND CHOICES
THAT IS I INCLUDES INCREASED
CAPACITY FLEXIBILITY AND
INNOVATION.
INTO THE NEW RATE SETTING
METHODOLOGY THE POINT.
THIS POINT HERE IS THE HEART OF
WHAT IS BEST ABOUT THIS UNIQUE
CIVIL RIGHTS HUMAN SERVICE LAW
WE CALL THE LANHAM ACT REMOVING
FLEXIBILITY TO MEET INDIVIDUAL'S
NEEDS WITH AN ARRAY OF SUPPORT
OPTIONS STRIKES AT THE HEART OF
OUR SYSTEM.
FOURTH IN THIS DAY AND AGE WE
MUST ENHANCE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY BUT LET TO DO IT IN
A WAY THAT DOESN'T MAKE THE
SERVICE SYSTEM RICHARD AND
AVERSE TO RISKS AND INNOVATION.
THE BURNS MODEL IS AT BASE A
GOOD APPROACH IN THIS REGARD IT
LETS EVERYONE SEE THE BUILDING
BLOCKS OF THE COSTS PERSONNEL
OCCUPANCY TRAVEL LEADERSHIP
PICKS THAT ARE -- THAT MAKE UP
EACH RATE FOR EACH SERVICE.
NOW THE BURDEN IS ON ALL OF US
TO MAKE SURE THOSE BUILDING
BLOCKS ARE SOUND AND THAT THE
RATES STRUCTURES A REALISTIC AND
SUSTAINABLE.
AND OUR FIFTH AND FINAL TEN AND
IS TO LOOK TO THE FUTURE AS WE
CONSTRUCT THIS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOUNDATION OF OUR
SYSTEM.
MANY OF US HAVE HAD A FRONT ROW
SEAT AND WATCHING THE EROSION OF
OUR BRILLIANTLY CONCEIVED SYSTEM
AS RATES HAVE STAGNATED AND THEN
WORK DECIMATED IN THE GREAT
RECESSION.
MORE INDIVIDUAL IN FAMILIES ARE
UNDERSERVED.
A SMALLER ARRAY OF OPTIONS OF
NEEDED SERVICES EXISTENCE
SOMETIMES NO SERVICES EXIST AT
ALL ESPECIALLY IN HIGH COST
AREAS.
THAT WE KNOW CAN HAVE A PROFOUND
EFFECT ON THE TRAJECTORY OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S LIFE.
IN CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING SERIOUSLY
RATE REFORM THIS EFFORT.
I BELIEVE AND WE BELIEVE WILL IN
LARGE MEASURE DETERMINE WHAT
KIND F FUTURE THOSE WE SERVE
WILL HAVE.
IN THE STATE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS -- NO WE'RE GONNA
BRING UP -- ANOTHER PANEL
THERE'S FOUR SO WE HAVE TO MOVE
PEOPLE AROUND SO WE CAN -- HAVE
FOR SEATED THERE -- SO -- WILL
BRING UP -- REBEKAH LENARD WITH
THE TIER OF THE SOUL FOUNDATION --
DOCTOR DIANE CLAY WITH
PROFESSIONAL CHILD DEVELOPMENT
ASSOCIATES RULE WITH PATH POINT
AND JACQUI DILLARD FOSS BUT STEP
THE CORPORATE.
SO NEED FOR SEATS THERE.
RIGHT THERE.
OKAY. SEVEN AND ASK IF YOU CAN
THE CHECK KEEP REMARKS TWO
WITHIN THREE MINUTES APPRECIATED
SO.
RIGHT SO WE'LL GO AHEAD SPENT
START WITH MS LEONARD.
WELCOME.
GREAT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS REBECCA LINE HARD AND
I'M CO THE TIERED ALSO
FOUNDATION WE PROVIDE A WIDE
RANGE OF SERVICES FOR
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MEN AND WOMEN SERVED
ACROSS LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
I ALSO SERVICE CO CHAIR OF THE
LOS ANGELES COALITION OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
WHICH COLLECTIVELY SERVICE MORE
THAN TWENTY ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE
NEARLY ACROSS NEARLY ALL AGES
AND SERVICE NEEDS.
OUR SERVICES COVER INFANTS TO
AGING ADULTS INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT
LIMITED TO GROUP HOMES SOARED
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT SUPPORTED
LIVING ADULT DAY SERVICES AND SO
FORTH.
THE L. O. CO LA COALITION
EMPLOYEES OVER SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES TO DELIVER
THIS WIDE ARRAY OF INNOVATIVE
AND UNIQUE SERVICES.
AND IN DOING SO WE INTERACT WITH
TWELVE WITH THE TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE INDIVIDUAL SERVICE
PLANS BASED ON THE INDIVIDUAL
PLANNING PROCESS.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE RATE STUDY
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS -- TO
DIRECTLY SERVE PEOPLE AND WITH
HIM OUR STATE REALIZE. TO MEET
ITS STATUTORY AND ETHICAL
RESPONSIBILITIES TO PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES -- I WE HAVE
BASICALLY THREE OVER ARCHING --
AREAS THAT WE'D LIKE TO DRAW
ATTENTION -- TO MAINLY IT'S THE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED WITH IN THE STUDY AND
THAT THOSE ASSUMPTIONS NEED TO
BE FULLY.
THAT IT BEFORE ADOPTED WE HAVE
PROVIDED A SIXTY FIVE PAGE
RESPONSE -- TO THE DEPARTMENT
INTO BURNS AND ASSOCIATES.
FOR A CONSIDERATION.
OUR FIRST AND MOST EGREGIOUS
ASSUMPTION IN THE STUDY THAT WE
BELIEVE IS THE D. S. P. WAGE --
RATE -- AND THE B. S. I'LL BE LS
DOT AND WHICH WAS DEVELOPED.
MORE THAN 80% OF ALL THE FUNDING --
THAT WE HAVE IS DEVOTED TO
IMPLANT A WORK FORCE TO PROVIDE
MANAGING COORDINATE DIRECT
SUPPORT -- FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
THEY'RE FORGETTING THIS
ASSUMPTION RIGHT AT THE START
MUST BE AT THE FOREFRONT OF ALL
WE DO.
CURRENTLY THE RATE STUDY BILLS
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
ON BASICALLY -- FOR A LEVEL
EXPECTATIONS FOR PEOPLE'S LIVES
FAR EXCEED THIS BASIC CUSTODIAL
CARE.
IN THE SETTINGS RULE ITSELF IT
STATES THAT WE SHOULD PROVIDE
ELIGIBLE PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES FULL ACCESS TO THE
BENEFITS OF COMMUNITY LIVING AND
OFFER THEM A LONG TERM SUPPORT
SERVICES IN THE MOST INTEGRATED
SETTING OF THEIR CHOOSING.
THE LETTERMAN ACT ITSELF STATES
PEOPLE DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES
AND THEIR FAMILIES HAVE A RIGHT
TO GET SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THE
NEED
TO LIVE LIKE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE DISABILITIES.
IF THE RATES OF REIMBURSEMENT
ARE SENATE TOILETING BEATING AND
FEEDING THEN WE MUST ASK
OURSELVES IF THE END RESULT WILL
BE TO CREATE A SYSTEM THAT WILL
ONLY SPEED AND WAREHOUSE PEOPLE.
RATHER THAN A INNOVATIVE AND
NIBBLED NETWORK OF SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES DESIGNED TO FOSTER
INDEPENDENCE INCREASE AND
EMPLOYABILITY.
THE LA COALITION HAS PROVIDED AN
ALTERNATIVE D. S. P. WAGE BASED
ON DEALS BLS DATA.
THAT MIRRORS THE DUTIES AND
EXPECTATIONS OF THIS WORK FORCE
WHO GOT.
DONE.
YES WITH THAT TWO MINUTES YOUR
THREE MINUTES AFTER THREE
MINUTES NOW OKAY.
RIGHT.
THAT WAS OUR MOST EGREGIOUS ONE
SAID THE DS AT THE D. S. P.
WAGES IF WE CAN FOCUS ON THAT.
OKAY YET TO OTHER I DID HE JUST
SAY WHAT THEY ARE REGULARLY AND
YOU HAVE THREE OTHER PANEL
MEMBERS ANYTIME ON THAT.
NATION OF SERVICE CATEGORIES --
IS REALLY CRITICALLY IMPORTANT --
TO FOR OUR COALITION ALONE IT
WILL BE ELIMINATION OF MANY.
AND AGAIN -- BACK TO WHAT IS
ALREADY BEEN SAID AND THAT IS
TAKE TIME TO FULLY THAT THE
STUDY BEFORE -- ANY HARM
COMPRISED OF THE PERSONAL
SUPPORT OF SUPPORTED LIVING
INDEPENDENT LIVING AND RESPITE.
THESE SERVICES COMPRISE OF MORE
THAN 55% OF TH DDS CASELOAD AND
WE KIND OF GAVE YOU THAT
DOCUMENT DIRECTLY FROM THE FACT
SHEET FROM DDS.
WE BELIEVE THE WORK CONDUCTED BY
BURGE ASSOCIATE AND DEVELOPING
RATE TO SOUND AND THE PROCESS
STRIVE TO DEVELOP TRANSPARENT
RATE STRUCTURES WHAT WE BELIEVE
A CRITICAL ASPECT OF ALL OF THIS
IS THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE RATES.
IS THE POLICY DECISIONS ON HOW
WE GUIDE OURSELVES AND WE ENACT
THESE RATES CALIFORNIA IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO SEIZE THE
MOMENT OF THIS STUDY AND USE
THIS NEW STRUCTURE.
NOT JUST TO MAINTAIN THE STATUS
QUO BUT TO BUILD A SYSTEM THAT
EMPHASIZES VALUES AND INDIVIDUAL
OUTCOMES AND CHOICE.
HOW THESE MODELS ARE IMPLEMENTED
WILL BE INDICATIVE OF THE KIND
OF CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO HAVE
FOR A FUTURE?
NATIONALLY COLLECTED DATA SHOWS
THAT INDEPENDENT LIVING AND
SUPPORTIVE LIVING SERVICES HAVE
BEEN INCREASING 3%.
ACROSS ALL STATES.
THIS IS BEEN OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS THESE ARE THE CHOSEN
PROGRAMS WE APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION OF THAT AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
BUT WE DO AGREE WITH THE BLS
DATA AROUND INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES WE HAVE THE SUBMITTED
COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO THAT.
AND WE NEED TO WORK WITH BURKE
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS MORE
WE ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
PART OF THAT CONTINUUM IS
RESPITE.
AND INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES
THESE PROGRAMS WORK HAND IN HAND
FROM CHILD TO THOSE WHO MAY NOT
NEED AS MUCH SUPPORT ALL OF
THESE ARE H. CBS COMPLIANT
PROGRAMS.
RESPITE ADMIN RATE WAS REMOVED
IN A AN EMPLOYER OF RECORD AND
THAT SHOULD BE BACK AND THE
OTHER THING IS -- WE DID READ
THE LA OWES -- INFORMATION IN
REGARDS TO SUPPORT A LIVING
SERVICES WE DO BELIEVE THAT
MOVING FOR WITH AN HOURLY RATE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES HAS ALREADY DONE SO
WITH -- SAN ANDREAS REGIONAL
CENTER GOLDEN GATE REGIONAL
CENTER AND ALL TO CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL CENTER IN NORTH BAY
AUDITOR'S DO NOT LIKE.
RATES THAT ARE NOT HOURLY WE ARE
ACCESS WE WERE TOLD ACCESS TO
GENERIC RESOURCE I HSS THAT IS
HOURLY AND YET WE HAVE COMPLETE
COMPLICATED CONVOLUTED RATE
STRUCTURES.
AT HOURLY RATE SEEMS TO BE THE
RATE THAT NEEDS TO BE HAPPENING
SO WE APPRECIATE THAT THAT WAS
RECOMMENDED AND THE BIRDS AND
ASSOCIATES -- I THINK THAT PART
OF THIS IS ALSO.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SAID
CALIFORNIA SICK I'VE BEEN
TALKING TO YOU AS A DOCTOR WE
ARE SICK LET'S DO RATE STUDY.
SO YOU HAD A RATE STUDY DONE
YOU'VE BEEN GIVEN A PRESCRIPTION.
THE QUESTION IS IS ARE YOU TO
FILL THE PRESCRIPTION OR WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO IGNORE ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS WE
ARE DOING A DROP SMALL STEP
FORWARD WE ALL HAVE ISSUES
AROUND HOW WE WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD WE'VE GOT TO MOVE
FORWARD.
YOU'VE GOT TO MOVE THIS DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS FORWARD
THIS RATE IS IT ACCEPTABLE IT'S
NOT ACCEPTABLE IS IT BETTER THAN
WHAT WE HAVE WHICH IS A PATHETIC
THING FOR US ALL SAY.
AND I THINK MY DIRECT SUPPORT
WILL ASK YOU TODAY IS THAT MY
WORTH AND I SEE THE TIME OUTSIDE
YOU LEARN SOME SIGN LANGUAGE
THAT'S VERY GOOD.
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PRACTICING.
WELCOME RIGHT THANK YOU I ABOUT
THREE MINUTES TALK ABOUT DAY
EMPLOYMENT TRANSPORTATION SO AGO
QUICK I APPRECIATE THERE'S A LOT
OF GOOD THINGS IN THE STUDY
WE'RE DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
COMMENTS FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS
THEN GET INCLUDED BEFORE WENT
TWO YEARS SO WE'RE GOING TO
SHARE SOME OF THOSE WITH.
YOU SO ONE DAY PROGRAMS A FEW
QUICK THINGS COMPLEXITY THE
STUDY IS BIKE WERE RUNNING --
WORKING ON A BASEBALL FIELD NOW
AND NOW IT'S A CRICKET MATCH SO
IT'S SAYING FEEL THE LOOKS
SIMILAR THE RULES ARE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT SO QUICK EXAMPLE I
USED TO HAVE SOMEONE COME RIGHT
PROGRAM THAT WE HAD ONE RATE FOR
SIX HOURS NOW THE SAME PERSON
COMES.
I RATE FOR THE FOUR HOURS THERE
WITH US I HAVE A DIFFERENT RATE
FOR THE TWO HOURS THEY GO IN THE
COMMUNITY I HAVE A ONE ON ONE
AID FOR MEALS WITH THE NEW RATE
I HAVE A A BEHAVIORAL EIGHT FOR
TWO HOURS WITH THE NEW RATE.
IT'S GOOD STUFF BUT BOY IT'S
GOING TO TAKE A LONG TIME TO
LAYER ALL THE STUFF IN TO REDO
INDIVIDUAL PLANS FOR EVERY
SINGLE PERSON.
FIGURE OUT THE SYSTEMS TO MAKE
THAT WORK SECOND WE HAVE A LOT
OF INDIVIDUAL ASSUMPTIONS WITHIN
CURRENT CORRECT THEY HAVE ABOUT
A HUNDRED PAGES OF NOTES FOR YOU.
ON THAT THE WILL PASS NOT TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED PAGES LIKE THE RATE
STUDY BUT WE'RE GETTING THERE
THERE'S A MISSING SERVICES THAT
REBEKAH TOUCHED ON PROJECTS
SEARCHES AND IN THERE.
WE HAVE A LOT O PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND ONE TO FOUR RATIO
IS THAT'S NO LONGER ALLOWED WE
THINK THAT NEEDS TO GET FIXED
AND THEN THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
WITH A PROGRAMS IS THE RATE FOR
THE DSP.
THAT WERE BACK I GOT INTO THIS
BUT THE INDIVIDUAL THE IT'S A
PHILOSOPHICAL APPROACH TO THE
RATE STUDY SAYS WE'RE ABOUT TO
STUDIO CARE FOR ABOUT FEEDING
PEOPLE HOUSING PEOPLE AND JUST
TAKING CARE THEIR BASIC NEEDS WE
AS PROVIDERS WOULD SAY WE'RE
ABOUT HELPING PEOPLE BECOME
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT APPROACH
OUR VISION IS THAT OUR APPROACH
LEADS TO LESS NEED FOR STATE
SUPPORT ON AN ONGOING BASIS
BECAUSE PEOPLE MOVING TO
INDEPENDENCE AND PLAY BILLION
PLAYING TAXES.
THE RATE STUDY PUSHES US OUT A
MODEL JUST ONGOING CUSTODIAL
CARE FOR FOR KIND EVER MORE --
IN TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT.
ARE WE LIKE THAT THEIR RATES FOR
JOB DEVELOPMENT IN THERE.
THERE ARE SOME REAL ASSUMPTIONS
THAT ARE WRONG SO WE'RE SAYING
CALIFORNIA'S UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
STATE BUT RIGHT NOW THE NEW RATE
PROPOSES LOWER.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE LESS
RESOURCES FOR THIS BUT THERE IF
IT'S BECAUSE THEIR ASSUMPTIONS
THE WRONG SO TOO QUICK
ASSUMPTIONS ONE IS THAT THEY DO
INCLUDE ANY SUPERVISION EVERY
SERVICE NEED SUPERVISION
EVERYTHING ELSE INCLUDED IT IT
MUST OF BEEN AN OVERSIGHT THE
SECOND IS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE REQUIRES.
A REST BREAKS UNINTERRUPTED REST
BREAK SMALL THING IT'S NOT IN
THE STUDY WE HAVE TO DO THOSE BY
LAW CHANGE THOSE TWO THINGS THE
RATE GOES UP 17%.
SOME OTHER ASSUMPTIONS THAT ARE
WRONG THEY'VE ELEVEN MINUTES PER
DAY TRAVEL TIME WE REQUIRE IT'S
A LOT MORE IN REALITY.
THE DSP WAGES WRONG
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD HAVE BEN
CUT 212% FIX ALL THOSE PROBLEMS
THE RATE GOES UP 69% SO THERE
ARE SOME REAL THINGS THEY CAN
ADJUST THESE RATES THAT NEED TO
GET FACTORED IN IN THE COMMENTS
AND HOPEFULLY DDS WILL ISSUE A
NEW.
REVISED VERSION OF THAT AND THEN
LASTLY QUICKLY ON TRANSPORTATION.
I TALKED TO A PROVIDER WHO WHO
DOES THIS HE SAYS THEY PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION FOR THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE THE NEW RATES WILL CAUSE
THEM TO LOSE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY JUST ON
TRANSPORTATION.
THEY WOULD STOP ALL
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES AND
WE'VE HEARD THAT ANECDOTALLY
FROM A LOT OF OTHERS SO THERE
ARE SOME THINGS THAT NEED TO GET
LOOKED AT IN THE TRANSPORTATION
FILTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS THAT.
THERE YOU GO GOOD AFTERNOONMY
NAME IS DOCTOR DIANE COLONNE NOW
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON.
I'M A PEDIATRICIAN WITH THE SUB
SPECIALTY AND NARROW
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS MY
CONCERN WITH THE PROPOSED
CHANGES SPECIFICALLY TO EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICE CODE --
EIGHT OH FIVE PER WHICH PROVIDE
SERVICES TO CHILDREN FROM BIRTH
TO THIRTY SIX MONTHS EITHER AT
HOME OR IN A CENTER BASED
PROGRAM.
JUST A LITTLE BACKGROUND ABOUT
ME I DID MY INTERNSHIP AND
RESIDENCY AT KAISER FELLOWSHIP
AT UCLA I WORKED IN A VARIETY OF
SETTINGS INCLUDING CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES LA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND PARTICULARLY AS A PHYSICIAN
WITH THE REGIONAL CENTER -- I'M
NOW AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
NONPROFIT AGENCY THAT PROVIDES
SERVICES TO CHILDREN BIRTH
THROUGH TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE.
AND WE DO HAVE AN EIGHT OH FIVE
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAM THAT
WE'VE HAD FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS.
SO HAVE A LOT OF YEARS IN THIS
FIELD.
OVER THE YEARS -- BEST PRACTICES
FOR EARLY INTERVENTION HAVE BEEN
WELL ESTABLISHED ESPECIALLY THE
PRACTICE OF INTERDISCIPLINARY
WORK.
OVER TIME DUE TO LACK OF FUNDING
CHANGES IN ELIGIBILITY OF OTHER
PEOPLE OF ALLUDED.
TO MANY EARLY INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS OF HAD TO CLOSE.
NOW THE PROPOSED RATE STRUCTURE
I BELIEVE IS ANOTHER THREAT TO
EARLY INTERVENTION.
IT PROPOSES PROPOSES TO DIVIDE
FUNDING INTO SEPARATE SERVICES.
INSTEAD OF ONE EIGHT OH FIVE WE
WOULD NOW HAVE EARLY
INTERVENTION TEACHERS A RATE FOR
SUPERVISORS AND ONE FOR EACH
TYPE OF SPECIALIST IN ADDITION
IT WOULD BE FURTHER DIVIDED BY
THE RATIO.
OF ONE TO ONE ONE TWO TWO OR ONE
TO THREE JUST AS AN EXAMPLE IN
OUR EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAM
OUR TEAM INCLUDES.
DEVELOPMENTAL INTERVENTIONIST AT
THE BACHELOR'S LEVEL THE MASTERS
LEVEL LICENSED PROFESSIONALS
FROM.
SPEECH LANGUAGE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ART THERAPY MUSIC
THERAPY PSYCHOLOGY MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPY SOCIAL WORK
DIETITIANS NURSING AND MYSELF IN
PEDIATRICS.
OUR STAFF WORK AS A TEAM WE
PROVIDE THE CURRICULUM WE
ADDRESS ISSUES WITH FROM EACH
DISCIPLINARY PERSPECTIVE AS THEY
OCCUR.
ALL OF THE TEAM MEMBERS PLAN
TRAIN WORK TOGETHER CREATED
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING
TREATMENT PLAN AND REPORT FOR
EACH CHILD AND FAMILY.
IMAGINE THAT FOR EACH CHILD
INSTEAD OF FUNDING A PROGRAM
THERE WOULD BE SEPARATE PRE
AUTHORIZATIONS AND BILLING FOR
EACH OF THE DISCIPLINES INVOLVED.
WHICH LEADS TO SEPARATE
TREATMENT PLANS IN SEPARATE
REPORTS THIS DOES NOT WORK ON A
PRACTICAL ADMINISTRATIVE LEVEL.
IN IT TRULY UNDERMINES THE
CONCEPT OF INTER DISCIPLINARY
SERVICES.
SO IN CONCLUSION WE ALL KNOW
EARLY INTERVENTION CAN CHANGE
LIVES I WOULD HIGHLY RECOMMEND
THAT EIGHT OH FIVE SERVICE
REMAIN AS ONE UNIT.
FULLY FUNDED.
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE'VE GAINED OVER
THIRTY YEARS.
WE KNOW HOW TO PROVIDE QUALITY
COMPREHENSIVE INTERVENTION IN IN --
JUST INTERDISCIPLINARY SERVICES
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
I SHOULD MENTION.
CHRISTIAN TRAIN BUS AND
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL BEAVER
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU.
A LITTLE HOSPITAL IN BOSTON --
ANYWAY ALL RIGHT -- SO -- WE'RE
GONNA.
LET'S MOVE ON TO KALLIO YOU HAVE
A PRESENTATION AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS AND SO NAY PADDOCK FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST' OFFICE
AND YOU SHOULD HAVE A HANDOUT
THAT WILL ACCOMPANY MY REMARKS
AND I I DON'T INTEND TO HIT
EVERY POINT IN THIS HANDOUT IT'S
MORE FOR YOUR REFERENCE I'M JUST
GONNA HIT SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS --
WE WERE ASKED BY A BULLS THE
SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF AS
WELL AS THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
SUB SUB COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES -- TO REVIEW THE
RATE STUDY AND PROVIDE SOME
OPTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER ABOUT WAYS TO BEGIN.
IMPLEMENTING A RATE REFORM IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY SO -- IN
MY TALK I'M JUST GOING TO
ADDRESS THEM.
AS THE TWO OPTIONS THAT WE HAVE
PROVIDED THEN TALK ABOUT SOME
OTHER WAYS THAT YOU COULD
PROVIDE PHYSICAL RELIEF -- IN
THE COMING FISCAL YEAR IN
COMBINATION WITH -- BEGINNING
RATE REFORM AND THEN TALK ABOUT
SOME OTHER HIGH LEVEL
CONSIDERATIONS SO IF YOU TURN TO
PAGE ONE OF THE HAND OUT.
I THINK I'D I'D LIKE TO START BY
FIRST EMPHASIZING THAT THREE
STUDY REALLY PRESENTS A REAL
OPPORTUNITY -- TO TAKE
SUBSTANTIVE ACTION.
IN -- TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AS
HAS BEEN EVIDENCED BY THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AND AS WE ARE
ALL AWARE THE SYSTEM IS IN NEED
OF REFORM THE THE CURRENT RATE
SETTING PROCESS IS SOMEWHAT.
OF A CONVOLUTED AND THE RATE
STUDY.
THE RATE MODELS RATHER THAT ARE
PROPOSED IN THE RATE STUDY THAT
WAS CONDUCTED BY BURNS AND
ASSOCIATES -- ARE BOTH A
TRANSPARENT AND LOGICAL.
THEY'RE ALSO RELATIVELY EASY TO
UPDATE -- ON A REGULAR BASIS --
YOU COULD ALSO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
TO THEM BEFORE YOU EVEN BEGIN TO
IMPLEMENT THEM -- YOU KNOW
REFLECTING SOME OF THE CHANGES
THAT THE PANELISTS TALKED TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER -- AND THEY ALSO
ARE PROVIDE MORE EQUITY ACROSS.
A SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO HAVE
SIMILAR CHARACTERISTICS.
WE WOULD -- ENCOURAGE THOSE THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TO BEGIN RATE REFORM --
THERE OBVIOUSLY SOME FISCAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE CONSTRAINTS THAT
WOULD MAKE THIS DIFFICULT IF YOU
WERE TO IMPLEMENT THE STUDY
FULLY AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
IT WOULD BE ONE POINT.
NINE BILLION DOLLARS OVER WITH
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED IN JANUARY
ONE POINT TWO BILLION GENERAL
FUND -- THERE ALSO A NUMBER OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND
ADMINISTRATIVE CONSTRAINTS THAT
HAVE BEEN -- SORT OF TOUCHED
UPON ALREADY NEVER THE LESS WE
THINK THIS REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY ON THERE'S A LOT OF
SORT OF MOMENTUM FOR THIS RIGHT
NOW -- AND THE SO TO THAT END
I'M GOING TO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
THREE I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
FIRST OPTION -- THAT WE PROPOSE
FOR CALLING THIS IS STAGED
ROLLOUT THIS IS ESSENTIALLY LIKE
PHASING IN RATE MODELS IN
CERTAIN SERVICE CATEGORIES --
BASED ON OUR LIMITED
UNDERSTANDING SO FAR OF WHAT'S
PROPOSED IN THE MAIN REVISION --
THIS IS SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSING
TO DO THERE I I BELIEVE
PROPOSING SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
BUT USING THE CURRENT STATUS QUO
RATE SETTING STRUCTURE -- WHERE
IS WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS? TO
ACTUALLY START ROLLING OUT THE
PROPOSED RATE MODELS IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND IN SOME OF THE SELECT
SERVICE CATEGORIES.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE -- FOUR
WE PRESENT. FOR SERVICE
CATEGORIES THAT -- BASED ON OUR
REVIEW WE FOUND WOULD BE AMONG
THOSE THAT WOULD -- THE MOST
FEASIBLE TO IMPLEMENT IN THE
COMING FISCAL YEAR -- THEY DON'T.
REQUIRE A LOT OF CHANGES TO THE
ACTUAL SERVICE PROVIDED PROVIDED
OR THE WAY THAT THE SERVICES
BUILD -- AND THEY ALSO ARE RATE
MODELS THAT PROBABLY REQUIRE AS
THE LEAST CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
INPUTS GOING INTO THE MODELS
THERE MAY BE SOME EXCEPTIONS TO
THAT SUCH AS INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES AS WE JUST DISCUSSED
THERE MAY BE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE WAGES OPTIONS THAT GO INTO
THAT.
I'M ON PAGE FIVE OURS THE SECOND
OPTION THAT WE'RE SUGGESTING --
COULD BE CONSIDERED IS
CONDUCTING A STAGE ROLL OUT AS I
JUST DESCRIBED BUT PACKAGING IT
WITH PILOT PROJECTS IN SOME OF
THE SERVICE CATEGORIES -- THAT
ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THE STAGE
FOR ALL OUT TO TEST SOME OF
THESE -- ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTATION -- SO IT TO THAT
END WE WE SUGGESTS THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE TO TO WANT TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH A PILOT
PROJECT APPROACH.
THAT IT DO SO IN SORT OF A
LIMITED NUMBER OF REGIONAL
CENTERS MAYBE THREE TO REPRESENT
THE DIFFERENT COST AREAS AND
MAYBE WITH JUST A SMALL HANDFUL
OF PROVIDERS IN -- EACH OF THE
VARIOUS SERVICE CATEGORIES IN
THE IDEA HERE REALLY WOULD BE TO
TO TAKE SOME OFTHESE TRICKIER
CATEGORIES LIKE DAY PROGRAMS
INFANT DEVELOPMENT.
AND SEE HOW THE RATE MODELS
WOULD PLAY OUT IN THOSE
CATEGORIES AND IT WOULD PROVIDE
A LOT OF ABSURD BEST PRACTICES
AND LESSONS LEARNED BEFORE
ROLLING OUT THE THE RATE MODELS
ON A STATEWIDE BASIS -- I SHOULD
JUST MENTION TOO THAT WITH PILOT
PROJECTS THE LEGISLATURE COULD
REALLY DECIDE HOW MUCH IT WANTS
TO SPEND IT DOESN'T NEED TO BE A
HUGE AMOUNT.
THE DEPARTMENT COULD DESIGN THE
PILOT PROJECTS BASED ON THE
AMOUNT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS TO SPEND.
IF YOU TURNED OUT TO PAGE SEVEN
I JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE A LIST
OF SOME OF THE OPTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED EITHER -- BY
MEMBERS ADVOCATES EVEN ALL OUR
OFFICE.
FOR LEASE THAT -- YOU COULD
PROVIDE SOME FISCAL RELIEF UNDER
THE STATUS QUO RATE SETTING
FRAMEWORK.
AS YOU DID MAYBE THE STAGE TO
ROLL OUT -- OF OF RICK MODELS SO
A COUPLE OF THESE HAVE TO DO
WITH -- EITHER STATE STATE AND
OR LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE ISSUES
THREE OF THEM HAVE TO DO WITH
RESTORING.
OF FUNDING THAT WAS CUT DURING
THE RECESSION AND THEN THE LAST
ONE WOULD BE AN ACROSS THE BOARD
RATE INCREASE AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED
BY BOTH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL.
AS ADVOCATES -- THERE CERTAINLY
SOME PROS AND CONS TO THIS
APPROACH FOR EXAMPLE IT WOULD BE
VERY ADMINISTRATIVELY SIMPLE TO
ADMINISTER THE SAME TIME IT
MIGHT NOT BE THE MOST COST
EFFICIENT WAY TO YOU KNOW SOME
PROVIDERS MIGHT NEED.
RATE INCREASES MORE THAN OTHERS --
ADDITIONALLY -- ONE CAUTIONARY
NOTE ABOUT THIS APPROACH IS THAT --
PROVIDERS WHO RECEIVE A RATE
INCREASE HUNDRED ACROSS THE
BOARD APPROACH COULD THEN BE IN
A SITUATION WHERE THEY FACE A
RATE REDUCTION ONCE THE RATE
MODEL IS IMPLEMENTED IN THAT
SERVICE CATEGORY IN THE FUTURE.
PAGE EIGHT SPREAD JUST PROVIDES
THE ESTIMATED TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY COSTS FOR EACH OF THOSE
OPTIONS AND THEN THE TABLE ON
PAGE NINE PROVIDES THE GENERAL
FUND COST.
IF YOU WERE TO PACKAGE SOME OF
THOSE OPTIONS WITH THE STAGE
ROLL OUT OF THE RATE MODELS.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF FIGURES
THERE BUT REALLY THE TAKE AWAY
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS A
LOT OF DIFFERENT.
OPTIONS AND APPROACHES THAT IT
COULD TAKE DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH
IT WANTS.
TO SPEND ON RATE REFORM IN THE
IN THE UP COMING FISCAL YEAR.
I AM SO I WILL JUST CONCLUDE IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE TEN WITH SOME
HIGH LEVEL CONSIDERATIONS.
WE DID MENTION AT THE BEGINNING
OF BETTER I'VE MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS TALK THAT.
THERE'S SOME REAL BENEFITS TO
THE RATE MODELS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED BY BURNS AND ASSOCIATES.
THEY'RE MAYBE ALSO SOME
POTENTIAL TRADE OFFS AND JUST A
COUPLE I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT --
THE PROPOSED THREE MODELS DO NOT
CURRENTLY -- CONSIDER LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGES SPECIFICALLY MEAN
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU COULD
EASILY CHANGE THAT WHICH IS ONE
OF THE BENEFITS OF THE RATE
MODELS IS THAT THEY CAN BE
UPDATED AND CHANGED THE THE
INPUTS ARE DON'T HAVE TO BE
STATIC.
AND THEN -- AS OUR EARLIER
PANELISTS MENTIONED THERE ARE
RATE MODELS IN CERTAIN
CATEGORIES THAT MAY LEAD TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND ONE
EXAMPLE IS IN THE EARLY START
AREA -- THAT MIGHT BE ONE THAT
NEEDS ADDITIONAL DELIBERATION --
FINALLY I WOULD MENTION AS WE
STATED LAST WEEK AT THE HEARING --
WE THINK IT'LL BE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO BE AS TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE ABOUT WHICH
SERVICES IT.
BELIEVES WILL AND WILL NOT BE
COMPLIANT WITH THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES RULE
THAT TAKES EFFECT IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND HOW THE INTEND TO
USE.
RATE MODELS TO REFLECT THE THE
DEPARTMENTS PRIORITIES -- AND
WITH THAT AND HAVE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU -- ACTUALLY COMES FOR
FINANCE.
CHRIS COOK FINANCE SO.
WELL THE ADMINISTRATION AGREES
THAT YOU KNOW THERE THERE IS A
NEED IN THIS AREA THAT THE MAYOR
VISION DOES REFLECT.
THAT -- INVESTMENT IN THOSE
SERVICE AREAS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED TO HAVE THOSE NEEDS.
AND TO STABILIZE THOSE AND AND
AND THEN AGREES THAT ADDS THAT
THIS POINT IN THE SUMMER THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR A BROADER CONVERSATION ON
WHAT THIS THAT THE RATES WOULD
LOOK LIKE MOVING FORWARD SO THE
MAYOR VISION PROPOSES A MODEST
INVESTMENT.
AND AS NOTED BY THE DIRECTOR OF
EARLIER -- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
INVESTMENTS IN AN AREA THAT HIS
SISTER IS GROWN SUBSTANTIALLY
YEAR OVER YEAR.
AND SO THIS ALLOWS US TO HAVE
THAT BROADER LOOK MOVING FORWARD
AND TO REALLY EXAMINE THE RATE
STUDY AND MAKE AND MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS.
TO THE ALEJO'S -- SUGGEST
INVESTMENTS OF ACROSS THE BOARD --
IN ADDITION AS POINTED OUT IN
THE ALLEY OWES AYE DOCUMENTS
THERE IS ALSO AN INVESTMENT IN
THE MAYOR VISION -- SIMILAR --
TO RECOMMENDED BY DAILY -- WHICH
IS TO A SUSPEND THAT UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE AS WELL OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THE QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
A CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE CAN JUST FOLLOW UP
ON YOUR COMMENT YOU YOU
MENTIONED IN THE AND THEN THE
MADE THE GOVERNOR'S REVISE IT
IT'S UP A MODEST INVESTMENT --
AND I AGREED TO IT SEEMS LIKE A
VERY MODEST INVESTMENT IS --
LAST YEAR AND GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES WERE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION AND THIS YEAR ACCORDING
YOUR BUDGET IS TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOUBLE THE DAUGHTER OF A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS -- WITH THE COST OF ONE
POINT TWO BILLION IF WE ARE
ACTUALLY -- BRING SERVICES -- TO
PARK -- BASED ON THE INFORMATION
THAT THE LA -- WAS GIVEN
[inaudible]
SO.
I'VE LEARNED IN. TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS OF BEING IN THIS BUSINESS
OF ELECTED OFFICIAL THE TRIP
BUDGET REALLY WERE FRACTURE.
YOUR PRIORITIES IN YOUR VALUES
[inaudible]
AND I'M OF THE OPINION.
AS WELL AS A MAJORITY OF THE
SENATE.
ACTUALLY AS COMPACT AS CUT
EVENLY -- SPLIT [inaudible]
THAT.
THIS IS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR US-[inaudible]
AND WHY ISN'T IT A HIGHER
PRIORITY FOR THE GOVERNOR WHEN
YOU HAVE.
PEOPLE THAT NEED SERVICES THAT
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T THE AFFORD A
LOT OF GOLD PLATED.
BELT BUCKLE LOBBYIST TO COME
HERE AND AND FIGHT FOR THEM.
BUT THESE ARE THE THE PEOPLE
THAT NEED OUR SERVICES.
PROBABLY THE MOST.
YOU KNOW I'VE WE HAVE A
WONDERFUL NEW COLLEAGUE US.
SENATOR HER COTTO THIS HERE --
HER DISTRICTS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE HARDEST HIT.
AND NOT EVEN BE ABLE TO GET.
CONTRACTORS TO TAKE CARE OF SOME
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE PRECIOUS
PEOPLE WE HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
SO -- I MEAN I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO HEARING SOME OF THESE --
PROPOSALS.
BUT YOU KNOW I WOULD URGE THE
GOVERNOR TO TAKE A SECOND LOOK.
AT THIS PRIORITY AMONGST THE
MANY PRIORITIES SAID HE'S HE'S
WHERE.
AND I'M HOPING [inaudible]
THAT HE HE RECONSIDERS
[inaudible]
MARTIN'S.
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO
PEOPLE.
MY MY REGIONAL CENTER.
THEY'RE LOSING CONTRACTORS.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T CONTINUE TO
PAY THESE RATES.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT I APPRECIATE A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
WHICH IS ABOUT 10% OF WHAT WE
ACTUALLY NEED TO BRING THE RATES
UP.
AND I'VE HEARD THIS EXCUSE IN
GOVERNMENT NOW 427- YEARS OLD WE
GOT TO STUDY SOME MORE.
WE STUDY EVERYTHING TO DEATH.
IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO SUFFER.
AND SO I THINK IS A VERY.
ACTUALLY I CANNOT ALLOW WE
CANNOT HAVE ANY VERBAL WE CAN NO
CLAPPING AND CHEERING YOU CAN DO
THIS.
OKAY GOOD ALL RIGHT THAT THAT
ACTUALLY MEANS OF FLAWS IN SIGN
LANGUAGE.
YOU CAN DO THIS BUT THAT'S SORRY
NO -- NO CLAPPING HISSING DOING
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
ALL RIGHT.
I THINK WE LET LAUGHTER GO BY
THERE IS.
THE CONTINUE ON I I DON'T ME BE
OVER PASSIONATE.
BUT TO ME THIS IS ONE OF THE
MOST IF NOT THE MOST IMPORTANT --
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET.
ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING BECAUSE
WE'RE SETTING THE STAGE FOR HOW
WE'RE GOING TO TREAT THIS FORMAL
POPULATION IN THE FUTURE.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN SAY
THAT THIS CAN'T BE A HIGHER
PRIORITY WITH TWENTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS.
IN ANTICIPATED REVENUE COMING
INTO THE STATE -- TO ME IT'S
GOING TO REALLY DEFINE -- THE
GOVERNOR'S -- CARE.
AND CONCERN. FOR PEOPLE THAT.
DIDN'T GET A FAIR SHOT A LIFE
UNFORTUNATELY WITH SOME
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENTAL --
ILLNESSES THAT THEY HAVE TWO
INDOOR THEIR FAMILIES HAVE TO
WONDER IT AFFECTS OUR AYE HSS --
IT'S TIME FOR US.
TO PUT THE RHETORIC ASIDE.
IT'S TIME FOR US. TO TO DO
ACTION.
AND THE WAY WE DO ACTION AS WE
START RESTORING THESE RATES WE
SHOULD HAVE A THREE YEAR PHASE
IN WHERE WE GET TO THAT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
GENERAL FUND -- AND WE NEED TO
START THIS YEAR.
AND SO -- I HOPE THE CHOKE.
MY MESSAGE TO THE GOVERNOR THAT --
THIS IS NOT ENOUGH AND WE NEED
TO DO MORE.
RIGHT THAT AGAIN YEAH THANK YOU.
SORRY.
ALL RIGHT SIR TARA.
WELL I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
STONE OR HIS COMMENTS TODAY AND
I AGREE WITH HIM A HUNDRED AND
50% -- I THINK EIGHTY THE ONE
THING THAT I WANT YOU ALL TO
KIND OF TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
IS THAT.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS KIND OF
SCENE THIS IS WHERE FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY -- IT'S SEEN AS A
AS A LOCATION AS A PLACE THAT --
IS A LOW COST PLACE TO LIVE AND
THE REALITY IS IF YOU REALLY
LOOK AT THE AVERAGE INCOME YOU
LOOK AT THE COST OF RENT TO LOOK
AT THE COST OF HOMES.
IT'S NOT A FOR BOTTLE AFFORDABLE
AT ALL -- IT'S MAYBE NOT IF YOU
KNOW THE SAME SALARY OR AS AS AS
YOU KNOW.
THE PEOPLE -- IN FROM OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE BUT THAT
THERE'S JUSTIN AT INCOME
INEQUALITY THERE THAT THAT WE
REALLY NEED.
TO THINK ABOUT AND RECONSIDER
WILMER LOOKING AT AT AT ALL OF
IT SO JUST WANT YOU TO KIND OF
KEEP THAT IN MIND AND OF COURSE --
MORE SUPPORT IS ALWAYS GREAT.
THANK YOU.
SO.
BEGIN APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION ALSO WANT THANK THE
PANELISTS IDEA OF SEVERAL
QUESTIONS AND I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY SO FIRST OF ALL.
AND DIED SO I'M SURE I GOT THIS
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I THINK -- YOU --
DOES THAT TO IT IS SO IN TERMS
OF THE WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S FOR
POSING FOR THIS COMING YEAR SO
WE HAD SO WILL BASICALLY HAVE
THE CURRENT SYSTEM WHICH WAS Z.
PRESENTED THERE'S A LOT OF
VARIATION THERE'S A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY AND CLARITY AND AND
NOW WE HAVE THIS.
RATE STUDY WHICH YOU KNOW IT.
I THINK YOU'RE GETTING SOME
FEEDBACK IT'S LIKE ANYTHING THIS
LARGE ISN'T PERFECT AND SOME
ISSUES THAT HAVE WORKED OUT.
ARE WE LOOKING AT BUILD SO.
ARE WE E. IF WE THE THE
RESOURCES THAT WE PUT THEM ON
TOP OF THE OLD SYSTEM AND SAY
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON THE RATE
STUDY OR RESTORING THE USE TE
THIS.
THIS IS THE BASIS OF FUTURE --
OR OF STARTING THIS YEAR'S SO
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
LIKE HOW.
THE RESOURCES WE ARE DEDICATING
OF WE DO ADD MORE RESOURCES TO
THE BILL THAT ON THIS RATE STUDY
IS THE SORT OF THE FACE
FOUNDATION FOR THAT -- BECAUSE
WE HEARD FROM THE LA -- FOR
EXAMPLE WELL WE BUILD ON THE OLD%
ONE AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT I'VE HEARD LOTS OF HOLD
HARMLESS BUT NOW WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT IS.
THOSE WERE DURING THE TRANSITION --
WHAT SHOULD BE THE THIRTY
UNDERLYING?
IT'LL STRUCTURAL BASE OF OF OF%
OF OF ANY SORT OF FAT FUNDING
WHICH WE CLEARLY -- I THINK
PEOPLE EXPRESS WE NEEDED SO.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN ON LOOKING
AT THE ASSUMPTIONS WHEN AND THAT
PROJECTION WITH THE WITHIN THE
SERVICES THAT I HAD OUTLINED --
THE WILD AND THE RATE MODELS OF
IMPLEMENTATION AS LA -- HAD
PRESENTED IS IS CERTAIN OPTIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
WAS NOT PART OF THE ASSUMPTIONS
IN LOOKING AT THE FISCAL
PROJECTIONS.
OF THE KIND OF METHODOLOGY AN
ALLOCATION HOWEVER LOOKING AT
INFORMATION FROM THE RATE STUDY
YOU KNOW THAT INFORMED KIND OF
THE ELEMENTS OF IT -- WAS
PARTISAN THE ASSUMPTIONS IN AND
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW TO DO SOME --
PROJECTED ALLOCATION SO THE I'LL
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE WHEN WE TAKE
A LOOK AT THEY SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICES AND KNOWINGTHAT
THERE'S WITHIN THE RATE STUDY
THAT IF.
OF PARTICULARS REGIONAL CENTER --
WOULD HAVE BEEN PROJECTED AT A
CERTAIN RATE -- ADJUSTMENT AS
COMPARED TO ANOTHER ONE KIND OF
FACTORY AND FACTORING IN THOSE
DIFFERENCES -- IF YOU WELL KINDA
WAITING IT -- WOULD KINDA HELP
MOVE THE NEEDLE TOWARDS
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE IN
EQUITIES BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT
REGIONAL CENTERS.
AS A THAT ASSUMPTION WAS BUILT
IN INTO TRAIN TO TAKE A LOOK AT
ON AN AVERAGE --THE FISCAL
PROJECTION WOULD BE AT ABOUT 18% --
ADJUSTMENT OVER EXISTING RATES
THAT SAID THAT WOULD BE VARIABLE
BASED ON THE DIFFERENT REGIONAL
CENTERS DIFFERENT PROVIDERS --
CONSIDERING SOME OF THOSE --
ELEMENTS THAT DO YOU.
IMPACT THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN.
PROVIDER RATE I'M SORRY FOR IT
IT'S SOMEWHAT COMPLICATED BUT IT
IS IT'S TAKING ELEMENTS THAT
INFORMED US TO BE ABLE TO APPLY
SO IT WOULDN'T JUST BE
PERPETUATING.
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO PERPETUATE BUT NOT
FULLY IMPLEMENTING A MODEL.
OKAY SO SERVE SOMETHING IN
BETWEEN.
THE HYBRID HYBRID IT'S IT'S IT'S
TAKING ELEMENTS THAT'S
INFORMATIVE TO US -- BUT NOT
IMPLEMENTING THE MODEL THAT WE
WE WANT TO USE THE INFORMATION --
TO CONSIDERATE AT ADDRESSING --
PRIORITIES OKAY SO BECAUSE I
THINK IT ALSO IN TERMS OF
SENDING.
I GUESS I'LL CALL SIGNAL OR
SITTING WHAT THE EXPECTATIONS
ARE.
AT WHAT POINT AGAIN RECOGNIZING
THEIR STILL NEEDS TO BE A LOT
MORE STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND
THERE'S SOME ADJUSTMENTS AND AND
I HAVE SOME MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT
SOME OF THE ASSUMPTIONS AND SO
FORTH THE AT WHAT POINT.
DO YOU ANTICIPATE SWITCHING OVER
TO SAYING THAT AND AGAIN I
REALIZE YOU MAY YOU KNOW YOU MAY
TWO THINGS IT'S AT RIGHT NOT
ONLY WITH THE RATES A SELF BUT
WITH EXACTLY WHAT YOU DO BUT
WHEN YOU SAY THIS IS IN THE
MIDDLE.
AT SOME POINT DO YOU TELL PEOPLE
LIKE ACTUALLY THE BASE
ASSUMPTIONS ARE THE BASIS IS
GOING TO BE.
RELATED TO THE METHODOLOGY
DEVELOPED FOR I DON'T TOLERATE
STUDY ANYMORE AT ALL THIS
BECAUSE IT WOULD PASS THE STUDY
PHASE RIGHT WE ACTUALLY THIS IS
NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WAR WE
CAN IMPLEMENT IT OR NOT -- SO
THE RATE PROPOSAL ORDER RATE
STRUCTURE -- BECAUSE NO LONGER
JUST THE STUDY SO WHAT POINT DO
WE SAY IS INTENTION TO SAY WELL
OKAY FOR NOW THIS IS THE
FOUNDATION ON WHICH WE BUILD.
WHETHER IT'S INCREASES ARE AT
CENTER -- AND DISS THE
METHODOLOGY WHICH WE'RE NOW
BRACING IS BEING THE WAY WE'RE
GOING TO HANDLE PAYMENTS GOING
FORWARD.
SO AS I WAS SAYING EARLIER THAT --
AN IMPORTANT PART OF LOOKING AT
THIS NEXT STEP IS THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE'RE HAVING THIS SUMMER.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING BROAD AS FAR AS THE NOT
ONLY THE RATE STUDY BUT THE
SYSTEM AND EVERY KIND OF EVERY
ELEMENT INTO IT.
SO SO AS FAR AS THOSE NEXT STEPS
THE IMPORTANT PART OF THAT IS
DEFINITELY HAVING THAT VERY
TARGETED DISCUSSION OVER THE
SUMMER ON THE THINGS THAT ARE
REALLY INFLUENCING THIS AND AND
EVERYTHING THAT YOU HEARD TODAY.
NO NO IT HAS TO BE PART OF IT
YOU DID I HEAR DISCUSSION
OBVIOUSLY DISCUSSIONS VERY
IMPORTANT AND THEN CHANGES WILL
BE MADE BASED ON THE DISCUSSIONS
BUT AS THE GOAL LIKE BY NEXT
YEAR FOR PHILLY OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S GONNA BE ADJUSTMENTS OR
CHANGES MADE BASED ON THE
FEEDBACK. TO TRY TO MOVE TOWARD
A SITUATION WHERE WE'RE SAYING
THAT THIS IS GONNA NOW BECAUSE
THE BASE AND I REALIZE THERE
MIGHT BE THINGS YOU DO CUTS
CLEANERS AND SO FORTH AS YOUR
TRAIN TRANSITION OVER BUT THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY WE MADE THE
DECISION THIS IS THE NEW MODEL.
SO TO DISCUSSIONS YOU KNOW WE WE
APPRECIATE THAT THAT THAT WE'RE
NOT WANTING TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
FOR THE PURPOSE OF HAVING
ANOTHER DISCUSSION RIGHT YOU
KNOW BUT WHAT IS THE PATH WHAT
IS THAT PATH FORWARD.
YOU KNOW AND AND AND THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE --
TO OBTAIN CLARITY YOU KNOW TO BE
ABLE TO GOAL BY NEXT YEAR TO
SERVE AT LEAST I MEAN YOU HAVE A
STUDY RIGHT YEAH I CONSULT NEED
TO STUDY YOU'RE GETTING YOUR
CALL BACK FROM PEOPLE.
CORRECT THE GOAL WOULD
DEFINITELY BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CLEAR PATH AS TO WHAT THOSE NEXT
STEPS ARE TO WHAT THOSE.
THOSE ARE.
WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION OKAY WELL I I GUESS
IS THERE GOING TO BE AND YOU
PAYMENT METHODOLOGY ESSENTIALLY.
BASED ON THE DISCUSSIONS THAT WE
HAVE WE WILL HAVE AN WILL BE
ABLE TO HAVE MORE CLARITY AS TO
WHAT.
APPROACH OR METHODOLOGIES WILL
BE DOING THAT TODAY WE DON'T
HAVE THAT ANSWER BECAUSE WE DO
NEED TO HAVE THAT BROADER
DISCUSSION -- AND WE'RE PREPARED
TO DO THAT OVER THE SUMMER
APPRECIATE.
KEEPING A SURPRISE TO THE A THE
I I THINK.
BY THE AT SOME POINT -- WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO THE EIGHTH AT SOME
POINT.
WE'RE GONNA TO MAKE A DECISION
ARE YOU GONNA STICK TO THE OLD
WAY ARE WE MOVING TO THIS NEW
WAY RIGHT I WAS WE MADE THIS
INVESTMENT THE LEGISLATURE
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE MADE DALY
THAT.
YOU DID THE STUDY ETCETERA AND
EVERYONE'S GONNA GIVE THEIR
FEEDBACK AND QUESTIONS YOU SAY
WELL ACTUALLY.
THIS IS THE WAY WE'RE PLAYING TO
DO THINGS WE MAY HAVE TO MAKE
SOME CORRECTIONS RIGHT SOME
ASSUMPTIONS ARE RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA KILL MAYBE NOT LIBERTIES
MANY TOES AT YOU BECAUSE
WHATEVER ELSE THOSE ARE KIND OF
LIKE THE FAINT BUT BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY WE GOING THIS
DIRECTION OR WE LIKE.
WELL.
WE PULLED EXCEL SOME POINT WE
GOT TO HAVE SOME CLARITY
ANYTHING PEOPLE NEED SOME
CLARITY WHETHER YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE DIFFERENT OPINIONS ABOUT WE
SHOULD DO BUT SOMEBODY AT THE
SAVE WELL WE'RE GONNA MAKE A
DECISION WHICH WAY WE'RE GOING
TO SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW HOW TO
PLAN MOVING FORWARD.
AND ALSO SAME HERE TO IN TERMS
OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO.
OUR OUR PAYMENTS I THINK THAT'S
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM LA AS WELL.
YES AND I I WOULD JUST ADD ON TO
THAT POINT THAT I THINK IT'S
IT'S GOING TO BE CHALLENGING I
MEAN THEY'RE GOING TO BE GROWING
PAINS ASSOCIATED WITH MOVING TO
A NEW RATE SETTING METHODOLOGY
AND IT'S ALSO GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO ANTICIPATE.
EVERY SINGLE POLICY REGULATORY
GUIDANCE LIKE EVERY CHANGE THAT
MIGHT NEED TO BE MADE AHEAD OF
TIME AND AT SOME POINT.
YOU HAVE TO JUMP IN AND SEE HOW
IT PLAYS OUT AND MAYBE MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS ALONG THE WAY I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T WANT TO PUT
ANYONE AT RISK.
GOING TO GET INTO LEGAL
CHALLENGES OR OR THAT SORT OF
THING BUT YOU COULD CONTINUE TO
STUDY THIS PROBABLY INSTEAD
NEVER.
REACH THE PERFECT SOLUTION SO --
WELL I MEAN I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING AND ANY IS IS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THIS WILL BE STILL
INVOLVING IT'S OUR AND
ADJUSTMENTS AND THINGS WILL
CHANGE IN ENVIRONMENT TO SELL.
BUT SORT OF I THINK THIS SOUNDS
TO ME LIKE YOU FROM YOUR
PRESENTATION FROM READING THINGS
THAT.
THERE ARE TWO VERY DIFFERENT
WAYS OF DOING THINGS THE WAY
WE'RE DOING NOW WHICH THERE'S
NOT A LOT TRANSPARENCY AND
THERE'S A LOT OF VARIABILITY AND
NOT ALL OF ITS HISTORY JUSTIFIED.
AND THEN WE'RE TRYING TO COME
WITH A MORE SYSTEMATIC WAY OF
DOING THINGS.
THERE ARE SOME WINNERS AND
LOSERS THERE SO PEOPLE MAY NOT
BE SO HAPPY WITH THAT EITHER BUT
JUST.
TELL AND AND NOT SAYING THAT.
WE HAVE A PERFECT SYSTEM EITHER
THE EACH ONE COULD OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT WAYS TO SELL ITEMS
THAT I HOPE THAT -- THERE THAT
WE CAN MAKE SOME PROGRESS IN
FIGURING THAT OUT THOUGH.
TELL OKAY -- AND THEN I CAN DO
SO SOME OF THE MORE SPECIFIC.
QUESTIONS ABOUT SO WE HEARD FROM
SOME OF THE PRESENTERS FOR
EXAMPLE -- LIKE ON THE LABOR
SIDE RATE WE HAVE.
CERTAIN LABOR RULES IN PLACE --
THERE TO PROTECT WORKERS AND SO
FORTH -- SO CLEARLY WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT MINIMUM WAGE BUT THINGS
LIKE BREAKS AND SO FORTH THAT
AND THE LEASE IT WAS REPORTED
THAT THEY FELT LIKE THAT THAT
WASN'T REALLY INCORPORATED INTO
THE METHODOLOGY IS.
LIKE MAYBE CAN PERHAPS THAT YOUR
TECHNICAL EXPERT CAN SPEAK -- TO
TO TO TO THAT ISSUE -- THAT WAS
REYES SO IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
USING THE BLS VERSES O OTHER
TYPES OF WAYS OF LOOKING AT
THINGS OF YOU.
OF OF COURSE SENATOR PAN AND AND
ALL HAVE -- OUR CONSULTING GO
AHEAD AND AND RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTION REGARDING SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE INCLUDED THE
KIND OF TECHNICAL PIECES OF IT --
BUT I DO WANT TO ALSO JUST --
SHARE WHICH I THINK IT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING BUT I DO WANT TO
ALSO GIVE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF KIND OF THAT INPUT.
YOU KNOW HAVING THE INPUT --
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE SOME
OF THOSE COMMENTS.
TODAY YOU KNOW THIS IS PRETTY
CONSISTENT WITH SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT -- THAT THE
COMMUNITY HAS SHARED ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK HAS BEEN A VALUE
IN LOOKING AT KINDA ELEMENTS OF
KIND OF THE OF TOTAL.
KIND OF PICTURE OF THE THE RATE
MODELS IS THAT THERE IS.
ELEMENTS OF IT THAT TALKS TO A
COMPENSATION PACKAGE -- AND THAT
WAS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT --
WAS IMPORTANT IN SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE ALSO RECEIVE SO
I JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT
ISN'T AS SO JUST POINT OUT YOUR
ANSWERS COOLEY WE'RE NOT WE
DON'T EITHER HAVE THE TIME AND I
HAVEN'T HAD DEAL TO GO THROUGH
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO GO THROUGH
EACH LITTLE.
DETAIL THE SERVER ON A HIGHER
LEVEL.
LIKE HOW -- HOW DID YOU APPROACH
AND GET INFORMATION ABOUT FOR
EXAMPLE BE SURELY MORE ACT
ACTUALLY REFLECT THE LABOR COSTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA GIVE?
OUR YOU KNOW OUR LAWS AND RULES
ABOUT THAT HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
I'LL TRY TO BE.
BRIEF MY ANSWER FOR WHAT WAS A
RELATIVELY COMPLICATED PORTION
OF THE ANALYSIS.
SO AS SOME OF THE PANELISTS
ALLUDED TO WE RELYON FIRST AND
FOREMOST ON DATA FROM
INDEPENDENT DATA SOURCES FOR OUR
WAGES OPTION SO PEOPLE MADE
REFERENCE TO THE BLS FOR THE
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS.
WHICH IS AN OFFICE WITHIN THE
FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF LABOR THEY
DO A EMPLOYER SURVEY.
TO GATHER INFORMATION ON CURRENT
WAGE LEVELS.
AS FOLKS INDICATED WE USED A
WEIGHTED AVERAGE OF A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT OCCUPATIONS TO SET THE
WAITRESS OPTIONS FOR MOST THOUGH
NOT ALL THE RATE MODELS.
AND WE'RE TALKING -- DSPS WHICH
ARE REALLY THE BALK OF THE WORK
FORCE THE ID SYSTEM WE STARTED
WITH THE PERSONAL CARE IN WHICH
FOLKS OF MANSION AND AND SOME
FOLKS HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE USE THAT PARTICULAR
CLASSIFICATION.
THE REASON WE START WITH THAT
THOUGH IS THAT IS WHERE BEYONCE
CURRENTLY ASSIGNS DIAZ PIECE OF
FOLKS MAY FEEL THE DESCRIPTION
DOES NOT DO JUSTICE TO WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING AND I WOULD NOT
DISAGREE WITH THAT POSITION.
BUT THAT IS WHAT -- FROM THE
ALSO PERSPECTIVE WEATHER
CLASSIFIEDS THAT WAGE REPRESENTS
WHAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY EARNING
TODAY WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ORGANIZATION MY PURPOSE LONG
FELT UNCOMFORTABLE RELYING ONLY
ON THAT CLASSIFICATION BECAUSE
WE DO THINK IT UNDERVALUES --
OCCUPATIONS. TO EFFECTIVELY COME
UP A WEIGHTED AVERAGE RECOGNIZE
THE OTHER WORK ABOVE AND BEYOND
SOME OF THE CUSTODIAL CARE THAT
FOLKS ALLUDED TO EARLIER SO THE
OTHER OCCUPATIONS WE USED WERE.
THE PSYCHIATRIC A TO ROCK TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OF FOLKS OFTENTIMES
OUR BEHAVIORAL CHALLENGES AND
HE'D BE MANAGED AS WELL.
THE HOME HEALTH AIDE AGAIN TO
HELP PEOPLE WITH MEDICAL NEEDS
ANOTHER RICK RICK RECREATIONAL
WORKER WHICH REALLY SPEAKS TO
HELPING PEOPLE ACCESS THE
COMMUNITY.
SO THAT REALLY IS OUR INTENT TO
MAKE THAT WERE REFLECTING THE
BROAD SORTS RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT DIAZ PEACE HAVE.
AFTER WE MADE OUR ASSUMPTIONS IN
TERMS WHAT THAT JOB MAKES IS WE
HAVE TO MAKE SOME ASSUMPTIONS ON
HOW TO ADJUST THE WAGES FROM THE
BLS BECAUSE THAT WAS PUBLISHED
THE DATA WAS AVAILABLE TO US --
WHAT REFLECTED WAGES MAY?
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BY NINE
YEARS CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
INFORMATION FROM THAT YOU DIDN'T
TAKE NATIONAL RATE CAPS IS A
NATIONAL SURVEY BUT MISTER
CHAIRMAN ABSOLUTELY WE USE STATE
SPECIFIC DATA AND THAT IN FACT.
TO COME UP WITH SOME OF THE
VARIATIONS ONE RESULTS IN THE
NEXT WE USE LOCAL AREA OF
INFORMATION IT'S ALSO BE ABLE TO
THE BLS AT ALL CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC WORK COUNTY SPECIFIC
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
BUT THEN WE ALSO HAD TO FURTHER
INFLATE THE WAGES TO REFLECT
CHANGES THAT OCCURRED SINCE MAY
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN MOST
NOTABLY THE RAISING THE RISING I
SHOULD SAY MINIMUM WAGE WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO IT'S ALWAYS IMPORT TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT OUR RATES REFLECT A
POINT IN TIME THE POINT IN TIME
THAT WE WERE TRYING TO REFLECT
IS THE COMING FISCAL YEAR
ALTHOUGH AS BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AS WELL AS A LOOKED AT
LA OLD INDICATED IT WILL TAKE
SOME TIME. TO IMPLEMENT THESE
RATES BUT WE HAD TO START WITH
WHEN IMPLEMENTATION COULD
CONCEIVABLY BEGAN WHICH WAS
COMING THE COMING FISCAL YEAR.
SO WE ADJUST THE RATE MODELS
REFLECTED INCREASE TO THIRTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR MINIMUM WAGE.
BUT WE ALSO ACCOUNTED FOR
GENERALIZED WAGE GROWTH WHICH
THE UREAU OF ECONOMIC ANALYSIS
ANOTHER FEDERAL OFFICE WITHIN
THE PUBLIC COMMERCE.
REPORTED BE THREE POINT 6% ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS HERE WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WE MADE THAT THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE BLS DATA TO
KIND OF BRING THEM CURRENTS AND
THE REASON I TALK ABOUT THIS
BEING A POINT IN TIME IS THIS IS
FOR THE COMING FISCAL YEAR.
BUT AS THE LA ALWAYS INDICATED
THE RATE MODELS KIND OF AN
THEMSELVES BEING UPDATED CAM
THAT'S A POLICY DECISION AFTER
REPORTS MAY BE MADE.
BUT IN A WAY TOOLS INCREASE TO
FOURTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FIFTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO THE IDEA
WOULD BE THAT THE REBELS COULD
THE FURTHER UPDATED TO REFLECT
THE ON GOING INCREASES THE STATE
MINIMUM WAGE.
THE REBELS AS EXISTE REFLECT
THIRTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR NOT
FIFTY DOLLARS NOW BECAUSE THAT'S
A COUPLE YEARS HENCE.
AND SO WHEN IT COMES TO THINGS
LIKE WELL SOMEONE SAID YOU
DIDN'T CORPORATION.
REST BREAKS AND OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS WE REQUIRES WELL IS THAT
BECAUSE DO YOU THINK THAT'S IS
INCORPORATED INTO THAT BLS DATA
OR AND THAT'S WHAT YOU DIDN'T OR
DID YOU IT'S SO I DID LIKE THAT
MAYBE A LITTLE INTO THE WEEDS
BUT MR JOURNAL I I WOULD NOT.
ARGUE THAT IT'S PART OF THE THE
BUT I'M ALSO NOT A A LABOR
ATTORNEY SO WHAT I HAVE TO SAY
IS WE CERTAINLY RECEIVE THAT
KIND OF BOTH IN WRITING HERE.
TODAY AND WILL HAVE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHETHER AND
HOW THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
CORPORATE ON THE RIGHT MODELS
AFTER CONSULTING WITH.
WITH MORE LEARNING LEGAL MINDS
AND FIND SO THIS IS A FREE OF
ANOTHER.
I UNDERSTAND FROM JUST READ THE
DESCRIPTION IN THERE THAT TIME
TO DIG THROUGH THE WHOLE REPORT
BUT FOR EXAMPLE USE MEDI CAL
RATES FOR SOME OF THE PROVIDERS --
SOME OFFICIALS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES IT WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ALMOST AT THE
BOTTOM.
OF THE COUNTRY -- MANY OF THE
MEDICAL PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES DO SO IN THE CONTEXT OF
THINGS LIKE COMMUNITY.
HEALTH CENTERS WHERE TO ACTUALLY
GET A BILL ADDITIONAL GRANTS TO
MAKE UP FOR THE COSTS SO IT MAY
NOT NESTLE ACTUALLY REFLECT WHAT
THE ACTUAL COST OF SERVICE
BECAUSE SINCE THOSE PROVIDER
ACTUALLY.
GET A DIGITAL FEDERAL FUNDS
BEYOND THAT MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATE.
SO I WONDERED IF YOU COULD
EXPLAIN TO ME WHY MEDI CAL RATE
WAS THE MOST APPROPRIATE VERSES
A MORE -- RATE LIKE MEDICARE
ACTUALLY SOME OF OUR MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO USE
MEDICARE RATES THEY FOUND OUT
THAT THAT IS THE ACTUAL TRULY
MORE COMPETITIVE RATE.
OR COMMERCIAL RATES WHICH ARE
EVEN HIGHER TO MEDICARE RATES
AWAY MEDI CAL RATES WHICH
CLEARLY THERE'S A LOT OF
EVIDENCE TO SHOW LESS YOU HAVE
THAT.
YOU KNOW ADJUSTMENT THE PBS
ADJUSTMENTS -- USUALLY DOESN'T
ENOUGH TO COVER THE COSTS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SO AS A KIND
OPENING REVIEW OF THE SERVICE
SYSTEM -- AS A GENERAL RULE DDS.
IS THERE RATES FOR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS. TO THE MEDICARE
FEE SCHEDULE WHAT THEY REFER TO
THE SCUTTLED MAXIMUM ALLOWANCES
SO THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
IN EXISTENCE PRIOR TO THE RACE
STUDY -- BEGINNING ONE WE TALKED
ABOUT HOW.
SOME OF THE MISCELLANEOUS
SERVICE BECAUSE OF A USED --
OUTSIDE THAT FEW SKETCH WE TALK
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO WRAP IT
BACK INTO THAT GENERALIZE
CONCEPT OF IF IT'S A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL LIKE A THERAPIST IT
OUGHT TO BE TIED BACK TO THE
MEDICARE FEE SCHEDULE.
SO THAT WAS THE THOUGHT PROCESS
IS THAT WAS THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK THAT EXISTS TODAY.
AS I THINK YOU MENTIONED WE DID
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ABOUT
BEYOND THE MEDI CAL FEES GO TO
BE APPROPRIATE SO WE PUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR THAT AUGMENTATION
OF OF 40%.
WHICH IS BORROWING FROM POLICIES
AVAILABLE IN THE CHECK
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES
PROGRAM FOR CERTAIN POSITIONS
SERVICES.
TOLD ME THAT WHEN YOU'RE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED ME HOW WE
ARRIVED THERE THAT'S HOW WE
ARRIVED THERE AGAIN CERTAINLY
WE'VE HEARD FEEDBACK FROM
THERAPEUTIC OF SERVICE PROVIDERS
AS WELL AS AN INFANT EARLY TO
BED EARLY INFANT DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AS WELL.
AND THAT'S PART OF THE
CONSIDERATION PROCESS WERE WERE
CURRENTLY UNDERTAKE.
TAKINGS PARTIES PUBLIC CONCERTS
SO USUALLY EM MEDIC TELLS NOT
THE SORT OF THE BEST BENCHMARK --
SO I THINK HOPEFULLY -- WE CAN
LOOK AT DEL BUT IT'S SO
HOPEFULLY THAT CAN BE VISITED
I'M SURE YOU'LL GET SOME
FEEDBACK ON THAT BUT CERTAINLY
IS THIS COMMITTEE WE ALSO
OVERSEE DTS AND MEDI CAL.
AND A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
MEDI CAL RATES AND THE ALL THE
DIFFERENT.
BOB DOLE SOURCES OF FUNDS THAT
FLOW INTO -- AND AND AND TO WHAT
WHAT FRAZIER WHAT PEOPLE
ACTUALLY GET YOU ARE TAKING CARE
MEDI CAL PATIENTS CELL.
AND OFTEN THEIR CROSS SUBSIDIZED
SO THE MOST YOU ALSO INCLUDE THE
VALUE OF THE ABOUT ACROSS
SUBSIDIES OR OTHER SOURCES
YOU'RE NOT REALLY YOU KNOW
CAPTURING WHAT.
IS NEEDED CELL.
AND THEN I GUESS THE OTHER -- IT
WAS BROUGHT UP TO I MEAN I'M A
GET A MENTION OF TEACHER XIN
EARLY INTERVENTION AND NOT
FRAGMENTING AND SO.
WHEN WE SAW IN TERMS OF -- AND
COMING UP WITH THE METHODOLOGY
HOW TO TAKE CARE OF WE WANT TO
DO TEAM BASED CARE TEAM BASED
EVALUATION AND SO IS IS THAT.
IS THAT THE TERMS OF I'M SURE
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY PLACE BUT OF
THE IT'S A BIG PLACE EARLY
INTERVENTION NINE THAT FAMILIAR
WITH THE WE DO TEAM BASED
EVALUATIONS SO WE DON'T WANT.
TO BREAK THAT ALL DOLLED
INDIVIDUAL PIECES SO THAT
SOMETHING -- YOU'RE LOOKING TO
CORRECT OR ADDRESS.
THANK YOU MISTER TERRY.
SIMILAR TO A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATIONS AND COMMENTS --
VERY IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE AND TAKING
A LOOK AND WERE REVIEWING ALL OF
THE COMMENTS ON WILL BE
RESPONDING TO THOSE -- WE DID
HERE WHEN WE WERE PRESENTING TO
WHEN WE'RE ROLLING OUT THE
STRUCTURE OF THE MODELS.
THAT SOME OF THE EARLY
INTERVENTION PROVIDERS HAD
SHARED THOSE CONCERNS EVEN AT
THAT POINT AND WE'RE CONTINUING
TO HEAR SOME SOME FEEDBACK ON
THAT AND SO.
AGAIN WITH EVERYTHING ELSE --
WORK WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT
ALL THE THE DIFFERENT PIECES
THAT ARE ARE COMING BACK TO US
AS FAR AS RESPONSES TO THE
MODELS.
I GUESS IS IS GO BACK THAT SORT
OF BACK.
AROUND TOO I REGIONAL QUESTION
IS IS THAT YOUR YOUR RIGHT
YOU'VE MADE A GOOD EFFORT RIGHT
WE THAT WE HEARD A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS ABOUT THIS MODEL YEAR
SOME THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
ADJUSTED.
DO YOU ANTICIPATE.
THIS MORE FOR THE PART AND OUT
OF THE CONSOLE STOVALL THEY'RE
NOT -- AT SOME POINT COMING BACK
AND YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
PEOPLE OVER THE SUMMER -- BUT I
ALSO THINK MY OVERSIGHT FUNCTION
WHAT POINT DO WE COME BACK AND
SAY OKAY SO.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE THE SMILE AND
THEY'LL MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
AND SO FORTH AND GO FORTH WITH
THAT -- ONE AND WE CAN DO THAT
OR SO AND SO I THAT I KNOW OF
THE I KEEP HEARING A LOT OF
DISCUSSION I ONE AT A TIME A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME LINE THAT'S
LIKE WHEN SHOULD WE COME BACK
AND HAVE THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT THOSE APARTMENT PLAN TO DO.
IN TERMS OF PAYMENTS WE
OBVIOUSLY DON'T PAY ENOUGH.
BUT BEYOND THAT NOT PAYING
ENOUGH HOW WE'RE GOING TO PAY
PEOPLE AND THEIR EXPECTATIONS
ARE GONNA BE IMPORTANT TO SELL
ARE WE GOING TO GO THROUGH THIS
IS THIS PATH.
THE PATH WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH.
TO ADJUSTMENTS OR ARE THERE SOME
OTHER PATH RINGO AT SOME POINT
WE SEE AFTER YOU GET THE
FEEDBACK.
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
SO.
BUT I MEAN WE WILL OBVIOUSLY BE
BACK HERE YOU KNOW A YEAR FROM
NOW HAVING.
THIS CONVERSATION I DON'T KNOWS
IT'S BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE WHAT WE
CAN FIGURE IT HERE SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS -- LOW EARLIER ABOUT
BY QUARTERS THE THINKING OF THE
DEPARTMENT NOW I WE'VE SPENT ALL
THIS WE SPENT THREE YEARS ON THE
CITY.
A A WE'VE BEEN WORKING A COUPLE
YEARS ON THIS RIGHT OKAY YEAH SO
IF OF FOR A LOT OF INVESTMENT IN
THIS SO.
YEAH.
SO.
YOU DON'T SIMILAR -- TO CAN I
GET I I DON'T WANT TO I'M NOT
DISMISSING -- THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT THE EARLY
START AND TAKING A LOOK AT KIND
OF THE THE KIND OF THE GROUP AND
AND THE COMMENTS THAT HE CAME
BACK -- BUT I I'M GOING TO KIND
OF COMPARE IT TO WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT THE RATE MODELS WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT FOR THE
ELEMENTS THAT ARE IN THE RIGHT
MODELS INFORMING US.
SO WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT PIECES.
YOU KNOW IT'S SIMILAR TO SOME OF
THE FEEDBACK THAT WERE RECEIVING
RIGHT NOW SO.
WE'RE WE'RE RECEIVING FEEDBACK
ON A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT --
ELEMENTS WITHIN THE RATE STUDY
AND SO I'M GOING TO GO BACK TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
CONVERSATION THIS BROADER
CONVERSATION.
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE YOU KNOW
OVER THE YEAH I SAY OVER THE
SUMMER JUST BECAUSE THAT THE
TIMING WORK PRETTY MUCH AT
SUMMER RIGHT.
SO HERE WE HAVE THIS VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION ABOUT.
KIND OF OURS ARE OUR SYSTEM IN
LOOKING AT THE RATE STUDY IN
LOOKING AT THOSE ELEMENTS AND
THEN LOOKING AT THE REGIONAL
CENTEROVERSIGHT AND LOOKING AT
ALL OF THESE BROADER PIECES.
SO TO TO SAY THAT I'M GOING TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE ON
EARLY START ON THIS PARTICULAR
COMMENT YOU KNOW AGAIN I'M NOT
MINIMIZING KIND OF THOSE
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS.
BUT IT HAS TO BE IN THIS BROADER
CONTEXT.
SO AND ENDS THAT IS REALLY WHERE
THOSE NEXT STEPS ARE AS IN THIS
BROADER CONTEXT.
WE ARE REVIEWING ALL THOSE
COMMENTS AND THAT IS OUR
PRIORITY IN THE PRIORITY OF OUR
CONSULTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN GET THROUGH THAT SO WE CAN.
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO AS
PART OF OUR TRANSPARENCY PIECE
OF OUR RATES STUDY IS TO SAY
HERE'S THE COMMENTS THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN RECEIVED AND MAKING
SURE THAT EVERYBODY CAN SEE
THOSE.
OKAY WELL ACTUALLY WHEN I SAID
TERMS OF FALL OFF IT IS ABOUT
THE BROADER CONTEXT RATE I MEAN
MY SERVE ASKING ABOUT SOME.
SPECIFICS THAT CAME UP IN THE
THE AND THE PRESENTATIONS BUT
REALLY IT IS ABOUT THAT'S RIGHT
THE BIGGER QUESTION IS IS THAT
ARE WE RESTRUCTURING THE WAY
WE'RE GOING TO THE PAYMENTS I
MEAN THAT'S BASICALLY.
RIGHT AND THAT'S DEL AND
OBVIOUSLY WE SPENT THIS TIME AND
EFFORT DOING GREAT STUDY -- WE
HEARD FROM LA -- SAYING THAT TOO
EASY ON TO PHASE I WHAT SOME
PILOTS AND SEE HOW THEY WERE
WORKING AT CETERA SO.
BUT I HAVEN'T HEARD THAT THERE'S
A YOU KNOW AND AND ME AND AGAIN
I UNDERSTAND MAYBE JUST THIS IS
NOT THE TIME YET TO MAKE THE
COMMITMENT.
AND WHETHER YOU FEEL THAT IT
SHOULD MAKE THE COMMITMENT
TOWARDS -- YOU KNOW YOU'D BE
GETTING FEEDBACK FROM PEOPLE IN
THERE ARE ADJUSTMENTS ARE GONNA
BE MADE RIGHT SO -- BUT THEY
SAID YOU KNOW IT I THINK THAT --
IT BE GOOD TO HAVE A BETTER IDEA
IS TO UNDERSTAND.
ONCE YOU HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
NOT TO LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OVER A
LOT YOU KNOW FOR FOR YEARS AND
YEARS BUT MAYBE WITHIN A YEAR
HAVE AN IDEA LIKE WHAT IS THE
DEPARTMENT THINKING ABOUT WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO GO AND BECAUSE
THE ANY IMPLEMENTATION OBVIOUSLY
IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
IMMEDIATELY IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME
TO DO THE TRANSITION IT'S
ADDRESS.
IF IF THAT'S THE DECISION RIGHT
IT COULD BE THAT OF WHAT WOULD
TO STICK TO THE OLD WAY IN.
OKAY YOU'RE SHAKING YOUR HEAD NO
NO WHAT I WHAT I I THINK THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I I JUST
WANT TO SHARE WITH WHAT'S
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISED IS.
ARE IMPORTANT ELEMENTS OF THINGS
THAT [inaudible]
TALK ABOUT.
THE STABILIZATION OF SOME KIND A
KEY AND TARGETED AREAS NO WHILE.
YOU KNOW THE AREAS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THOSE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT AREAS THAT WE DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE FOCUS ON
SOME STABILIZATION AND TAKING A
LOOK AT BEING ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW FOCUS ALSO ON THE H.
CBS YOU KNOW OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COMPLIANCE AND BEING ABLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN HAVE.
SOME ADDRESSING KIND OF SOME
STATE STATE WIDE AREAS SO WHEN
WE LOOK AT THAT AND THAT ALL IS
ABOUT.
KIND OF ENHANCING SOME CONSUMER.
EXPERIENCES YOU KNOW AND WHILE
IT MAY NOT BE EMPLOYMENT TEEN
KIND OF THIS BROADER PIECE OF IT.
IT'S IT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
OF FRAME IN OUR CONVERSATIONS
THAT WERE HAVING THIS SUMMER IS
TO SAY WHAT ARE THOSE.
WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ON BUT NOT TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF?
KIND OF THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
PUT FORWARD RIGHT NOW. TWO TO
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN HAVE KIND OF
THIS.
THIS PIECE OF IT THAT WE CAN --
MOVE FORWARD RIGHT NOW -- SO I I
DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE USE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN KIND
OF THE THE FOCUSED IN TARGETED
AREAS AND AND USING KIND OF THE
PIECES ALSO ON THE SIDE OF THE
OVERSIGHT AND AND AND BRINGING
IT.
TO KIND OF THE GROUP THAT WE'VE
HAD THE CONVERSATIONS WITH AND
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR TEARS YOUR
YOUR YOUR COMMENTS AND SAYING
OKAY WELL WHAT WHAT ARE THOSE.
WHERE WHERE DO WE GO WITH THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND AND -- WELL I
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO GIVE YOU A
SPECIFIC DATE RIGHT NOW -- I
HEAR YOUR QUESTION.
OKAY WELL WHY THE US SO -- I'D --
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE ONGOING
CONVERSATION I KNOW THAT FIRST
OF ALL YOUR DEPARTMENT CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW WE'VE.
CLOSING DOWN DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS WE'RE DOING A CBS WHICH
WE HEARD PREVIOUSLY WE NOW THIS
RATE STUDY DOES A LOT OF BIG
MOVING PARTS THAT'S GOING ON THE
SAME TIME WE ALSO KNOW THAT --
WE'RE HAVING A LOT OF CHALLENGES
WITH -- PROVIDING DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES BECAUSE LOW PAYMENTS --
THE ABILITY TO RECRUIT PEOPLE
WITH -- YOU KNOW THE THE THE
GROWING POPULATION YOU SAID YOUR
CASELOAD IS INCREASING AS WELL --
AND THE SO THE AND DOES SO YES
AND SO I WENT IS FIGURE OUT LIKE
WHAT HOW HOW DO WE PAUL THESE.
THREADS TOGETHER AND ALSO.
YOU KNOW IT IN MANY WAYS -- IS
WE'RE TRYING TO GET MORE
RESOURCES.
IT'S IT WILL BE A NEW BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE TO THE PUBLIC NOT
JUST THAT -- WELL WITH LIVING
SERVICES BUT ALSO IS THAT WE THE
ROOTS BEING DONE IN A YOU KNOW
AN ORGANIZED TRANSPARENT WAY
THAT MAKES SENSE TO PEOPLE SO
THAT -- SO AGAIN IT'S THERE'S
EXPECTATIONS FROM THE COMMUNITY
ABOUT WHAT THERE'S GONNA BE A IN
THERE'S A AND ALSO TO
COMMUNICATE TO THE PUBLIC THAT
THEIR DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT
WISELY.
AND THAT DID AND SO I THINK
PEOPLE IN GENERAL WANT TO HELP
OUT MORE.
NO LIFE A FRIEND THAT I
COLLEAGUES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE WANTING TO DO MORE.
AT THE SAME TIME THEY'RE GOING
TO ROUTE SAID OKAY NOW THAT WE
PUT.
MONEY THERE WE PUT YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY LARGER AMOUNTS OF
MONEY IN FEAR AS A WELL WHAT WE
GET OUT YEAH WHAT HAPPENED THE
RETURN I HAVE WE CHANGED MOVE
THE NEEDLE HAD FIELD ARE MORE
PEOPLE GETTING CARE AND SO FORTH
AND WE CAN ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
IT'S HARDER TO GET MORE
RESOURCES SO -- SO ANYWAY OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ALL RIGHT
OKAY SO -- WE'RE GONNA TAKE THEN
HERE ARE THERE'S A PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT HAS TO DO WITH THE
RATES AND THEN AFTER THAT WE'LL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THOSE TWO
ITEMS TOGETHER SO -- WILL MOVE
ON SAYS ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
OKAY SO ABOUT THE ISSUED AND HAS
A WE HAVE A INVESTMENT PROPOSAL.
YEAH SO THAT'S ISSUE -- TO
THAT'S AND THAT'S HIS PRESENTING.
AND THAT SIDE TOWARD LINDSEY
SECOND RECTOR OF THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS.
OKAY IS MISTER LINDSEY HERE ARE.
THINGS MISTER LINDSEY.
FROM THE ARC [inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
THERE.
O..
OKAY IS ON HIS WAY DOWN
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
HEY.
ALL RIGHT SO -- CAST YOU TO KEEP
YOUR REMARKS THIS OUT -- I THINK
THE PROPOSAL'S PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD SO -- HOPE WE
CAN DO IT AND LESS -- IN NATURE
LOT PEOPLE HAVE WANT TO MAKE
COMMENTS AS WELL SO THANK YOU
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND SENATOR D'AMATO -- JORDAN IN
THE WITH THE ARE CAN YOU HAD TO
PULL THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE -- I CAN BE BRIEF
THE THE PROPOSAL ITSELF IS
STRAIGHT FORWARD WHAT I JUST
WANT TO GIVE EXPLANATION TO IS
FOR THE BACKGROUND FOR IT AND
THE REASON FOR IT -- WE KNEW
GOING IN TO THIS YEAR THAT THIS
WAS REALLY A MAKE OR BREAK
COUNTY YEAR WHERE WE ARE ON A A
CRISIS IN PRESS BUT IT'S WHERE
WE ARE IF.
INVESTMENT IS NOT MATED.
AND THEN -- CRUMBLING WILL
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN OF SERVICES
WE WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT WHICH
WITH DATA WHICH WE KNEW WE
USUALLY -- OUR COMMUNITY --
SOMETIMES IS AND BRING IN WE
BRING LOTS OF ANECDOTES
SOMETIMES NOT SO MUH DATA.
AND SO AS A RESULT WE CONDUCTED
A FEW DIFFERENT SURVEYS ONE OF
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
OVER FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED
RESPONDED -- INDICATING THAT --
THE VAST MAJORITY OF MANY ARE
LIVING -- IN ITS CIRCUMSTANCES
OF POVERTY WITH 42% HAVE
CHILDREN A MEDI CAL 20% OF THE
S. P. IS RECEIVE UP PUBLIC FOOD
ASSISTANCE.
I'M 36% OF THEMSELVES ARE MEDI
CAL ECCENTRIC CETERA WE ALSO DID
A SURVEY OF THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS THEMSELVES 45% OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINE RESPONDED 45%
INDICATED TURNING AWAY OR PLACE
ON WAITING LISTS.
INDIVIDUALS WITH BEEN REFERRED
BY -- REGIONAL CENTERS 49%
REPORT DOWNSIZING PROGRAM
CAPACITY -- AND SO WE KNEW THAT
THIS YEAR WE HAD TO DO SOMETHING
ALL OF YOU SEE WILSON WITH THE
RATES THAT HE RESULTS IT WAS A
COUPLE WE'RE GOING TO BE COMING
FORWARD IN MARCH.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE HOWEVER
THAT -- ONE WE DON'T KNOW IF THE
RATES THAT HE WAS GOING TO COME
OUT AND SAY MAYBE WERE OVER
FUNDED WE DIDN'T KNOW LIKELY
COME OUT AND SAID ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS -- IT
WICH WE INTO BELIEVES ABOUT THE
RIGHT NUMBER A BILL WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD A PROPOSAL
MOVING FORWARD -- AND THAT WOULD
PUT MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENT INTO
COMMUNITY -- SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH ADD THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND SO -- WE'RE VERY THANKFUL
THAT BOTH SENATOR STERN --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF HOLDEN AND
ALSO SOME WOMEN FRAZIER -- ON
THIS ON THE SIDE ARE PUTTING
FORWARD -- LETTERS A REQUEST FOR
AN 8% ACROSS THE BOARD INCREASE --
FOR SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
MANY SENATORS HAVE SIGNED ON IN
WE DO NOT BELIEVE JUST TO
CLARIFY FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THIS IS KIND OF CONTRADICTORY TO
ANY PROPOSALS TO ANOTHER RATE
STUDY BUT RATHER COMPLIMENTARY
AND WHAT WE'VE IT'S A DOWN
PAYMENT.
THIS YEAR WILL THE SECOND
CONCERN WE HAD IS THAT NOT ONLY
MAYBE YOU WOULD COME BACK WITH A
LESSER INVEST IN BUT THAT BE TOO
COMPLICATED TO REALLY DO MUCH
WITH THIS YEAR.
AND THAT SEEMS TO BE AS WE WERE
HEARING THERE'S GONNA BE A OT
OF CONVERSATIONS WHICH SHE KNEW
IT HAPPEN -- IN EARNEST DURING
THE SUMMER AND FALL -- WE KNEW
THAT WE DIDN'T WANT TO LET
COMPLICATIONS HOWEVER KEEP US
FROM MAKING NEEDED INVESTMENTS
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD WE WE ARE SUPPORTING
THAT 8% ASK.
BY -- CENTER STERN'S LIMóN
HOLDEN FRAZIER -- AND SO WE ARE
WE ONE THING WE'VE ALSO HEARD
TODAY IS IS DO NO HARM.
AND ONE THING THAT WE ARE
PUTTING FOR THIS PROPOSAL SAYING
THAT.
DOING NOTHING IS HARM IN SO IF
WE DO NOTHING THAT IS CAUSING
HARM AS WELL TO THIS OF PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FORCES ON
SERVICES LA -- FINANCE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ANY QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE TWO ITEMS
SO I JUST WANT TO STRESS -- SO
FIRST OF ALL YOU KNOW.
TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO A
MINUTE -- WE'VE HEARD A FAIRLY
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSION AND IF
SOMEONE'S ARRAY SAID WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY IT'S FINE JUST TO
SAY ME TOO I AGREE WITH THEM.
AND SO -- YEAH WE DO A LOT OF
ITEMS ARE STILL GOING TO HAVE TO
HEAR AFTER THIS AS WELL SO WE
WANT TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE BUT
ALSO PLEASE -- PRE SHEET --
BEING TO THE POINT AND BRIEF --
SO WE CAN CONTINUE AND DAY.
THE FAIR TO ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING TO COME AFTER YOU WHO
ALSO WANT TO PRESENT THEIR ITEMS
AS WELL.
SELL WITH US SAID WE'VE WE'VE
SPENT -- WE DID SPEND QUITE A
BIT OF TIME DISCUSSING THIS ITEM
AS WELL SO ALL RIGHT SO WITH
THAT A SIDE.
YOU CAN -- SMALL.
THE BEGIN INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
ARE [inaudible]
EIGHT OKAY.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS MILES ON A
PROGRAM MANAGER WORKING FOR STEP --
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO I'VE BEEN
WORKING.
ALTURAS EXCUSE ME.
THE VOICE OF THE OTHER SORRY.
SO I'M HE WAS USING ACRONYMS SO
SORRY I'LL GO AHEAD HELLO.
MY SISTER'S TAMI OF YEARS HOW TO
TALK REAL FAST OKAY GO HEAD
START OVER AGAIN OKAY GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MILES I'M A
PROGRAM MANAGER AND I WORK FOR
STEP I'VE BEEN THERE FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS HI MAY I DO
SUPPORTIVE LIVING SERVICES I
WORK FOR STATE HOW HARD THE
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL FOR
SO MANY YEARS.
AND WHAT THEIR WAGES ARE I'D
REALLY.
APPRECIATE IF YOU'D REALLY STUDY
THE LETTER THAT WE'RE GIVING YOU
RIGHT NOW AND ABOUT THE SERVICES
THAT THEY'RE DOING AND STOP THE
TURNOVER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE THE LETTERS FROM THE
YEAH.
THE SERGEANTS KEY FINDER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS CALVIN.
I WORK FOR STEP. FOR TWO YEAH
WHAT YEAR AND A HALF AS A THIS.
WHEN THEY MEET AGAIN SORRY AND
EXPLAINING THE ACRONYMS IT'S AT
SLS MEANS SUPPORT OF THE
RESEARCH SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICES ABOUT POLITICS?
MY LIVING SALARY AND WHAT I HAVE
TO PAY OUT IS.
IN AS I FEEL LIKE I'M IN THE
POVERTY LEVEL I CAN'T AFFORD
ANYTHING.
I FEEL THAT MY WORTH AND THE
WORK THAT I DO AS A LOT OF HARD
AND WORK -- YOU NEED TO LOOK AT
OUR OWN PERSONAL LIFE STRUGGLES.
TRYING TO SURVIVE ON THE WAGES
THAT WE GET AND I HAVE A LETTER
ALSO THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SUBMIT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CARLTON.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS CARL.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING NOTICES.
I A L. I. WHY A BUT I GOT IT
HELLO GO AHEAD.
THAT'S RIGHT MY NAME IS CARL
I'VE BEEN WITH STEP FOR FIVE
YEARS.
I REALLY RECOGNIZE THAT MY STAFF
HAD SO MANY OF THEM ARE QUITTING
I REALLY WANT THEM TO STAYI
REALLY PREFER THAT MAYBE YOU PAY
THEM MORE.
AND THAT IT WOULD BE THAT I
WOULD HAVE AND THAT ALSO YOU
SHOULD HAVE A VERY NICE DAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY WELCOME.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS
RIGHT.
HIS HIS HIS NAME IS HARD TO
SPELL HIS NAME IS RAZA.
I WORK -- I'VE BEEN WORKING AS A
DIRECT SUPPORT FOR TWO YEARS I
DO SUPPORT IS LIVING I REALLY
CHERISH THE PEOPLE I WORK I'M A
DEAF DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
I REALLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE.
THAT ALL OF OUR MORE PEOPLE THAT
ARE DEAF CAN WORK FOR STEP.
SO AND I ALSO HAVE A LETTER FOR
YOU.
THE OF LETTERS ON THE THANK YOU.
THAT'S RIGHT I GOT IT.
I'M A I'M A MULTI FACETED WOMAN
LIKE THAT OKAY.
HELLO HI MY NAME IS OLAF AND I
DO LANDSCAPING I WORK IN A VAN I
DO I WILL DRIVE A VAN AND I'VE
BEEN DOING THAT JOB FOR TEN
YEARS.
AND ALL OFF USED TO BE A BAPTIST
HOSPITAL.
HE WORKS FOR TWENTY YEARS AS A
LANDSCAPER SO.
THAT'S ALL THEY WANT YOU TO KNOW
OKAY.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS MARK.
OSBORNE.
I WORK FOR TWELVE AND A HALF
YEARS AS A DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL I REALLY ENJOY MY
JOB.
AND I JUST APPRECIATE IF YOU PAY
ME MORE OKAY.
HI.
THANK YOU -- HOPE SORRY JACK IS
BEING A MULTI TASKER SORRY IT IS
KNOCKED HIM OVER HELLO MY NAME
IS DENNIS.
I AM FROM SACRAMENTO I WORK AS A
SUPPORTIVE LIVING SERVICES
MANAGER.
I'VE BEEN DOING THAT WITH THEM I
WORK WITH FOLKS THAT ARE DEAF
AND BLIND I'VE SUPPORTED THEM
HIS NAME IS JOHN.
AND RANDY AND TOM THEY'RE ALL
THREE DEAF AND BLIND.
THEY CAN'T BE HERE BECAUSE THEY
ARE SHORT STAFFED.
THEY DID THE STAFF DON'T GET
PAID ENOUGH SO THE BUDGET TO
REALLY BAD AND SO.
THAT IS ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU CAN.
MY NAME IS VANESSA COMPOSED A BE
WORKING WITH THE STEP FOR TWO
YEARS.
I MADE THE S. P..
I WOULD LIKE TO DO YOU.
BABY DEPORTED FOR US THE D. S.
P. AND THAT AS A LAST. NINETY
THE QUIT.
BUT THANK YOU THANK YOU BYE MASS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I'M VERY NERVOUS MY NAME IS
REBECCA BY I'VE BEEN AND I WORK
IN SACRAMENTO I DO AYE ALAS AND
I'M A DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL.
AND I WANT TO GIVE YOU MY LETTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
MY NAME IS KIM.
MY NAME IS KIM AND I WORK FOR SO
FOR ALMOST A YEAR AND I AM A
FACILITATOR. FOR THE DEAF UNIT
IN SUPPORT OF LIVING SERVICES IF
YOU GUYS COULD PLEASE --
CONSIDER THIS INCREASE AND
DECREASE THINKING.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS TUESDAY I'VE BEEN
WAS THERE FOR SIX YEARS -- THE
TYPE OF WORK THAT WE DO AS THE
REX SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
MANAGERS SUPERVISORS IT TAKES
THE COMMUNITY.
WE REALLY WANT YOU GUYS TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS MORE PEOPLE KID POOR
PEOPLE WHEN IT COMES WORK
BECAUSE THEY FEEL LIKE.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T VALUE THEM AS
PEOPLE WHICH IS NOT TRUE JACQUI
DOES HER BEST AS SHE CAN'T TO
SUPPORT US AND WE DO OUR BEST A
SUPERVISOR THIS MANAGERS. TO
SUPPORT THE STAFF TO BE ABLE TO
FOURTH SUPPORT THE PEOPLE THAT
NEED THE MOST SUPPORT.
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT
YOU GUYS.
GIVE THE FUNDING BECAUSE THEY
NEED IT IT'S NOT A MORE SO ABOUT
US IS ABOUT THEM WHAT ABOUT THE
QUALITY OF LIFE THE BODY THINK
ABOUT THAT.
SO HERE'S MY LETTER.
AND I'LL GO ON ALL THE FUN THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME'S TREVOR AND I I WORK
I'VE BEEN IN THIS FIELD FOR
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AND I WORK
WITH CALIFORNIA VOCATIONS.
INK -- THAT WAS FORMALLY OUT OF
PARADISE.
AND WE ALL GOT BURNED OUT AND
YOU KNOW WOULDN'T BE SURVIVING
IF IT WEREN'T FOR CRAFTY CEO AND
YOU KNOW IN THIS FIELD WE WE
LEARN TO BE MAGICIANS AND MAKE
SOMETHING OUT OF NOTHING BUT YOU
KNOW.
THAT PAYS STAFF MINIMUM WAGE
RIGHT NOW THAT LIKE RISK THEIR
LIVES TOLD THEIR FAMILIES TO GO
GET OUT OF THE FIRE AND WE GOT
TO GO GET OUR FOLKS YOU KNOW IS
INSULTING.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY INSULTING THAT'S
NOT A GUILT TRIP IT'S JUST
REALITY AND IF YOU'RE LIVING
ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU
DON'T THINK YOU'RE IN DANGER AT
THIS POINT YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S
A HOUE OR TWO AND IT'S BEEN
VERY DEVASTATING TO OUR PROGRAMS
AND WE HAD SOME REALLY GOOD TAX.
PAYING JOBS UP THERE THAT
BASICALLY ALL BURNED UP IN WITH
AN ARTY THIN BUDGET YOU KNOW ITS --
IT'S REALLY HARD AND I'VE BEEN
IN MIDDLE.
MANAGEMENT FOR ABOUT THIRTEEN
YEARS SO I DIRECTLY SUPERVISE
THESE SUPPORT STAFF IN.
I'VE EITHER GOT A THE THE KIND
THAT ARE REALLY GOOD AND GET
PAID NOTHING OR BE WE GET WHAT
WE PAY.
FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS
SO MUCH [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK YOU'RE DOING ON THIS
PROJECT -- COULD YOU JUST RAISE
YOUR HAND IF YOU'RE A PARENT
[inaudible]
THERE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF YOU'RE
EIGHTEEN MONTH OLD WASN'T
TALKING YET.
OR WASN'T WALKING YET.
WILL THAT HAPPEN TO A LITTLE KID --
NAME JOHNNY AND ONE OF OUR
SPEECH THERAPISTS FROM EASTER
SEALS FOR NON PROFIT WITHOUT
THEIR SEEN JOHNNY FOR THE EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAM.
WELL GUESS WHAT THEY GOT JOHNNY
TALKING.
HE GOT A DIAGNOSIS OF AUTISM HE
GOT OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY HE GOT
PHYSICAL THERAPY BECAUSE WE WERE
ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER NOT BILL
SEPARATE CODES OR SEPARATE --
AMOUNTS AND THEN THEY HAD A
CHILD DEVELOPMENT SPECIALISTS
HELP HIS FAMILY.
JOHNNY IS NOW IN A REGULAR
PRESCHOOL AND NO LONGER
QUALIFIES FOR THE DIAGNOSIS OF
AUTISM.
THAT IS WHAT REALLY ENCOURAGING
AND DO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO LISTEN TO OUR CONCERNS TODAY
MY NAME IS LEAH HALEY AND I'M
ALSO FROM THE EASTER SEAL
SUPERIOR IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
THIRTEEN CHILD DEVELOPMENT
SPECIALISTS THAT I SUPERVISE --
THE EIGHT OH FIVE INFILL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS ARE
DESIGNED TO WORK AS A TEAM TO
DELIVER EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES IN A TRANCE
DISCIPLINARY APPROACH.
SEPARATING OUT OF THESE SERVICES
WOULD NOT BE CONDUCIVE TO THIS
APPROACH AND WOULD MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE THE POS
PROCESS BETWEEN THE REGIONAL
CENTER AND THE VENDORS.
THERE IS CONCERN FOR OVER THE
OVER ESTIMATE OF THE TWENTY SIX
WEEKLY VISITS INDICATED IN THE
RATE MODEL PROPOSED.
THIS MODEL IMPLIES THAT MORE
THAN HALF OF THE THIRTY SEVEN
AND A HALF FULL TIME HOURS PER
WEEK WOULD BE USED ON HOME
VISITS.
THIS DOESN'T ACCOUNT FOR THE
TRAVEL TIME BETWEEN CLIENTS WHO
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE IN
REMOTE LOCATIONS WHAT IS A
CONSIDER THE DOCUMENTATION
REQUIRED TO STAY IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE ID A LAWS.
AROUND THE AYE OFFICE P. PROCESS.
CBS'S ARE OFTEN USED TO KEEP AN
EYE ON THE OVERALL DEVELOPMENT
OF THE CHILD AND TO REINFORCE
THE OUTCOME SET BY THE OTHER
DISCIPLINES.
THEREFORE SUPPORTING THE FAMILY
AND CHILD THROUGHOUT THEIR TIME
IN EARLY INTERVENTION.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED A PERCENT RATE INCREASE
THAT WILL BE CRUCIAL TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE SERVICES UNTIL RATE
MALL JUST READ THAT COVERS
EXPENSES IS ENACTED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU[inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS JACKIE CLARK AND I
HAVE BEEN A ADMINISTRATOR AND
AND PROGRAMS FOR FORTY THREE
YEARS.
AND I'VE -- HAD GREAT HOPE THAT
ONE DAY WILL BE ABLE.
TO REVISE THE RATE MODEL SO I'M
EXCITED THAT WE'LL GET TO THAT
LEVEL.
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT I
WANTED TO BRING UP ABOUT THE THE
DRAFT PROPOSAL AND I THINK THAT
THE TWO BIGGEST FACTORS ARE.
THE PRODUCTIVITY ASSUMPTION THAT
WE CAN SEE I'M TWENTY SEVEN
FAMILIES A WEEK -- WINS IN OUR
COUNTY WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
WENTY MILES BETWEEN OUR FOR
THIS -- FAMILIES AND SO IT DOES --
TAKE ALL DAVE -- OF TRAVELING TO
SEE THREE TO FOUR KIDS ON A DAY
SO.
REALISTICALLY WE'RE LOOKING AT
MORE OF EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
MINUTES.
A WEEK INSTEAD OF TWENTY SEVEN
BUT THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THAT IS
THE BILLABLE -- RATE PER HOUR
WAS REALLY SET ON THAT
PRODUCTIVITY LOVERS LEVELS ARE
REALLY DROVE THE RATES DOWN.
BUT I THINK EVEN MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY IS IF WE HAD TO
HIRE -- T. SPECIES AND SPEECH ON
MEDI CAL RATES BECAUSE WITHOUT
THE ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTED BE
TWENTY NINE DOLLARS.
AND WE PAID. TWENTY NINE DOLLARS
JUSTIN TRAVEL FOR THE DAY AND WE
WOULD HAVE NOTHING LEFT OVER FOR
SALARIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA MICHAEL
ALBERS AND I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S THERAPY CENTER WHERE
A PRIVATE NON PROFIT WHOSE
MISSION IS THAT NO CHILD SHOULD
GO THROUGH LIFE WITH A
DISABILITY THAT CAN BE AIDED FOR
PREVENTED THROUGH EARLY
INTERVENTION.
WE HAVE BEEN A VENDOR DIFFERENT
PROGRAM OF THE REGIONAL CENTER
FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS I HAVE
TWO ISSUES THAT I WANT TO DRESS
VERY QUICKLY REGARDING THE RATE
STUDY AND THESE ARE ISSUES THAT
WILL DO HARM FIRST THE
RECOMMENDATION TO REIMBURSE.
INFANT DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
THERAPY AT MEDI CAL RATES IS
GROSSLY UNSUSTAINABLE IF THAT
HAPPENED OUR PROGRAM WOULD SEE A
24254% REDUCTION IN OUR CURRENT
HOURLY RATE WHICH IS ALREADY
FORTY FIVE DOLLARS LESS THAN OUR
COST.
THIS WOULD RESULT IN THE REASON
REGIONAL CENTER LOSING US AS A
VENDOR AND THE HUNDREDS OF
CHILDREN THAT WE SERVE WOULD GO
WITHOUT SERVICE.
SECOND QUICKLY IS A SEPARATION
OF ID P. SERVICES IN TWO
DIFFERENT BILLABLE CATEGORIES
WOULD RESULT IN A LESS EFFECTIVE
EARLY INTERVENTION THE INTENT OF
EARLY INTERVENTION IN BOTH
REGULATION AND BEST PRACTICE IS
TO FOCUS ON THE WHOLE CHILD
WHICH IS WHAT MAKES IT SO.
EFFECTIVE.
ON DOING THE STRUCTURE THE
PROGRAM WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TO
OUR MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN AN
EARLY START THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALSO GIVEN YOU GUYS
WILL HAVE OKAY.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
YES THE DOORS.
TIMES -- KERRISON WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RATE STUDY
MUST REFLECT THE VALUES OF
INCLUSION INTEGRATION.
AND CHOICE AT THE CORE OF THE
LANCER MEN ACT THE FEDERAL HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED SETTINGS
FINAL RULE AND CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYMENT FIRST LAWS.
THE R. C. APPRECIATES THE
IMMENSE UNDERTAKING BY TEDIOUS.
AND BURNS AND ASSOCIATES. TO
COMPLETE A REYES STUDY.
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
REFORM THE RATES RATE SETTING.
PROCESS IN CALIFORNIA'S
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
MAINTAINING THE STATUS QUO IS
NOT AN OPTION AND DEAR SEE
SUPPORT SUBSTANTIVE RATE RELATED --
ACTION THIS YEAR HOWEVER WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE RATE STUDY
DOES NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS.
HOW?
THE PROPOSED RATE.
METHODOLOGY INCENTIVES OUTCOMES
FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES.
THESE OUTCOMES INCLUDE INCLUSION
INTEGRATION AND CHOICE OF CHOICE
AT THE CORE OF THE WOMEN ACT.
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYMENT FIRST
LAWS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATION
EMPLOYMENT -- BLUEPRINT FOR
CHANGE.
TOWARD THESE GOALS WE PROPOSE
THE FOLLOWING ONE THE RATE STUDY
MUST PLACE A GREATER EMPHASIS
OUTCOME BASE RATE METHODOLOGIES.
PREMISE ON COMMUNITY BASED
INTEGRATION AND CHOICE AS THIS
IS NECESSARY TO INCENTIVIZE H.
B. H. C. B. S. COMPLIANCE.
HERNANDEZ COULD WRAP UP -- A
CONCLUSION CALIFORNIA HAS A REAL
OPPORTUNITY TO TO TAKE
SUBSTANTIVE RATE RELATED.
ACTION THIS YEAR AND THE FAILURE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY JEOPARDIZES THE
HUMAN AND CIVIL RIGHTS OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
AS WELL AS POTENTIALLY BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF FEDERAL H..
H. CBS FUNDING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
I MISS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CARL
LONDON -- HERE'S THE ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE SUPPORTING
PEOPLE WITH -- INTELLECTUAL TO
ALMOST DISABILITIES WE SUBMITTED
A LETTER TO YOUR STAFF AS WELL
TO THE DEPARTMENT SO JUST MAKE A
COUPLE OF BRIEF POINTS -- ONE
THE BIGGEST HEADLINE ENDING IN
THE ROOM HERE FOR THE WHOLE
ISSUES THAT YOU'RE.
BASICALLY GETTING A DECLARATION
FROM READ STUDIES SAYS THE
SYSTEM IS UNDERFUNDED BY OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS -- THAT SO THAT
CREATES FOR YOU WITH THE RATE
STATE WHAT I'M HEARING PRETTY
EASILY IS A TODAY IN A TOMORROW
PROBLEM.
THE TOMORROW PROBLEM IS HOW DO
YOU IMPLEMENT THE RATE STUDY
WHICH WILL.
SORT OF SET THE STABLE FOR THE
FUTURE THE TODAY PROBABLY HAVE
RECEIVER OVER AND OVER AGAIN
LAST COUPLE YEARS.
THAT SERVICE PROGRAMS TODAY ARE
ADEQUATE WE HAVE A CAPACITY
PROBLEM WITH A SHORTAGE OF STAFF
PROBLEM.
AND YOU HAVE TO SOLVE THAT
IMMEDIATELY SO I THINK WHEN YOU
LISTEN WITH THE LA -- OFFERS AS
AN ALTERNATIVE.
THE POSSIBILITY OF DOING
SOMETHING TODAY LIKE AN 8%
INCREASE WHICH EIGHTEEN OR
EXCUSE ME NINETEEN EVERY
COLLEAGUES ARE SUPPORTING TODAY
IN THE SENATE.
HE GIVES YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HANDLE TODAY'S PROBLEM WHILE WE
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION FOR
TOMORROW AND FIGURING OUT HOW
IT'S GONNA WORK.
GIVING I'D SAY JUST BRIEFLY I'M
LOOKING BACK AT THE LANGUAGE
THAT WAS THE IMPETUS FOR THE
RATES STAY IS AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION THERE THAT WE
THINK IT'S BEEN LEFT OUT.
THE VERY FIRST BALL IT OF THAT
WAS WHETHER OR NOT THE CURRENT
METHOD RATE SETTING.
PROVIDES AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY
PROVIDERS IN THAT CATEGORY.
AND WHETHER THERE'S A SUFFICIENT
QUIET TO ENABLES SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE BELIEVE THE RATE CITY
COMPLETELY IGNORES THAT NEEDS TO
BE HANDLED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I CAN HOOK EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LOS TROPICS IN LAFAYETTE WE
PROVIDE ADULT RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES DAY PROGRAM SERVICES
SUPPORTED AND INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES AND WE'VE SEEN THE
CRUNCH -- OVER THE YEARS WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS CURRENTLY OF
CLOSING OUR FOURTH RESIDENTIAL
HOME IN AS MANY YEARS -- BECAUSE
WE JUST CAN'T SUSTAIN THIS
ANYMORE I ALSO HEAR YOUR
FRUSTRATION BECAUSE I TOO AM NOT
HEARING A COMMITMENT TO WIN WE
ARE GOING TO SEE THIS CHANGE.
AND I AGREE WITH MISS PATRICK'S --
IT COMMENT THAT SHE HAD MADE IT
AT SOME POINT YOU HAVE TO JUMP
IN AND NOW IT'S OUR TIME TO JUMP
IN.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE
IT VERY MUCH LONGER IF I IF I
DON'T SEE AN INCREASE THIS YEAR
NEXT IS MY INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES PROGRAM AND THE
FOLLOWING YEAR IS PROBABLY GOING
TO BE MY SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICES PROGRAM AND THAT'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
WITHOUT SERVICES SO NOW'S THE
TIME TO JUMP IN IT IT'S TIME TO
MAKE A COMMITMENT AS TO WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO AND I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT IT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN BY NEXT YEAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT I'M MARGARET FIREMEN FROM
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY THE NORTH
BAY AND I'VE DONE THIS WORK FOR
FORTY FIVE YEARS I'VE BEEN
THROUGH THREE DIFFERENT RATE
SURVEYS.
I REALLY APPRECIATED YOUR
PRESSING THE DEPARTMENT ON WHO
AND WHEN WHO AND BY WHEN SO YES
28% NOW.
AND THEN -- TO SENATOR STONE'S
ISSUE THIS IS A FIRST YEAR ONLY.
I AM -- SUPPORTING SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY CHILDREN ADULTS AND
ADULTS IN THE NORTH BAY.
I CAN'T HIRE ENOUGH STAFF THE
RATE SURVEY SAYS THAT MY RATE
FOR MY DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL SHOULD BE FOURTEEN
DOLLARS AND SEVENTY CENTS I'M
CURRENTLY PAYING MORE THAN THAT
AND I'M LOOKING AT ADDITIONAL.
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES COMING IN
THE NEXT TWO YEARS I AM UNDER
WATER I NEED THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND I NEED IT NOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WELCOME HELLO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE MY NAME IS YOLANDA
SPEED ON THIS CEO AND DIRECTOR
FOR FAMILY OPTIONS OUT OF FRESNO
CALIFORNIA.
AND A REPRESENTS CENTRAL VALLEY
AREA OUR ORGANIZATIONS CURRENTLY
SERVE.
IN ADULT FAMILY HOME AGENCIES
SUPPORTIVE LIVING INDEPENDENT
LIVING ERVICE -- SERVICE AS
WELL AS COMMUNITY INTEGRATION.
SO WE ARE IN.
SUPPORT OF THE INCREASE FOR
SERVICES ALSO CONSIDER CENTRAL
VALLEY AND IN COMPARISON TO
LARGER CITIES WE'RE REALLY IN A
CRISIS.
AS FAR AS BEING ABLE TO
STABILIZE OUR WORK FOURTH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI I'M JESSIE CLAYTON I'M
ACTUALLY WITH FAMILY OPTIONS AS
WELL DID -- TO A LOT OF WHAT YOU
WANT TO JUST STATE IT -- WE ARE
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF THE
INCREASE -- ONE OF THINGS THAT
OUR ORGANIZATION HAS HAD TO DO
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS JUST
OUR OWN NONPROFIT JUST TO BE
ABLE TO ASSESS.
MOST OF OUR CONSUMERS THAT WE
SERVICE AS WELL AS SOME OF OUR
STAFF WHEN YOU SPEAK OF OF
PAYING -- FOR UTILITY BILLS AND
MOVING COSTS IN THOSE THINGS ARE
CURRENT RATES JUST OF NOT
SUSTAIN THAT AND SO WE'RE
DEFINITELY FOR THE INCREASE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS JASON KIDD THE ARM
I'M ARE.
SUPPORTED LIVING SERVICES SORRY
I I GET I GET THOSE.
SERVICES -- I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE 8% INCREASE -- IN
THE LAST FOUR MONTHS I'VE LAST
FIVE STAFF. FOR BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO MAKE A LIVING --
I'M HERE.
TO TRY TO MAKE THAT INCREASE
HAPPENED SO THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
BECAUSE I I ALSO GO TO A DAY
PROGRAM WHERE THAT THAT IS A
HIGH.
AND OVER.
EIGHT SO I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE
8% INCREASE.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH
[inaudible]
JEFF [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
WHEN WE ARE RESERVED FOR MY HOME?
IN A NEARBY THE EVER STAY ANGRY.
HELLO I AGO DURING THE PROGRAM
AND IT IS VERY HARD TO KEEP
THEIR OF WITH THE HEY THERE WE
HAVE NOW.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
YOUR LOVE.
MY NAME IS ALEX WOULD HAVE AN I
AM A CLIENT OF FEATURES
EXPLOITED.
THAT IS A JOB TRAINING PROGRAM
IN LAFAYETTE [inaudible]
IBM.
I LIVE IN.
A COUPON AND CONTENT.
WITH FIVE OTHER MEN WITH
DISABILITIES.
I TAKE PRIDE TO WORK EVERY DAY.
PLEASE HOLD GROUND [inaudible]
OUR A FOUR BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
IN OUR HELPING ME TOO MICHAEL OF
THEIR PARENTS.
F. WITH THEIR EIGHT BUDGET IS
NOT.
BANK PLEASE THE WORKERS WERE NOT
CAT.
BUT NOT BE PAID.
ENOUGH TO LIVE ON AND THE
PROGRAM.
ARE BE SHUT DOWN.
I DON'T WANT TO DO WITH MY
SEVENTH.
AND MY SUPPORT STAFF.
FOR THAT THE PUT ME ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS.
BUT THAT.
MIGHT HAPPEN FS DATE DOES NOT
BUT ENOUGH MONEY FOR THEM.
RIGHT NOW ARMED FAERIE FAERY
UPSET.
WITH THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
SELECT [inaudible]
SERVICES FINDING.
WELL IF CUT DURING THE RECESSION.
WE HAVE BEEN PATIENTS.
WERE TELLING OUR IPOD NOW WITH
THAT THE STATE BUDGET IS DOING
BETTER THE GOVERNMENT.
AND PLEASE.
THAT IS A PER SERVICE THIS
BUDGET.
BY A SENSE STATE GOVERNMENT NOT
DOING HIS PART.
HEY I'M GONNA HAVE TO ASK YOU TO
WRAP OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH.
A YEAR OR REYES YET MY NAME IS
DAN CUTS GOING.
I STARTED A FEW YEARS FOR OUR
JOBS AND VOLUNTEERING WE ARE
LOSING JOB COACHES AT MY PROGRAM
ANOTHER STAFF BECAUSE OF LOW PAY
I SUPPORT THE 888% INCREASE IN
FUNDING SO I CAN WORK.
AT MY PROGRAM KEEP THE PROMISE.
THANKS FOR MUCH.
HE THE LITTLE [inaudible]
WHO WOULD -- LOAN ME.
THERE WEREN'T THERE -- YOU.
IN.
THE IN [inaudible]
THE JUNE WALLY WHO [inaudible]
IN -- MOOD.
THE TECHNICAL FOR YOU YOU.
I SUPPORT THE 8% BECAUSE I AND
OTHERS NEED QUALITY QUALIFIED
STAFF TO LIVE AT HOME
INDEPENDENTLY WE NEED TO PAY THE
STAFF. EIGHT LIVING WAY SO I CAN
BE INDEPENDENT COMMUNITY KEEP
THE PROMISE.
THANK YOU AND FOR MYSELF.
I'M SHORT AND SWEET.
WITH PASSING THE 8% INCREASE YOU
WILL NAY ABLE ADULTS WITH ID DE
TO LEAD A FULFILLING LIVES TO
HELP BETTER STAFFING AND
RESOURCES TO FIND EMPLOYMENT
THUS GIVING MORE BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY.
THIS WILL LEAD TO AN INCREASE
SPENDING AND BROADEN THE TAX
BASE IT WILL ALSO PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORTS FOR THOSE
SEEKING THEIR COLLEGE GOALS. TO
GET BETTER BETTER JOBS BOB.
PERSONAL INDEPENDENCE AND SELF
IBD UP FOR SUCCESS IS THE
OUTCOME OF THIS [inaudible]
OF THOSE.
OTHER SMALL ONE TIME INCREASE OF
A PERCENT.
JUST.
THIS IS JUST ONE STEP IN KEEPING
THE PROMISE OF THE LANHAM ACT
PASSED BY LEGISLATOR KEEP THE
PROMISE OF THE LANHAM ACT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MIKE SWEAR ENGINE I'M WITH --
LIFE WORK SUPPLIED COMMITTED TO
SERVICES.
AND THE THE THE THE S. RATES
STEADY CONTAINS A RECOMMENDATION
THAT IS A FATAL FLAW.
AS MENTIONED EARLIER TO THE
EARLY START CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN THE VALLEY MOUNTAIN
REGIONAL CENTER CATCHMENT AREA.
THE STUDY RECOMMENDS ELIMINATING
SERVICE CODE ONE ONE SIX AND
REPLACING IT WITH SERVICE CODE
EIGHT OH FIVE FOR DEVELOPMENT
SPECIALISTS AND DEFAULTING.
AS ALREADY MENTIONED TO MEDI CAL
RATES FOR CLINICIANS.
THIS REPRESENTS A 65% DECREASE
IN OUR PROGRAM FUNDING.
AND DOES NOT SUPPORT.
THE MANDATE TO SERVICE DELIVERY
STRUCTURE OF ONE ONE
INTERVENTIONS THE CHILD'S
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
I HIGHLY RECOMMEND THE SERVICE
COULD WIN ONE SIX IN THE
SPENDING RATE REMAINS IF THE
CURRENT RECOMMENDATION IS A HELD
WE WILL BE FORCED TO SHUT DOWN
OUR OPERATIONS THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES WILL BE DISPLACE.
LEGALLY BINDING -- INDIVIDUAL
FAMILY SERVICE PLANS.
WILL REMAIN ON TO FILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI I'M DEBBIE LAKE WITH UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY IN THE STOCKTON
AREA AND LIKE MIKE HAS SAID THAT --
I APPRECIATE THE ENORMITY OF THE
STUDY BECAUSE IT REALLY IS
COMPLEX AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
IT'S HUGE I THINK THERE ARE
FLAWS IN THE RATE.
EARLY START WAS DONE AND LIKE HE
SAID THAT OUR PROGRAM WOULD ALSO
HAVE TO SHUT DOWN IF -- THE
RIGHT TO PUT INTO EFFECT SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO KEEP SERVICE CODE
ONE SIXTEEN AND I'D LOVE AN 8%
RATES BUT I'D LIKE TO KEEP THAT --
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI GOOD AFTERNOON I
MELODY MARIE FROM PROFESSIONAL
VALUATIONS AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES WERE ALSO AND EARLY
INTERVENTION -- PROGRAM IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY IN THE PMR SEEING
CATCHMENT AREA -- WE SERVE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY INFANTS AND
TODDLERS UP WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
FROM ALL AND WALKS OF LIFE WE GO
INTO THEIR HOMES ONE ON ONE WITH
THEM.
TRAVEL TO THEIR HOMES WHICH IS
SOMETIMES CAN BE FIFTY MILES TO
GET TO THE HOME OR COULD BE.
THREE MILES DOWN THE ROAD IT
JUST DEPENDS AND THE ELIMINATION
OF CODE ONE ONE SIX WOULD
BECAUSE OUR PROGRAM.
I AM A FORTY EIGHT EMPLOYEES AND
THEY'RE GONNA FIFTY CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES TO NOT GET SERVICES
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO CLOSE.
I AM IT'S ABOUT IT'S IT'S A 60%
OR MORE RATE CUT FOR US. FOR OUR
FAMILIES AND ALREADY NOW IT'S
HARD TO FIND PROVIDERS AND AND
THIS WOULD EVEN MAKE IT THAT
MUCH HARDER.
AND AND THE MEDI CAL RATE
THERE'S NO WAY THAT YOU CAN PAY
STAFF ON A MEDICAL RATE A
THERAPIST PHYSICAL THERAPIST
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST SPEECH
CANNOT DO THAT THERE'S NO WAY.
I AM WE WE DID TURN AND ALL THE
STUFF FOR THE RATE STUDY WHEN
THEY ASKED US THREE DIFFERENT
TIMES.
BUT NO ONE EVER SPOKE TO US
ABOUT ANYTHING AND SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY AND HOW IT AFFECTS US --
SO I WOULD SAY.
NO MORE I MEAN KEEP RATE ONE ONE
SIX IN THERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS LISA DRAKE AND I'M A
LICENSE SPEECH AND LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST FOR FORTY YEARS
THIRTY ABOUT AN EARLY
INTERVENTION I'M REALLY THAT OLD.
I'M ONE OF THE OWNERS OF THE
PROFESSIONAL VALUATIONS AND FOR
YOUR VENDOR BY PROBABLY MEANT
REGIONAL CENTER CODE ONE ONE SIX
WAS GIVEN TO US BY DDS IT WAS
IMPLEMENTED.
SO THAT WE COULD RECRUIT MORE
PROFESSIONAL STORY TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES.
AND SO NOW THEY ARE GOING TO
TAKE THAT AWAY AND WE'RE JUST
SORT OF BEHIND SQUARE ONE NOW SO
I AM JUST ASKING THAT ONE ONE
SIX SERVICE CUT REMAIN IN OUR
AREA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME'S KATHLEEN MOMENT I'M
ALSO FROM PROFESSIONAL
VALUATIONS IN DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES I'M ONE OF THE OWNERS I
ALSO MATCHING THAT YOU KEEP.
CODE ONE ONE SIX WE WOULD LOSE
SOMANY PEOPLE ARE TEACHERS ARE
SPEECH THERAPIST OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST NURSES THAT WE HAVE
THAT GOING TO HOMES AND SERVE
THE FAMILIES.
AND THEY ARE COMMITTED TO THESE
FAMILIES IN.
I CAN GET A LITTLE EMOTIONAL
HERE I'VE BEEN IN THIS.
BUSINESS FOR OVER FORTY YEARS.
THIS IS BEEN A AWAKENING FOR ME.
AND I REALLY HOPE THAT THIS
SUMMER.
YOU LOOK AT THINGS.
WHAT DOCTOR PAN?
SAID THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMIR BEARDSLEY
I PARKING THE SOCIAL SERVICES
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW.
AND I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE
POSITIVE IMPACT THESE SERVICES
HAVE ON THE PEOPLE WE SERVE
THEIR FAMILIES IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND I BELIEVE KEEPING THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICE SYSTEM
SUSTAINABLE WOULD GIVE THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE THE ABILITY TO
ACHIEVE.
THE AMERICAN DREAM THROUGH
BETTER QUALITY SERVICES ACCESS
TO MORE SERVICES AND A FULLY
INTEGRATED FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING IN
CONSIDERING AN 8% INCREASE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAURIE
ANGLE I AM A SELF ADVOCATE FOR
THE ORCA PLASTER COUNTY.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY I WHOLE
HEARTEDLY SUPPORT 8% INCREASE
FOR DS PEACE IN.
THE REFER WIDER TO BECAUSE I'D
BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH QUITE A FEW
ON WHAT MY OR OUR PROGRAM
VENTURA.
AND QUITE A FEW LONG HAD TO
LEAVE BECAUSE I THOUGHT THEY
WERE GETTING PAID ENOUGH WHERE
THEY HAD TO TAKE A SECOND OR
THIRD JOB.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY I FEEL
BURNED SO MUCH STATE THE THIRD.
DAY ARE THEY DEAD THEY DO SO
MANY GREAT THINGS FOR ME THEY
DID SOME PART MANY PEOPLE AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY THIS ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES.
WILL A. R. I'VE BEEN WELL AWARE
IN RECENT YEARS ABOUT AND
POSSIBLY COLLAPSING OR JUST
GOING AWAY ENTIRE AND I WANT TO
SAY.
I DON'T WANT TO EVER SEE THAT
HAPPEN THE MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
AT AYE -- IT'LL WORK WE HAVE YOU
KNOW WHAT I ADVOCATE WITH MY OLD
PROGRAM MANY OF ON THE PAN ON
THE SUPPORT AND SERVICES FOR OUR
LIVELIHOOD.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY.
DEMI WHAT THEY MEAN A LOT TO ME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO US TODAY.
MY NAME IS JIM MACEDA AND I RUN
A SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCY THAT IS
ALMOST ENTIRELY.
RUN BY -- IN ADULTS WITH
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL.
DISABILITIES I'M ALSO THE CHAIR
PERSON -- THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
FOR TERROR DAHLE SOUL IN LOS
ANGELES.
AND I KNOW YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT
ORGANIZATION.
I DON'T NEED TO SAY AND I'M ALSO
THE PROUD MOM OF A THIRTY FIVE
YEAR OLD DEVELOPMENTALLY DELAYED
DAUGHTER.
WITH PROFOUND TO INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU WHAT
THE LANHAM AN ACCESS I THINK ALL
OF US KNOW WHAT IT SAYS.
THE REGIONAL CENTERS IN THE
DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS AND THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND
FAMILIES.
WE HAVE WORKED VERY HARD OVER
THE LAST FIFTY YEARS OF THIS
LANHAM ACT TO GET WHERE WE ARE
TODAY.
WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO KEEP THE
PROMISE GIVEN TO US FIFTY YEARS
AGO.
AND SUPPORT OUR REQUEST FOR AN
8% RATE INCREASE THIS YEAR AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY. TO TAKE THE
TIME TO CAREFULLY READ THE RATE
STUDY.
AND MAKE THE RECOMMENDED
RECOMMENDATION RECOMMENDED AND
SUGGESTED CHANGES THAT WERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
BEFORE IT BECOMES IMPLEMENTED.
CALIFORNIA USED TO BE THE BEST
STATE IN THE COUNTRY FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
I'M GONNA WRAP UP NOW AND OVER.
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND OF THEM ARE HOPING AND
PRAYING THAT IT CONTINUES TO BE
SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS FOR
MUCH [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE AGUERO AND I'M
COMING TO REPRESENT TEAR THE
SOUL FOUNDATION.
AND I AND AND MY JOB THERE AT T.
ERA IS AS A CASE WORKER AND I
SUPPORT ABOUT THIRTY INDIVIDUALS
WITH INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
AND I ALSO SUPERVISE AND UNDERGO
TRAINING TO ABOUT.
TEN DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
AND IN MY THREE YEARS IN THIS
FIELD AND COMING AS ALSO AS A
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
THERE IS NO -- TRAINING IN
SCHOOL THERE'S NO CREDENTIALS
THERE'S YOU HAVE TO BE IN THE
FIELD AND BECOME A PROFESSIONAL.
AND WORK YOUR TRUST WITH THE
PERSON WITH IDT.
NOW WHEN I'M FACING AS IT NOW IN
THIS ROLE WITH THE 45% TURN OVER
I HAVE TO DEAL WITH STAFF THAT
ARE EXHAUSTED THEY'RE WORKING
EIGHTY HOURS A WEEK BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO HAS TWO JOBS. THREE JOBS
AND THEY'RE STILL PASSIONATE
ABOUT.
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY'RE WORKING
WITH -- THERE'S A THEY IMPACT
PEOPLE WITH ID DE PERMANENCY AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE 8%
INCREASE TO KEEP THIS
PROFESSIONAL LIFE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
PLACE OF THE MICROPHONE.
OUR HELLO AYE MAXIMILIANO REESE --
FROM REPRESENTING TERRIBLE SOUL --
I JUST ON MY POSITION HERE --
SOUL IS COST CREE INSTRUCTOR.
ARE WE HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS HAVE GRADUATED FROM
HIGH SCHOOL IN THAT WE ARE IN
TRANSITION INTO THE COLLEGE
SETTING.
WE ALSO HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN COLLEGE FOR
ONE A STRUGGLING WITH THE
CLASSES.
I FEEL THE WORK THAT WE DO IS
IMPORTANT BUT WE ARE PAID THE
SAME WAGES AS MCDONALD'S
EMPLOYEES BUT UNLIKE THE
MCDONALDS EMPLOYEES YOU WE ARE
WORKING WITH PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
CAREER PATHS.
INSTEAD OF FAST FOOD.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE ENJOYED THIS
JOB YET THEY'VE HAD TO LEAVE IT
DUE TO BEING UNABLE TO GET BY
FROM THE WAGES THAT THEY'RE
BEING PAID -- THOSE OF US WHO
WISH TO SANTA COLLEGE CAREER
POSITION WE HAVE TO GET SECOND
JOBS ARE FINANCIAL HELP FOR
PARENTS.
AND WE OFTEN COME TO WORK TIRED
EXHAUSTED FROM HAVING WORKED --
TEN HOUR SHIFTS FROM THE
PREVIOUS DAY.
BUT WE STILL CHOOSE TO STAY IN
THIS POSITION BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
IN THE WORK THAT WE DO.
NOT CAN TELL YOU THERE IS NO
GREATER JOY THAN IT AND AND THIS
POSITION WHEN A STUDENT.
COMES UP TO YOU AND SAYS THEY
PASSED THE CLASS WITH A NAY WHEN
THEY WERE STRUGGLING WITH THAT
COST SO MUCH OR WHEN THEY SHOW
YOU THEIR CERTIFICATE.
OR THEIR ASSOCIATES DEGREE AND I
CAN HONESTLY SAY THAT I'VE NEVER
HAD A JOB SO FOR FILLING MY LEFT
IN THE JOB I HAVE A TERRIBLE
SOUL.
OUR IN CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT THE RACE STUDIES A VERY
IMPORTANT BUT IT'S MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STUDY IS RIGHT.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT IT CREATES A
SUSTAINABLE WEIGHT FOR STUFF
LIKE ME.
OUR IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT
MODELS LIKE SUCH AS THE COLLEGE
TO CAREERS ARE NOT OVERLOOKED IN
THE NEW STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME I GET AFTERNOON BRIAN
STILL.
ALSO DISAPPEAR TERREL DEL SOL
OUT OF NORTH LA COUNTY COUNTY --
WHENEVER I TELL SOMEONE WHAT I
DO.
MOM ALMOST INEVITABLY I GET THE
SAME RESPONSE -- WHICH IS THAT
SOUND SO REWARDING -- THEY'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT FINANCIALLY OF
COURSE -- WHAT THEY'RE REALLY
SAYING THOSE MORE TROUBLESOME --
THEY'RE SAYING THAT IT'S SUCH A
NICE THING TO DO.
IT'S NOT SEEN AS A CAREER --
IT'S IT'S JUST SEEN IN THAT WAY --
AND AND THERE'S A THERE'S A AN
EFFECT THAT THIS HAS WHICH IS BY
DELEGITIMIZE OUR WORK IN THAT
WAY IT FURTHER MARGINALIZES A
POPULATION THAT CONSTANTLY
HOUSES THE VISIBILITY IN THE
FIRST PLACE -- FIVE ONE ONE
OTHER POINT TO CENTRALLY RUNS
OFF THE GOOD WILL.
OF OF THOSE FEW TO WHOM IT
SPEAKS ALREADY.
ON AND INSULATES THE THE
COMMUNITY FROM PEOPLE ON THAT
NORMALLY WOULDN'T WHAT MIGHT
CONSIDER IT AFFECT PAID MARK.
ON THE OTHER THE ONLY OTHER
THING IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
LEVERAGE TO THE TEACHERS HAVE.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE SEEN AS
ESSENTIAL TO SOCIETY BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT A WE CANNOT GO ON
STRIKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
DONNA FONDLED WITH THE ADOPTIVE
LEARNING CENTER.
BOBBI MICHAEL GEORGE TJ JOHN
JORDAN TAMI THOSE ARE THE SEVEN
YOUNG MEN BOYS WITH AUTISM.
I WORK WITHIN MY FIRST JOB OUT
OF COLLEGE NEARLY FORTY YEARS
AGO THIS IS ONE AUTISM WASN'T A
HOUSEHOLD WORLD.
I HAD NO PROP PERSONAL OR
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE NO
SKILLS NO TRAINING THREE HOURS
INTO MY FIRST FOURTEEN HOUR
SHIFT WAS NO LABOR LAWS BACK
THEN EITHER -- I WONDERED I
THOUGHT I HAD MADE THE WORST
MISTAKE OF MY LIFE.
AND I WAS WONDERING WHY IT
WASN'T AN ACCOUNTING MAJOR.
HOWEVER IT TURNS OUT IT WAS THE
BEST. ONE OF THE BEST DECISIONS
I EVER MADE THE CHANGE MY LIFE
THESE YOUNG MEN TAUGHT ME SO
MUCH THE TOP TAUGHT ME THAT WE
ARE MORE ALIKE THAN WE ARE
DIFFERENT.
AND THAT WE MUST RESPECT AND
HONOR OUR DIFFERENCES.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY THEY TAUGHT
ME THAT.
US THE DIRECT CARE STAFF WERE
THE MOST IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN
THEIR LIVES EXCEPT FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND WE HAVE THE MOST
IMPACT INTO THE QUALITY OF THEIR
LIVES.
WE KNOW THROUGH A STUDY THAT WE
HAVE A WORKFORCE THAT IS LIVING
IN POVERTY THIS IS NOT RIGHT WE
HAVE INDIVIDUAL SITTING AT HOME
BECAUSE AGENCIES CAN'T PROVIDE.
STAFF THIS IS NOT RIGHT WE NEED
TO DO BETTER FOR A CITIZENS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES THAT WE NEED TO DO
BETTER. FOR A WORKFORCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIMPLY
SUPPORT THE 8%.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS APRIL A ROO AND
I'M A DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL ADDED AFTER
LEARNING CENTER IN CONCORD.
WE'RE ASKING FOR AN 8% RAISE
BECAUSE AS JOHN F. KENNEDY
JUNIOR STATED.
QUALITY IS DEFINED AS THE POINT
OF INTERACTION BETWEEN THE STAFF
MEMBER AND THE INDIVIDUAL WITH A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY.
A DIRECT SUPPORT PERSON CAN BE
COMPARED TO A SURE BET WORKING
QUIETLY AND CONSTANTLY IN THE
BACKGROUND LIVES OF THE PEOPLE
WE SUPPORT.
WE ARE HIGHLY SKILLED AND
EXPERIENCED PROFESSIONALS WHO
PREPARE THE WAY FOR OTHERS TO
MAKE IT ON THEIR OWN THEIR OWN
MOUNTAIN TO A FULFILLED LIFE.
WE WALKED BESIDE HIM OURSELVES
CARRYING MOST OF THE LOAD.
PLEASE GIVE THE 8% RAISE TO HELP
IMPROVE OUR QUALITY OF LIFE EVEN
AS WE IMPROVE THERE'S THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
BUT AFTERNOON AFTERNOON A JENNY
WILCOX AT THE I'M A DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL ADAPTIVE
LEARNING CENTER CONCORD.
ON THE DIVERT DID OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY SYSTEM
DESPERATELY NEEDS A RATE
INCREASE SO THAT DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS LIKE MYSELF CAN
MAKE BETTER WAGES WHICH IN TURN
WILL LEAD TO HIGHER RETENTION
AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY AND
STABILITY.
OF THE WORK FORCE FOR DSPS.
TODAY TO REQUEST A PERCENT
INCREASE TO HELP STABILIZE THE
SYSTEM HERE'S WHY.
THE COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S ASTRONOMICAL WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON THAT THE US NATIONAL
COST OF LIVING INDEX IS BASED ON
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF ONE HUNDRED
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY'S OVERALL
COST OF LIVING IS A HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE POINT.
NINE NEARLY DOUBLE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
HOUSING IS THE BIGGEST FACTOR IN
THE CAR FACTOR IN THE COST OF
LIVING DIFFERENCE AT 310070% NOT
TO MENTION.
TRANSPORTATION 142% GROCERIES
HONORED 10% HEALTH CARE 110% ON
AND ON RENT RENT AVERAGE RENT
AND CONTRA COSTA IS TWO THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS
TOTAL TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
COST OF LIVING HAS INCREASED ITS
FASTEST RATE IN TEN YEARS AND
IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
ESCALATE CALIFORNIA MADE A
PROMISE THE LETTERMAN ACT TO THE
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES. TO PROTECT THEIR
DIGNITY INDEPENDENCE AND THE
PEOPLE ARE RELYING ON THE
PROMISE TO BE KEPT PLEASE KEEP
THE PROMISE TO GIVE YOU.
HE'S GOT THE MICROPHONE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS LINDA CRUISING AND
I HAVE AN EIGHT OH FIVE PROGRAMS
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND
WE SERVICE THE MOST WELL
VULNERABLE INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
I'M NOT GOING TO REPEAT
EVERYTHING THAT.
EVERYONE BE THANK YOU HE SAID SO
I JUST WANT YOU TO CONSIDER THE
INFANT DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM AND
NOT DESTROY IT.
WE DO DO WONDERS FOR OUR
FAMILIES.
THANK YOU FOR THE CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU AS A PEDIATRICIAN I DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO I'M A LONER YORKSHIRE I'M --
THE CLINICAL DIRECTOR AT THAT
OLD SKILL CENTER NUMBER OF
PRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES AREA --
SIMILARLY TO THE EIGHT OH FIVE
AND ONE ONE SIX PROGRAMS THAT.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT I DO WANT
TO POINT OUT THERE'S ALSO ONE
ONE SEVEN WHICH SIMILARLY SERVES
ADULT OVER.
TWENTY ONE AND A WITH THAT MULTI
DISCIPLINARY PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL TEAM AND THOSE ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE COMING OUT
OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IN
INSTITUTIONALIZED SETTINGS.
WHICH WE ALL WANNA OBVIOUSLY OP
CLOSE THOSE DOWN AND AND IT
WITHOUT THOSE PROGRAMS WITH THE
PROPOSED -- LAYERING OF SMA READ.
THEY WILL BE DECIMATED AND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
LEAVE THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
AND MOST WILL BE COMMON
INCARCERATED OR RE
INSTITUTIONALIZED IN STATE
HOSPITALS.
ON THE OTHER PART -- AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT THE DEPARTMENT AND
EVERYONE RECOGNIZES THIS AND
WITH THE RATE STUDY WE WILL COME.
TO A SOLUTION -- FOR FOR ALL OF
THESE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES WHAT
I WANT TO SAY IS THAT WITHOUT
THE 8% NOW.
THERE WILL BE A COLLAPSE OF MANY
OF OUR SERVICES SO THAT IS WHAT
WE NEED THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME'S MICHELLE
HEIGHT I'M A BOARD CERTIFIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM FOR
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING I KNOW
IT'S ALL BEEN A LONG HEARING BUT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HEAR
FROM THE COMMUNITY SO I
APPRECIATE THAT.
AS BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS WE DO
APPRECIATE MANY ASPECTS OF THE
RATE STUDY INCLUDING THE
INCLUSION OF REGISTERED BEHAVIOR
TECHNICIANS FOR SOME PROGRAMS.
HOWEVER AS STATED FOR OTHER AND
WAIT FOR OTHER WAGES.
THOSE THE WAGES IN THE RATE
STUDY DO NOT SUPPORT THE HIRING
OF RB TEASE THE SO THAT'S GOING
TO BE A REALLY BIG CHALLENGE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE TIME TO VET
THE ASSUMPTIONS WE ALSO REALLY
URGE REVIEW OF THAT I'M RATE
MODELS DUE TO OTHER CONCERNS
THAT WE PUT IN WRITING TO THE
DEPARTMENT SO WE'LL HOPEFULLY
HAVE SOME I'M DISCUSSION.
THERE'S ALSO ELIMINATION OF
SERVICE CODE SIX OH FIVE WHICH
FOR BEHAVIORAL SERVICE PROVIDERS
THAT'S OFTEN USED -- TO TEACH
ADAPTIVE SKILLS TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO.
REALLY BENEFIT FROM THAT
TRAINING.
WHAT WAS SO AND WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE 8% THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING APPRECIATED?
THANK YOU IT'S COME WITH MICHAEL
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DEBORAH TO NELLY AND I'M WITH
THE EARLY START VENDOR IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY GREATER LOS
ANGELES AREA AND I'M REALLY
PROUD TO BE HERE AS A CITIZEN OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND REALLY PROUD TO SEE
EVERYBODY AND I CONCUR SOMETIME
IN EARLY START VENDOR FOR THAT
INCREASE OF 8%.
AND WHAT -- EVERYBODY IS SAID SO
BEAUTIFULLY MINUTE CREAM IT WITH
THE PROBLEMS WITH THE LOW THE
MEDI CAL RATE WILL NOT SUSTAIN
OUR LICENSE PEOPLE WE WILL LOSE
THEM.
BUT EVEN.
WHAT I CAN'T GET OVER IT TODAY
IS I'VE NEVER BEEN SO WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT EARLY START SO I
JUST?
ASK THAT WE TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
AND REALIZE THAT EARLY START
WORK.
AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID BEFORE WE
HELP BABIES WE AMELIORATE MANY
OF THEIR DELAYS.
BUT WE DO IT UNDER THE AUSPICES
OF A TEAM APPROACH AND IT WOULD
FRACTURE IN FRAGMENT THE WAY
THAT WE CAN INTERACT WITH OUR
FAMILIES.
ON A DAILY BASIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE MARTIN BEEN
DOING THIS FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS --
I'M SPEAKING FOR ALL OF ABILITY
FIRST AND THAT'S LIKE ALL OF OUR
LOS ANGELES LOCATIONS EVEN OUR
CAMP IN SAN BERNADINO MOUNTAINS --
I WANT TO ADDRESS THE ZERO TWO
EIGHT WELL BACK IT UP WE NEED
THAT 8% AND WE NEED IT LIKE
YESTERDAY BUT WILL.
AND SOMETIMES EIGHT ONE TEN BUT
BIRDS DO NOT VERY MANY PEOPLE OF
SPOKE ABOUT -- ZERO TWO A WHICH
IS SOCIALIZATION -- I PROVIDE
AFTER SCHOOL CARE FOR EIGHTY
THREE CHILDREN FROM CLAREMONT.
FROM FONTANA TO GLENDORA CHINO
AND WE'RE GETTING THESE GUYS
READY FOR WORK TO JOIN THAT
WORKFORCE BUT WHEN.
WE HAVE SO MANY SINGLE PARENTS
SO MANY SINGLE MOMS DADS THAT
COULD NOT GO TO WORK IF THEY
DIDN'T HAVE A PROGRAM SO.
AND THE LOVELY RATE STUDY I KNOW
WE ALL WERE EXCITED YES WE'RE
TRYING TO GET PAID THIS CAN BE
BEAUTIFUL CAN BE WONDERFUL.
AND I GOT A CALL THEY'RE CUTTING
YOU IN HALF I'M GOING TO BE
REIMBURSED EIGHT DOLLARS AN
EIGHTY NINE CENTS I CAN'T RUN
PROGRAM THEY'LL BE POSING OUR
PROGRAMS.
AND PROBABLY TH ABOUT SIXTEEN
OTHER ONES IN LOS ANGELES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER PAN.
MY NAME'S DAVID MULTI -- I AM
HERE REPRESENTING THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
COMMITTEE WE REPRESENT.
REGIONAL CENTER AND DIRECT
SERVICE WORKERS -- ALONG WITH
LETTERMAN COALITION WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE 8% BRIDGE FUNDING
HAS BEEN REQUESTED FOR THIS YEAR.
AND SUPPORTING THE NEED TO MAKE
CORRECTIONS AND IMPLEMENT THE
RATE STUDY.
DOLE OUT TO GO THE WAY OF THE
CITY GATES STUDY THAT WAS DONE
TWENTY YEARS AGO BY THIS
LEGISLATURE.
AND COMPLETELY IGNORED AND HAS
LEFT US WITH CRITICAL FUNDING
DEFICIENCIES REGIONAL CENTER
OPERATIONS TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE
WAGE STUDY WAS BASED ON THE S.
P. DIFFERENT JOB TITLES.
BUT IN FACT THE S. PEAS ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE NOT ONE OF
THOSE SKILLS BUT ALL OF THEM
SIMULTANEOUSLY IN A NUMBER MORE
INCLUDING THAT OF TEACHER COACH --
PERSONAL TRAINER -- SO THE MUCH
MORE COMPLEX PICTURE THAN THAT.
POINTS OUT I'M ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT PROPOSAL TO
TARGET FUNDING FOR A. T. B. S.
COMPLIANCE SERVICES -- THE
SERVICES THAT NEED HELP TO
BECOME COMPLIANT MAY AFFECT ME
THAT FUNDING MORE THAN THE
SERVICES ARE ALREADY COMPLIANT
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
IS REALLY TOP GOOD AFTERNOON --
SENATOR PAN -- SENATOR TADO AND
SENATOR STONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO OUR CAUSE
THANK YOU TO THE LA OWES OFFICE
FOR YOUR PROPOSAL.
HI MY NAME IS YOLANDA BOSCH AND
I'M WITH BOSCH CONSULTING I
REPRESENT A NUMBER OF VENDORS
DOWN IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY -- DO
OUR RESIDENTIAL FIGHTERS AND A
PROGRAM PROVIDERS SERVE OVER
THOUSAND CLIENTS I'M AN ATTORNEY
I'M AN ADVOCATE ON THE FORMER'S
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF PERSON.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY A MAN WHOSE
MOM AYE ANDERS MY SON WHO'S
FIFTEEN WHO HAS AUTISM -- BUT I
AGREE WITH THAT WOULD -- WHEN
SAYS SO FOR THAT I JUST SAY
PLEASE LISTEN TO EVERYONE ELSE
SAW FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON -- JUST
WANT ONE THING PRETTY MUCH AND
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO MY
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE NANCY
PARCHMENT -- THIS SYSTEM ISN'T
DDS AND IT ISN'T REGIONAL
CENTERS THE SYSTEM IS ALL THESE
PEOPLE HERE ALL OF THE CLIENTS
ALL THE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
SERVING.
EVERYONE WHO NEEDS HELP IT'S
FAMILIES IT'S IT'S BUT SELF WHO
HAS A SON IT'S ALWAYS PEOPLE WHO
TOOK THEIR TIME TO COME HERE
TALK TO YOU THAT'S THE SYSTEM.
AND I JUST AND OUR SYSTEM NEEDS
HELP NOW IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
HELP WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE HERE.
AND SO MY POINT IS THAT NO
MATTER HOW MUCH WE HAVE TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH CMS OR HOW MUCH
REGIONAL CENTERS DID OVERSIGHT.
IF WE DON'T FIX THE SYSTEM.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE NO SYSTEM
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE NO VENDORS SO
NO VENDORS NO SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR PAN MY
NAME IS CHERYL JACKSON I'M HERE
REPRESENTING NEW HORIZONS IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY FROM THE LOS
ANGELES AREA.
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I CONCUR
WITH EVERYONE OF COURSE AND HERE
TODAY TO US.
TO ASK YOU TO APPROVED A PERCENT
INCREASE -- THIS INCREASE IS AN
IMMEDIATE NEED TO STOP THE
DAMAGING IMPACT OF INCIPIENT TO
INSUFFICIENT FROZEN RATES OF THE
NEED FOR FURTHER DISCUSSION NEED
TO CONTINUE WITH RELEVANT AND
CURRENT FEED THAT.
LEADING TO A DECISION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION THE DRESSING
SEVERAL AREAS OF SUPPORT AS
BECAUSE THE STAFF MEMBER.
AND ALSO I SPEAK AS A PARENT
WITH OF A PARENT OF A PERSON
WITH DISABILITIES WHO WANTS A
QUALITY OF LIFE SAFETY AND A
FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY PEOPLE CAN COME UP YOU
KNOW THE STAND THAT FAR BACK
FROM THE MICROPHONES AT HOME.
HI MY NAME IS KIM AND I
REPRESENT EASY PEEL A UNITED-CEREBRAL PALSY OF THE GREATER
LOS ANGELES AREA -- AND I WANTED
TO JUST ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
IMPROVING -- APPROVING THE 8%
INCREASE YOU'VE HEARD MANY --
WORDS TODAY BUT I THINK THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL WORDS ARE FROM THE
PEOPLE THAT RECEIVE SERVICES SO
PLEASE CONSIDER EVERYTHING
THAT'S BEEN SAID TODAY AND GOOD
ABOUT FOR US WHEN YOU'RE MAKING
YOUR DECISION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI WELCOME.
THE DOCTOR PAN SENATOR D'AMATO'S
DISTINGUISH STAFF RICKROLLING
TRIPS IN ARKANSAS SHE SHE
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES --
TRACTORS EGGMAN DID A TERRIFIC
JOB OF EXPLAINING OUR POSITION
ON THE RATE STUDY I JUST LIKE TO
ADD OUR SUPPORT FOR THE 8%
INCREASE IS A PROUD MEMBER OF
THE LETTERMAN COALITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS CRAIG ROSEN WITH
COMMUNITY INTEGRATED WORK
PROGRAM WE HAVE AND ALL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS BEHAVIORAL
PROGRAMS TRANSPORTATION CRISIS
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
AND LET'S SAY IT'S NOT HYPERBOLE
TO SAY THAT OUR INDUSTRY.
IS TEETERING ON THE EDGE OF A
CLIFF IN FACT PEOPLE OF FALLING
OVER IT THEY'RE ALREADY
CASUALTIES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE'VE HAD
TREMENDOUS DIFFICULTY RECRUITING
NEW STAFF ESPECIALLY OVER THE
PAST TWELVE MONTHS FOR THE MORE
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF OUR
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
TELL US THEY CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD TO DO THE WORK THEY LOVE.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OUR THIRTY
TWO THIRTY TWO YEAR HISTORY WERE
FORCED TO SUSPEND SERVICES TO A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS.
AT ONE OF OUR LOCATION SIMPLY
BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE THE STAFF
IN PLACE TO PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF SUPPORT. FOR THIS
PROGRAM WE HAD ONLY TWO OPTIONS
INTERNET SERVICES FOR SOME OF
OUR PARTICIPANTS ARE CLOSE THE
PROGRAM AND PER MILLION SERVICES
FOR EVERYONE.
WHICH IS THE FORMER WITH THE
HOPES THAT YOU WILL TAKE THE
STEPS NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE THE MEANS TO RETAIN
EXISTING TALENT.
AND ALSO ATTRACT A NEW
GENERATION OF DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS SADLY THIS
DISCUSSION TAKING IS TAKING
PLACE AT SEVERAL OF A OF OUR
OTHER LOCATIONS AND I KNOW WE'RE
NOT THE ONLY ONES HAVING IT --
THE EFFECT WAS HELD FELT BY A
HANDFUL OF INDIVIDUALS BUT WHEN
OTHER AGENCIES HAVE TO MAKE
SIMILAR CHOICE IS THE PEOPLE
AFFECTED WILL DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE BECAUSE OF THE
STRANGLEHOLD ON OUR RATES.
AND FOR EVERY PERSON WHO IS AT
RISK OF LOSING SUPPORT THEIR
COUNTLESS INDIVIDUALS WHO STILL.
STILL WAITING TO EVEN BEGIN
RECIEVING SERVICES WITHOUT THE
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS STAFF
SERVICES ARE GET CENSORING WRAP
UP PLEASE OKAY.
IT IS UP TO YOU TO WAKE THEM
FROM THE NIGHTMARE THEIR TWO
CHOICES YOU EITHER CARE CARE YOU
DON'T THERE'S NO MIDDLE GROUND
IF YOU WANT BASIC ADULT DAY CARE
CONTINUE WITH THE CURRENT
FUNDING LEVELS BUT LOWERED
EXPECTATIONS.
IF YOU WANT SKILLED
PROFESSIONALS WHO TEACHERS ALL
CRISIS PHASES SOLD AND I AM
GONNA THAT'S A WRAP UP PLEASE --
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE PERCENT
INCREASE THANK THANK YOU.
OKAY SIDE YOU KNOW AGAIN WE WANT
TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE ALLEN JUST
REMIND PEOPLE WE'VE HAD OVER AN
HOUR OF PUBLIC COMMENTS -- AFTER
THIS ITEM I HAVE TO HEAR WE THIS
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BE HEARING
ANOTHER TWENTY FOUR PROPOSALS.
AND THOSE PEOPLE ARE WAITING --
SO AGAIN AND WE WANNA HEAR FROM
YOU -- BUT I ASK YOU TO TRY TO
BE TO THE POINT OF SOMEONE
ELSE'S REYES SAID WELL YEAH SAY
YOU CAN SAY I AGREE WITH THEM
AND WE CAN.
SELL.
ALRIGHT SO WELCOME THANK YOU --
JOHN BELOW EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CONTRA COSTA A. R. C. -- I'D
LIKE TO SAY SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THE THE THE 8% THAT MANY MANY
PEOPLE HAVE -- EXPRESSED SUPPORT
OF AT I DON'T THINK THEY FINISH
TO STAY MINUTES 8% ACROSS THE
BOARD.
AND I REALLY WANT TO STRESS THAT
BECAUSE KIDS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
ARE IMPORTANT -- TO THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE CLOSING -- TO THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE STRUGGLING TO SO I
REALLY WOULD URGE -- THE
COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION TO UNDERSTAND --
I THINK THE GOVERNOR IS IS VERY
IN SUPPORT OF KIDS IN THESE
UNDERSTAND THE KIDS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS OUR KIDS -- TO AND THAT
THAT THAT THAT DOES FIT WITHIN
IS HIS HIS INITIATIVE.
AND THAT AND THAT CUTTING THEM
OUT I DID LOOK AT THE MAY REVISE
AS A LITTLE UPSET BY CUTTING
THAT OUT PLAYING FAVORITES IS
NOT ACROSS THE BOARD.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
RIGHT WELCOME.
YEAH I WAS HOPING TO BE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT BOTH SUBJECTS
SEPARATELY BUT I'LL DO TOGETHER%
SO -- FIRST I WANTED -- TO THANK
THE CENTER PANNED DOCTOR PANZER
TAUGHT OF CENTER STONE FOR HIS
EARLIER COMMENTS AND CERTAINLY
THAT OF OF THE THE PERSONAGES OF
DDS AND THE ALEJO'S OFFICE --
FIRST FOR AS MANY AS MY CAREER --
I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
L. ACOSTA CENTERS WHICH PROVIDES.
IT SERVICES TO FOR AFTER SCHOOL
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS AND ADULTS
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAM AND I'M
LOCATED IN BERKELEY -- I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PERCENTS FOR A
LOT OF THE REASONS A MIKE BUT
MANY OF OUR IN HOUSE SAID -- AND
REALLY.
THE THING I WANT TO UNDERSCORE
AND I THINK IT'S BEEN KIND OF
UNDERSTOOD BY THOSE WHO SPOKE IN
THIS ROOM BY THOSE WHO ARE HERE
TODAY.
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING CRISIS
ON MULTIPLE LEVELS.
THERE'S YOU KNOW CRISIS OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
NEED TO GET RETAIN SERVICES
WHICH IS WHY ONE THING THAT
HASN'T BEEN DISCUSSED.
ENOUGH IS THE RETENTION OF
CAPACITY.
WE NEED TO HAVE BEEN PROTECT AS
MANY SERVICES AS POSSIBLE SO
THAT.
OUR PEOPLE CAN -- GET WITH A
NEED SO -- YOU KNOW IT'S VERY
COMPLEX ISSUE IT WAS COMING FOR
YOU I WOULD HELP CONFRONT THAT
SO THANK YOU -- IRISH THE 8% AND
CERTAINLY -- ADOPTION OF THE
REMOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME'S
LESLIE WEST AS WELL IN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BUILDING NOW BAY AREA WHICH WAS
FORMERLY THIS REAL POLICY CENTER
FOR THE BAY AREA LOCATED IN
OAKLAND.
WE PROVIDE US SUPPORTS TWO
ADULTS AND THREE DAY SERVICES WE
PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TOTAL AND PERSONAL CARE SUPPORTS
THROUGHOUT THE DAY WE SUPPORT
ENTREPRENEURS THAT WANT TO RUN
THEIR OWN BUSINESSES.
AND I HAVE THIRTY EIGHT STAFF
FIVE OF THOSE POSITIONS ARE
CURRENTLY VACANT AND IT IS
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING.
TO CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THE
STAFF THAT I HAVE AND TO RECRUIT
EXCITING NEW TALENT TO BE ABLE
TO BE YOU KNOW AS PASSIONATE
ABOUT PROVIDING.
THE SUPPORTS TO INDIVIDUALS AS
ALL THE REST OF US ARE AYE ECHO
EVERYTHING THAT EVERYONE HAS
SAID IN THE ROOM I REALLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE 8% ASK AND TO
KEEP THE PROMISE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU MY NAME IS
SERRA VERITY AM REPRESENTING
GATE PASSED THE PROVIDER IN SAN
MATEO AND SANTA CLARA COUNTIES
AND I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
8% ACROSS THE BOARD INCREASE I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
THE SYSTEM IS IN CRISIS NOT
CRISIS ISN'T SILO ROAD. TO A
SPECIFIC THIRD BASE COAT OR A
CERTAIN AGE IT'S A CRISIS ACROSS
THE BOARD AND THIS 8% AS A DOWN
PAYMENT IT'S PUTTING A BANDAID
ON A GUNSHOT WOUND.
WE CANNOT RECRUIT AND RETAIN
STAFF THE FUNDING WE RECEIVE
FROM THE STATE FORCES OUR WORK
FORCE TO LIVE IN POVERTY AND I'M
JUST GOING TO REPEAT WHAT JORDAN
SAID. 34% HAVE SECOND JOB
WORKING TWENTY HOURS OR MORE 42%
HAVE CHILDREN ON MEDI CAL 36% --
ON MEDI CAL 20% RECEIVE PUBLIC
FOOD ASSISTANCE AND 10% RECEIVE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE THEY DESERVE
BETTER I SUPPORT A PERCENT
ACROSS THE BOARD INCREASE THANK
YOU THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
PEOPLE IN A ROOM FOR STUFF BUT
YOU KNOW AGAIN WE WANT TO BE
CONSCIOUS OF THE OTHER PEOPLE
ALSO A PRESENTER.
ITEMS SO THANK YOU WELCOME THANK
YOU HAVE TO PAN VERY DIRTY ANY
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION ONE THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF AS WELL SENATOR TITLE
FOR THE HEARING TODAY.
WANT TO JUST BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
THE RATES THAT I WANT TO THANK
DDS AND BURNS FOR THE TREMENDOUS
WORK THEY'VE DONE ON THIS SO FAR.
AS YOU HEARD THERE ARE NUMBER OF
CORRECTIONS AND ASSUMPTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE MADE BUT I DO THINK
THERE ARE SOME GOOD THEY'RE GOOD
BONES THERE.
AND IF WE CAN MAKE THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS WE DO HAVE A
BUILDING BLOCKS FOR NEW SYSTEM
GOING FORWARD.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
SOME PART OF THIS RATE STUDY
GETS IMPLEMENTED THIS YEAR
WHETHER IT MEANS PUTTING SOME
MONEY INTO THE BUDGET -- AND
THEN FIGURING OUT IN SIX MONTHS
THAT'S ONE THING BUT WE DON'T
WANT LET THIS BECOME A
PAPERWEIGHT ESSENTIALLY -- ON
THE PERCENT I DON'T THINK I'LL
SAY IT ANY BETTER THAN SERRA'S
OF RELATES TO WORKFORCE BUT ALSO
WANT TO REITERATE WHAT IT MEANS
TO SERVICES TO PEOPLE WE HAVE
CLOSING ERVICES WEIGHTLESS
PEOPLE NOT GETTING WHAT THEY
NEED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WELCOME.
COME ON CITY PAVEMENTS CO A BILL
THE ABILITY XIN INDUSTRIES IN
THE LOS ANGELES AREA IS ONE
START BY THINKING YOU GUYS FOR
HEARING US TODAY I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT.
THE MOMENTUM IS HERE FOR THE
RATE STUDY AND WE APPRECIATE YOU
GUYS TAKING THE TIME TO DO THAT
AND IT'S IT'S IT'S A GREAT START
IT'S IT'S MORE THAN A START.
BUT I COME FROM THE UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE OF ALSO WORKING AT
THE REGIONAL CENTER DURING A
TIME WHEN I PERSONALLY HAD TO
TELL MY SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ONE HALF
PERCENT OFF THE TOP OF YOUR
PAYMENTS WE'RE GONNA.
ONLY GIVE YOU MEDIUM RIGHT
MEDIAN RATES THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THE RATES THAT YOU HAVE EVEN
THOUGH YOU'RE ALREADY FAILING
ARE FROZEN AND WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING MORE FOR YOU TO THIS 8%
IS A START AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS MUCH WELCOME
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SORRY.
DAVIES ASSET I READ FOR HER
TODAY SHE'S -- KINDA NERVOUS.
HI AM DEBBY CAMPBELL I'VE CHOSEN
STEP FOR BY SUPPORTED LIVE EVEN
AGENCY.
MY IDEAS PD DELIVERABLE WAGE SO
SHE CAN TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ME ANOTHER TEN YEARS
[inaudible]
I READY ONE MONTH WE ARE FAMILY
WE ARE A FAMILY.
BY D. S. P. AND MEAN MEAN.
SO -- THAT'S FROM DEBBIE'S
PERSPECTIVE M. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AS A D. S. P. FOR
TEN YEARS -- ELEVEN ACTUALLY.
CAN YEARS JUST WITH DEBBIE.
BUT I WAS PERSONALLY REALLY
COUNTING ON IT 8% RAISE JUST TO
HI BE LOOKING GAS FOUR DOLLARS A
GALLON I MEAN WHAT.
CHU I DRIVE TO WORK OR DO I PAY
MY UTILITY BILLS I MEAN IT'S
JUST AS SIMPLE AS THAT SO PLEASE
FROM THIS THE CALIFORNIA'S.
STATE PAIN THE PERSON JUST WE
NEED OUR 8% THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BOTH [inaudible]
I OKAY.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHERYL WHITE
AND I'M THIS IS EXECUTIVE
IRECTOR AT CEDARS WHICH IS A
HUNDRED YEAR OLD ORGANIZATION
THAT OFFERS DAY AND RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES INCLUDING A LARGE HOME
AND ROSS WHICH IS OUR MOST
SOUGHT AFTER RESIDENTIAL
PLACEMENT.
ON PAGE SIXTEEN OF THE ALLEY --
REPORT AHMED NOTES THAT LARGER
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM THE RECOMMENDED RATE
INCREASES DUE TO THE PRESUMPTION.
THAT THEY WILL NOT BE COMPLIANT
WITH A CVS REGULATIONS WE
STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH THIS
PRESUMPTION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT IT BE RECONSIDERED
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS.
CMS IS ALREADY OUTLINED A
METHODOLOGY FOR ASSESSING
PROVIDER COMPLIANCE WITH EIGHT
CBS RULES.
AND THE PRESUMPTION THE REPORT
APPEARS TO SIDESTEP THIS PROCESS
AND AIMS TO INSTEAD START
PROVIDERS OUT OF EXISTENCE.
RATHER THAN ENGAGE IN THE
PROCESS.
FIGURES IS CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTING AN EIGHT CBS
COMPLIANCE GRANT FROM DDS
SPECIFIC TO OUR LARGE FACILITY
SO HOW DOES THIS PRESUMPTION
MATCH WITH THAT INVESTMENT.
THIS RECOMMENDATION AS IT IS HAS
POTENTIAL TO DO HARM.
FORCING ON WANT TO CHANGE ON THE
LIVES OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
WRITTEN FULL LIES IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF SAN ANSELMO AND
ROSS.
I'M HERE BECAUSE OF THEM AND I
HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER THE POWER
YOU HAVE OVER THEIR LIVES THANK
YOU THANK YOU I HAVE EXTENDED
COMMENTS IDEA PLEASE.
PLEASE TURN THAT INTO THE
SERGEANTS.
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU WELCOME.
MY NAME IS ANDY FRESH I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
AND I APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
THE BACK AND FORTH DIALOGUE
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON I REPRESENT
THE KIND OF SOMEONE TRAINING
CENTER.
WE PROVIDE HOUSING AND SUPPORTS
TO OVER SEVENTY FIVE INDIVIDUALS
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY ROUGHLY HALF
OF THOSE SERVED.
LIKE CHERYL LIVE IN -- HOME
SEVEN SEVEN PEOPLE ARE MORE DUE
TO A MISUNDERSTANDING OR A
MISREPRESENTATION OF THE
REGULATION THEM RULES.
IN A CBS A SENTENCE GUIDELINE --
THESE RESIDENTIAL HOMES ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THE BURNS RATE
STUDY THERE WAS NO
RECOMMENDATION WHATSOEVER --
UNLIKE VIRTUALLY EVERY OTHER
SERVICE CATEGORY -- I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT A MORE APPROPRIATE
AND TRANSPARENT APPROACH WOULD
BE TO TREAT THESE PROGRAMS THE
VERY SAME WAY THAT EVERY OTHER
BAND RISE PROGRAM IS BEING
TREATED.
FUND THEM ACCORDING TO THE DATA
THAT WAS RECEIVED IN THE RATE
STUDY AND THEN ENGAGE IN A
DISCUSSION WITH OUR RESIDENTS
ARE FAMILIES THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND SERVICE PROVIDERS.
ABOUT WHAT RESIDENTIAL SERVICES
THE STATE WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN
THE FUTURE PROVIDING INCENTIVES
FUNDING OR AT LEAST TO SAY FROM
REASONABLE PATH TO THIS DESIRED
OUTCOME INSTEAD THE CURRENT
TACTIC.
PENALIZES THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE PUTS THEM AT RISK BY
CREATING A TWO TIERED SYSTEM OF
FUNDING THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
WELCOME SENATOR PAN HAS HAVE
LONG SUFFERING STAFF THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUING ATTENTION
I'M CHRIS RICE WITH CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION.
THREE QUICK POINTS REGULATIONS
MONEY AND MAKE IT WORK IS TIM
BROWN WOULD SAY.
WE ARE FACING A REGULATORY
DECISIONS BEING MADE BY BY RATE
SETTING AND THAT IS
INAPPROPRIATE -- THE POINT THAT
THE LAST TWO SPEAKERS MADE.
IS A VERY IMPORTANT --
MISERICORDIA IN CHICAGO LARGE
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES INVOLVED.
PAST HEIGHTENED SCRUTINY IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT MANY OF THESE
SERVICES CAN CONTINUE IN THE
STATE ALSO -- THERE ARE OTHER
SERVICES THAT ARE ALSO GOING TO
GET STRANGLED IF WE DON'T SEE
FUNDING CALM NOW AND CERTAINLY
WITH THE THE RATE STUDY AS
CURRENTLY.
OUTLINED THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER
SERVICES SOME OF WHICH ARE VERY
EACH CBS COMPLIANT THAT COULD BE
KILLED OFF WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
THAT HAPPEN.
THAT IS WHY IT IS IMPORTANT TO
CONSIDER THE 8% ACROSS THE BOARD
INCREASE NOW FINALLY IN TERMS OF
MAKE IT WORK.
CHAIRMAN YOU HAVE THE POWER TO
ASK FOR A PLAN TO BE GIVEN TO
YOU BY THE DEPARTMENT THAT WILL
HELP YOU.
SET DEADLINES TO ENSURE THAT
WHAT YOU WANT TO SEE HAPPEN.
COMES ABOUT SO I URGE YOU TO DO
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
STORY TANAKA COMMUNITY SERVICES
DIRECTORATE MARIN VENTURES.
OUR INABILITY TO PAY A DECENT
WAGE AND RETAIN STAFF.
INHIBITS OUR ABILITY TO COMPLY
WITH H. CBS AND CLOSES DOORS FOR
OUR CLIENTS ON A DAILY BASIS.
FOR INSTANCE I TAKE A SMALL
GROUP OF SENIORS TO A LOCAL
SENIOR CENTER JUST FOR CLASS.
I WAS TRYING TO BUILD A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THAT AGENCY TO
SHOW WE WERE RELIABLE AND
DEPENDABLE AND PERHAPS LEAD TO A
VOLUNTEER POSITION FOR A YOUNGER
CLIENT.
AND A PATHWAY TO C. I. E.
HOWEVER EVERY TIME A CLIENT A
STAFF PERSON CALLED IN SICK WE
ARE SO CONTINUOUSLY UNDERSTAFFED.
BUT WE HAVE TO CANCEL OUR TRIP
TO THE CLASS AND I WAS RECENTLY
TOLD BY THE AGENCY THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE BEEN SO
UNRELIABLE IN OUR ATTENDANCE
THAT THEY CANNOT SEE US AS A
POSSIBILITY FOR EVEN A VOLUNTEER
POSITION.
SO DOOR CLOSED RIGHT THERE YES
ON THE 8% AND ON FROM THERE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MY COMMENT IS VERY
SHORT AND SWEET -- MY NAME'S ONE
HYTNER I'M A PROGRAM DIRECTOR.
OF AS A LESSON I A LESSON NAPA
COUNTY SOLANO AND SO NO MY
COUNTIES HAD RATTLED THEM OFF --
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
READY RIGHT NOW TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH PROFESSIONAL RISING OUR DS
PEAS WITH WAGES AND QUALITY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU -- ENTER KERN WITH AN
ALLIANCE -- I JUST DATA ON ALL
THAT 8% AS WELL AS WHAT BARRY
WAS TAKE ABOUT.
IF GOOD BONES IN THE RIGHT STUDY
BUT THERE'S SOME TWEAKS THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU WELCOME.
JOHN SCHMIDT ON THE PARENT OF A
FORTY SIX YEAR OLD MAN WITH
AUTISM NONVERBAL BEHAVIOR BYE
BYE -- I ALSO WAS A FOUNDER OF A
SUPPORTED LIVING AGENCY AND CAL
IN SACRAMENTO AND CREATIVE
LIVING OPTIONS AND I'M RETIRED
ALSO SAY I'M SEMI RETIRED I KEEP
COMING BACK -- BUT I WANT TO SAY
TWO THINGS WHO'S DOING THE WORK
RIGHT NOW FABULOUS PEOPLE YOU
HEARD FROM THEM TODAY I MEAN
THESE PEOPLE BACK AT OUR AGENCY
WE SUPPORT -- ABOUT ONLY ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE PEOPLE AND THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE WE KEEP
SAYING.
OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SALES WE
HIRE PEOPLE WITH HEART AND
YOU'VE HEARD THEM TODAY THEY'RE
JUST AND ALL THE AGENCIES THAT'S
IT BUT THEY ONLY CAN HAVE THE
HEART FOR SO LONG SO WEA.
INDOORS OF COURSE 8% BUT IT'S A
BANDAID -- THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SUPPORT ARE GETTING SO USED TO
HAVING NEW PEOPLE COME IN AN
INTERVIEW SO MANY PEOPLE.
QUICKLY MY SON HUGGED THE AIR
CONDITIONING.
PRESIDENT OF THE OTHER DAY
BECAUSE HE THOUGHT HE WAS A NEW
STAFF AND I HAD TO SAY OH NO YOU
KNOW HANSEL AND HENCE YOURSELF.
BUT THAT'S HOW HE JUST THOUGHT
HERE COMES SOMEONE ELSE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND YOUR HELP.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
DO YOU WANT A CO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CREATIVE LIVING
OPTIONS -- LOOK AT THEIR INVEST
SACRAMENTO -- WERE ONE OF THE
MANY MANY MANY AGENCIES THAT IS
STRUGGLING TO FIND -- QUALITY
SUPPORTS THAT YOU TO A LOCAL BY
THE BRIDGE THAT WE CAN AFFORD --
WE SUPPORT THE 8% OKAY THANK YOU.
HI WELCOME TRIED THAT ROBISON
DOWN BEEN WORKING HARD WITH MY
CASE MANAGER IN THAT BASS OFFICE.
TINA BELT HEY GAMES JOBS
BEGINNING OF JOBS IN THEIR MOB
CASE MANAGER GAVE ME A NICE JOB
TO BE INDEPENDENT.
AND NOT I SAY THAT YOU YOU.
NEED TO GO -- HERE [inaudible]
DEGREES.
DEGREES MORE ARE FUNDING FOR THE
ON THE WORK.
BECAUSE A WE NEED FOR US TO HAVE
PEOPLE LIKE.
BASS AND ROOM MY TO MY STAB WHY
HERE SHE'D TAKE ME TO MY DOCTOR
APPOINTMENT AND GIVE MY SOCKS
EVERY.
MONTH THERE STABILIZE ME AND
DANCE TO TAKE ME TO GET MOM WE
FEEL OF MY MEDICATION.
AND DâN ALSO SHE MADE SURE ARE
GONNA TRYING AND SEE MY FAMILY
ONCE A MONTH AND I GOT TWO KIDS
I'M HERE TO PORTS AND ONE GIRL.
EDUCATIONAL.
OF ME BECAUSE I ARM BEEN.
HELP GIVE MY HELLO.
AND GET MY SELF TOGETHER OKAY
THANK YOU THANKS RUSH
[inaudible]
RIGHT WELCOME [inaudible]
HELLO. SEVEN YEAR FOX WATSON
FROM CENTRAL VALLEY TRAINING
CENTER WE HAVE A DAY PROGRAMS
INDEPENDENT LIVING IN SUPPORTED
LIVING AND MOBILE CRISIS
RESPONSE FROM SACRAMENTO TO BUY
SELL YEAH.
SO -- WE TIME AND DOUBLE SHIFTS.
OF ESPECIALLY IN OUR MOBILE
CRISIS RESPONSE WHICH DEALS WITH
SOME OF THE MOST DIFFICULT TO
BEHAVE REALLY CHALLENGED
INDIVIDUALS AND AND THE
COMMUNITY.
SO WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE 8%
INCREASE TO STABILIZE RIGHT NOW
AND THEN ALSO A FAIR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OUTCOME OF
THE RATE STUDY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WELCOME.
PEOPLE CAN COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M PETER CARTER
AT SALAS PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITH
CHOICES IN OUR RANCHO CORDOVA.
LIKE THE SEVERAL DOZEN PEOPLE
BEFORE US TIME ASKING FOR MORE
FUNDING -- THE DIRECT SERVICE
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS WE
EMPLOYEE I'D LIKE TO REALLY
EMPHASIZE ARE NOT ANGELS THEY
ARE NOT FAIRY GODMOTHERS AND
THEY'RE NOT DOING THIS.
SOLELY OUT OF THE GOODNESS OF
THEIR HEART THEY'RE
PROFESSIONALS AND THEY'VE GOT
BILLS TO PAY JUST LIKE THE REST
OF US.
AND IF YOU'RE UNABLE TO FIND US
TO PAY THEM THEY'RE GONNA GO
WORK RETAIL WHERE THEY CAN GET
PAID ENOUGH TO AFFORD THEIR RENT --
FINALLY WILL I DON'T UNDERSTAND
ALL THE COMPLEXITIES OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET SYSTEM.
COMING FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
AN AVERAGE VOTING SLAB IF YOU DO
NOT FIND THIS RATE STUDY WHAT
I'M WONDERING IS WHY DID YOU PAY
ALL THIS MONEY TO GET THE RATE
STUDY.
DONE IN THE FIRST PLACE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HI NANCY CHANCE CHOICES PERSON
CENTERED SERVICES THE CALIFORNIA.
PERSONS UNDER PARTNERSHIP
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY COMMUNITY
ACT OF CHEN NETWORK AND TOUGH
FOR COLLABORATIVE -- I AM HERE
TO URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
IMMEDIATELY MOVE FORWARD WITH
IMPLEMENTATION OF PORTIONS OF
THE RATE STUDY WE PUT MONEY INTO
GETTING OUR EIGHT STUDY IN
PUTTING OUT THINK IT'S GOT SOME
GOOD BOUNCES OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
SAID.
I THINK WE NEED TO TO HELP
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT GOING TO BE
IN THE PORTIONS THAT ARE MOVE
FORWARD AND THAT WORK THEN I
THINK BILL LA -- MADE SOME GOOD
SUGGESTIONS IN THAT WAY BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO MOVE FOR WITH
THE THINGS THAT CAN BE MOVED FOR
WITH NOW I WOULD SUGGEST THINGS
THAT ARE EIGHT CBS COMPLAIN
ALREADY IS THAT'S THE WAY THAT
THE STATE IS GOING -- THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS DEBORAH HENRY I
WORK AT CHOICES AS AN AISLE AS
FACILITATOR.
I LOVE WHAT I DO I LOVE
SUPPORTING MY CLIENTS BUT IT'S
IT'S HARD TO STAY IN THIS FEEL
AT THE PAY RATE -- I WOULD LOVE
TO DO THIS AS A CAREER BUT IT IT
DOESN'T IT'S IT'S HARD LIKE THE
COST OF LIVING IS GOING UP THE
COST OF GAS IS INCREASING THINGS
EVERYONE HAS SAID -- PLEASE I
JUST SUPPORT THE 8% INCREASE AND
THEN I ALSO WANT TO READ
SOMETHING ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING HOUSING
DIRECTOR FOR CHOICE IS.
NICOLE LOW SHE SAYS I AM HERE IN
FULL SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGEMENT
OF THE RATE INCREASE.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE RATE TO
BE INCREASED TOO HOT TO THE
HIGHEST AMOUNT POSSIBLE WAY
BEYOND 8%.
I WANT TO MAINTAIN AND RECRUIT
QUALIFIED DS PEAS THAT PROVIDE
QUALITY SUPPORT AND I CAN ONLY
DO THAT WITH A RATE INCREASE.
I HAVE DSPS ASSISTING CLIENTS
WITH LOW INCOME COMMUNITY
RESOURCES AND LOW INCOME HOUSING
AND THEN USING THE SAME
RESOURCES THEMSELVES.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BETSY
KATE'S AND I'M ON THE BOARD OF
OUR CALIFORNIA AND I'M ALSO THE
PARENT OF AN ADULT SON WITH AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY.
OUR FAMILY HAS LIVED WITH THE
INADEQUACY.
AND UNCERTAINTY OF FUNDING FOR
THIS SYSTEM FROM.
VIRTUALLY MY SON'S ENTIRE LIFE
THAT WOULD BE THIRTY SEVEN YEARS --
YOU'VE HEARD ALL THE REASONS WHY
THAT IS A PROBLEM SO I WON'T
REPEAT IT BUT TODAY YOU DO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO BEGIN TO
RESTORE FISCAL HEALTH AND
STABILITY TO OUR SERVICE SYSTEM
SO I URGE SUPPORT FOR AN
IMMEDIATE INCREASE OF 8% INTO
OUR SYSTEM THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY MY NAME IS DANA THOMAS I'M
C. E. O. OF JABBER JIM IT'S A
PRIVATE AND NON PUBLIC AGENCY.
A SERVING KIDS -- FROM BIRTH --
TO TWENTY TWO CURRENTLY WE
EMPLOY APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS AND
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS.
AND TO SO MANY OF OUR THERAPISTS
HEARTS ARE AN EARLY INTERVENTION
THEY WANT TO WORK FOR THE
REGIONALS ARE THEY WANT TO DO
THE BIRTH.
TO THREE AND SO TO WEEK HOWEVER
SADLY WE'VE HAD TO RE ALLOCATE A
LOT OF OUR PROFESSIONALS TO
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES -- FOR
EXAMPLE MEDICAL -- JUST BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THEY PAY MORE AND I
CAN THEN PAY THEIR SALARIES SO
WE WOULD LOVE TO GET BACK INTO
EARLIER INTERVENTION ON A MUCH
GREATER LEVEL THANK YOU THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO -- MY NAME IS JOSH WHAT
THOMAS -- THAT WAS MY WIFE AND
MY BOSS -- WE DIVERGED HAVE BEEN
DOING EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES FOR OVER SEVENTEEN
YEARS NOW -- MY WIFE GIVE YOU
SOME OF THE STATISTICS BUT A
COUPLE OF THINGS I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT.
THAT I THINK THAT ARE IMPORTANT
IN THE RATE STUDY AROUND EIGHT
OH FIVE SERVICE CODE -- IS --
THE ASSUMPTION THAT --
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN HOURS
IN THE WEEK OUR BILLABLE THAT IS
COMPLETELY OFTEN IT'S THROWING
THE WORK RATE STRUCTURE
COMPLETELY -- NOT WHERE IT
SHOULD BE IT'S MORE LIKE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY BILLABLE
HOURS A MONTH AND THAT'S BECAUSE
OF ME I'M SORRY WEEK.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE TRAVEL TIME
THAT OUR THERAPIST TO BETWEEN
HOMES THE PAPERWORK ALL THE
STUFF THAT'S NON BILLABLE REPORT
WRITING THAT THEY DO THROUGHOUT
THE WEEK.
SO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF BILLABLE HOURS AND
THAT RATE SURVEY IT'S MORE LIKE --
TWENTY ALSO I WANNA SUPPORT NOT
MOVING S. T. O. T. M. P. T.
FIRMANDO FIVE INTO SEPARATE
SEPARATE SERVICE CODES WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO A WHOLE
CHILD APPROACH.
AND THAT WE KEEP THOSE --
SERVICES UNDERNEATH EIGHT OH
FIVE AND BROUGHT I'VE ALSO HEARD
A COUPLE OF PEOPLE MENTION
KEEPING THE ONE SIXTEEN SERVICE
CODE I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE REASON WE THEY WANT TO KEEP
IT IS BECAUSE IT'S VERY SIMILAR.
TO EIGHT OH FIVE AND IT'S FUNDED
AT 35% HIGHER THAN THE CURRENT
EIGHT OH FIVE SERVICE CODE WE
GOT A LOOK AT MAY BE CHANGING IN
A FIVE TO ONE SIXTEEN THANKS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KATHERINE
ROLLIN I WORK FOR A SELL SIDE
UNLIMITED A LOCAL NONPROFIT
PROVIDING SERVICES TO ADULTS.
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
HERE IN SACRAMENTO FIRST I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MCH
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE ALL
DONE SO FAR IT'S A REALLY GREAT
START.
BUT WERE IN CRISIS RIGHT NOW AS
A PROVIDER OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES HIRING AND RETAINING
STAFF.
AT THE WAGES THAT WE CAN AFFORD
WITH OUR CURRENT RATES WE HAVE
STAFF THAT HAVE TO LEAVE JOBS
THAT THEY LOVE ALL THE TIME
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T PAY THEIR
BILLS AND WE CAN'T BE MAD AT
THEM FOR THAT.
BECAUSE WE FEEL WHAT THEY FEEL
WHICH IS THAT.
ARE THE COST OF LIVING INCREASES
EVERY YEAR BUT OUR RATE STAYS
THE SAME OUR INCOME STAYS THE
SAME AND WE CAN'T TIGHTEN OUR
BELTS ANYMORE THAN WE ALREADY
HAVE.
BUT WE'RE NOT THE ONES THAT ARE
SUFFERING FROM THIS THE
PARTICIPANTS WE SERVER THE ONES
THAT ARE SUFFERING BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO DEAL WITH NEW STAFF
CONSTANTLY TRYING TO LEARN THEIR
JOBS. TO TEACH HOW TO BE.
INDEPENDENT AND SUPPORT PEOPLE
TO LEAVE.
PRODUCTIVE LIVES WHEN THEY CAN'T
EVEN PAY THEIR OWN BILLS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT TO PAY THEIR RENT OR PUT GAS
IN THEIR CAR SO THEY CAN COME TO
WORK WE SUPPORT 8% INCREASE
ACROSS THE BOARD.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS KATE HALICKI AND I
ALSO WORK WITH OUTSIDE UNLIMITED
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT WE
SUPPORT 8% INCREASE.
AND THEN A NOTE FOR THE RATE
STUDY PLEASE ALSO CONSIDER
INDIVIDUAL I SUPPORT WHERE DAY
PROGRAM WE OFFER ONE TO ONE
BEHAVIORAL SUPPORT WHICH IS NOT
AN OPTION -- OR ANYONE TO WIN
SUPPORT FOR DAY PROGRAM WHICH IS
WHAT EFFECT PERSONAL CHOICE AND
ALSO THE CBS FINAL ROLE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS TINA ABOUT COM THE E.
D. OF TO NONPROFIT AGENCIES IN
THE BAY AREA.
I BEEN SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
THE ID DE FOR THIRTY YEARS MY
FIRST JOB WAS -- AT STOCKTON
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WE SHOULD
BE REALLY PROUD OF THE WORK WAY
OF ALL DONE COLLECTIVELY THE
PEOPLE.
LIVING IN THEIR COMMUNITIES WE
SHOULD BE VERY ASHAMED HOWEVER
THAT WE'RE DOING IT ON THE BACK
OF PEOPLE THAT WERE PAYING
MINIMUM WAGE TO WORK WITH THEM
NOW.
PLEASE -- ED DO WHATEVER YOU CAN
IMMEDIATELY FOR US I THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS TO LEAVE AS THE
IRA AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS FOR MINUS HOME CARE I
WE ARE PRIMARILY A RESPITE
AGENCY IN THE EAST BABIES ARE
ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED CLIENTS.
THROUGHOUT THAT AREA AND I
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE PROBLEM
WITH THE LACK OF ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
OF THE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGES AND
SICKLY BORDERS AS IN MY AREA.
MY AGENCY IS CURRENTLY UNDER SIX
DIFFERENT LOCAL MINIMUM WAGES
AND THREE DIFFERENT SICK LEAVE
PALE ORDINANCES -- OUR RATES DO
NOT ADEQUATELY SUPPORTED AT ALL --
WE ARE HAVING PROBLEM RETAINING
STAFF ATTRACTING STAFF -- AND
ALSO IT'S BEEN REALLY DIFFICULT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE -- GOOD EMPLOYMENT A AND
TRAINING WILL UP TO OUR STAFF
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE RATES TO
SUPPORT SO.
WHAT I WOULD REALLY LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO IS TO CONSIDER?
POSSIBLY ADDING SOME TYPE OF
WAGE DIFFERENTIAL TO THE THE
RIGHT MODEL -- FUNNY THE 8%
WOULD BE A GREAT START BUT I
THINK IT ONGOING METHOD WHICH IS --
WITHIN YOUR SEATTLE IN MATERIALS
THAT WERE GIVEN TO YOU EARLIER
WOULD BE TO ATTACH SOME THINGS
THAT LOCAL MINIMUM WAGES ARE
ADDRESSED OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU AND ACTUALLY WE
DID DISCUSS THAT AT A PREVIOUS
HEARING CELL.
ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME.
BUT INSTEAD IS I'M FROMMINUS
TWO WEEKS I'D LIKE TO ADD THAT
WE SERVE A LOT OF MARGINALIZED
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
OUR AGENCY.
AND IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE POS
DISPARITY WE NEED TO DO WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PROPOSED AND WHAT
THE LA -- AS TO POKE PROPOSED WE
NEED TO FIND PERSONAL SUPPORTS
IN THE FIRST ROLLOUT.
THAT MEANS RESPITE.
AN IOS AND PERSONAL ASSISTANCE
AND SLS.
AND SO PLEASE PLEASE HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL PAY ATTENTION THAT I WANT
TO ADDRESS ONE MORE THING -- AND
THAT IS IN -- PUTS BUT DIRECTED
EMPLOYER RECORD SERVICES AND
RESPITE FOR RESPITE AND THE
OTHER PERSONAL SUPPORTS -- WE
NEED EMPLOYMENT SUPPORTS. TO BE
RESTORED THE RATE STUDY WITHOUT
ALL SUPPORTS FOR EMPLOYMENT
SPORTS BY RIPPING OUT ALL THE
ADMIN.
THIS IS -- THIS IGNORES THE
CRUCIAL ROLE THAT CMS REQUIRES
FOR MATCHING FUNDS TO PROVIDE
EMPLOYMENT SUPPORTS THAT GO
ALONG WITH THE EMPLOYMENT
AUTHORITY.
THAT PEOPLE HAVE WHEN THEY
DIRECTOR D. S. P. STAFF.
THIS WILL HELP TIAS PEAS AND
WILL HELP.
CONSUMERS IT IT IT WILL ALSO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WELCOME --
THIRD PASSED OVER FROM ADD IN
SUPPORTED LIVING IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY IN THE PERSON SENATE
ADVOCACY PARTNERSHIP.
BEHIND THE FRIDGE AND I JUST
WANTED.
TO THANK EVERYBODY HERE FOR
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO BETTER
SUPPORT.
SERVICES AND I DO HOPE THAT
WHATEVER WAY YOU ALL FIND
TOGETHER WILL ADDRESS.
THE UNMET NEEDS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES I CAN'T THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JORDAN
THROUGH THE ARE CAN YOU SEE
PIANO PRESENTED ON THE 8% BUT
SPECIFICALLY ONE QUICK COMMENT
ON THE RATE STUDY -- IS HOW IT
RELATES.
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
WE MUST MUST MUST.
MANDATE THAT THIS RATE CITY GETS
UPDATED EVERY YEAR AND TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IF THE TO MANDATE
THE DEPARTMENT DOES IT OR D. O.
F. OR IF THEY NEED MONEY TO
CONTRACT WITH SOMEBODY.
PUT A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY IN
THERE SO THEY CAN UPDATE EVERY
YEARS THAT YOU WE'RE NOT STAB IN
THE DARK EVERY YEAR
LEGISLATURE'S NOT SEVEN DOCTOR
NEAR WE KNOW EXACTLY WHERE WE'RE
GOING OVER THE FUTURE.
THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL OVER TIME
AND BECAUSE I KNOW WE'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME IS GOING HEARINGS ON
THEM RIGHT MAY REVISE I'M SURE
NEXT WEEK BUT BECAUSE IT WAS
BROUGHT UP IN.
TODAY FOR THAT HEARING WE HAVE
HEARD THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
SERVICES THAT THE GOVERNOR TODAY
IS PROPOSING TO INVEST IN FOR
THAT MAY REVISE WHEN WE START
TALKING ABOUT THAT NEXT WEEK IN
WEEK AFTER -- WE'VE HEARD THAT
THERE'S A METHODOLOGY ABOUT
DETERMINING THE NEED THERE IS A
NEED FOR THOSE SERVICES TO GET
INVESTMENT.
BUT I THINK FOR TRANSPARENCY FOR
ALL OF US WHAT WAS THAT
METHODOLOGY HOW WAS THAT NEED
DETERMINED SO THE GOVERNOR.
BUT DECIDED INVEST IN THOSE
INSTEAD OF FOR EXAMPLE.
IS NINETY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVE SERVICES IN DAY PROGRAMS
WHO RECEIVE NOTHING OUT OF WHAT
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN MY STAFFERS IN HERE
SOON SORDO THIS HEARING BY THE
WAY WE STILL TWENTY FOUR ITEMS
AFTER THIS.
ONE THIS REALLY WAITING TO GO
BACK AND SPEND ON ALL NIGHTER
GOING THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
ARE TWO OR THREE ALL NIGHTERS
ALL RIGHT SO WE WANT LETTER FEEL
TO GET TO THAT TASK ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S KRISTEN
HIM AND I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES.
WE HAVE AN ADULT DAY CARE
CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE -- AND
WE SUPPORT THE 8% INCREASE FOR
PROVIDER RATES THANK YOU THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NAME THEIR CHAMP I'M WITH
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO -- WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE 8%.
A LOT OF OTHER CAME HERE TODAY
TO REALLY LOOK AT WHAT THE NEXT
STEPS WERE FOR THE RATE STUDY.
A LOT OF GOOD COMMENTS THERE'S
LESS REASON TO BE OPTIMISTIC AND
WITH THE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
MODEL THERE'S CHALLENGES
CERTAINLY WITH THE WAY TO BLS
DATA.
BUT WE WERE REALLY LOOKING TO
SEE WHAT THE NEXT STEPS WERE
BEING PROPOSED BY THE DEPARTMENT
SO IT'S HARD TO BE OPTIMISTIC TO
DAVIES WE DIDN'T SEE THAT.
WE LOOK AT THE COMP SOME OF THE
COMMENTS TODAY AND WE LOOK AT
THE MAY REVISE.
THEIR THERE'S A LOT MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT WE WANT
TO TALK ABOUT AND DO -- TALK
ABOUT RATHER THAN WHAT WE WANT
TO DO THE MAY REVISED TALKS A
LITTLE BIT I KNOW THEY'LL BE
MORE HEARINGS ABOUT THIS ABOUT
ABOUT REGIONAL CENTER OVERSIGHT --
PROVIDER OVERSIGHT AND SO WHEN
NOT MAKING A STATEMENT ON WHAT
OUR GOALS ON OUR NEXT STEPS ARE
ARMY IS MAKING A STATEMENT TO
THE COMMUNITY.
SO I'M JUST ENCOURAGING THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHERS TO REALLY
ASK WHAT THOSE NEXT STEPS ARE AS
A PROVIDER WE CLOSE TO PROGRAMS
LAST YEAR SERVING FOLKS THAT THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT NEED.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO DRAFT A
LETTER FOR ANOTHER ONE AND I'VE
BEEN SAYING LET'S WAIT TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS THIS YEAR.
I'M NOT ASKING YOU TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR OUR PROGRAM AND
TO THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE ACTIONABLE STEPS SO
THAT WE CAN PLAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT [inaudible]
COM.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA MENTOR WOULD LIKE TO
STAY ARE STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
8% ACROSS THE BOARD PROVIDER
RATE INCREASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
LARA PRESTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPEECH LANGUAGE
HEARING ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS.
A WE SUPPORT THE 8% I ALIGN
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS ON THE
EARLY INTERVENTION -- BEFORE AND
I WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR STAFF
TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES TO K.
TWELVE THAT WOULD HAPPEN WITH
THE K..
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HER NAME HOLDEN WITH EASTER SEAL --
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE HOW COMPLEX
THE RATE STUDY IS HAPPY TO WORK
WITH EVERYONE ARE WE FEEL OUR
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN WELL HEARD.
IN THE COMMENTS THAT YOU HEARD
TODAY -- WE ARE COURSE IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH TAKING A LOOK AT
WHAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT NOW FOR
THE RATE STUDY AS WELL AS WHAT
WE CAN DO IMMEDIATELY TO
STABILIZE THE SYSTEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING HI MARC LANCE
INJECTOR COMMUNITY SERVICES THAT
TO WORKS IN SAN FRANCISCO
GREATER BAY AREA -- SO I
APPRECIATED YOUR LINE OF
QUESTIONING ABOUT MINIMUM WAGE
LAST -- LAST WEEK -- FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR -- AN HOUR THERE --
I ALSO VOLUNTEER PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED LIVING
NETWORK IN MY SPARE TIME -- SO
JUST WANNA.
MANY THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
TODAY -- WE DO FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
PARTS THE RATE CITY THAT -- CAN
BE IMPLEMENTED TODAY THAT ARE
READY TO GO ON AND WITH MINIMAL
ADJUSTMENTS -- CAN REALLY MAKE
UP -- BENEFIT FOR BETTER
OUTCOMES.
FOR THE PROVIDERS OF PEOPLE
SEARCH AND HOW THE T. S. P.'S SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEN ON ALSO THE MICRA JUST
WANT THANK EVERYONE WHO CAME TO
TESTIFY -- I PRE SHEET THE
COMMON SAID I THINK WE HAD THE
VARIETY -- YOU KNOW THE FUTURE
OF THE CONCERNS.
I HOPE WE CAN GET SOME CLARITY
SO -- I THINK PEOPLE I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD FROM PEOPLE WE ARE
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT
OF YOU SEE PEOPLE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE RATE STUDY PEOPLE ALL.
ALSO SAID THAT IT'S A GOOD PLACE
TO START YOU KNOW THERE'S THINGS
WERE OBVIOUS CAN MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS BUT ALSO I THINK WE
ARE WE NEED TO GET SOME --
GREATER DIRECTION SO -- I LOOK
FORWARD OVER TO THIS COMING YEAR
CERTAINLY -- CAN WE KEEP AN EYE
ON IT BUT I KNOW YOU WILL LISTEN
TELL AND I'M WITH ALL THE WITH
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AND IS THAT
THE PEOPLE I HAVE TO DO THE WORK
THE ONE AND KNOW THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GET THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED SO -- LET'S SAYS BE SURE WE
MOVE THAT PATH FORWARD AND AND
AND GET YOU GIVE SOME CLARITY TO
PEOPLE ABOUT.
HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD AND THAT
BOTH THE PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING
WITH -- THEIR CLIENTS BUT ALSO I
THINK WITH THE MORE GENERAL
PUBLIC AS WELL AND WE SAID WE
INVEST A LOT WE TOLD BAILEY WE
TOLD PEOPLE YEAR AFTER YEAR --
WE'RE DOING A RATES THAT YOU
WERE DOING A RATE STUDY GOTTA
WAIT TILL THE RATE STUDY I MEAN
REMEMBER THAT PREVIOUS HEARINGS
NOW WITH THE RATE STUDY.
RATE STUDIES TELLING A CERTAIN
THINGS SO -- AND THE STUDIES
DONE WE NEED TO HAVE A IT'S
BROKEN MANY CERTAIN STRUCTURED
OR SOME ADJUSTMENTS THAT SEEM
LIKE THEY NEED TO BE MADE BUT
IT'S ALSO SAYING THAT WE HAVE A
BIG GAP IN FUNDING THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE MORE CLARITY.
SO -- AND NOW THEY'RE WAITING TO
HEAR FROM.
US IN THE ADMINISTRATION LIKE
OKAY WAR YOU'RE GOING.
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT OR YOU
JUST GOING TO WE DID THE STUDY
IN THIS JUST SAID.
ACOSTA KALI RATE STUDY BECAUSE
THE STUDY'S DONE ARE WE GONNA
HAVE ANY RESTRUCTURING NOT SO.
OKAY ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
BEFORE OKAY SO I JUST WANT TO SO
OUR NEXT IS -- WE HAVE RIVER A
VARIETY OF PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENTS -- YOU'VE HEARD ME
MAKE COMMON FOR THEIR TWENTY
FOUR OF THEM -- WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS IS THAT -- AGAIN I'M GONNA
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT I ASK PEOPLE
2% WITHIN.
A THREE MINUTE PRESENTATION
THERE MAYBE SOME QUESTIONS SO
GIVE ME OP DE TALK SOME MORE --
SO WE HAVE -- I THINK I'M GONNA
TRY TO DO AS IT.
IS -- FIRST OF ALL I NEED TO
TAKE A TWO MINUTE BREAK -- IF
YOU CAN BUY UNDERSTAND AND THEN
WHAT WE'LL DO IS IS THAT WE'LL
JUST HAVE PEOPLE QUE IT'S
INTENDED GENERALLY TAKING THEM
IN ORDER SO BE SURE YOU KNOW
WHO'S IN THE BATTER CIRCLE.
COMING UP AND THEN WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IS IS THAT -- WILL DO I
THINK THE FIRST FIFTEEN A SO
THAT'S THAT FORGET WHEN ABOUT
CHAFF -- WE HAVE VIEW ABOUT US
BY DOING THE OF SOME FOR
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES -- AND AND I THINK.
SO THAT IT'S UP TO NUMBER
FIFTEEN THEN WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE FIRST FIFTEEN AND
I MEAN I THINK FOR MOST PART FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT LIKE.
WHICH ONES YOU LIKE AND THEN
WE'LL START UP AGAIN DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH SO THAT
STARTING WITH NUMBER SIXTEEN AND
THEM THE HEALTH SERVICE
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION THAT
COVERED CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
PRETTY MUCH WRAPS THINGS UP SO --
SO THE FIRST PERSONS UPS GOING
TO BE -- CHAFF THE CALIFORNIA
OPTOMETRIC ASSOCIATION SO JUST
REALIZE THAT -- DON'T YOU CAN
WAIT A MOMENT I'M GOING TO GO.
THE RED THAT WE CAN TAKE A
LITTLE BREAK AND THEN WE'LL GET
ROLLING OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO JUST A ONE MINUTE
BREAK RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY
WE DON'T THIS WE HAVE THE
NAMES OF EVERYONE WHO'S GOT A
PERCENT SO THEY JUST THE
ORGANIZATIONS -- WILL HAPPEN IS --
IT'S CALLED THE ORGANIZATION IF
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T WANT
PRESENTING JUST COME UP HERE.
ALL RIGHT AND BASICALLY IS AT
THREE MINUTES TOTAL FOR ALL THE
PRESENTERS AND HEY AND SINCE I
WILL MENTION A FINANCE --
THEY'VE SAID THAT THEIR THEIR
COMMENTS EACH TIME WILL BE IT'S
NOT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WILL
CONSIDER IT.
SO THEY DON'T NEED TO BE HERE TO
SAY THAT I GUESS -- SO ANYWAY
WITH THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
START WITH THE COMMITTEE CLINIC
VISION INTEGRATION PROJECT.
AND CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION.
OF SHOULD OKAY HOLD ON ACTUALLY
WHAT CAN WE JUST DO ONE QUICK
BECAUSE MY WIFE CALLS A BETTER
COLOR BACK
.
THANK YOU SORRY FOR THE
INTERRUPTION THERE -- SO WHEN WE
GO AHEAD AND BEGIN -- SO THANK
YOU NO PROBLEMS GERMAN THANK YOU
I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY TRY
TO BE BRIEF BUT TO THE POINT SO
COOPER HERE BE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE SPONSORING WITH THE
CLINICS A POSTAL FOR TWENTY SIX
MILLIONDOLLARS TO FIND --
VISION SERVICES IN A CLINIC
CLINIC SETTING IT'S ONE TIME
ONLY CAPITAL OUTLAY -- WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF CLINICS IN
CALIFORNIA THEY DO NOT EITHER
HAVE THE SPACE OR THE EQUIPMENT
TO PROVIDE VISION SERVICES WE
THINK THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS IN TERMS OF HEALTH CARE
AND HEALTH CARE ACCESS. TO THIS
PROGRAM FIRST OF ALL.
WHEN BENEFITTED THIS PROGRAM IS
PROVIDING VISION SERVICES IN
AREAS WHICH THERE THEY ARE NOT
AVAILABLE CALIFORNIA HAS AN
AGING POPULATION THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF VISION
RELATED PROBLEMS THAT COME WITH
AGING SUCH AS?
DIABETIC RETINOPATHY BOMB IN
ADDITION YOU HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF PEOPLE HAVE SERIOUS
UNDERLYING MEDICAL CONDITIONS
WHO DON'T JUST DON'T GO TO SEE A
DOCTOR.
AND IN FACT THE GO TO SEE A
OPTOMETRISTS BECAUSE THEY NEED
TO GET AYE GLASSES CAUSING YOU
TO DRIVE THE TO READ -- AND SO
ONCE YOU GET THEM INTO THE
OPTIMISTIC VISION SERVICES EXAM
THE OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THEIR BLOOD PRESSURE LOOK FOR
SIGNS OF DIABETES.
BOB SO ONE OF THE REALLY GREAT
BENEFITS TO THIS IDEA IS TO IN
ESSENCE TO PROVIDE AN INTEGRATED
HEALTH CARE MODEL IN THE IN
THESE CLINICS IN AREAS WHERE
THERE IS NOT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET THE SERVICES.
SO WE THINK WOULD BE AS WISE AND
SIGNIFICAN IN INVEST SOME BY THE
STATE.
IN THIS PROGRAM AND ITS ONE TIME
ONLY MONEY.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS FROM LA -- YES MISTER
CHAIR MARK NEWTON FROM THE LA --
JUST ON THIS TOPIC OF VISION
RELATED SERVICES JUST FOR THE
COMMITTEES INFORMATION -- THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION RELEASED
THIS MORNING DOES PROPOSED TO
RESTORE OP -- OPTICAL OPTICIAN
OPTICAL LAB SERVICES FOR ADULT
MEDICAL BEEN FISHERS OKAY AND
OTHER PROJECT THAT WE SUPPORTED
IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR MEDI CAL OPTIONAL
STRUGGLE US.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OKAY AT A A ACTUALLY MY
UNDERSTANDING AS WE ARE SHE
PASSED IT -- THE REVIOUS YEAR
AND SOMEHOW IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
I WAS IN IT WAS IN A TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE YOU GUYS WE
THOUGHT WE HAD AN AGREEMENT WITH
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION SOMEHOW
THAT THAT DID NOT HAPPEN -- WE
ARE VERY GLAD THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR AND DEPARTMENT FINANCE FOR
INCLUDING IN THE MAY REVISED ON
THE PROJECT I'M TALKING TO YOU
ABOUT TODAY THOUGH IS COMPLETELY
SEPARATE AND AND YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THAT ALSO.
SO THIS IS THIS IS REALLY FOR
THE INFRASTRUCTURE I MEAN THIS
IS FOR THE SITE'S APTLY WRITING
AXES IN PROVIDING IN A CLINICAL
SETTING WHERE YOU'RE GETTING
COVERAGE IN AREAS THAT WERE NOT
WOULD NOT.
BE OTHERWISE COVERED FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE -- IN IT WILL BE
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAMS TO
THE CLINICS WILL HAVE TO APPLY I
HAVE TO SAY HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION OPTOMETRIST GET NO
MONEY UNDER THIS YOU KNOW
PROPOSAL.
IT'S ALL GOING OUT TO THE
CLINICS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES OKAY ALL RIGHT
EXCELLENT OKAY -- THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP IS --
NONPROFIT ACCESS TO THE ASHFORD
PUBLIC USE FILE -- WELCOME
[inaudible]
GLASSES -- A CLASSES TALK ABOUT
OPTICAL.
YOUR PERSONAL THERE YOU GO.
RIGHT WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON --
JOAN ALLEN ON BEHALF OF THIS
YEAH YOU YOU H. W. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL BROUGHT
FORWARD BY US YEAH YOU STATE
COUNCIL.
FROM NINETEEN NINETY NINE FOR
TWENTY FOURTEEN SEIU AND MANY
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS OBTAIN DATA
SETS FROM ASHKHABAD CALLED THE
PUBLIC USE FILES.
OF THESE INCLUDED -- PATIENT
LEVEL DE IDENTIFIED DATA FOR
HOSPITALS AND FOR AMBULATORY
SURGICAL CENTERS.
THESE DATA FILES WERE THE ONLY
COMPREHENSIVE PATIENT LEVEL
PRODUCT THAT ADVOCATES COULD
RECEIVE FROM OFF PUT AND THEY'VE
BEEN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AS A
COMPONENT FOR US YEAH YOU IN
TERMS OF OUR WORK EXAMINING
UTILIZATION.
QUALITY DISPARITIES AND MANY
OTHER ISSUES WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
HOWEVER OFFERED HIS
REINTERPRETED WHAT DATA MAY BE
PUBLICLY RELEASED UNDER EXISTING
STATUTE.
THIS IS LET US YEAH YOU AND
OTHER ADVOCATES LED DOES HE ARE
YOU ANOTHER ADVOCATES LOSING
ACCESS TO THE DATA CONTAINED IN
OUR SPOT PUBLIC USE FILES.
SINCE.
TWENTY FOURTEEN WITHOUT ACCESS
TO THESE FULL DATA SETS SEIU
ANOTHER ADVOCATES DO NOT HAVE
THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED TO FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE POLICY MAKING
AND REGULATORY PROCESS.
WELL SUMMARY DATA THAT IS STILL
AVAILABLE FOR MARCH BUT CAN HELP
US UNDERSTAND GENERAL TRENDS IT
IS INSUFFICIENT FOR
INVESTIGATING THE MORE COMPLEX
SITUATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE USING
THE OFFERED PUBLIC USE FILES WE
HAVE EXAMINED DISPARITIES IN
MATERNITY CARE BY RACE AND PAYER.
AND HAVE SHOWN THE IMPACT ON
COMMUNITIES WHEN HOSPITALS
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE PARTICULAR
LINES OF SERVICE.
THE ALL THE INFORMATION OFFERED
COLLECTS FROM HOSPITALS AND
AMBULATORY SURGICAL CENTERS CAN
BRING IMPORTANT DATA DRIVEN
VOICE TO THE POLICY MAKING
CONVERSATION PARTICULARLY ABOUT
EXPANDING ACCESS TO CRITICAL
SERVICES.
AND IDENTIFYING UNNECESSARY
HEALTH CARE COST DRIVERS.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD EXTEND AN
EXISTING DATA ACCESS PROCEDURE
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE RELEASE OF
SENSITIVE EDUCATION RELATED DATA
TO ALSO APPLY TO SENSITIVE
HEALTH CARE RELATED DATA -- IT
WOULD BE SPECIFIC TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN
DEMONSTRATE AN ABILITY TO FOLLOW
ESTABLISHED DATA SECURITY.
PROCEDURES INCLUDING A HUMAN
SUBJECTS REVIEW -- MAINTAINING
THE DATA IN A SECURED SERVER
PLANS AND AGREEMENTS WITH
ASHKHABAD.
TO ONLY REALLY ONLY RELEASE THE
MINIMUM DATA NECESSARY FOR THE
RESEARCH PROJECT.
AND PLANS TO DESTROY THE DATA
ONCE THE RESEARCH PROJECT WAS
COMPLETE ALL OF THOSE WERE
CONTAINED WITHIN THE INFORMATION
IT WITHIN THE DAY TO USE
AGREEMENTS.
THAT WE HAD WITH US BUT IN THE
PAST AND THE MIRROR DATA USE
AGREEMENTS THAT S. YEAH YOU AND
OTHER ADVOCATES HAVE WITH CMS.
TO OBTAIN MEDICARE DATA.
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE DATA ON THE
MEDICARE POPULATION BUT THAT
LEAVES US WITHOUT THE INSIGHT
INTO HELPING INFORM POLICY ON
MEDI CAL.
AND ON COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS.
THIS PROPOSAL BUILDS ON THE
COMMITMENT TO HEALTH CARE DATA
TRANSPARENCY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MADE LAST YEAR IN AB.
EIGHTEEN TEN WHICH PUT
CALIFORNIA ON THE PATH TO
CREATING A COMPREHENSIVE CLAIMS
DATABASE.
HOWEVER THAT AFTER WILL TAKE
SEVERAL YEARS.
AND IN THE INTERIM WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO RESTORE ADVOCATES
ACCESS TO THE DATA CONTAINED IN
THE OFFERED PUBLIC USE FILES
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS FROM AVAIL.
RIGHT QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT -- THIS HAS
TO DO WITH THE SHIFT ICD.
TEN AND THAT IS WHAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM OFSHE PART IS THAT THE
SHIFT TO ICD.
TEN GIVE SUCH MORE GRANULAR DATA.
THAT COMBINED WITH THE ABILITY
TO LINK IT UP WITH OTHER DATA
SETS.
THAT AN INCREDIBLY INDUSTRIOUS
RESEARCHER COULD FIGURE OUT HOW
TO IDENTIFY INDIVIDUAL PATIENTS.
OKAY -- WE FIND THAT.
HAS NOT BEEN A CONCERN THAT CMS
HAS HA PUT FORWARD THAT THEY
FEEL THAT THE DATA USE
AGREEMENTS WITH I INDIVIDUALS
WITH THREE OTHER THINGS OR NOT.
THIRTEEN THESE FILES OUT ON A
PUBLIC WEBSITE THIS WOULD ONLY
BE TRANSFERRED WITH A DATA
SHARING AGREEMENT THAT CONTAINS.
CONTRARY L. STRONG CONTRACTUAL
PROTECTIONS YES FOR EXAMPLE SCA
YOU HAS A HIPPA COMPLIANT SERVER.
RIGHT IT'S NOT LIKE -- HERE IT
IS ON A THUMB DRIVE RIGHT AND I
THINK OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT OKAY NEXT UP FOR US I
CARRIED G. FELLOWSHIPS.
OFFERS OCCURRED PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING SENATOR PAN MANY
MEMBERS MY NAME XIN AND SO I'M
ONE OF THE CO DIRECTORS FOR THE
UC RIGHT YOU SEE DAVIS TRAINEE
TRAINERS PRIMARY CARE PSYCHIATRY
FELLOWSHIP.
I SUCH A COUPLE MONTHS AGO ON
BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH CARE
WORK FORCE COMMISSIONER PORCH --
WHICH IS A TWO POINT SIX FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING FOR THE
EIGHTEEN T. -- FELLOWSHIP ON
THIS WE GO TOWARDS SCHOLARSHIPS
THAT WILL PAY FOR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS TO PARTICIPATE
IN OUR FELLOWSHIP -- IS ALSO A
COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS INCLUDING
RESEARCHING SOME THE OUTCOMES
THAT WE HAVE.
NOT YET BEEN ABLE TO GET TO
BECAUSE WE NEED SEPARATE FUNDING
FOR THAT -- JUST TO GIVE YOU AN
IDEA WE HAD ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET LAST
YEAR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT -- AND SO THAT FUNDED SIXTY
FOUR SCHOLARSHIPS OF FOR THIS
YEAR AND NEXT YEAR WE MANAGED TO
GET FORTY OF THOSE AWARDED.
IN THREE MONTHS FOR THE CURRENT
CALENDAR YEAR THAT WORD IN THE
FELLOWSHIP.
AND WE ARE LITERALLY -- JUST
CLOSE THE APPLICATIONS FOR NEXT
YEAR'S TWENTY TWENTY AND FORTY
FIVE APPLICATIONS FOR THE
REMAINING.
TWENTY FOUR SO WE HAVE A TOTAL
OF EIGHTY FIVE APPLICATIONS
ALREADY -- FOR TWENTY TWENTY WE
HAD A HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
FELLOWS THIS YEAR -- THAT'S UP
FROM SIXTY SIX THE PREVIOUS YEAR
SO THIS PROGRAM IS GROWING AND
GROWING PEOPLE ARE VERY EXCITED.
AND OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE IDEA OF
BEING ABLE TO HAVE SCHOLARSHIPS
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE FELLOWSHIP.
IT COMES FROM LU.
I WOULD JUST -- MISTER CHAIR
THAT OUR PRELIMINARY REVIEW OF
THE HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE DATA
DOES SHOW RELATIVELY ROBUST
EVIDENCE OF THERE BEING
STATEWIDE SHORTAGES FOR
PSYCHIATRISTS.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
QUESTION COMES FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OKAY WELL.
THANKS VERY MUCH CERTAINLY WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT THE ISSUES WITH A
SHORTAGE OF PERSON -- OF
PROFESSIONALS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SO THANK YOU THE PROPOSAL.
NEXT UP HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
AND UNDERSERVED AREAS I THINK
STOSSEL CESSATION. FOR HOUSE
BILL CESSATION CALIFORNIA PLUS
ADVOCATES.
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION [inaudible]
WELCOME.
CHAIRMAN PAN A BARBER GLAZER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION.
I AM HERE TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE STATE BUDGET
INCLUDE AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. TO GROWING DIVERS
SUPPLY THE HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
TO MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES BY AUGMENTING.
AUGMENTING FUNDING TO THREE
EXISTING PROGRAMS CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERED BY US PAT.
SPECIFICALLY THE FUNDING WOULD
BE USED TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
PRESIDENT SINCE THIS IS IN THE
SONG BROWN PROGRAM.
EXPAND LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS
IN STRENGTHEN OUT REACHING
RECRUITING PROGRAMS TO STUDENTS
FROM LOW INCOME AN UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES TO HELP
THEM ENTER HEALTH CAREERS.
WE KNOW YOU IN THIS COMMITTEE
ARE INTIMATELY FAMILIAR WITH THE
SHORTAGE OF HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
IN THIS STATE.
IN PARTICULAR UNDERSERVED AREAS
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
IN INLAND EMPIRE WE'RE THEIR
NUMBER POSITIONS PER RESIDENT IS
DANGEROUSLY LOW.
THE PROGRAMS UNDER OFSTED WE ARE
PROPOSING DOG MAN HAVE A LONG
AND POVEN TRACK RECORD OF BEING
AFFECTED.
THE FIRST IS THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM WHICH FUNDS PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCY AND TRAINING AND
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS OF
THE STATE WE KNOW THAT.
POSITIONS WHO DO THEIR RESIDENCY
IN A PARTICULAR AREA ALMOST
ALWAYS STAY IN THAT AREA SO
WE'RE DRAWING THESE RESIDENTS TO
THESE UNDERSERVED AREAS.
THERE'S ALSO THE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM THE NUMBER OF APPLICANTS
FAR EXCEEDS THE MONEY AVAILABLE
SO WE KNOW THAT THOSE DOLLARS
WOULD BE UTILIZED TO HELP WITH
STUDENT.
WITH LOANS AND THEN RECRUITMENT
AND OUTREACH.
BOSCH FITTED MINISTERS MANY
GRANTS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
UNDER REPRESENTED AND
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS
INTERESTED IN PURSUING
HEALTHCARE CAREERS.
THESE SERVERS YOUNG STUDENTS IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL WHO MIGHT NOT
OTHERWISE EVEN THINK ABOUT
HEALTH CAREERS EXCEPT FOR THESE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS SO WE'RE
HERE TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION.
NO I BOTTOM -- CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
OF THE REQUEST SO TO SERVE OUR
STUDENTS THAT ARE CONSTITUENTS
IN THESE UNDERSERVED RURAL
CENTRAL VALLEY AREAS STATEWIDE.
THANK YOU AND HOW MUCH MILLION.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT TODAY IN
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
THERE ARE TWO HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE RELATED PROPOSALS ONE
CONCERNS ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE MEDIC HOW LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM FOR PHYSICIANS AND
OTHERS.
AS WELL AS AN AUGMENTATION TO
THE GENERATOR PROPOSAL FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE WHO
WERE CURRENTLY ANALYZING THE NEW
PROPOSALS AND THE INTENT TO
RELEASE ANALYSIS TO THE TO TO
THE LEGISLATURE VERY SHORTLY.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES
CENTER TYLER. TO SUPPORT THIS
SACK REQUEST.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
OKAY SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
BRAINS FOR NIGHT I WOULD MAKE NO
WE DO HAVE A AND I THINK YOU
KNOWLEDGE AT YOUR PROPOSAL WE
HAVE SEVERAL DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
RELATING TO THE WORK FORCE SO --
CERTAINLY THE NEEDS THERE AND SO
JUST BE SURE WE SERVE.
BALLOTS OUT ICE OF BALANCE OUT I
MEAN BE SURE THAT WERE.
USING THE FUNDS AND MOST
EFFECTIVE MANNER SO.
RIGHT LOOSELY OKAY THANK YOU BUT
THANK YOU DOCTOR THANKS MUCH.
RIGHT NEXT UP IS TRANSGENDER
GENDER NON CONFORMING INTERSECTS
INCLUSIVE HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
TRAINING THE TRANS LATIN AND A
COUNTRY LAND AT POLLUTION
[inaudible]
THE HERE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT AND READ INTO THE
RECORD.
OKAY SO BASICALLY -- SO I THINK
THERE'S A PROPOSAL IS AGAIN ON
TRANS GENDER GENDER NON
CONFORMING INTERSEX.
INCLUSIVE HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE --
FROM THE TRANSPLANT AND
COALITION REQUESTING EXPENDITURE
THIRTY FOUR MILLION FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING FOR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROVIDERS.
AND ORGANIZATIONS AND AGENCIES
SO.
YES -- THIS WILL JUST LEAVE IT
AT THAT FOR THE RECORD ANY
COMMENTS FROM ILIO MILL RD OKAY
WHEN I PRESENTER.
LET'S MOVE ON THEN -- UP. TO NOW
THE FARM HEALTH CARE SERVICES
PERSONAL NEEDS ALLOWANCE
INCREASED CAL FOR LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN YOU'RE READY THERE
RIGHT WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING -- LISA COLEMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION VERY
PLEASED TO BE PRESENTING THIS
BUDGET REQUEST FOR RESOURCES
SUFFICIENT TO INCREASE THE MEDI
CAL BENEFICIARY.
PERSONAL NEEDS ALLOWANCE PNA OF
FROM THE CURRENT THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS EIGHTY FIVE DOLLARS A
MONTH.
THESE THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS IS THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT RESIDENTS ON MEDI
CAL WHO LIVE IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ARE ALLOWED TO KEEP
AFTER THEY PAY THEIR SHARE OF
COSTS.
ON THIS THIS REMAINING IS
REFERRED TO ADD TO COVER
PERSONAL AN INCIDENTAL EXPENSES.
THE CALIFORNIA.
CHEMICAL LEADERSHIP WE JUST HEAR
HEART RENDING STORIES OF OF OF
RESIDENTS SUFFERING TRULY
PERSONAL -- INDIGNITIES HAVING
TO DO WITHOUT -- ARE HAVING TO
RATION OF PERSONAL ITEMS OVER
THE COUNTER MEDICATIONS
INCONTINENCE PRODUCTS.
ALL OF IT DUE TO HAVING SUCH A
OF A MINIMAL MONTHLY INCOME.
OF MANY OF THE RESIDENTS THAT
ARE IN THESE FACILITIES ONCE
ENJOYED A MIDDLE CLASS LIFESTYLE
OF OF HAVING TO WIN THREE AND
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH.
SO FOR THOSE OLDER ADULTS AND
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES
TRANSITIONING INTO LIVING INDEED.
LIVING IN A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY HAVING TO SHARE A ROOM
IN A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY --
RELYING ON MEDI CAL TO TO PAY
OVER AND ABOVE WITH THEIR 100%
OF THEIR SHARE OF COSTS IT IT
IT'S JUST DEMORALIZING.
IT'S IT'S JUST.
IT'S VERY SAD I'VE WITNESSED IT.
TOO MANY TIMES PEOPLE HAVING TO
MAKE THE DECISION OF TWO I
PARTICIPATE IN THE MONTHLY
OUTING OR DO I PAY FOR HEARING
AID BATTERIES.
IT'S JUST NOT OKAY THAT WE'RE
ASKING THEM TO MAKE THESE KINDS
OF CHOICES -- WHEN WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO INCREASE IT TO MAKE
US A PAR WITH THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY -- I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT ONE OF THE THE BIGGEST ITEMS
THAT PEOPLE USE THE THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR HIS CELL
PHONES.
THERE'S A MISCONCEPTION THAT
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE ON MEDICARE
YOU CAN GET A FREE PHONE.
YOU HAVE TO BE UNDER THAT
THRESHOLD SO FOR THOSE PEOPLE
THAT HAD A MIDDLE CLASS INCOME.
THAT THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS IS ALL
THEY HAVE AND IT'S HARD PRESSED
TO FIND A CELL PHONE COMPANY.
THAT THAT COVERS FOR THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS A MONTH SO WE JUST
BELIEVE IT'S TIME TO INCREASE
THE STEPS ON SO WE THANK SENATOR
DODD FOR FORWARDING THIS.
I THANK YOU VALUE INCOMES ALL
RIGHT QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SO JUST TO CLARIFY THIS IS AN
ALLOWANCE THAT.
THE THAT THE PATIENT CLIENT
RECEIVES WATER IN LONG AND A
LONG TERM CARE FACILITY IT'S NOT
THAT ARE SEAT AREA IT'S THAT'S
IF I IF MY MONTHLY INCOME IS A
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
PER AND MY SHARE OF CLOAKING
SIMILAR TO WHAT HAPPENS IS THE
THAT'S EIGHT THEY GET THEIR
MONEY AS A DAY HAVE A PENSION --
COLLECTING OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT SO DOLLARS IT'S THEIR MONEY
YES THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
THEY END UP AND YOU KNOW THE
SPEND DOWN THEIR ASSETS ARE NOW
IN A NURSING HOME RIGHT THAT'S
UNFORTUNATELY VERY COMMON FOR
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES.
THAT ALL THEIR THAT STREAM OF
MONEY THAT THEY GOT FROM WHAT
THEY HAVE LEFT THE SPEND DOWN
ASSET TODAY LET'S HAVE A PENSION
AND THAT THAT STREAM OF MONEY
THEY CAN ONLY KEEP THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS OF THAT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TELLING YES
OKAY SO IT'S SO HUMAN BEING THAT
RIGHT.
IF AND WHEN ITS PER MONTH YES
THAT'S PER MONTH.
AND SO THEY GOT IN OKAY LIVING
ON THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH AND I'LL BECAUSE IT COST
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS SO THERE
IT'S IT'S MONEY THAT THEY'RE
HAVING COMING IN AND DIMAS IS
THAT THEY ALL GET SWEPT UP
EXCEPT FOR THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
YES OKAY.
YES AND AND WHILE IT.
IT IT MAKES A HUGE DRAMATIC
DIFFERENCE IT IS NOT A BIG
DOLLAR AMOUNT TO THE STATE
BECAUSE IT'S NOT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY.
BUT FOR THOSE THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING THIS.
OKAY IS REALLY QUITE.
DE HUMANIZING OKAY.
HERE OKAY.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT NORTH THE NORTH EAST
VALLEY HEALTH WELLNESS GARDEN
PROGRAM [inaudible]
WELCOME.
DOES THAT THE NO CENTER HERTZ
BURGLARIES MADE A PITCH ON THIS
[inaudible]
ONE SEC [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME SELF THREE MINUTES FOR
BOTH OF YOU SO KEEP IN MIND YOU
HAVE THAT HE OF THE OTHER PERSON
SPEAKING DON'T USE OF ALL THE
TIME.
BEEN REMINDING ME ALL AFTER.
GOOD MORNING A GOOD EVENING
CHAIRMAN PAT AND SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND OXYGEN JOHNSON
PEDIATRIC MEDICAL DIRECTOR AT
NORTHEAST VALLEY HEALTH
CORPORATION AND I'M JOINED BY MY
COLLEAGUE DENISE TORRES HEALTH
EDUCATION PROGRAM MANAGER.
WE THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
PRESENT OUR PLAN TO ADDRESS FOOD
SECURITY SUPPORTED BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG.
EVERY DAY I HAVE THE JOY OF
WORKING WITH FAMILIES LIKE ME TO
YES WHO IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FACE THE DIFFICULT
PREGNANCIES.
WORSENED BY THE STRESS OF TRYING
TO FEED AND HOUSE HER FAMILY
AFTER HER HUSBAND WAS LAID OFF
AND THEY LOST THEIR HOME.
SHE LIKE MANY OF MY PATIENTS
WORRIED ABOUT WHERE HER NEXT
MEAL WOULD COME FROM SHE DID NOT
HAVE THE LUXURY OF DETERMINING
IF FOR FOOD CHOICES BUT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND SUPPORT A HEALTHY
OUTCOME FOR HER PREGNANCY AND
HER BABY.
BUT WE IDENTIFIED THAT SHE WAS
EXPERIENCING FOOD AND SECURITY
AND AS A RESULT REFER HEARD
REFERRED HER TO RESOURCES
INCLUDING OUR COMMUNITY GARDENS
PROGRAM.
BEAR SHE LEARNED ABOUT HEALTHY
EATING.
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND SOCIAL
SERVICE PROGRAMS TO HELP HER
SECURE NUTRITIOUS FOOD FOR HER
FAMILY.
MARIA'S EXPERIENCE IS NOT UNIQUE
AMONG THE SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
PATIENTS ARE BY CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS.
THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCES TWO
THIRDS OF THE NATION'S FRUITS
AND NUTS ONE EIGHT PEOPLE OUR
FOOD IS IN SECURE.
CHILDREN WHO LIVE IN FOOD
INSECURE HOUSEHOLDS HAVE POOR
OVERALL HEALTH AND ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT AS WELL AS MORE
HOSPITALIZATIONS.
THEIR FAMILY SPACE INCREASED
RISK OF DIABETES CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE IN ADDITION TO THE WELL
KNOWN UNTOWARD EFFECTS OF TOXIC
STRESS.
AND NORTHEAST VALLEY HEALTH
CORPORATION WE FOUND GREAT
SUCCESS IN USING OUR WELLNESS
GARDENS AND FOOD DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAM TO EDUCATE PATIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO NUTRITIOUS FOOD.
AND TO IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES
FOR PATIENTS EXPERIENCING FOOD
SECURITY.
THE ONE IS GARDENS AND FOR
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM AT ANY
BEACH SEE IS COUNTY SCREEN
PATIENTS FOR FOOD SECURITY AT
EIGHT EVER HEALTH CENTERS.
AND DOCUMENTING THOSE RESULTS IN
THE PATIENT'S HEALTH RECORD. ONE
OUT OF TWO OVER DAHLE PATIENTS
ARE FOOD INSECURE AND REFERRED
TO A COMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM
WHERE THEY WORK WITH A TEAM OF
MEDICAL PROVIDERS HEALTH
EDUCATORS AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
TO LEARN ABOUT HEALTHY EATING
AND ACCESSING -- CHURCHES FOODS
A LOW OR NO COST OUR PROGRAM HAS
BEEN EFFECTIVE IN EMPOWERING
PATIENTS ON THE PATH TO WELLNESS
AS WELL AS REDEFINING THE
PATIENT EXPERIENCE AND THE
HEALTH CENTER.
THE GARDEN PROVIDES THE WALKING
GREEN SPACE TO CONDUCT SHARE
MEDICAL VISITS AND SUPPORTS
MENTAL WELLNESS FOR PATIENTS
THAT TRADITIONALLY ASSOCIATE
HEALTH CENTERS WITH THE COLD
STERILE ENVIRONMENT WITH YOUR
SUPPORT WE WILL DEVELOP A TOOL
KIT FOR CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS. TO INTEGRATE
THEIR OWN COMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM
THAT WILL STRENGTHEN.
COMMUNITY WELL BEING BEYOND THE
WALLS OF THE HEALTH CENTERS ARE
PROGRAM WILL INCLUDE ANY ABOUT
AN INDEPENDENT EVALUATORS
ASSESSMENT OF THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS WE WILL ADDRESS
HOW TO OVERCOME PHYSICAL SPACE
AND FINANCIAL -- LIMITATIONS AND
HOW TO IDENTIFY AND DEVELOP
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS APPLE
SUPPORT SYSTEM ABILITY -- THE
COMMUNICANTS PROGRAM WE HAVE
HELPED THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS
LIKE MEDIA IMPROVE THEIR HEALTH
OUTCOMES NOT ONLY BY CONNECTING
THEM WITH RESOURCES THEIR DRESS
FOOD AND SECURITY BUT ALSO BY
CREATING.
A SAFE HAVEN TO HELP THEM REACH
THEIR HEALTH GOALS WE HOPE TO
COUNT ON YOUR SUPPORT SO WE CAN
INTRODUCED THIS MODEL TO ALL
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS.
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS MILIEU THE OKAY
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALL
RIGHT OKAY WELL THANK YOU THANKS
VERY MUCH.
COMMITTEE GUARDS ALWAYS GOOD.
ALL RIGHT NEXT IS RATE INCREASE
FOR PSYCHOLOGISTS AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES.
OKAY WELCOME.
CGB HERE HOLD SERVICES.
GOOD EVENING AS SENATOR PAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JODY HEX
REPRESENTING CG.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
WE'RE HERE TO REQUEST SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING. FOR
A MEDICAL RATE INCREASE AND I AM
IN A GIANT TAKE ONE MINUTE OF
YOUR TIME BECAUSE I KNOW THE
COMMITTEE IS IS QUITE AWARE.
OF LOW MEDICAL RATES AND HOW
THAT TRANSLATES INTO AN ACCESS
TO CARE PROBLEM -- FOR
CALIFORNIANS I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A MINUTE TO TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS POPULATION
AND SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES --
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
ARE ADMITTED TO SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ANNUALLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
ABOUT 66% OF THOSE RELY SOLELY
ON MEDI CAL SO ABOUT THREE OUT
OF FIVE PATIENTS AND OF THOSE
MORE THAN SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS.
THAT RESIDE IN THOSE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES HAVE
EXPERIENCE SOME SORT OF TRAUMA%
ONE IN TWENTY FOUR CALIFORNIANS
SUFFER FROM SOME SORT OF MENTAL
ILLNESS AND MANY OF THOSE ARE
JUST NOT GETTING.
CARE BECAUSE OF OUR LOW MEDI CAL
RATES AND AND PARTICULARLY --
WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN FOCUSING ON
IS IT IS A BROADER -- HOMELESS
POPULATION THAT ARE BEING
pAFFECTED BY THIS SO MANY ARE
COME IN THROUGH THE EMERGENCY
ROOM THEY BE GET REFERRED TO
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
AND BECAUSE THE THE CARE JUST
ISN'T THERE TO TREAT THEM FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THERE
OFTENTIMES AND DISCHARGED BACK
ONTO THE STREETS AND WE KNOW --
THOSE PATIENTS ARE MORE --
LIKELY TO COMMIT CRIME OR TO BE
THEN.
ADMITTED BACK INTO A HEALTH
FACILITY -- ALSO THERE'S A
RECENT STUDY THAT HAS SHOWN THAT --
SUICIDE RATES IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ARE ARE RISING SO
ABOUT TWO POINT 2% OF SUICIDES
IN THAT AGING POPULATION COME
SO WE'RE JUST LOOKING FOR AN
INCREASE IN RATES SUCH THAT --
ACCESS CAN BE BETTER PROVIDED
FOR FOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH FOR
AGING POPULATION AND AND THEY
JUST DESERVE BETTER CARE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COMMENTS MILLIONS.
OKAY QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH OKAY --
NEXUS UP AS POSSIBLE.
GRAHAM THAT IT FELL QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS.
WE HAVE TROUBLE P. AMERICA
WELCOME.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN SENATOR --
RANDY I'M A MY CHILD CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST I'M BASED IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND I WORK WITH ABOUT
HALF OF THE COUNTIES IN THE
STATE TO IMPLEMENT POSITIVE
PARENT TEEN.
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU WOULD
APPROPRIATE EIGHT MILLION TO
EQUIP COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
FQHC IS A RURAL HEALTH CLINICS
WITH AN ONLINE.
EVIDENCE BASED POSITIVE
PARENTING PROGRAM TO WEB BASED
APPROACH THAT CAN SCALE ACROSS
THE STATE.
I REPRESENT ONE SUCH PROGRAM
TRIPLE P. WHICH IS A SYSTEM OF
PARENTING SUPPORT DESIGNED TO
IMPROVE BEHAVIORAL DEVELOPMENT
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN TEENAGERS
AND FAMILIES.
WITH THE EIGHT MILLION WE
CONSERVE ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
FAMILIES OKAY ASSUMING TWO KIDS
PER FAMILY THAT'S TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND KIDS.
POTENTIALLY BENEFITING FROM THIS
APPROACH SO IT CAN REALLY SCALE.
FQHCS ARE IDEAL SETTINGS TO TILT
TO DELIVER PARENTING INFORMATION.
PARENT TEEN IMPACTS IN MEDIATES
VIRTUALLY ALL ASPECTS OF CHILD
HEALTH.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO THINK OF ONE
ASPECT THAT DOESN'T DEPEND UPON
PARENTS INCLUDING WHETHER KID
MAKES IT TO AN APPOINTMENT.
IN PRACTICE EVIDENCE BASED
PARENTING INFORMATION HASN'T
BEEN TRANSMITTED TO PARENTS AS
WELL AS IT COULD AND THIS IS
PRIMARILY DUE TO A LACK OF
RESOURCES.
THE PC PEAS AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH STAFF SIMPLY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO PARENTING E. BP'S.
SO THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES ACCESS
TO PARENTS WHO DESIRE PARENTING
INFORMATION.
AND THE INFORMATION IS
STRENGTHENED BECAUSE THE
REFERRALS INTO THE SYSTEM COME
FROM A TRUSTED SOURCE YOUR
DOCTOR AND PEER PA.
YOUR SOCIAL WORKER.
THERE IS A WIDENING GAP BETWEEN
BEST PRACTICES AND STANDARDS OF
CARE FOR WORKING WITH FOR
EXAMPLE CHILDREN WITH ADHD OR
SOME OTHER DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR
PROBLEMS IN THE SETTINGS.
NON PHARMACOLOGIC EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENTS FOR THESE PROBLEMS
EXIST THEY WORK AND ARE PROMOTED
BY THE CDC AN H. P..
BUT WE ARE STILL FACED WITH
BARRIERS AND ACCESS AND DELIVERY
WE KNOW PARENTS SEEK THIS
INFORMATION ONLINE.
OKAY THREE DAYS AGO I DID A
GOOGLE SEARCH FOR PARENTING HELP
AND I GOT TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION HITS IN POINT FOUR
SECONDS.
SO WHERE IS A PARENT SUPPOSED TO
START OKAY SEARCH ALGORITHM
BUSINESS IT ISN'T SMART ENOUGH
YET TO DETECT EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS FROM EVERYTHING ELSE SO
PARENTS REALLY NEED HELP.
THIS PROPOSAL EQUIPS HEALTH
CENTERS WITH THE ABILITY. TO
MAKE A GOOD REFERRAL INTO A
CLINICALLY TESTED PROGRAM AN
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM AND THAT
IS THE HIGHEST STANDARD IN THE
FIELD TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS
PROPOSAL HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
I THANK YOU WELL.
ANYONE WHO FOR SCHOOLS PARENTING
DON'T GOOGLE VACCINES THAT
[inaudible]
ANYWAY.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT LA YOU COMES
NOW QUESTIONS REMEMBERS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WILL CERTAINLY
PARENTING SUPPORT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT SO APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT REIMBURSEMENT --
COMMITTEES WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR PENCIL
HER TITLE JOHN VALENCIA HERE ON
BEHALF OF ALL COMMITTEES WHICH
IS A MANUFACTURER OF A
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
LONG ACTING INJECTABLE -- THAT
RACKS ONCE MONTHLY AND IS NOT A
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE.
IT'S READILY AVAILABLE.
FOR DELIVERY IN AVAILABILITY FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PATIENTS.
IN NARCOTIC TREATMENT PROGRAMS
NARCOTIC TREATMENT PROGRAMS FOR
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF HAVE
BEEN AUTHORIZED TO SUPPORT --
MAKE AVAILABLE TO ALL PATIENTS
THE ARRAY OF MEDICATION SISTER
TREATMENTS.
WE'RE BEFORE YOU WITH A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL -- RUDE LANGUAGE
REQUEST THAT RESOLVES TO
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IDENTIFIED IMPEDIMENTS
TO FULL AVAILABILITY OF
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENTS
IN THOSE SETTINGS.
IMPEDIMENT NUMBER ONE THAT WAS
IDENTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT AS
EARLY AS JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SHORTLY AFTER THE ENACTMENT OF
THE OF THE OPERATIVE THE FACT OF
THE LEGISLATION.
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE DIDN'T
PROVIDE FUNDING EVEN THOUGH NO
FUNDING FOR ANCILLARY SERVICES
PSYCHOSOCIAL SUPPORT.
BEHAVIOR MODIFICATION EVEN
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS YOUR
ANALYSIS TO SEE IF PATIENTS WERE.
TRYING TO RETURN TO THEIR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AFTER A
DRUG OF CHOICE.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ASSOCIATED
DID NOT PROVIDE ASSOCIATED
FUNDING FOR THOSE SERVICES WHILE
AT AUTHORIZED THE AVAILABILITY
OF FUNDING.
FOR MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENTS THE LANGUAGE THAT WE
ARE PROPOSED TO YOU SAYS.
DEPARTMENT PLEASE ADVISE US ON
WHAT THAT SON SHOULD BE.
THAT'S OBJECTIVE NUMBER ONE AN
IMPEDIMENT NUMBER ONE IDENTIFIED
BY THE DEPARTMENT IMPEDIMENT
NUMBER TWO IDENTIFIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT IS.
THEY PURPORT AND ASSERTED BEFORE
SUBCOMMITTEES THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE SPECIFIC DIRECTION TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE ADOPTION OF
REGULATIONS THAT WOULD IMPLEMENT.
REIMBURSEMENT CODES AND RATES
FOR THOSE VERY SAME ANCILLARY
SERVICES WITHOUT WHICH SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER PATIENTS HAVE VERY
LITTLE PROSPECTS OF SUCCEEDING
IN OVERCOMING THEIR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER.
SO WE'RE NOT BEFORE YOU
REQUESTING SPECIFIC FUNDING BUT
RATHER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD REMOVE TO DEPARTMENT
IDENTIFIED IMPEDIMENTS TO MAKE.
AN EIGHTIES FULLY AVAILABLE I
WOULD CLOSE BY NOTING THAT IN
TODAY'S MAY REVISION.
CORRECTIONS IS GETTING AN
INFUSION OF SUPPORT FOR WHAT'S
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS A AN
INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE TREATMENT
PROGRAM THAT WAY.
WELL INMATES ARE STILL
INCARCERATED OR ON HE WAY OUT
OF INCARCERATION WILL MAKE ALL
MEDICATIONS SISTER TREATMENTS.
THAT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THE
PATIENT AVAILABLE.
THEY MAY START OFF CORRECTLY
BEHIND BARS BUT IF THEY MEET A
NARCOTIC TREATMENT PROGRAM ON
THE OUTSIDE THAT ISN'T ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM THE ASSOCIATED
SERVICES.
THEY'RE GONNA GET LESS ON THE
OUTSIDE THEN THEY'LL GET BEHIND
THE BARS UNDER THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU COMES FROM ILLEGAL NO
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH ALL
APPRECIATE.
OKAY NEXT UP TAKE TAYLOR ADULT
DAY HEALTH CENTER FUNDING.
THE KILLER CENTER WELCOME.
IS THIS A GOOD AFTERNOON BUT
GOOD EARLY EVENING ACTUALLY -- I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AND AND
THE STAFF HERE FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING --
MY NAME IS KAREN MILLER AND THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT THE PEG
TAYLOR CENTER WE ARE THE ONLY
ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE CENTER IN
BUTTE COUNTY.
WHICH SERVES A HIGH POPULATION
OF OLDER ADULTS WHO MAKE UP
ALMOST 30% OF THE PARADISE
COMMUNITY.
OUR MISSION IS TO SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS IN CARE GIVERS
EXPERIENCING HEALTH CRISES SUCH
AS STROKES PARKINSON'S DISEASE
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY AND OTHER DISABLING
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS.
ON NOVEMBER EIGHTH WHEN THE CAMP
FIRE BROKE OUT OUR PARTICIPANTS
FROM PARADISE MAY GALIA AND
OTHER IMPACTED AREAS WERE SAFE
BECAUSE THEY HAD ALREADY ARRIVED
AT OUR CENTER.
OR OVER THE COURSE OF THAT FIRST
DAY ALMOST ALL OF THEM LOST
THEIR HOMES.
WE WERE ABLE TO SHELTER THEM
SAFELY UNTIL THEY WERE REUNITED
WITH THEIR FAMILIES WHICH WAS.
QUITE A FEAT IF YOU COULD
IMAGINE BECAUSE THEIR FAMILIES
WERE IN SHELTERS AND ON THE ROAD --
WE SHELTER THEM UNTIL THEY'RE
EVACUATED CARE GIVERS COULD GET
TOGETHER AND THEN WE WORKED
UNTIL THE FIRE DANGER HAD PASSED
TO ENSURE THAT ALL OUR
PARTICIPANTS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY STATE SAFE. SIX MONTHS
LATER BUTTE COUNTY REMAINS
HEAVILY IMPACTED IN THIS TIME WE
FIELDED MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
URGENT REQUESTS FOR HELP FROM
FAMILIES COPING WITH
OVERWHELMING LOSS.
AS WELL AS DIFFICULT HOUSING
PLACEMENTS WITH HELP DISABLED
SENIORS LIVING WITHOUT HEAT OR
UNABLE TO ACCESS BEATING
FACILITIES OR PREPARE MEALS IN
THE AREAS IN THE PLACES WHERE
THEY'RE STAYING.
CARE GIVER AFTER CARE GIVER HAS
EXPRESSED HOW HARD IT IS TO TRY
TO RECOVER WHILE CARING FOR AN
ILL ELDERLY OR DISABLED FAMILY
MEMBER.
OUR FIRST WALK IN WAS A CARE
GIVER WHOSE MOTHER IN LAW WAS A
HUNDRED AND THREE AND SHE WAS
HAVING TO SIT IN THEIR CAR FOR
HOURS.
IN THE SMOKE AND THE COLD AIR
WHILE THEY NAVIGATED FEMA AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT TOOK HOURS
AND HOURS.
WE QUICKLY ENROLLED HER FOR CARE
WE EXPEDITED ALL OF THE PEOPLE
WHO CAME TO US FROM REALLY
QUICKLY.
OVERALL WE'VE HAD A 45% INCREASE
IN PROGRAM REFERRALS AND WE'RE
GOING FULL BORE TO ADDRESS THEM
AS FAST AS WE CAN.
THE PIG TAYLOR CENTER HAS THE
FACILITY CAPACITY TO ROLL IN
ROLL UP TO FIFTY MORE
PARTICIPANTS.
BUT EACH ONE OF THEM IS IN
CRISIS SO THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FUNDING
BEING REQUESTED BY SENATOR
NIELSEN IS URGENTLY NEEDED.
SO WE CAN ADD THE NECESSARY
SOCIAL WORK NURSING STAFF AND
OTHER STAFF.
AND IN ROLL THIS MANY NEW
INDIVIDUALS WHILE PROVIDING CARE.
WRAPPING OUR SAFETY NET OF
SERVICES AROUND THESE FAMILIES
IS CRITICAL AS WE HEAD INTO
ANOTHER HOT SUMMER AND WILL
REDUCE THE IMPACT OF OUR
COUNTY'S EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THE FUNDING WILL ALSO PROVIDE
SUBSIDIZED CARE FOR FAMILIES WHO
DON'T QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL
THEREBY AIDING CARE GIVERS WHOSE
ECONOMIC STABILITY HAS BEEN
THREATENED THROUGH THE LOSS OF
THEIR HOMES AND LIVELIHOODS.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THOMAS MILIEU.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE TO I KNOW YOU'RE
SERVING -- A COMMUNITY THAT WAS
WELL SEVERELY CHALLENGED ME
UNDERSTATEMENT.
TODAY SO THANK YOU TICE'S BUT AS
TRAUMATIZED YES THAT'S MORE
ACCURATE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO WE NEED A PEOPLE
COVER OKAY ASSISTED LIVING
WAIVER EXPANSION -- ALRIGHT WE
HAVE OUR BUDS BEEN ASSOCIATION
BACTERIA WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS LISA
COLEMAN WITH CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION
AND I WISH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WAS HERE FOR THIS.
ONE BECAUSE AFTER SUCH A LONG.
EMOTIONALLY DRAINING DAY AND
I'VE SUCH GREAT EMPATHY FOR YOUR
STAFF.
I GET TO COME BEFORE YOU IS
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY SAVES
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MONEY.
IT IMPROVES THE QUALITY OF LIFE
IT MAKES EVERYBODY HAPPY YEAH
HEY WHAT A WAY TO END THE DAY.
SO.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT A BUDGET
REQUEST FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO
INCLUDE A ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OVER A FOUR YEAR
INCREASE. TO THE ASSISTED LIVING
WAVING PROGRAM TO INCREMENTALLY
EXPAND THE CURRENT PROGRAM
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SLOTS BY MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE KHALKHAL IS A MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION COMPRISED OF THE
LOCAL LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
SIR STAFF AND VOLUNTEERS.
IT IS WITH GROWING URGENCY AND
FREQUENCY THAT OUR LEADERSHIP
ARE REPORTING OF INCREASING
NUMBERS OF CALLS.
CALLS FROM VERY FRUSTRATED AND
OFTEN FRANTIC OLDER ADULTS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS AT A LOSS AS TO
WHERE TO FIND IT HOW TO FORD
LONG TERM CARE.
THIS GROWING NUMBER OF
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS BOTH
OLDER ADULTS AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE SLIPPING
THROUGH THE CRACKS OF OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM. FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY RESIDING
IN SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES A
UTILIZING VERY EXPENSIVE CARE AT
AN AVERAGE OF SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- AND THEN WE
HAVE THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY LIVING IN THE
COMMUNITY WHO ARE IN DESPERATE
NEED. FOR ADDITIONAL CARE BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
AFFORD THE AVERAGE MONTHLY
ASSISTED LIVING RATE PRIVATE PAY
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND THEN FOR THOSE THAT ARE
TRYING TO MAKE BALK MAKE USE OF
THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
THE NINE HOURS A DAY JUST
DOESN'T COVER THEIR NEEDS.
SO WHILE WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND THE DEPARTMENT FOR LAST YEAR
INCREASING THE PROGRAM BY AN
ADDITIONAL TWO THOUSAND SLOTS.
THE PROGRAM IS STILL WOEFULLY.
INSUFFICIENT FOR THE NEED AS
EVIDENCED BY THE FACT THAT THE
WAIT LIST CONTINUES TO GROW.
OMBUDSMAN'S REPORT OF
HEARTBREAKING STORIES OF
INDIVIDUALS FINALLY GETTING TO
THE TOP OF THE WAIT LIST ONLY TO
FIND THAT THEY ARE NO LONGER
QUALIFIED.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE GROWN TO
GUILTY SAFELY UTILIZED ASSISTED
LIVING.
THIS IS THE MOST TIMELY OF
REQUEST SENATOR DODD JUST LAST
WEEK ONE OF HIS CONSTITUENTS WAS
IN THE NEWS.
A WOMAN WHO WAS A HUNDRED AND
ONE YEARS OLD A HOSPICE WOMAN
WHO WAS WHEELED INTO A COURT --
AN EVICTION HEARING FOR FAILURE
TO PAY IN ASSISTED LIVING AFTER
HAVING FUN.
SPEND ALL OF HER LIFE SAVINGS
NOW BUT IS ONE OF THE PROGRAM
ONE OF THE COUNTIES THAT
UTILIZES THE ASSISTED LIVING
WAIVER.
BUT CURRENTLY THAT COUNTY HAS
TWO SLOTS.
IT.
IT THIS IS A A WIN WIN FOR THE
STATE.
BOB [inaudible]
WE THIS IS CHALCO IS JUST PROUD
TO SUPPORTED -- A LARGE NUMBER
OF CONSUMERS OF PROVIDERS THIS
IS.
IN IN MY EXPERIENCE THE BROADEST
SUPPORT SYSTEM AB SO.
WHEN WHEN FOR THE STATE?
THANK YOU -- ANY COMES FROM
ALEJO.
WE WE WOULD CERTAINLY CONCUR
WITH THE POTENTIAL -- FOR FOR
SAVINGS FROM THE USE OF HOME AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES AS OPPOSED --
TO SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
WHERE APPROPRIATE IN THE
CERTAINLY IS IN.
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE GENERAL
GENERAL DIRECTION OF THE THE
STATE IN LEGISLATIVE POLICY TO
MOVE PEOPLE FROM INSTITUTIONS
COMMUNITY SETTINGS WHERE
CERTAINLY WHERE WHERE
APPROPRIATE.
OKAY WELL SO I THINK ILL I MEAN
SOMETIMES WE NEED TO FIND OUT
WHAT WHAT IS THE EXACT AMOUNT
THE BEST OF THE CLEARLY WE ARE.
NOT THERE YET SO WE HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STAY AWAY.
ABSOLUTE OKAY IT'S IT'S GROWING
VERY QUICKLY AND THEN.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ALREADY
EXPRESSED AN INTEREST OF OF
MERGING THE ASSISTED LIVING
WAIVER INTO THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICE.
PERHAPS IN FOUR YEARS WHICH IS A
STATE WIDE PROGRAM SO IT WOULD
JUST BE OKAY HE WHEN THE BALL
OUT RIGHT THANK YOU EXTRA MUCH
ALL RIGHT.
TEXAS MEDICAL INTERPRETER PILOT
HAS ASKED ME HERE THERE YOU GO
WELCOME.
I THINK WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS SINCE I CAME IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
INDEED WE HAVE SIR.
WITH THE CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE -- BRIGHT ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES -- WE'RE
GRATEFUL -- FOR TO YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- FORTUNE THAT'S IN THE
STAKEHOLDER REQUEST TODAY -- AS
YOU POINTED OUT WE PORT -- WITH
SEVERAL ADVOCATES IN THE AND IN
THE LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS THE
PRO TEM.
UM FOR MANY YEARS NOW TO LAUNCH
A PILOT PROJECT IN CALIFORNIA
COMPREHENSIVELY ASSESS THE WELL
KNOWN DEFICIENCIES IN MEDI CAL --
PROGRAM WITH RESPECT -- TO
DELIVERY OF MEDICAL
INTERPRETATION SERVICES -- AND
DURING OUR WORK IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ON THIS ISSUE A NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS AND
CONSTITUENCY CAUCUSES WERE CLEAR.
THAT NOT ONLY DID STATE
LEGISLATORS AND UNDERSTAND THIS
ISSUE -- BUT THEY INTENDED
ACTIVELY WORK WITH US IN OF
OTHERS IN THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY UP TO STUDY THE EXTENT
OF LANGUAGE ACCESS -- TO MEDICAL
INTERPRETATION SERVICES -- THE
ORIGINAL -- BILL -- AB SIX THREE
FIVE I WENT TO PLACE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN IT WAS SLATED
TO GO INTO EFFECT ON JANUARY
FIRST -- THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES DID NOT
RELEASE AN RP UNTIL APRIL TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHICH IS MORE
THAN A YEAR AFTER THE EFFECTIVE
DATE -- AND NEARLY TWO YEARS --
FROM THE PASSAGE OF THE LANGUAGE
IN THE BUDGET -- THE DEPARTMENT
DID SELECT THE VENDOR TO CONDUCT
A STUDY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND FINALIZE THAT
AGREEMENT EARLIER THIS YEAR --
BUT GIVEN THE EXISTING STATUTES
EXPIRATION IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY WE WE'RE RECENTLY
CONCERNED AT THAT WILL LEAVE US
VIRTUALLY NO TIME TO CONDUCT.
A LEGITIMATE POWER PROJECT
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE
DEPARTMENT'S INTERPRETATION OF
THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE --
PREVENTS US FROM BEGINNING
APOLLO PROJECT CONTROLS THE
STUDIES UNDER -- THIS CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY IS COMPLETE -- SO. TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE CONCERNS
THE STATION PRO TEM INTRODUCE SB
ONE SIX FIVE THIS YEAR WHICH
EXTENDS TO SUNSET THE BUT ALSO A
D. COUPLES TO STUDY -- FROM THE
THE POWER PROJECTS THAT WILL
CALL FOR BUT IN THE PROCESS OF
THAT WE FOUND THAT ONLY ABOUT
THAT ALL OF THE MONEY THAT WAS
AB ALLOCATIVE TOOK FOR BOTH TO
STUDY IN THE PILOT PROJECT WAS
USED JUST ON THE STUDY PORTION
ALONE -- AND SO WE'RE BEFORE YOU
TODAY WITH A ONE TIME FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST -- THAT
WE BELIEVE FULFILLS THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT WITH THE
PREVIOUS STATUTE OF IMPLEMENTING --
POLLOCK PROJECTS TO BEGIN THE
STUDY TO LACK OF LANGUAGE ACCESS
THAT EXIST IN OUR COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE -- AND AND JUST
QUICKLY -- THE REASON WHY THIS
CONTINUES TO BE AN ISSUE EARLIER
THIS YEAR AT THE THERE WAS AN
AUDIT OF THE MEDICARE PROGRAM
THAT FOUND THE DH CS HAS DONE
LITTLE TO ENSURE THAT FAMILIES.
ARE AWARE OF THE AVAILABILITY OF
INTERPRETERS TO MINIMIZE THE USE
OF CHILDREN -- AND CUSTODIAL
STAFF OF THE HOSPITAL WORKERS --
FOR INTERPRETATION SERVICES SO
WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THIS IS A
PROBLEM -- AND HOPE THAT -- WE
CAN TAKE STEPS IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET.
TO BEGIN TO WANT TO COUPLE THAT
PROJECT BUT ALSO BEGIN ALLOCATE
SOMEONE A SPECIFICALLY TO THE
POWER PROJECTS WE CAN BEGIN.
THANK YOU SIR I THANK YOU ALEJO
MOMENTS OKAY I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT -- CERTAINLY IS A POSITION
TAKES YOUR MEDICARE PATIENTS --
IT'S EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING NOT
TO HAVE -- MEDICAL INTERPRETER.
NOW IT'S MAYBE FRUSTRATING FOR
ME IS THE PHYSICIAN.
I A CAN IMAGINE IT'S NOT JUST
FRUSTRATING FOR THE PATIENT THE
PATIENT'S FAMILY WHO ONE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND -- ARE HAVING
DIFFICULTY UNDERSTANDING -- WHAT
I'M TELLING THEM -- FOR THE
TREATMENT PLAN OR TRYING TO
EXPLAIN TO ME WHAT'S GOING ON
AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT --
SO IT'S BEYOND FRUSTRATING FOR
THEM IT'S JUST FRUSTRATING IT'S
FRUSTRATING FOR ME BUT IT'S
BEYOND FRUSTRATING FOR THEM.
AND A THE OTHER THING IS
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE LEADERSHIP
BY PRO TEM ATKINS ON THIS ISSUE
BUT WE'VE THIS IS I MEAN.
I SAID THIS BEEN GOING A LONG
TIME I JUST DEAL WE'VE DRAGGED
HER FOOT ON THE STUDY HAD --
THAT THEY USE ALL THE MONEY FOR
THE STUDY AND NOW OR SEEM LIKE
AS DRAGGING THEIR FEET AND THIS
IS CERTAINLY A SHE I ISSUE FIGHT
A LOT OF PEOPLE YOU KNOW THEY P.
I. CAUCUSES IDENTIFIED IS IS
THIS IS A TOP PRIORITY ISSUE FOR
IN THIS IS A MAJOR.
ISSUE FOR MANY COMMUNITIES.
SO HELPFUL STOP DRAGGING HER
FEET AND GET SOMETHING DONE SO I
APPRECIATE DOING A STUDY BUT
THEY'LL THIS IS THE AND BUT IF
YOU DRAG YOUR FEET ON THE STUDY
I'D.
YEAH WE WE JUST NEED TO HELP
PEOPLE THANK YOU THESE ARE MUCH.
ALL RIGHT OUT REGION ROMAN
ASSISTANCE SEE CHRO.
HERE.
NO ONE FROM CC HRA OKAY SO
CALIFORNIA COVERAGE IN HEALTH
INITIATIVES REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FIFTEEN
MILLION. 201-920-2020 ONE FOR
MAINTAINING STRENGTHENING A
ROLAND PROCESS AT THE COMMITTEE
LEVEL OKAY SO THIS THAT'S ON THE
RECORD.
ALL RIGHT NEXT SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT PREVENTION.
IF SOMEONE NINE OKAY WELCOME.
SHE ANY COMMENTS MILLION CCH I
VICE COMING UP OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PEOPLE JUST AS
BEAU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CLIFF BURKE HERE IN THE OFFICE
AND WERE RECOUNTING.
WANNA THANK SENATOR JACKSON --
FOR MAKING THIS REQUEST ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY I HAVE TO
SAY THE COUNTY IS LOOKING AT IN
A WAY INNOVATIVE WAYS -- TO IT
REALLY DIVERT MENTALLY ILL.
PATIENTS OUT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM SO WE'VE COME UP
WITH -- THREE IDEAS THAT I THINK --
BOTH LOW COST COST EFFECTIVE AND
ARE LOOKING FOR THE STATE.
TO PARTICIPATE IN.
DEVELOPING THESE PROGRAMS -- TO
KEEP THE MENTALLY ILL OUT OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SO ITEM
NUMBER ONE I THINK THERE IT'S
NOT CORRECT IN YOUR ANALYSIS.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR DEVELOPING A MENTAL HEALTH
REHABILITATION CENTER RIGHT
SHORT TERM INPATIENT MENTAL
HEALTH CARE FOR INDIVIDUALS I
THINK THE ANALYSIS AS ITS
ONGOING I THINK THIS IS A ONE
TIME ASK -- IS FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY FOR NET SINCE THE
COUNTIES ALREADY COME UP WITH
THE PROPERTY THE BUILDING -- IS
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE THE ONGOING
MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS I THINK
THIS IS FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME ONLY FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY FOR THE BUILDING --
ITEM NUMBER TWO TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR ALL
HALL WAS SICK DEFENSE
PARTNERSHIP THE COUNTY'S PUBLIC
DEFENDER PARTNERED WITH THE
FAMILY SERVICES AGENCY THE PILOT
A HOLISTIC DEFENSE MODEL IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY.
IT'S AN INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO
REPRESENT A POOR CLIENTS WHICH
IS PROVEN EFFECTIVE REDUCE
INCARCERATION RATES REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AND SAVE TAX DOLLARS
VERY COST EFFECTIVE LOW DOLLAR
AMOUNT ASK -- WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AND FINALLY WE HAVE A
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE DIVERSION
PROCESSING MAPPING PROJECT ONLY
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- AIM DID ACHIEVING
THESE GOALS OF KEEPING THEM YOU
MENTALLY ILL OUT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
SO I THINK THESE ARE THREE
INNOVATIVE IDEAS TO RESPOND TO
THE PROBLEM ALL OF OUR MENTALLY
ILL WINDING UP IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM WHICH THEY SHOULD NOT BE.
SO ARE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A THANK YOU COMES FROM LA --
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION IN A CENTER JACKSON
THIS IS SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT
TO HER WELL CELL AND THAT'S
RIGHT SO WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON AND THESE -- PROVIDE
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT --
THESE FIRST FIFTEEN THAT COVERS
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH FACILITIES
FINANCING AUTHORITY THE OFFICE
THE WHITE HAT HEALTH PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT AND THE PERMIT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
RECOGNIZING THERE'S FIFTEEN WE
HAVE HAD PRESENTATIONS ON EACH
OF THOSE I THINK OF YOU MAINLY
FOCUS ON WHICH ONES YOU REALLY
LIKE -- THAT BE GREAT RIGHT
THANK YOU WELCOME. TO HI LYDIA
MISCELLANEOUS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT
DAY SERVICES -- FOR THIRTY YEARS.
OF WE ARE SUPPORTING THE PEG
TAYLOR CENTERS ONE TIME ONLY
REQUEST FOR HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS ALSO SUBMITTED
AS A MEMBER REQUEST BY SENATOR
NIELSEN.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THEY'RE ONE
OF OUR FIVE STAR PROGRAMS IN THE
WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THEY'RE FANTASTIC AND THEY COULD
REALLY USE YOUR HELP.
AND WE'RE ALSO SUPPORTING THE
ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER REQUEST
BY THE OMBUDSMAN AS MANY OF THE
PARTICIPANTS WE SERVE AN ADULT
DAY HEALTH AN ADULT THEY
PROGRAMS NEED MORE OPTIONS FOR
HOUSING OR JUST A STEP AWAY FROM
HOMELESSNESS SO THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
REQUEST THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME WE BEING HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND WERE IN SUPPORT
OF EFFORTS TO FUND THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE -- IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS PROPOSAL.
THE I'M LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED UNDER PROPERTY SIX
WITH TO INTERN TWENTY MILLION
ONE TIME FUNDING LAST YEAR JUST
CLOSED OUT THE APPLICATION
WINDOW.
AND RECEIVED ALMOST -- THIRTEEN
HUNDRED APPLICATIONS FOR A
HUNDRED FIFTY SLOTS -- IT SHOWS
THAT PROVIDERS ARE WILLING TO
SERVE IN A MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
AREA AND MAINTAIN AT LEAST A 30%
MEDI CAL PATIENT CASELOAD.
THE NEED ACROSS THE STATE IS
GREAT AND SEE ME APPRECIATES THE
GOVERNOR'S ALLOCATION OF AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION THIS MORNING -- BUT THIS
COALITION WORKFORCE REQUEST AS
IMPORTANT AS WELL IS THAT I
DON'T INCLUDE STUDENT
RECRUITMENT AND RETIREES AND SEE
POSITIONS AS WELL.
WE LOOK FOR TO PARTICIPATING IN
THE CONTINUE BUDGET DISCUSSION
SURROUNDING WORKFORCE SHORTAGES
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
IN THE COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
JUST I WILL LIST THE FOR ITEMS
THAT WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THAT YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY.
THE COMMUNITY CLINIC VISION
INTEGRATION PROJECT THE
PSYCHIATRIC FELLOWSHIPS -- THE
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY A TOP PRIORITY FOR THE
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND THE REQUEST FROM
NORTHEAST VALLEY HEALTH HEALTH
WELLNESS.
OF GARDEN CENTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME HONEY DELGADO
ON BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUM HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE HEALTHCARE
WORK FOR SHORTAGE AT WORK FORCE
AND UNDERSERVED AREAS ANYTHING
WE CAN DO TO INCREASE A THE
PHYSICIANS IN THE STATE'S
PRECIADO.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WELCOME.
LEANING MICHELLE JOHNSON WITH
THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION AS
THE UPCOMING SPEAKER I'LL
DEFINITELY KEEP IT BRIEF.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE PEG TAYLOR
DON'T THEY HEALTH CENTER FUNDING
AND THE SYSTEM LIVING WAY FOR
EXPANSION.
THANK YOU.
WE HAD A LEASE A COMMON WITH CAL
CAUGHT OUT IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THAT MENTAL HEALTH DOLLARS FOR A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES --
AND THE REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS
THEY WANTED TO SUPPORT THE
PERSONAL NEEDS ALLOWANCE AND THE
ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER.
AND FOR THE ASSISTED LIVING
WAIVER I HAVE THE SIX BEDS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOME REFORMS
CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM LIVING
ASSOCIATION LEADING EDGE.
LEADING EDGE CALIFORNIA JUSTICE
AN AGING THE GALLATIN THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE OF LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS A
COALITION OF THIRTY SEVEN
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS AND MANY
REGIONAL COALITIONS IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE ASSISTED
LIVING WAY.
FOR OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE
SEVERAL -- THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTING.
SEVERAL THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING --
FIRST PERSONAL NEEDS AN
ALLOWANCE INCREASE.
ON SECOND ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER
EXPANSION AND THIRD THE SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY -- MENTAL HEALTH
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT
PREVENTION.
A THANK YOU.
THE EVENING WENT AWAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY HERE IN SUPPORT OF THAT
THE US HAD.
A CA YOU PUBLIC USE FILE AND
UNDER DH CS THE PERSONAL NEEDS
ALLOWANCE INCREASE THAT ASSISTED
LIVING WAIVER EXPANSION AND THE
MEDICAL INTERPRETER PILOT
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
CASEY KNOWS OF THE MICROPHONE
REMOVE ON SO DEPART PUBLIC
HEALTH LITTLE BY LITTLE EARLY
LITERACY PROGRAM WELCOME.
HELLO TO HEALTH [inaudible]
OKAY EXCELLENT [inaudible]
IS ON GERMAN PAN MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE -- GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS DOCTOR BLING COLOR I'M A
PHYSICIAN -- MET PETE'S TRAINED
BY THE WAY BROWN.
RESIDENTS OF THE NONPROFIT
PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCY CALLED
BALLOON HEALTH.
OR AGENCY PROVIDES DIRECT
PROGRAM AND SUPPORT SERVICES TO
OPTIMIZE POPULATION HEALTH.
AND WE'VE BEEN INCREASINGLY
FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH INCLUDING
EARLY EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REQUEST FUNDING IN SUPPORT OF A
PROPOSED STATEWIDE EXPANSION OF
THE LITTLE BY LITTLE SCHOOL
READINESS PROGRAM.
READINESS PROGRAM IS AN EVIDENCE
BASED EARLY LITERACY PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED THROUGH WEEK
CENTERS.
THAT HAS DEMONSTRATED GREAT
SUCCESS AND RETURN ON INVESTMENT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
HELLO TO HELP DECIDED TO DEVELOP
LITTLE BY LITTLE BECAUSE TIME
AGAIN RESEARCHERS SHOWN THE
CHILDREN FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES FALL BEHIND IN LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT VERY EARLY IN LIFE
AS YOUNG AS AGE.
THREE AND ONCE THEY HAVE BEEN
FALLING BEHIND THEY ARE LESS
LIKELY TO CATCH UP.
IN FACT CHILDREN LIVING IN
POVERTY HERE FEWER THAN ONE
THIRD OF THE WORDS HEARD BY
CHILDREN FROM HIGHER INCOME
FAMILIES.
AND EARLY RESEARCH STUDY BY
HARDEN RISLEY FOUND THE BY THREE
YEARS OF AGE THERE IS AN
ESTIMATED THIRTY MILLION WORD
GAP.
IN LANGUAGE HEARD BETWEEN
pPOOREST FAMILIES.
WITH SUPPORT OF FIRST BY THE
LADY WHO HELPED LAUNCH LITTLE BY
LITTLE IN.
TWO THOUSAND THREE AS A PILOT
PROGRAM AND OPERATED IT AND SIX
SITES IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
IN ITS FIVE YEAR PILOT PHASE
FROM 200-032-2000 EIGHT LITTLE
BY LITTLE REACHED A HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND CHILDREN
BETWEEN BIRTH TO AGE FIVE AND
PROVED REMARKABLY EFFECTIVE.
A RESEARCH STUDY FROM THIS PILOT
PHASE REVEALED THAT WITH WITH
CHILDREN WHO HAVE RECEIVED
LITTLE BY LITTLE SERVICES.
AT HIGHER SCHOOL READINESS IN
LANGUAGE SCORES THAN THOSE WITH
CHILDREN WHO HAD NOT.
WE ARE SUBMITTING A COPY OF
RESEARCH PUBLISHED IN PEDIATRICS
FOR YOUR REVIEW.
GIVEN THE EVIDENCE THAT LITTLE
BY LITTLE WORKS FIRST FIVE
REFUNDED THE PROGRAM IN TWENTY
TWELVE FOR TEN YEARS.
IN THIS PROGRAM WHICH STAFFER
TRAINED AND PROMPTED BASED ON
THE CHILD'S AGE TO EDUCATE
PARENTS ON APPROPRIATE
DEVELOPMENTAL MILESTONES.
AND TO ENCOURAGE PARENTS TO READ
TO AND WITH THEIR CHILD.
FREE HIGH QUALITY BOOKS ARE
PROVIDED EACH VISIT SO THAT BY
THE TIME THE CHILD ENTERS
KINDERGARTEN THEY HAVE ALREADY
RECEIVED A SMALL HOME LIBRARY OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY BOOKS.
LITTLE BY LITTLE CURRENTLY
SERVES MORE THAN SIXTY THOUSAND
LOW INCOME PARTICIPANTS IN TEN
WEEKS SITES IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
AN ADDITIONAL TWELVE THOUSAND
WITH PARTICIPANTS IN FIVE SITES
IN TULSA OKLAHOMA.
IT IS OUR BELIEF THAT THIS
PROGRAM CAN BE GREATLY EXPANDED
TO REACH A LARGER PORTION OF THE
NEARLY ONE MILLION LOW INCOME
PARTICIPANTS.
THAT ARE SERVED EACH YEAR
THROUGH CALIFORNIA'S WITH
PROGRAM.
BUT USING THE WEB PLATFORM FOR
PROGRAM DELIVERY PROGRAM COSTS
REMAIN LOW AVERAGING ONLY FIFTY
TWO DOLLARS ER CHILD PER YEAR.
IN ADDITION WEEK SITES ARE ONE
OF THE FEW PLACES THAT YOUNG
FAMILIES VISIT REGULARLY FROM
THE MOTHER'S PREGNANCY THROUGH
THE CHILD'S FIFTH BIRTHDAY.
MAKING THEM UNIQUELY SUITABLE
FOR EVIDENCE BASED EARLY
LITERACY PROGRAMS LIKE THIS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE LITTLE
BY LITTLE HAS SERVED OVER A
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND
UNIQUE INDIVIDUALS AND
DISTRIBUTED NEARLY A MILLION NEW
BOOKS.
IN ADDITION TO THE STRONG
SUPPORT WE'VE RECEIVED FROM
FIRST FIVE LOS ANGELES WE HAVE
RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT
FROM KEYSTAKE HOLDERS INCLUDING
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA.
AND THE GEORGE KAISER FAMILY
FOUNDATION.
IN ADDITION MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY WICKS STUFF WITH
PARTICIPANTS AND LITTLE BY
LITTLE PARTICIPANTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
HAVE SUBMITTED SUPPORT LETTERS
FOR THIS REQUEST.
HELLO TO HELP BELIEVE THAT WHEN
CHILDREN ARE GIVEN EQUAL ACCESS
TO OPPORTUNITY THEY WILL THRIVE.
AND WE ALL BENEFIT FROM A MORE
EDUCATED AND MORE PRODUCTIVE
SOCIETY.
FINALLY I JUST WANTED YOU TO
KNOW WE'VE SUBMITTED A RANGE OF
FUNDING OPTIONS FROM ONE POINT
SEVEN TO THIRTY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
WELL WE SUPPORT SCALING
STATEWIDE IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE
WRAP UP YES BECAUSE OF NEED --
BEING MINDFUL OF COST WE HAVE
SUBMITTED THREE ALTERNATIVE
BUDGETS FOR REVIEW YOUR REVIEW
THANKS SO MUCH A HAPPY HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU AT LU COMMENTS.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL IT SOUNDS THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A REACH OUT AND READ
PROGRAMS AT THE WAKE.
WELL THE DIFFERENCE IS THERE'S A
COUPLE OF VERY IMPORTANT
DIFFERENCES WHICH I CAN EXPLAIN
IF YOU WANT A VERY BRIEFLY YEAH.
BRIEFLY DOES IS VERY IMPORTANT
SO ON AVERAGE PARTICIPANTS COME
TO WORK ABOUT FOUR TIMES A YEAR
AFTER A CHILD'SFIRST YEAR OF
LIFE AS YOU KNOW -- THE AND IF
THE CHILD AS WELL THEY COME TO A
PEDIATRICIAN MAYBE ONE TIME A
YEAR SO SO AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
PETE.
IT'S ARE A LITTLE BIT MORE
RELAXED THEY HAVE REALLY LONG
AND STABLE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
WHAT PROVIDERS WITH AS THEY
MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
STRESSED THEIR CHILD IS ILL.
THE PEDIATRICIAN'S OFFICE THEY
MAY NOT HERE -- IF THEIR
MESSAGING AROUND READING AS MUCH
OF A REACH OUT REDUCE BUILT
DURING WELL CHILD VISITS SO IT'S
STERN OUNCE PORTERHOUSE AROUND
NOT SAYING THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY
PERHAPS WORK TOGETHER.
AND THEY'RE BOTH VERY
COMPLIMENTARY WE SEE THEM AS
COMPLEMENTARY THE ONE LAST THING
I JUST WANT TO SAY IS WHICH IS A
100% SERVING LOW INCOME FAMILIES
WHICH IS ADDRESSING THE HEALTH
DISPARITY.
REACH OUT AND READ REPORTS THAT
IT'S A REACHING ABOUT 50% OF ITS
PARTICIPANTS LOW INCOME OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT -- SUGAR AWARENESS AND
RESEARCH PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES
HERE.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO -- JUST TO READ AND
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES RECORDS TO REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPOSURE THREE OF
TEN MILLION OVER THREE YEARS FOR
DPH IS DIVISION OF CHRONIC
DISEASE AN ENTRY CONTROL.
DECISION EDUCATIONAL BUSY
PREVENTION BRANCH TO ISSUE
STATEWIDE COMMITTEE GRANTS TO
CALIFORNIA RESERVATIONS FOR
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGE
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN OKAY.
RIGHT YOU'RE NOT HERE FOR THAT
ARE YOU OKAY ALL RIGHT AND DAY
COMES FROM EARLY ON THAT OKAY.
RIGHT BEHAVIORAL RISK FACTOR
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION.
GOT TO PAN AND THEN I'M I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION MY
EDUCATIONAL TRAINING IS IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND I'M ALSO HAPPY
TO BE HERE IS A CONSTITUENT OF
YOUR DISTRICT.
AND THANK YOU FOR ADDING THIS NO
COST BUDGET ITEM TO YOUR AGENDA
THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION SIX
BUDGET AUTHORITY TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
USE EXISTING ALZHEIMER'S
RESEARCH DOLLARS. TO PAY FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY BEHAVIORAL RISK
FACTOR SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM
SURVEY ON COGNITIVE DECLINE.
THE REVENUE EXISTS THE BUDGET
THEY ARE AT THE READY DOES NOT.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THIS ONE TIME COST
IS LESS THAN FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
DATA COLLECTION AND DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE ARE CUR OUR
RESEARCH WE SIMPLY NEED YOUR
HELP TO TRANSFER EXISTING LOCAL
SYSTEMS DOLLARS TO STATE
OPERATIONS TO CONDUCT THE CDC.
DISEASE SURVEILLANCE ALL FIFTY
STATES ARE ASKED TO CONDUCT THE
SURVEY WHEN CALIFORNIA
PARTICIPATED IN THE SURVEY LAST
IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE LEARNED THAT
MORE THAN ONE IN FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH MEMORY
PROBLEMS LET ALONE.
AND TWO OUT OF THREE HAVE NEVER
TALKED TO HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE TWENTY FIVE
ACTIONS CONTAINED IN THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL HEALTHY
BRAIN INITIATIVE WITH YOUR
ACTION WE CAN PROBABLY SAY THE
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN ITS FIRST
STEP TOWARDS FORWARD ON THE
HEALTHY BRING INITIATIVE.
THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO MAKE THIS NO
COST TECHNICAL CHANGE IN FY
NINETEEN TWENTY STATE BUDGET
THANK YOU I THINK YOU COMES FROM
OHIO OKAY.
ALL RIGHT CERTAINLY SEEMS TO
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE THANK YOU
THROUGH H..
OKAY NEXT UP IS -- PARKINSON'S
REGISTRY FUNDING MADE MICHAEL J.
FOX FOUNDATION FOR PARKINSON'S
RESEARCH.
WELCOME.
CHAIR AND STAFF APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR HARD WORK NEEDS ALL OF OF
THE OF THE MICHAEL J. FOX
FOUNDATION FOR PARKINSON'S
RESEARCH WERE REQUESTING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND.
AND LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO
CONTINUE THE CALIFORNIA
PARKINSON'S DISEASE REGISTRY FOR
THREE MOREYEARS THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET CREATED AND
THE INCIDENCE AND PREVALENCE OF
PARK INSTANCES PARKINSON'S
DISEASE AND ULTIMATELY IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF THOSE AFFECTED.
BUT THAT FUNDING RUNS OUT THIS
YEAR THOUSANDS OF CASES HAVE
ALREADY BEEN REPORTED TO THE
REGISTRY AND THOUSANDS MORE ARE
ARRIVING THIS MONTH AS MEDICAL
GROUPS AND HOSPITALS BEGIN TO
SUBMIT THEIR PATIENT DATA.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
JUST GOT THE PARKINSON'S PROGRAM
OFF THE GROUND AND WE BELIEVE
IT'S CRITICAL TO CONTINUE
FUNDING SO IT CAN EXPAND AND
IMPROVE IN THE COMING YEARS.
THE MICHAEL J. FOX FOUNDATION IS
A NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO FINDING
A CURE FOR PARKINSON'S DISEASE
THEY PROVIDED THE MOST FUNDING
TO CALIFORNIA OF ANY STATE FOR
RESURGENT THERAPIES.
THE FOUNDATION'S EFFORTS
TOGETHER WITH THE DEPARTMENTS
REGISTRY WILL GREATLY BENEFIT
CALIFORNIANS.
PARKINSON'S DISEASE IS A CHRONIC
DEGENERATIVE NEUROLOGICAL
DISORDER THAT AFFECTS ONE IN ONE
HUNDRED PEOPLE OVER AGE SIXTY
GET INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED AS YOUNG AS EIGHTEEN
LITTLE IS KNOWN ABOUT HOW
PARKINSON'S IMPACTS DIFFERENT
POPULATION GROUPS AND IF THE
PATTERNS.
OF THE DISEASE ARE CHANGING OVER
TIME CALIFORNIANS A LARGE AND
DIVERSE POPULATION MAKES IT
IDEAL FOR THE REGISTRY TO EXPAND
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF PARKINSON'S
AND PROVIDE IMPORTANT CLUES TO
THE CAUSES AND RISK FACTORS OF
THE DISEASE.
THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH DID
AS MUCH AS THEY COULD WITH A
LIMITED ORIGINAL FUNDING IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT THE NEW FUNDING WE'RE
REQUESTING WILL HELP THE
DEPARTMENT IMPROVE AND EXPAND
THE REGISTRY TO MAXIMIZE ITS
BENEFIT FOR RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS AND CALIFORNIANS.
PARKINSON'S PATIENTS THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
WHEN IT COMES MILLENNIAL ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT
EXCELLENT?
RIGHT -- NEXT UP IS TWENTY THIRD
BI ANNUAL INTERNATIONAL AIDS
CONFERENCE IS [inaudible]
TWENTY TWENTY WELCOME.
HI THERE THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
SPEAK SURE GOLDMAN FROM THE
TWENTY THIRD INTERNATIONAL AIDS
CONFERENCE ALSO KNOWN AS AIDS.
TWENTY TWENTY IT WILL BE COMING
TO THE BAY -- IN IT TO LIVE --
TWENTY TWENTY NAMELY TO OAKLAND
AND SAN FRANCISCO IT'S THE FIRST
TIME IT'LL BE BACK HERE IN
THIRTY YEARS SO IT'S SORT OF A
WONDERFUL HOME COMING.
A CHANCE TO PUT A MAGNIFYING
GLASS ON THE STELLAR BEST
PRACTICES WE HAVE IN THIS AREA
AND ALSO WHERE WE STILL HAVE
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT AND THE
CONFERENCE WILL ATTRACT ABOUT
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS.
FROM ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
COUNTRIES M..
IT IS ANTICIPATED THAT IS TWENTY
TWENTY WILL GENERATE ABOUT FIFTY
NINE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ECONOMIC IMPACT TWO POINT
SEVEN DOLLARS IN TAX TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
REVENUE.
AND SUPPORT OVER AT NINE
THOUSAND JOBS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA WON THE
BID FOR THIS CONFERENCE AFTER A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS WITH TWELVE
CITIES INTERNATIONALLY -- AT THE
LGBT CAUCUS AND SENATOR WIENER
PRESENTED OR IF REQUESTED A TWO
MILLION DOLLARS OF STATE FUNDING
FOR AIDS -- TWENTY TWENTY THE
CONFERENCE IS EXPECTED TO COST
ABOUT TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
THIS IS A 30% INCREASE FROM THE
LOS CONFERENCE DUE IN PART TO
SERVICING TWO LOCATIONS.
AND ALSO DUE TO AN INCREASED
FOCUS ON SCHOLARSHIPS THIS TIME
AROUND -- NAMELY FOR LOCAL
PARTICIPANTS WHO WOULD NEVER
OTHERWISE GET THE CHANCE TO GO
TO A CONFERENCE -- IT'S TWENTY
TWENTY IS A VERY SPECIAL FORUM
TO SHOWCASE CALIFORNIA'S
RESEARCH ADVOCACY POLICY AND
TECHNOLOGY THERE WILL BE OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED JOURNALISTS.
FROM LOCAL NATIONAL
INTERNATIONAL PUBLICATIONS
THEY'RE GENERATING OVER ONE
BILLION MEDIA IMPRESSIONS -- ALL
THAT BEING SAID I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART OF ITS TWENTY
TWENTY IS THE LEGACY IT WILL
LEAVE BEHIND A THAT
RELATIONSHIPS BEING BUILT.
ACROSS THE BAY WILL LONG OUTLIVE
THE CONFERENCE AND CONTINUED TO
POSITIVELY AFFECT THE STATE'S.
RESPONSE TO THE EPIDEMIC THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU -- COLLEGE MILIEU NO
ALL RIGHT.
WELL IT'S GREAT THAT'S COMING
BACK HERE -- AND SAID WE WANT TO
GET TO ZERO CELL THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
OKAY NEXT UP USED YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH DROP IN CENTERS SET UP
WELCOME BACK TO BE.
THANK YOU CENTER PLAN CHAIR AS
AS YOU KNOW WHEN I CLICK HERE MY
GOAL IS TO GET A COMMENT OUT OF
THE LA OUT [inaudible]
SO.
LET'S SEE IF TODAY IS THE DAY.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF A REQUEST
FROM.
FROM SENATOR BELL AND THERE'S A
SIMILAR QUESTION TO MEMBER
GIPSON ON THIS ON THE SIDE WE'RE
ASKING FOR TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND I'M GOING FUNDING TO
SUPPORT IS DROP IN CENTERS.
THE THE COMMISSION IS SPENT THE
LAST TWO YEARS REALLY LOOKING AT
THIS MODEL THAT WAS ORIGINALLY
DEVELOPED IN AUSTRALIA AND
EXPANDED AROUND THE WORLD
ACTUALLY WE WERE ABLE TO VISIT
WITH THAT THE SITES IN VANCOUVER
AND WE PRIDE IN FOLKS FROM
CANADA AS WELL AS AUSTRALIA TO
MEET WITH.
COUNTIES IT REALLY IS AN AMAZING
MODEL.
AND THERE'S EVIDENCE.
PRIMARILY OUT OF AUSTRALIA BUT
EMERGING EVIDENCE IN CANADA.
THAT THIS IDEA OF DESIGNING USE
DROP IN CENTERS WITH KEY
CHARACTERISTICS THAT IT IS YOUTH
DRIVEN USE BRANDON IS PROMOTED.
THAT IT PROVIDES INTEGRATED CARE
FROM MENTAL HEALTH PHYSICAL
HEALTH BUT ALSO COMPONENT CARE
AROUND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IN
SUPPORT FOR HOUSING EMPLOYMENT
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES AS WELL.
CAN BETTER SERVE USE PRIMARILY
BECAUSE USE ARE MORE WILLING TO
ACCESS THESE SERVICES BECAUSE OF
THEIR ROLE ON THE FRONT END
WE'RE ALSO SEEING THAT THERE'S
GREATER PERSISTENCE IN TERMS OF
THE DELIVERY OF CARE PRIMARILY
BECAUSE OF THE INTEGRATION.
THE EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT
OUTCOMES IMPROVED DRAMATICALLY.
THE FUNDING REQUEST IS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY COUNTIES
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO START THIS
INITIATIVE AND IT WOULD ALLOW
THE STATE TO REALLY SHAPE.
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE SERVICES
STATEWIDE AND SO THE REQUEST IS
FOR TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT -- ANNUALLY ON GOING --
IN REALLY INTENDED TO SUPPORT
OUR ABILITY TO RESOURCE COUNTIES
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO BRING THEM TOGETHER AS A
LEARNING COLLABORATIVE TO DO THE
RESEARCH AND EVALUATION TO
UNDERSTAND HOW BEST THIS MODEL
WORKS.
INCLUDED IN THAT OF COURSE AS
YOU UNDERSTAND IS THE CAPACITY
TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL FUNDS AND
OTHER FUNDS OVER TIME.
SANTA CLARA AS THEY ROLLED THIS
OUT AS OUR FIRST SITE IS DOING
THIS IN A WAY THAT THEY'RE
SERVING ALL COMERS IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT ALL KINDS WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND WE'RE VERY EXCITED THAT THIS
IS A MODEL THAT REALLY WOULD
ALLOW THE STATE TO DESIGN MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND WAYS THAT ARGUES CENTRIC.
SO WITH THAT HAPPENED ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS AND REALLY ASKING FOR
SUPPORT ON THIS.
OKAY THANK YOU LA JOH.
I WILL PROFESSIONS ON NOW MR
EWING'S REFERENCE TO EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES FROM CANADA HAS
SOLD ME ON THIS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT -- SO YOU
KNOW ACTUALLY THE YEAH THE OF
HIS OF PLEASED TO HOST A TOWN
HALL SPONSORED DIED STEINBERG
INSTITUTE THIS WAS ONE OF THE
MODELS AND WE ACTUALLY WERE ABLE
TO SKYPE IN -- THE TRAINING OF
REMEMBER THE NAME OF THE PERSON
IS RIGHT BUT THE THIS THIS
PROGRAM AND CERTAINLY IS IS VERY
CITING AND LET THEM KNOW THAT
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO DO THIS YEAR
AND HE'S IN CALIFORNIA PROGRAM
WE'VE ENGAGE STANFORD UNIVERSITY
FOR TA THERE'S A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE AROUND.
THE WORLD AS AS YOU HEARD THIS A
LOT OF INTEREST AROUND THE STATE
SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY.
NOW IT ISN'T FUNDING ONE IN
SACRAMENTO THOUGH RIGHT.
WELL THE TEN WIN WIN THE
COMMISSION FIRST -- BROUGHT THE
FOLKS TOGETHER WE ENGAGE ALL OF
THE COUNTIES ARE SAID HEY WHERE
WHERE IS THEIR INTEREST AND SO I
I DO THINK THE AND THE INTENT OF
THE FUNDING AS AN ON BECAUSE IT
IS ON GOING.
IS THAT THIS WOULD ACTUALLY
ALLOW THE STATE OVER TIME TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS ACCESS TO
THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
IN SACRAMENTO OKAY THANK YOU.
IT TAKES REMOTE OKAY NEXT UP
THEN YOU GOT THE OTHER COMMENT.
NEXT UP IS INNOVATION AND
PROJECT TIMELINE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PROPOSAL FOR A
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OKAY WILL
COME.
PROBLEM WITH THE COUNTY BE ABLE
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION --
AS YOU'RE AWARE UNDER CURRENT
LAW COUNTIES HAVE A VERY LIMITED
TIME TO COMPLETE AN ENTIRELY
SPEND THEIR APPROVED DOLLARS FOR
IMAGES A INNOVATION PROJECTS.
SO CVH DA'S REQUESTING THAT THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE GRANT A
TECHNICAL CHANGE TO THE MENTAL
SERVICES ACT FOR THE FINANCING
OF THESE INNOVATION PROJECTS.
OFTENTIMES SIMPLE THINGS LIKE
CONTRACTING NIMBY IS THEM --
LOCAL POLITICS OR ROBUST
COMMUNITY PLANNING PROCESS WILL
CREATE.
UNAVOIDABLE DELAYS TO THE
PROJECTS THAT COUNTIES TO JUST
SIMPLY CANNOT CONTROL.
THESE IMPEDIMENTS CAN PREVENT
COUNTIES FROM OPERATIONALIZE IN
PROGRAMS IN A TIMELY WAY SO IN
RESPONSE TO THIS RASKIN THAT THE
CURRENT PROVISION BE REMOVED AND
INSTEAD EACH PROJECT TIMELINE BE
LINKED. TO THE APPROVAL PROCESS
WHEN IT'S HER DURING THE
COMMISSION.
WITH THIS CHANGE COUNTIES WILL
BE ABLE TO FURTHER CREATE CROSS
COUNTY COLLABORATIONS AND HELP
FURTHER THE INTENT OF THE M. AND
JUST SAY.
LIKE I SAID BEFORE THIS WILL BE
DONE DURING THE EXISTING
COMMISSION PROP COMMISSION
PROCESS AND THEREFORE IN THE
PUBLIC MEETINGS WITH INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND COMMISSION
STAFF A FEW EXAMPLES OF SPECIFIC
PROJECTS YOU'D LIKE BUT
CONSIDERING I'M SECOND FROM LAST
I'LL.
JUST ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ALEJO COMMENTS.
SO JUST TO CLARIFY THE THE THREE
YEAR TIME LINE ACTUALLY --
STARTS WHAT THE WIN I MEAN IT'S
AFTER YOUR APPROVAL THE PROJECT
RIGHT.
SO YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TIME TO
PLAN AND AND SO.
WELL IT THE THREE OR TIMELINE IS --
CONSISTENT -- FOR REGULAR
ACCOUNT OR SO FROM THE NORMAL
SIZE COUNTIES FOR SMALL COUNTIES
IT'S FIVE YEARS YEARS YEAH OKAY
SO WHAT THIS PROPOSAL WOULD DO
IS IT WOULD LINK THAT TIME LINE.
TO THE TIMELINE OF THE PROJECT
AND NOT AN ARBITRARY THREE YEARS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO I'VE EIGHT
EIGHT THE ONE CONCERN IS HOW
LONG WAS DOWN WE HAVE THREE
YEARS FIVE YEARS YOU KNOW HOW
HOW LONG AND WE KNOW THAT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT SOME
CHALLENGES WITH.
SOME COUNTY SAY REALIZES OTHER
ISSUES BUT YOU KNOW SEEM LIKE IF.
THE MONEY'S NOT MOVING RIGHT AND
SO WOULD SO I BE SURE THAT THERE
SOME SAFEGUARDS TO BE SURE THAT
THE THERE'S NO.
THAT THE MAN THAT -- THAT WERE
LIVING IN A TIMELY MANNER SO
RIGHT YEAH.
OF THE I JUST -- SORT OF YOU
KNOW DRESS THAT AND A COMMENT
YOU KNOW THE COMMISSION HAS A
ROBUST -- ANALYSIS THEY WERE
ROBUST COMMISSION MEETING AND
ULTIMATELY THE COMMISSIONERS
SHARETHAT SAME CONCERN ABOUT
MAKING SURE THESE DOLLARS ARE
AWARDED TO PROGRAMS AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE SO -- I'M NOT
SPEAKING FOR THE COMMISSION I AM
SPEAKING FOR THE COUNTIES WE
SHARE THAT CONCERN I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN PARTNER WITH THE
COMMISSION TO MAKE SURE THAT
TIME LINES.
THE MEDICINE IN THE DOLLARS
THEY'RE ACTUALLY A TOOL THAT
COUNTIES CAN USE TO GET THESE TO
THE PROGRAMS OKAY HI THANK YOU
THINK SO MUCH.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE -- BRONZE HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLAN TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE HEALTH ACCESS OKAY
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING.
RONALD COLMAN HERE WE HAVE THE
OF HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA THE
STATE WIDE HEALTH CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COLLECT COALITION
WORKING FOR AFFORDABLE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
HERE TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
TO CHANGE EXISTING STATE LAW ON
THE ACTUARIAL VALUE THRESHOLDS
OF PLUS AND MINUS 2% AND THE
PLUS 4% PER BROWN'S HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH.
PLANS KNOWN AS H. D. H. PEAS
WHICH ARE SOLD ON AND OFF OF
COVER CALIFORNIA.
EXISTING STATE LAW DEFINES
LEVELS OF COVERAGE FOR THE NON
GRANDFATHERED INDIVIDUAL AND
SMALL GROUP MARKET FOR EXAMPLE
THE BRONZE LEVEL IS DEFINED AS
PROVIDING A LEVEL OF COVERAGE
THAT IS ACTUAR LEE EQUIVALENT
260% OF THE FULL AB OF THE
BENEFITS PROVIDED UNDER THE PLAN
CONTRACT.
THE AV FOR THESE CONTRACTS CAN
NOT VERY BY MORE THAN PLUS OR
MINUS 2% THE IRS RULES FOR
SETTING THE MAXIMUM OUT OF
POCKET COSTS FOR BRONZE HD AIDS
PLEASE.
THAT A COMPANY TAX FAVORED
ACCOUNTS LIKE HEALTH SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS ARE DIFFERENT THAN THE
RULES FOR THE MAXIMUM OUT OF
POCKET COSTS FOR OTHER EXCHANGE
PLANS FOR EXAMPLE FOR PLAN YOUR
TWENTY TWENTY THE MAXIMUM OUT OF
POCKET. FOR BRONZE HDHP IS
ALMOST ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
LOWER THAN THE MAXIMUM OUT OF
POCKET COSTS FOR OTHER BROWN'S
PRODUCTS OF THE ACTUAL AERIAL
VALUE IS ACTUALLY RICHARD
EXCEEDS THE THRESHOLD EXISTING
IN CALIFORNIA LAW PLUS AND MINUS
2%. TO MEET THE IRS.
RULES FOR THESE PRODUCTS THE
LEGISLATURE WILL NEED TO CHANGE
STATE LAW IN ORDER FOR THESE
PRODUCTS TO CONTINUALLY BE
OFFERED.
OF SIXTY TWO POINT 2% AB BRONZE
H. D. H. P. PRODUCTS IN THE
MARKET WHILE THIS IS MERELY ONLY
TWO TENTHS OF A PERCENT OVER THE
62% ACTUARIAL VALUE THRESHOLD IS
STILL OUTSIDE THE BOUNDS OF
EXISTING STATE LAW.
AND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS COULD LOSE
COVERAGE AND TO THEIR EXISTING
COVERAGE WITH NO LONGER EVEN BE
ABLE TO BE PURCHASED AS A
PRODUCT.
IN THE EXCHANGE OR OUTSIDE OF IT
THIS REQUEST HAS NO GENERAL FUND
BECAUSE IT IS TIMELY IN ORIGIN
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE SO THAT.
IT IS IN EFFECT FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY RATE YEAR FOR PLAN YOUR
TWENTY TWENTY HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURANCE CARRIERS ARE READY
SUBMITTING PRODUCTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FOR APPROVAL TO RATE
REVIEW PROCESS FOR THESE
PRODUCTS WILL ALSO BEGIN SOON
AND COVER CALIFORNIA AND OFF
EXCHANGE KERRY'S WILL BE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO START MARKETING IN
OCTOBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A GOT THAT
ALL RIGHT.
LIAM ANY COMMENTS ALL RIGHT.
OKAY CERTAINLY HOPEFULLY WE
SHOULD BILL HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIX
THIS IN A TIMELY MANNER SO WE
DON'T -- OF THE MARKET ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ALSO PRESENTING ON
SINGLE INVOICE ON ALL PLAN
COVERS SERVICES AS WELL YES OKAY.
LAST FALL DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES ISSUED A
PROPOSED RULE CHANGE FOR
EXCHANGE PROGRAM INTEGRITY THE
PROPOSAL DRASTICALLY CHANGES HOW
CONSUMERS CAN BE BILLED BY
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS FOR
SERVICES IN THEIR QUALIFIED
HEALTH.
PLANS SOLD WITHIN COVER
CALIFORNIA THE RULE WOULD
REQUIRE INSURERS TO SEND IN FOR
CONSUMERS TO PAY TWO ENTIRELY
SEPARATE BILLS FOR THE AMOUNT OF
THE PREMIUM -- ATTRIBUTABLE TO
CERTAIN MEDICAL SERVICES THAT
CANNOT BE COMMINGLED WITH
FEDERAL FUNDS AND THE AMOUNT OF
THE PREMIUM FOR ALL OF THE
SERVICES THE RULE COULD IT
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT BERNARD
BURDENS TO AND INSURERS AND
CONSUMERS AS WELL AS BECAUSE
SIGNIFICANT CONSUMER CONFUSION.
CONSUMERS COULD POTENTIALLY
BASED TERMINATION OF COVERAGE IF
THEY DIDN'T PAY THE PREMIUM FOR
BOTH BILLS ADDITIONALLY THIS
PROPOSAL CHANGE WOULD MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURANCE.
ANSWERS TO COMPLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONAL
REQUIREMENT CONNECTED TO
COVERING ALL MEDICALLY NECESSARY
SERVICES AND ALSO -- THE
CHANGING FEDERAL RULES WE ARE
PROPOSING THAT LANGUAGE THAT
SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT A CONSUMER
RECEIVED ONLY ONE INVOICE AND
SUBMITS ONLY ONE PAYMENT WHAT
THE HELL HELP PLAN AN INSURER
SEGREGATE.
THE PORTION OF THE PREMIUM
COLLECTED FOR THE SERVICES THEY
CANNOT BE CALLED COMMINGLED WITH
FEDERAL FUNDS THERE IS NO
GENERAL FUND COST TO THIS
PROPOSAL AS WELL AND THE ISSUE
IS URGENT SIMILARLY TO THE
PREVIOUS PROPOSAL THE CHANGING
TO BE IN FACT.
IN EFFECT BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN IN ORDER TO AFFECTED
THAT THE RATE YEAR IN THE
PLANNING FOR TWENTY TWENTY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU COLLEGE MILIEU OKAY
AND I HOPE THIS IS THIS IS TO
DEAL WITH -- CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
HOPEFULLY WON'T HAPPEN BUT WE
DON'T KNOW.
OKAY WE WE CAN BE READY THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WILL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
WE HAVE -- SEVERAL ITEMS A SAID
THE PART PUBLIC HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES -- SAY
COMMISSION AND COVER CALIFORNIA.
SO TELL ME THE ONES YOU LIKE.
WELCOME LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE LAST TWO
PROPOSALS RELATED TO COVER
CALIFORNIA THE SINGLE INVOICE AS
WELL AS THE BROWN'S HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE.
ALTHOUGH WE'RE NOT FANS OF THE
BRONZE PLANS THIS DOES PROVIDE A
MUCH NEEDED FIX FOR THE OVER.
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT
IT IMPACTS THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU OKAY -- AIR CARRIERS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH DROP IN -- CENTERS
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
A WELCOME.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA SPEAKING
TO THE LITTLE BY LITTLE PROPOSAL
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
LEVERAGING EXISTING WAKE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO EXPAND EARLY
LITERACY THAT WE KNOW IS CRUCIAL
TO PREVENTING THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP.
BUILDING UPON FIRST FAMILIES
LONGTIME SUPPORT OF AN
INVESTMENT IN THE LITTLE BY
LITTLE PROGRAM FIRST OF
CALIFORNIA IS PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS BUDGET ACID THAT MORE
FAMILIES CAN BENEFIT FROM THE
SERVICES.
THANK YOU HEY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
I'M MORE MCGREGOR PH IF YOU WAKE
PROGRAM ONE OF THE LOCAL AGENCY
CENTERS PROVIDING LITTLE BY
LITTLE SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES.
AND I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOUR
FIRST HAND MY EXPERIENCE IN
OBSERVING THE PARENTS AND THE
FAMILIES WHEN THEY RECEIVE THE
AGE APPROPRIATE HANDOUTS THE
DEVIL MATT DEVELOPMENTAL
MILESTONES.
AND THE EDUCATION THAT THEY
RECEIVE ABOUT ENGAGING WITH
THEIR CHILDREN AND THE
EXCITEMENT OF THE KIDS WHEN THEY
RECEIVE THE BOOKS AND THEY HUG
THE BOOKS AND THEY READ THEM.
IT'S JUST A GREAT PROGRAM THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
YOU'RE IN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
WITH ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
THE A THREE WEEK AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE WHOLE IN A HEALTH
LITTLE BY LITTLE EARLY LITERACY
PROGRAM.
EXCELLENT OKAY THANK YOU WELCOME
SIR MANY HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES HE
SHOULD -- WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT
THAT TEN MILLION OR BUDGET
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PARKINSON'S DISEASE REGISTRY.
WE WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM OUR FRIENDS AT THE MICHAEL
J. FOX FOUNDATION THAT THIS WILL
INCREASE IN KNOWLEDGE ABOUT.
THE PREVENTION AND FURTHER OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE DISEASE
ITSELF INCLUDING COLLEGES AND
THE RISKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THE PHD SUPPORTS THE
COMMISSION'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT DROP IN
CENTERS THE WORK THAT WE SEE IS
DONE WITH SANTA CLARA IS A
SUCCESS AND WE LOOK FOR TO SEE
AN IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEEN ON US AT THE
MICROPHONE NO I THINK EVERYONE
WHO CAME TO PRESENT THIS
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA OF THE
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEWS OF
COULD BE NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES.
SO I JUST WANT TO BEFORE WE
ADJOURN JUST MAKE SURE OF ONE
UNDERSTANDS WE'RE HOLDING ALL OF
THESE AT THAT PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENTS OPEN ALSO WANT TO
MENTION JUST TO BE SURE IT'S
CLEAR THAT -- WE ARE ALSO
HOLDING OPEN.
TO PROPOSAL FOR THE PARMA
DEVELOP THE SERVICES -- BECAUSE
WE HAD -- INVESTMENT PROPOSAL
THERE COMES UP EVERY THING ELSE.
YEAH OKAY SO EVERYTHING THAT WE
DID VOTE ON MORE HOLDING OPEN.
BUT NEXT WEEK WE WILL BE MOVING
ON AND CLOSING LOTS OF ITEMS SO
WITH THAT -- THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING WITH THAT THE
AGENDA IS COMPLETED WE ARE
ADJOURNED